COMMITTEE AND ENERGY UTILITIES
AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS. COURSE
THREE ONE KNOWS WHY WE'RE HERE
HI THIS PAST OCTOBER WITH
FORECASTS OF FOUR HI OFFSHORE
WINDS. MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
WERE LEFT IN THE DARK AS THE
STATE'S THREE LARGEST ELECTRIC
UTILITIES PROACTIVELY SHUT OFF
POWER TO NUMEROUS CIRCUITS ON
THEIR GRITS. PLEASE SHUT OFFS
WERE USED AS A TOOL TO PREVENT
THE UTILITIES EQUIPMENT FROM
IGNITING WILDFIRES. AFTER IT IN
THE IN THE PAST TWO YEARS SOME
OF THE MOST DEADLY FIRES. IN
OUR STATE'S HISTORY WERE
IGNITED BY UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING NORTH
BAY FIRES A TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THOMAS FIRE IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
OF COURSE THE VERY DEADLY
CAMPFIRE. THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
IN AN EFFORT TO STYMIE UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE FROM FOR
SPARKING FIRES IN JULY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION.
AUTHORIZED PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON. TO UTILIZE
POWER SHUT OFF PROGRAMS AND
RELATED PRO PROTOCOLS ALREADY
IN USE IN IN PLACES LIKE SAN
DIEGO. BY SEND YOU GAS AND
ELECTRIC. BOB FOLLOWING OF
FIRES THAT THE. THE AREA IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN IN PREVIOUS
YEARS AS A AS A RESULT WE ARE
WITNESSING AN EXPANSION AND
GROWTH THESE POWER SHUT OFFS
WHEN CONDITIONS ARE DRY AND
WINDS ARE HIGH AND THERE'S BEEN
AN ENORMOUS EXPANSION ACTUALLY.
NOW POINT PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT OFFS THESE SHUT OFF TO
CREATE THEIR OWN CHALLENGES AS
COMMUNITIES AND RESIDENTS ARE
LEFT WITHOUT POWER AS WILL
LEARN TODAY THE IMPACTS OF THE
POWER SHUT OFFS WERE WIDE
RANGING AND CREATED NUMEROUS
HARDSHIPS AND NUMEROUS SCHOOLS
WERE CLOSED RESIDENTS FOOD
SPOILED THE- MEDICAL. MEDICALLY
VULNERABLE WHO RELY ON
ELECTRICITY OF TO STAY ALIVE IN
MANY CASES HAD TO FIND WAYS TO
MAINTAIN THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE.
AND MANY OTHER IMPACTS WILL
ALSO DISCUSS OUTAGES IMPACTING
TELECOMMUNICATIONS WHICH
OCCURRED. EVEN IN PLACES WHERE
THE POWER STAYED ON. AND
LIMITED CALIFORNIANS ABILITY TO
CALL NINE ONE ONE AND RECEIVE
NO. EMERGENCY NOTIFICATIONS
AND- JUST PLAINLY- THEY WERE
UNABLE TO COMMUNICATE AND
CONDUCTOR DAILY LIVES. TODAY'S
HEARING IS INTENDED TO LAOS TO
LEARN WHAT HAPPENED AND WHAT
CAN BE DONE TO MITIGATE ALL THE
RISK AS WELL AS TO INFORM. OUR
POLICIES AS TO WHAT CONSTITUTES
PROTECTING PUBLIC SAFETY. WE
UNDERSTAND THIS ISSUE AFFECTS
MANY ACROSS OUR STATE INCLUDING
THOSE WERE WARNED OF THE POWER.
SHUT OFFS AND NEVER EXPERIENCED
THE LOSS OF POWER. THIS WAS
ONLY ONE HERE IN IN A
CONTINUING EFFORT TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS A NO DOUBT ADDRESS
CHALLENGES WITH THE POWER SHUT
OFF SPECIFICALLY AND ALSO- THIS
LEGISLATURE'S ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE WITH PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AND TO UNDERSTAND.
THE EXTENT IN WHICH- THESE
POWER OUTAGES AFFECTED THEIR
LIVES. WE HAVE QUITE A LENGTHY
AGENDA TODAY WE HAVE OVER
TWENTY PRESENTERS AND WE ALSO
WILL HAVE A TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT
ARE HERE THAT WISH TO BE HEARD.
WE WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DO THAT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING WE HAVE TRIED TO DO OUR
VERY BEST TO PROVIDE- SOME
LEVEL OF GEOGRAPHIC. DIVERSITY
IN THIS PRESENTATION TO UNDER
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
UNDERSTAND. HOW THE THOUGH THE
MEANS IN WHICH EVERYONE WAS IT
WAS AFFECT THAT WERE AFFECTED
BY THESE OUTAGES. WE ALSO KNOW.
THAT THERE IS MUCH MORE THAT WE
NEED TO HEAR THAT IS NOT
INCLUDED IN THIS AND- AGENDA
TODAY. SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK IN THE COME COMING MONTHS
TO ENSURE THAT WE GET THE FULL
PICTURE WE UNDERSTAND THE FULL
STORY SO. HAVING SAID THAT I
WANT TO WELCOME OUR OUR
PRESIDENT PRO TEM TONI ATKINS
TO ALLOW HER TO PROVIDE SOME
OPENING COMMENTS AND- WE- WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'VE DONE TO GET THE SENATE
OF. TO BE RESPONSIVE ON THIS
ISSUE AND- WAR WAR ALL
COMMITTED REALLY TO WORK IN I
WITH OUR COMMUNITY TO ENSURE
THAT- SOME OF THE- MISTAKES
THAT WERE MADE IN THIS PROCESS
ARE NOT REPEATED AND THAT WE'RE
MUCH BETTER PREPARED. IN IN
HANDLE IN THESE SITUATIONS IN
THE FUTURE AS WE CONTINUE TO
SEE EXTREME WEATHER AFFECT OUR
STATE. WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND- GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE- TO MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND CERTAINLY-
OTHER SENATORS WHO HAVE CHOSEN
TO JOIN I ALSO. A KNOWLEDGE
THAT I SAW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
AGUIAR-CURRY AND WAS IN THE
AUDIENCE THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US TODAY- TODAY WE ARE LOOKING
AT THE APPLICATION OF THE
POWERSHOT ALSTER IN THE RECENT
FIRES AS THE CHAIRMAN SAID. A
FOLLOW UP HEARING WILL ADDRESS
BUILDING ON STEPS THAT WE HAVE
ALREADY TAKEN REGARDING WILD
FIRES AND UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE. THOSE STEPS
INCLUDE THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR'S BROWN AND NEW SOME
ESTABLISHING NEW WILD FIRE
SAFETY PLANS OVERHAULING THE
STATE'S PREVENTION AND RESPONSE
EFFORTS. SUPPORTING LOCAL
RECOVERY EFFORTS AND COMMITTING
NEARLY ONE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
IMPORT INVESTMENTS IN NEW
EQUIPMENT AND STAFFING CAL FIRE.
WE ALL KNOW THIS CRITICAL WORK
MUST BE ON GOING I WANT TO
ESPECIALLY THANK THE PANELISTS
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
ARE PARTICIPATING TODAY. THE
EXPERIENCES THAT YOU SHARE
WHETHER IN PERSON OR IN WRITING
WILL HELP US AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
ONE OF THE BEST PARTS OF HUMAN
NATURE IS THE STRONG INSTINCT
TO HELP IN A CRISIS. WITH
WILDFIRES WE'VE SEEN THAT TIME
AND TIME AGAIN NEIGHBORS
HELPING EACH OTHER EVACUATE
WORKING TOGETHER TO SAVE THEIR
HOUSES AND EVEN PROVIDING
SHELTER FOR ANIMALS AND PETS.
THERE HAVE BEEN SIMILAR STORIES
ABOUT CALIFORNIANS AFFECTED BY
THE POWER SHUT OFFS. A SMALL
ANTIQUE STORE IN SHINGLE TOWN
USE THEIR GENERATOR TO HELP A
NEIGHBORING RESTAURANT KEEP ITS
FOOD FROM SPOILING. IN CLEAR
LIKE A HOME CARE AID WAS UNABLE
TO HELP HER ELDERLY CLIENTS
WASH CLOTHES ARE DISHES WITHOUT
ELECTRICITY. AND YET SHE TOOK
THEM HOT COFFEE AND JUST SPEND
TIME WITH THEM REASSURING THEM
THROUGHOUT THE SHUT OFF. AND
THERE ARE MANY MANY MORE
STORIES SOME WE MIGHT EVEN HERE
TODAY. AND THE CAPITAL AS WE
FOLLOW THE NATURAL INSTINCT TO
HELP IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE DO
SO IN A COMPREHENSIVE AFFECTED
WAY THAT MAKES A REAL
DIFFERENCE. YOU MAY HAVE SEEN
THE ARTICLE I WROTE CALLING FOR
A COMPREHENSIVE ACTION PLAN.
LET ME SHARE JUST A FEW OF THE
TOP LINES FROM THAT ARTICLE. TO
MINIMIZE THE RISK TO THE PUBLIC
FROM WILDFIRES IN POWER SHUT
OFF. THERE MUST BE ONE
OVERARCHING UMBRELLA THAT
ENCOMPASSES ALL THE MOVING
PARTS INVOLVED. I EXPECT THIS
HEARING AND THE UPCOMING ONE
WILL HELP INFORM THE SENATE'S
NEXT STEPS WHICH WILL BE TAKEN
WITHIN THE THREE AREAS OF FOCUS
LEGISLATION OVERSIGHT. AND
FUNDING THROUGH OUR STATE
BUDGET. THOSE NEXT STEPS TO BE
PART OF A COMPREHENSIVE ACTION
PLAN. THE ADMINISTRATION IS
CONVENING STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADDRESS HOW PGD GOES FORWARD
AND THE PUBLIC A CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION IS
ALSO INVESTIGATING THE
POWERSHOT OFFS. THOSE OUTCOMES
ALSO MUST BE CONSIDERED PART OF
A COMPREHENSIVE ACTION PLAN. A
FEW OVERALL POINTS ARE HOPEFUL
GODDESS IN OUR APPROACH. ENERGY
MUST REMAIN AVAILABLE WITH
MINIMAL TARGETED DISRUPTION
DURING EMERGENCIES. BACKSLIDING
ON OUR FIGHT AGAINST CLIMATE
CHANGE MAKES WILD FIRE
CONDITIONS WORSE AND COST
REPAIRS MORE. TAXPAYERS SHOULD
NOT BE ON THE HOOK FOR BAILING
OUT SHAREHOLDERS WHO HAVE
PROFITED FROM UTILITY
INVESTMENTS. UTILITIES PLANS
FOR HARDENING THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE TO REDUCE FIRES
MUST INCLUDE A REALISTIC TIME
LINE A WORK SCHEDULE THE PUBLIC
CAN SEE AND DEPEND UPON. AND
REAL ACCOUNTABILITY IF GOALS
ARE NOT MET. WE MUST ALSO
RECOGNIZE WILDFIRES ARE ALSO
STARTED BY SOURCES OTHER THAN
UTILITY EQUIPMENT. LIGHTNING
CAR ENGINES DRAGGING CHANGE AND
SO ON ONE MAN WAS ARRESTED
RECENTLY AFTER FLYING HERE FROM
MISSOURI JUST TO START FIRES.
OUR PREPARATIONS NEED TO TAKE
THAT INTO ACCOUNT AND THAT'S
WHY MOVING FORWARD ON IMPROVING
FIRE CONDITIONS BY COMBAT IN
CLIMATE CHANGE REMAINS SO
IMPORTANT. THERE ARE ALSO MANY
QUESTIONS THAT THE WORK OF I'D
DEVELOPING A COMPREHENSIVE
ACTION PLAN CAN HELP ANSWER.
ARE THERE WAYS TO JUMPSTART THE
HARDENING PROCESS SO MORE
PEOPLE ARE SPARED SHUT OFF
FASTER WITHOUT TAXPAYERS ARE
UTILITY CUSTOMERS BEING LEFT ON
THE HOOK. HOW CAN WE IMPROVE
COMMUNICATION FOR EVACUATIONS
AND OTHER EMERGENCY
NOTIFICATIONS AND FIND
SOLUTIONS TO CELL TOWERS
FAILING AT A TIME WHEN THE
PUBLIC IS RELYING ON THEM THE
MOST. HOW CAN WE BEST DEPLOYS
STATE ASSETS SUCH AS COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS FOR USE IN
EMERGENCIES WITH RESOURCES LIKE
WIFI AND CHARGING STATIONS THAT
CAN BE ON SITE. IN A STATE
ALREADY SHORT OF HOUSING HOW DO
WE ADDRESS INSURANCE AND
BUILDING ISSUES NOW THAT WILD
FIRES OWNS HAVE EXPANDED TO
INCLUDE BOTH RURAL AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES. HOW DO WE ENSURE
THAT BUSINESSES BUSINESS
RESPONSIBLE FOR CHILDREN AND
THE ELDERLY AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ADEQUATELY PROTECT
AND ARE ABLE TO PROTECT THEIR
CLIENTS WHEN THERE ARE FIRES
POWER SHUT OFFS OR OTHER
EMERGENCIES. SO THANK YOU ALL
AGAIN FOR BEING PART OF THIS
HEARING AND FOR LETTING ME
SHARE SOME THOUGHTS I BELIEVE
THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS EXPECT US
TO TREAT THESE ISSUES URGENTLY.
BUT ALSO EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY AND AGAIN TO ME
THAT MEANS A COMPREHENSIVE
ACTION PLAN FOR ALL THE
DOCUMENTED FACTS NEW PROPOSALS
EXISTING POLICIES ARE ASSESSED
AND IMPLEMENTED IN A TIMELY AND
TRANSPARENT MANNER.
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE TO KNOW
WHAT TO EXPECT AND WHEN AND
WHAT HAPPENS IF THOSE
EXPECTATIONS ARE NOT MET SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL OF YOU TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
AGAIN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BACK TO YOU THANK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A MATTER PRESIDENT TO
NOT WE'LL HEAR FROM OUR VICE
CHAIR SENATOR MORLOCK WHO IS
GOING TO BE ASSISTANT. RUNNING
THIS COMMITTEE HERE TODAY SO
ONE OF MAKES COMMENTS YES
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IN TWO THOUSAND ONE WE
HAD- AN ISSUE WITH THE
UTILITIES WHEN I WAS THE
TREASURER OF THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE. SO I FEEL LIKE I'VE
BEEN HERE BEFORE BUT BACK THEN
WE CALL THEM BROWN OUTS IN THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE WENT AHEAD AND
PAID A LOWER UTILITY RATE. SO
THAT WE CAN TURN OUR
ELECTRICITY OFF TO PROVIDE
ENOUGH ELECTRICITY FOR
NEIGHBORS BUT THAT WAS RESULT
OF. STATE LEGISLATION IT THERE
WAS THE RESULT OF DEREGULATING-
THE ELECTRIC MARKET AND WE SAW
THAT- IT- HAD A MAJOR IMPACTED
PROHIBITED AND NATURAL GAS
ACQUISITION IN THE FUTURES
MARKET. AND WE WATCHED
UTILITIES BE MANIPULATED IN THE
SPOT MARKET- AND THEN WE SAW
POOR GOVERNOR DAVIS- KIND OF
TURN A PROBLEM INTO A MESS. SO
SACRAMENTO- HAD TO MAKE MASSIVE
ENERGY LOANS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON WAS
DOWNGRADED P. JEANNIE FILED FOR
CHAPTER ELEVEN THE FIRST TIME.
AND WITHIN A FEW WEEKS WE'VE WE
LOST GOVERNOR DAVIS TO THE
SECOND RECALL OF THE SITTING
GOVERNOR IN U. S. HISTORY SO
THIS IS A BIG ISSUE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT. KINDA
REVERBERATES WITH ME BECAUSE I
WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF IT AND IN
THAT COMMOTION I EVEN FOUND
MYSELF BEING THE CHAIR OF THE
CREDITORS COMMITTEE FOR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON SO
TWO TWO DECADES LATER HERE. WE
HAVE SOME INTERESTING
SIMILARITIES SO WHEN SACRAMENTO.
SACRAMENTO MAKES DEMANDS. THE
OF ON THE UTILITIES PERHAPS
THIS TIME IN THE PURSUIT OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY GENERATION-
SUBSIDIZING ELECT THE ELECTRIC
CAR INDUSTRY. BUT WE NEED TO
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION THE
ADDITIONAL LOW DEMANDS THAT
RECHARGING EXACTS. AND WITH NEW
MANDATES THE I. O. U.'S. SEEM
TO HAVE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
AND DID NOT FOCUS ON HARDENING
ASSETS FROM PROVING
TRANSMISSION LINES BUT
SCORCHING. SANTANA DIABLO WINS
WE'VE HAD FOR MILLENNIA SO THIS
IS NOTHING RELATIVELY NEW BUT
INVERSE CONDEMNATION CERTAINLY
HAS MADE THE FOCUS A LITTLE
MORE INTERESTING SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC BECAME VERY PROACTIVE-
FACT COMMUNICATING WITH ME
ALMOST A- MULTIPLE TIMES A DAY
IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS. WHEN WE
HAD A SANTA ANA CONDITION CITY
OF ANAHEIM WHICH HAS ITS OWN
PUBLIC UTILITY TWENTY YEARS AGO
STARTED TO UNDERGROUND IT'S- A
HIGH VOLTAGE LINES IN. WHILE I
AYE WILDFIRES OWNS- IN THERE
ABOUT 90% COMPLETED YES IT
TAKES A LOT OF MONEY YES IT'S
EXPENSIVE YES IT TAKES TIME BUT
YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE A PLAN
YOU'VE GOT TO BE MOVING
FORWARD. BECAUSE IT'S A WHOLE
LOT CHEAPER AND LESS TO
STRESSFUL BEEN LOSE LIFE AND
PROPERTY. SO MISTER CHAIR. I'VE
HAD BEEN HAVING FUN IN THIS
SPACE BECAUSE ORANGE COUNTY HAD
A RATHER TRAGIC WILDFIRE BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND THREE WITH THE
LAGUNA BEACH FIRE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED HOMES WERE LOST- LIVES
WERE CHANGED AND- SO WE TRY TO
GET TO IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
CPUC IN CALIFORNICA MAPS- IN
POPULAR THE WILDFIRES OWNS IN
ORDER TO PRIORITIZE AREAS IN
NEED OF HARDENING OR UNDER
GROUNDING. AT WAS SENT SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN SIXTY THREE BUT
IT WAS VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR
EVEN THOUGH IT RECEIVE NO ZERO
VOTES. IN BOTH CHAMBERS. THE
CPUC IN CALIFORNIA TO WORKING
FOR EIGHT YEARS BEHIND. ON ON
FIRE MAPS THEY WERE BEHIND
SCHEDULE WHEN SANTA ROSA SONOMA
NAPA. SAW THE LOSS OF FORTY TWO
LIVES SO WE CAN DO BETTER
MISTER CHAIR I DIDN'T EITHER
BILL IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
TO USE CAP AND TRADE TAX
REVENUES TO HARDEN ELECTRIC
LINES. IT WAS KILLED BUT IN
ENVIRONMENT QUALITY BUT I'M I'M
I'M REALLY PLEASED THAT SENATOR
DODD INCLUDED IT IN SB NINE OH
ONE- LATER THAT YEAR. WE'VE
ALSO DONE A BILL TO USE RULE
TWENTY A AND I LIKE TO ASK THIS
WHEN WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ASK QUESTIONS. ON TRYING TO USE
FUNDS THAT ARE READY AVAILABLE
FOR UNDER GETTING ANOTHER.
OPPORTUNITIES BUT WE'RE
GENERATING GREENHOUSE GASES
WITH THESE WILDFIRES AND WE
NEED TO MONITOR THOSE AND- I
HAD- BILL THIS YEAR FIVE THREE
FIVE TWO GOT LOCKED UP IN ITS
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS HAVING
FUN BUT WE'RE TRYING. BUT WE'VE
GOT TO WORK A LITTLE BETTER A
LITTLE MORE THOUGHTFUL. AT
WHAT'S GOING ON IN A HOLISTIC
APPROACH IT'S INTEGRATED WHEN
IT COMES TO ADDRESSING CLIMATE
CHANGE ELECTRICITY- WILDFIRES.
SO I'M I'M GRATEFUL MISTER
CHAIR THAT YOU PUT THE INDUSTRY
REPRESENTATIVES UP EARLY IN THE
AGENDA- THEY HAVE DIFFICULT
QUESTIONS TO ANSWER BUT
SACRAMENTO HAS MADE THEIR CORE
MISSION. AND NOT VERY EASY AND
WE MAY HAVE TO. LOOK AT THE
ROOT CAUSE FOR THEIR PS PS
STRATEGY IN IT MIGHT BE STARING
US IN THE FACE. SO WITH THAT
MISTER CIARA HOPING TO SERIOUS
REFLECTION ON THE ENTIRE TOPIC
OF PROVIDING ELECTRICITY. THE
CALIFORNIANS THE DECADES TO
COME AND I HOPE WE FIND WAYS TO
PROVIDE. IT MORE SAFELY. AND
MORE CHEAPLY. OUR RESIDENTS PAY
A HIGHER. TAXES. HI UTILITY
BILLS HI HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE
PREMIUMS IF THEY CAN. GET THEM.
AND NOW THEY'RE PAYING MASSIVE
SUMS TO REFILL THEIR FREEZERS
WITH LAS PROVISIONS. SO
CALIFORNIA. THE YOU KNOW NEEDS
TO BE SENSITIVE TO ALL THESE
ISSUES THESE ARE LEARNING
EXPENSE AND LEARNING AND
EXPENSE OF LESSONS. SACRAMENTO
NEEDS TO MAKE SERIOUS
MODIFICATIONS INTERNALLY. AS IT
IMPROVES ITS OVERSIGHT ON THESE
CRITICAL ENERGY PROVIDERS LET'S
BE STRATEGIC. LET'S AVOID
CHASING THE CONCERN OF THE DAY
LET'S PROVIDE INTELLIGENT
LEADERSHIP THAT EMPOWERS. THE
PROVIDERS ANYA OVERSEERS LET'S
BE BIG PICTURE. AND PROVIDE A
BALANCED APPROACH TO LECTURE
CITY IN CLIMATE CHANGE AND
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
LETTING ME. THROW THAT INTO THE
MIX THANK COLLEAGUES AND I KNOW
WE HAVE OTHER MEMBERS THAT WERE
AFFECTED BY THESE FIRES IN A
VERY BIG WAY. AND THE PRESENT
HERE TODAY AND- WE HAVE- QUITE
A LINEUP OF SPEAKERS AND
THEY'LL BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ASK QUESTIONS BUT IF ANY
MEMBERS AT THIS POINT WANT TO
MAKE SOME OPENING COMMENTS SO.
ALLOW THAT IF THE BRIEF. CENTER
DOT. IDEA MISTER CHAIR I
CERTAINLY HAVE A LOT TO SAY
ABOUT THE SUBJECT BUT IN
RESPECT TO- THE MATTER SPEAKERS
WE HAVE IN YOUR ADMONITION TO
BE. CONCISE I WILL BE BRIEF-
YOU KNOW SINCE THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN NORTH BAY WILD FIRES-
THE I AUTHORED SB NINE OH ONE
IN IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. I
BELIEVE THE DE ENERGIZING POWER
LINES IN ADVANCE OF THE SEVERE
WIND STORM WOULD BE A RARE.
STRATEGICALLY TARGETED AND LAST
OPTION DEFENSE AGAINST A
UTILITY IGNITION OF A WILDFIRE.
I ALSO BELIEVE THAT PS PS
PROTOCOLS CALLED FOR AN SB NINE
OH ONE WOULD BE CAREFULLY
REVIEWED AND IF NECESSARY.
MODIFIED BY CBC BEFORE APPROVAL
AS CALLED FOR IN THE STATUTE.
UNFORTUNATELY IN A AN
ACCEPTABLY UNACCEPTABLY IN THIS
CASE A P. JEANNIE SHUT OFFS
HAVE BEEN APPLIED BROADLY WITH
LITTLE OR NO STRATEGIC
PLANNING- IT'S APPARENT THE P.
GENIES IMPLEMENTATION OF THE P.
S. P. S. IS A DIRECT FUNCTION
OF. THE DECREPIT CONDITION OF
ITS TRANSMISSION AND
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM. REFLECTING
DECADE TO DISREGARD TO ITS
MANDATE TO SERVE ITS CUSTOMERS
RELIABLY AND SAFELY. THIS NO
LONGER CAN BE THE CASE THE CPUC
MUST AND I BELIEVE WILL
EXERCISE ITS AUTHORITY AND DO A
BETTER JOB OF REGULATION
OVERSIGHT AND ENFORCEMENT. WHAT
A PS PS MUST BE INITIATED HOW
COULD BE DONE IN THE MOST
PRECISE AND STRATEGIC MANNER SO
AS TO MINIMIZE THE NUMBER OF
IMPACTED CUSTOMERS FOR THE
LEAST AMOUNT OF TIME AND WITH
THE GREATEST AMOUNT OF RELIEF
FOR AFFECTED BUSINESSES AND
HOUSEHOLDS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE YOU. CENTER
STERN. BUT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TEM FOR. RESPONDING WITH THE
URGENCY I THINK THE PUBLIC IS
DEMANDING IN CALLING US HERE
TODAY AT OF SESSION- AMID TO
FOR MY COMMENTS TO THOSE WHO.
COULDN'T MAKE IT HERE TODAY. WE
ALL CAN TAKE A SOUTHWEST FLIGHT
AND TAKE TIME OUT OF OUR
SCHEDULE BECAUSE THIS IS OUR
JOB TO BE HERE- BUT ALLEN FROM
SEAMY VALLEY. T. FROM THOUSAND
OAKS IN ABOUT FIFTEEN HUNDRED
OTHER CONSTITUENTS OF MINE
WHO'VE WEIGHED IN WITH SPECIFIC
COMMENTS COULDN'T SO IF I COULD
JUST READ TWO SENSES OF THEIRS-
IS MY OPENING COMMENTS- SO
ALLEN SAYS MIKE MY FAMILY.
INCLUDING MY WIFE IS ON OXYGEN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY. AND A
VENTILATOR TWELVE HOURS A DAY
MY PARENTS WHO ARE IN THEIR
EIGHTIES HAVE SUFFERED POWER
OUTAGES CAUSED BY. EASY FIRE
AND MULTIPLES A SCHEDULED AND
UNSCHEDULED OUTAGES. I
PURCHASED A BACKUP GENERATOR
KEEP MY WIFE'S MEDICALLY
NECESSARY EQUIPMENT RUNNING
SPECIFICALLY TO ADDRESS THESE
PROBLEMS THE WAR IN A FIXED
INCOME. AND EDISON IS OFFERED
NO FINANCIAL AID AT ALL. I'M AN
ADDITIONAL EMERGENCY CRISES
THERE'S BEEN SERIOUS PROBLEMS
WITH AIR QUALITY. AND DUE TO
SMOKE ASH ANOTHER PARTICULAR
TEN IN THE PAST TWELVE MONTHS
MY WIFE HAS BEEN HOSPITALIZED
TWICE. ONCE FOR FIVE DAYS AND
ONCE FOR THIRTY DAYS. T. SAYS.
MY SON SHE'S FROM THOUSAND OAKS
MY SON RELIES ON A FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLAR VILE MEDICINE TO STAY
ALIVE. THE SCHOOL STORES THAT-
THAT VIAL AT SCHOOL BUT ON
OCTOBER ELEVENTH ELECTRICITY
WAS SHUT OFF AT OUR MIDDLE
SCHOOL BECAUSE OF HIGH WINDS IS
BEEN SHUT OFF MULTIPLE TIMES
SINCE. THE SCHOOL CONTACTED ME
AND TOLD ME THE MEDICINE GOT
WARMED. WAS SPOILED AND THEY
REFUSE TO USE IT. NOW IT'S
COSTING ME OVER FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS EVERY SINGLE TIME THE
POWER GOES DOWN TO KEEP MY SON
ALIVE THIS IS NOT RIGHT.
COMPLETELY AGREED MY
CONSTITUENTS ND LOOK FOR
DIGGING IN FURTHER HERE TODAY
TO PROTECT THEIR INTERESTS
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
TO YOU IN THE PRO TIME FOR
CONVENING THIS- TIME SENSITIVE.
HEARING BECAUSE FRANKLY WERE IN
A STATE OF EMERGENCY RIGHT NOW
PARTICULARLY IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA- WHERE WE HAVE
UTILITY THAT IS REPEATEDLY
STARTING CATASTROPHIC FIRES-
AND THAT IS TURNING OFF THE
POWER TO MILLIONS OF PEOPLE. IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I KNOW
THE P. JEANNIE LIKES TO TALK IN
TERMS OF ACCOUNTS THERE ARE
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND ACCOUNTS
THAT WERE TURNED OFF. THAT IS
LIKE TWO AND A HALF MILLION
PEOPLE WE NEED TO START TALKING
ABOUT THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE IMPACTED. WHO HAVE TO STORE
THEIR MEDICINE RETURN ON THEIR
VIOLATORS. WHO CAN'T GO TO WORK
BECAUSE THEIR JOB SITE IS SHUT
DOWN AND THEY DON'T GET PAID
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO STAY HOME
BECAUSE THEIR KIDS DON'T HAVE A
SCHOOL TO GO TO AND SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE SHUTTING
DOWN AND POTENTIALLY GOING OUT
OF BUSINESS BECAUSE BEING SHUT
DOWN FOR A WEEK DOESN'T WORK-
FOR MOST- BUSINESSES. DON WE
THOUGHT THAT P. GINNY WOULD USE
A SCALPEL- IN IMPLEMENTING THIS
PLAN BLACKOUTS- AND INSTEAD P.
GINNY HAS CHOSEN TO USE A
SLEDGEHAMMER AND THEN TURN
AROUND AND ESSENTIALLY TELL THE
PUBLIC SORRY SUCK IT UP WE'LL
FIX IT IN TEN YEARS- AND WE
KNOW THAT THIS HAS RESULTED-
NOT TRUST FROM CLIMATE CHANGE
YES CLIMATE CHANGE IS PART OF
IT. BUT THIS IS A UTILITY THAT
FOR DECADES NOW HAS NOT
INVESTED APPROPRIATELY AND IT'S
INFRASTRUCTURE WHILE IT HAS
PAID DIVIDENDS TO ITS
SHAREHOLDERS- AT A COMPANY THAT
HAS SIMPLY BEEN BEYOND THAT
YOU'RE RESPONSIBLE IN THE WAY
THAT IT HAS MAINTAINED AND
OPERATED AT SYSTEM AND SO WE
NOW HAVE WILD FIRES- ON A SCALE
THAT UNIMAGINABLE AND BLACKOUTS
ON A SCALE UNIMAGINABLE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD WHERE IT
APPEARS THAT WE CAN NO LONGER
EVEN KEEP THE LIGHTS ON AND
THAT IS BEYOND UNACCEPTABLE- I
ALSO BECAUSE I AM IN P. JEANNIE
TERRITORY I GET ALL THE EMAILS-
IMPLORING ME AND OTHERS TO GO
OUT AND PURCHASE DIESEL
GENERATORS US BECAUSE SINCE P.
GINNY CAN'T KEEP THE LIGHTS ON.
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BUY DIESEL
GENERATORS- WHICH POLLUTE-
WHICH CAUSE FIRES AND WHICH
BECAUSE CARBON MONOXIDE
POISONING AT THE SAME TIME. BUT
ALL THIS IS HAPPENING RPG ANY
CONTINUES TO HIRE ARMIES OF
LOBBYISTS TO OPPOSE EVERY
SINGLE AFTER TO EXPAND SOLAR
ENERGY STORAGE AND OTHER
DISTRIBUTED. ENERGY RESOURCES
SO THAT PEOPLE CAN ACTUALLY
GENERATE. OUR OWN POWER AND
STORE IT AND THEN HAVE BACKUP
POWER THAT IS NOT POLLUTING AND
CAUSING FIRES AND CAUSING
CARBON MONOXIDE. POISONING AND
AS WE SPEAK RIGHT NOW PGA ANY
IS ADVOCATING TO THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION NOT
TO FULLY FUND THE S. CHIP
PROGRAM WHICH WILL HELP
CALIFORNIANS TO OBTAIN ENERGY
STORAGE. WHY IS P. GINNY
ADVOCATING AGAINST EXPANDING
ENERGY STORAGE SERVICE COMPANY
IN MY MIND. HAS FORFEITED ITS
RIGHT TO OPERATE AS AN INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITY WE NEED
FUNDAMENTAL STRUCTURAL CHANGE
AT PGA ANY BECAUSE THE STATUS
QUO JUST ISN'T WORKING AND
HASN'T WORKED FOR A LONG TIME
THANK YOU. SIR MCGUIRE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND I
WANNA TAKE A MOMENT IS A VERY
FINE TO THE CHAIR WHO CHECKED
IN- THROUGHOUT- FIRES AND POWER
SHUT OFF THE VERY VERY GRATEFUL
AND OF COURSE TO THE PRO TIM.
WHO IS DONE THE SAME ALL THE
WAY THROUGHOUT. NOW IN FOR
BRINGING US TOGETHER TODAY SO
WE- TRULY APPRECIATE IT. MY
WORDS AND I'LL BE QUICK FOR THE
CHAIR MY WORDS ARE NOT
REFLECTED TO THE HARD WORKING
MEN WOMEN TO KEEP THE LIGHTS ON
EVERY DAY. OR TURN THE GAS BACK
ON. BUT WITH MY FRUSTRATION
WITH THE PACIFIC GAS ELECTRIC
CORPORATION. EVERY POWER ALMOST
EVERY POWER OUTAGE WITH SOME
NUMBER WOULDN'T AS SOON
AGUIAR-CURRY MYSELF AND CENTER
DOT OF SCENE OF MOSTLY BEEN IN
OUR BACKYARDS IN IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE REPRESENT.
AND THE RESIDENTS OF THE NORTH
BAY AND THE NORTH COAST ARE
TIRED. THEIR SUFFERING THEY
NEED ASSISTANCE. NOT JUST FROM
THE DESTRUCTIVE FIRES BUT BY
THESE THE BUCKLES OF POWER
OUTAGES IT IS BEEN CHRIS BECOME
CRYSTAL CLEAR TO ME THAT P.
JEANNIE LACKS THE BASIC
FUNDAMENTALS TO SUCCESSFULLY
EXECUTE SUCH A LARGE AND
COMPLEX OUT EACH LET ALONE
MULTIPLE OUTAGES. THERE ARE
SOME COMMUNITIES ON THE NORTH
COAST THAT DID NOT HAVE POWER
FOR ELEVEN STRAIGHT DAYS. MOST
COMMUNITIES IN OCTOBER DID NOT
HAVE POWER IN NORTHERN
MINISTERIAL. I TWO NOMINEES
ZENO NORTON CINEMA AS WELL AS
LAKE COUNTY FOR SEVEN STRAIGHT
DAYS TRY TO BE A OPERATE YOUR
SMALL BUSINESS. BUT WITHOUT
POWER. HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
HAVE BEEN LOST IN COMMERCE.
HOSPITALS ARE PUT ON DIVERT
SAINT JOSEPH HOSPITAL IN.
DOUBLE COUNTY HAD TO CANCEL
SURGERIES FOR THE GREATER PART
OF A WORK WEEK DAYS AND DAYS OF
SCHOOL HAVE BEEN CLOSED WITH
LITTLE TO NO CHANCE BE TO MAKE
HIM UP. I THINK THERE ARE THREE
REASONS WHY WE ARE HERE TODAY.
OVER ONE THE LACK OF INVESTMENT
IN CANDIDLY DECADES OF
MISMANAGEMENT BY PACIFIC GAS
ELECTRIC. PUTTING THEIR
SHAREHOLDERS ABOVE THEIR
CUSTOMERS. NUMBER TWO THE LACK
OF SUPERVISION ENFORCEMENT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE
FOR OVERSEEING P. GENIES PLANS
FOR THESE PUBLIC SHUT OFF
EVENTS. THEY ALSO HOLD
RESPONSIBILITY. PASSIVELY THAT
WE'RE FACING A NEW CLIMATE
REALITY WHICH IS CAUGHT UP WITH
P. JEANNIE THANK OUR USER OWN
STATISTIC BACK IN 20001215% OF
THEIR LINES WERE AN ELEVATED
FIRE RISK ZONES TODAY. IT'S 50%
OF ALL LINES. WE CANNOT
CONTINUE WHAT SOME CALL THE NEW
NORMAL WITH POWER SHUT OFF. WE
NEED TO BE A EXPERT I GREAT
HARDENING THAT YOU MANAGEMENT
AND MODERNIZATION. TEN YEARS
TELLING CUSTOMERS TEN YEARS IS
SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE. WE MUST%
BETTER PINPOINT OUTAGES VERSUS
TAKING THE NEAT MEAT CLEAVER
APPROACH THAT HAVE IMPACTED
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS. REASON
WHY HUMBOLDT COUNTY LOST THEIR
POWER- HERE A FEW WEEKS AGO WAS
BECAUSE IT DIDN'T HAVE AN
ABILITY TO BE A SWITCH THE
LINES THE MAIN FEEDER LINES
COMING INTO THE COUNTY AND IT
WASN'T BECAUSE THEY'RE IN FIRE
DANGER. WE NEED TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE COMMUNITY
RESPONSE PLANS ESPECIALLY FOR
THE MEDICALLY FRAGILE
PINPOINTING CUSTOMERS BASED OFF
OF THE CARE PROGRAM WITHIN P.
JEANNIE SIMPLY DOESN'T WORK AND
IN FACT RELIEVING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF THE MOST MEDICALLY
FRAGILE IN THEIR TERRITORY. OUT
OF COMMUNICATION HUNDREDS UPON
HUNDREDS OF CELL TOWERS WENT
DOWN DURING THIS LATEST OUTAGE.
AND IT'S NOT ABOUT CHECK IN THE
LATEST FACEBOOK STATUSES
LITERALLY ABOUT LIFE AND DEATH.
AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS
THOUSANDS BEEN PUT AT RISK
BECAUSE CELL PHONE TOWERS WENT
DOWN AND I WILL BE CANDID WITHYOU MISTER CHAIR. I WAS TOLD BY
EXECUTIVES IN JUNE. A TELECOM
EXECUTIVES IN JUNE THAT THE
WORST CASE SCENARIO WOULD NOT
HAPPEN. AND UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE
SEEN IT HAPPEN OVER THE LAST
MANY WEEKS. AND WE ALSO NEED TO
HAVE PERFORMANCE METRICS IN
STATE LAW. TO ENSURE UTILITIES
HAVE REAL CONSEQUENCES IF
THEY'RE NOT HITTING THEIR GOALS
AND WRAP IT UP RIGHT HERE. I
THINK WE'RE ON OUR THIRD STRIKE.
THIRD STRIKE FOR P. JEANNIE.
RIGHT ONE WAS A SANGRIA SAN
BRUNO GAS EXPLOSION AT THE
TRIED TO COVER UP. AND THEN
THEY LIED ABOUT IT. STRIKE TO
WHERE THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND EIGHTEEN
WILDFIRES. STRIKE THREE'S A
WOEFULLY INADEQUATE RESPONSE.
TO THESE POWER SHUT OFFS. WE
CANNOT NIP AROUND THE EDGES
IT'S NOW TIME FOR THE STATE TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE. ALL OPTIONS ON
THE TABLE. HEY FAILED US TOO
MANY TIMES THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU CENTER CHIANG. THANK
YOU I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
PRO TEM IN THE CHAIR FOR
CALLING FOR THIS OVERSIGHT
HEARING. I AM SO I AM FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THE
SHUT OFF HAVE OBVIOUSLY
IMPACTED ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS
IN FACT I HAD TO OF FIRES IN MY
DISTRICT- WITHIN THIS PAST
MONTH AND A COUPLE OF A- PEACE
PS PST VANS. I'M LOOKING TO
HEARING MORE ABOUT WHAT'S BEEN
DONE WHAT WE NEED TO BE FOCUSED
ON I MEAN FRANKLY THIS IS
HORRENDOUS AND IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE. ON A SIMILAR NOTE
I'M EAGER TO HEAR FROM ANDERSON
BECAUSE MOST OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS AT THIS AND- I
WANT TO KNOW WHAT THEY'VE
LEARNED- IN ORDER TO STRENGTHEN
THEIR ASSETS AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
TALK ABOUT. AND FRANKLY THERE'S
AN OBVIOUS NEED FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY WHETHER IT BE
THE UTILITIES ARE REGULATING
ENTITIES AND IT'S CLEAR THAT WE
NEED TO WORK TOGETHER ON THIS
AND WE NEED ANSWERS OKAY SO I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING. OF
FROM FROM. THE TESTIMONIES
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
NIELSEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND- PRO TEM FOR
ALLOWING US THIS OPPORTUNITY
AND THANK YOU FOR INDULGING ME
IS NOT A MEMBER THIS COMMITTEE
BE ABLE TO SIT HERE. WE HAVE
SUFFERED ALL OVER CALIFORNIA
BUT PROBABLY NONE GREATER THAN
THE COMMUNITY OF PARADISE IN
THE REGION BUTTE COUNTY.
TOMORROW A NUMBER OF
LEGISLATIVE STAFF AND
LEGISLATORS ARE GOING TO GO
WITH US UP THERE TO SEE THE
PROGRESS THAT HAS BEEN MADE.
BUT EIGHTY FIVE PEOPLE WILL NOT
BE AROUND TO SEE THIS. AS WE
THEN PROCEEDED. AND I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES BECAUSE HOW
IT'S AFFECTED THE PEOPLE I
REPRESENT THAT EVERYBODY FOR
THE LEGISLATION THAT HAS MOVED
FORWARD IN FACT THIS PAST YEAR.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS RESPONDED
BUT WE HAVE MUCH YET I HAD TO
DO. AND AS A STRATEGY FOR
CONTAINING CATACLYSMIC
WILDFIRES THE NEW NORMAL CANNOT
BE. PUBLIC SAFETY SUSPENSIONS
BUT POWER. THAT CAN NOT BE FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHAT A
DISGRACE IT THAT'S HOW WE'RE
GOING TO BE HANDLING OUR
BUSINESS AND THE MAGNET THAT
MAGNITUDE TO WHICH THIS HAS
AFFECTED INDIVIDUAL LIVES ALL
OVER CALIFORNIA. IS INTOLERABLE.
WE WILL BE RESPONDING. IN
MAKING THIS BETTER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU ARE WILL MOVE FORWARD
WITH OUR FIRST PRESENTER. OR
DID YOU WANT MAKES COMMENTS
OKAY. THANK YOU MISTER JENNER I
WANT TO ALSO THANK THE PRO TEM
AND ARE CHAIR FOR A PUTTING
THIS TOGETHER AND- IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL THAT WE ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE AND I DON'T WANT TO
BELABOR THE POINT I KNOW
EVERYONE TOUCHED UPON
EVERYTHING I WANTED TO SAY BUT
IN PARTICULAR. THERE'S SO MANY
STORIES IT ON HERE AND- BY WAY
OF EXAMPLE I GOT CALLS FROM
MANY MOTHERS WHO HAVE. STUDENTS
EITHER IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE STATE AND THE READING A
LITTLE APARTMENT THEY CAN'T
AFFORD FOOD AND I WAS ONE OF
THE BIGGEST ISSUE THAT I'VE-
CONSISTENTLY- HEARD FROM MY- MY
CONSTITUENTS THEIR KIDS WHO.
DON'T HAVE FOOD AND- AND THEY
DON'T HAVE POWER AND WHAT DO
THEY DO IT THEY COULD. AFFORD
TO. PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE SALE
THANK YOU FOR ADDRESSING THIS
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
TO ALL THE- SOLUTIONS
MITIGATION EFFORTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE WILL MOVE FORWARD
WITH OUR PRESENTATION. I'M
BEGINNING WITH ROSS BROWN HE'S
THE PRINCIPAL OFFICE SAID
FISCAL. AND POLICY ANALYST WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. AND HE'LL BE SPEAKING
IN ON THE. WHAT IS THE PSP AND-
WHAT. IS WHAT ITS HISTORY AND
WHAT HAS GIVEN ITS AUTHORITY TO
BE. IMPLEMENTED IN THIS PART OF
OUR FIRE FIGHTING STRATEGY FOR
THE STATE. AND JUST A LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT- RELATED TO
SIMPLY MEMBERS WOULD AND
AGUIAR-CURRY THAT ARE HERE
JOINING US FROM THE- PUBLIC.
MISTER ROSS MISTER BROWN SORRY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ROSS BROWN AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
I'LL BE OFFERING JUST SOME
COMMENTS AND BACKGROUND ON PS
PS AND THE AUTHORITY AND
GUIDANCE IN THE STATE ROLE- YOU
SHOULD HAVE A HAND OUT THAT
I'LL BE SPEAKING FROM HOPEFULLY
THAT WAS- YOU CONTACT IN
ADVANCE IF NOT THE SERGEANTS AT
A COPY SO PLEASE FLAG THEM DOWN
COMMENTS BRIEF GIVEN THE NUMBER
OF SPEAKERS YOU HAVE AND I'M
SURE GOING TO LET THESE ISSUES
IN MORE DETAIL LATER ON- I HAVE
BEEN ASKED TO COMMENT ON. ON
FOUR MAIN THINGS ONE THE
HISTORY OF THE AUTHORITY AND
GUIDANCE AROUND P. S. P. S.
ADVANCE TO THE STATE ROLE AND
IN PARTICULAR ON SOME OF THE
REQUIREMENTS- THAT HAVE BEEN
PLACED ON UTILITIES FROM THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
THREE SOME OF THE SUPPORTS FOR
OF HONORABLE RESIDENTS ARE
AVAILABLE FOR THEM AND DURING
P. S. P. S. OFFENSE AND FINALLY
SOME OF THE BUDGET ALLOCATIONS.
AND RESOURCES THAT WERE
PROVIDED IN THE MOST RECENT
BUDGET. TRYING TO PUT OUT AT A
HIGH LEVEL SO IF YOU TURN TO
PAGE ONE OF YOUR HAND OUT. WE
HAVE A- TIME LINE THAT- TOUCHES
ON SOME OF THE MAJOR
MILESTONES. GOING BACK. TEN OR
ELEVEN YEARS. AROUND PS PS
AUTHORITY AND GUIDANCE- IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT- AFTER SOME
SEVERE FIRES IN SAN DIEGO. SAN
DIEGO GAS AND A LESS ELECTRIC
REQUESTED- AUTHORITY FOR A PLAN
TO IMPLEMENT SHUT OFFS FROM THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
THAT REQUEST WAS. INITIALLY
DENIED. WITHOUT PREJUDICE- BUT
PC DID NOTE THAT- SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC HAD UNDER CURRENT LAW
THE AUTHORITY TO EMPLOYMENT THE
PROGRAM BUT THE PC TONIGHT FOR
THE SPECIFIC PROGRAM THAT WAS
BEING REQUESTED- SH SEVERAL
YEARS ATER ANSWER SOME FURTHER
ANALYSIS AND TWENTY TWELVE THE
PC ADOPTS. A GENERAL SHUT OFF
REQUIREMENTS FOR SDG AND GINNY-
SOME GENERAL REQUIREMENTS
AROUND NOTIFICATION AND SOME OF
THE CRITERIA THAT. UTILITIES
MIGHT USE SUCH AS- WIND SPEED
AND HUMIDITY ONE OF TRIMMING
WHETHER NOT TO SHUT OFF. POWER
FAST FORWARD TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AFTER SEVERE FIRES AS YOU ALL
KNOW IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
UTILITIES WERE CONSIDERING
IMPLEMENTING. E. S. P. S.
EVENTS- MORE FREQUENTLY. THE P.
C. ISSUED A RESOLUTION
EXTENDING SOME OF THOSE
REQUIREMENTS THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY- JUST. IMPOSED ON
SDG NEED TO THE OTHER I'LL USE.
LATER IN THAT YEAR AS YOU ALL
KNOW THE LEGISLATURE PASSED SB
NINE A ONE REQUIRING UTILITIES
TO INCLUDE YES YES- PROTOCOLS
IN THEIR WILD FIRE MITIGATION
PLANS. EARLIER THIS YEAR
SEVERAL IMPORTANT MILESTONES PC
IN RESPONSE TO THOSE SB NINE A
ONE REQUIREMENTS ISSUED SOME-
DISS A DECISION- THAT INCLUDED
MORE SPECIFIC GUIDANCE ON PS PS
EVENTS MOSTLY ON SOME OF THE
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS-
CUSTOMERS AND PUBLIC SAFETY
PARTNERS. AND COORDINATION WITH
SOME OF THOSE PUBLIC SAFETY
PARTNERS THERE'S A SECOND PHASE
OF- THAT THE PROCEEDING WHERE
THEY- PLAN ON GETTING INTO MORE
DETAIL AROUND. SOME OF PROCESS
SEASON CRITERIA THAT ARE USED
TO DETERMINE WHEN AND HOW THOSE
SHOTS OCCUR. THE LGISLATURE
ALSO PASSED A FEW BILL BILLS
THIS YEAR PROVIDING SOME MORE
SPECIFIC GUIDANCE ON THE PIECE
OF INFORMATION THAT SHOULD BE
INCLUDED- IN THE UTILITY P. S.
TS PROTOCOLS. AND THEN- FINALLY
IN IN OCTOBER AFTER SOME OF THE
PRESIDENT AND EVENTS- THE UC
STATED ITS INTENT TO RE EXAMINE
THE CURRENT GUIDANCE AND
LAUNCHED A FORMAL INVESTIGATION
INTO UTILITY COMPLIANCE WITH
THE GUIDANCE OF THIRTY IN-
ALREADY. IN THE REGULATIONS. TO
TURN THE PAGE TO YOUR HAND OUT-
BUT JUST A QUICK A HIGH LEVEL
SUMMARY OF THE STATE ROLE WITH
PARTICULAR EMPHASIS ON THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE IMPOSED ON
UTILITIES- AND SOME OF THE
GUIDANCE OFFERED JUST UC
PROVIDES GENERAL GUIDANCE FOR
WHEN UTILITIES MAY DEPLOY P. S.
P. S. EVENTS- SPECIFICALLY IT
SHOULD BE USED AS A- MEASURE OF
LAST RESORT- BUT I THINK. AND
PERHAPS THE KEY POINT HERE IS
THAT THE UTILITIES ABOUT THE
STATE DETERMINE WHEN AND WHERE
POWER IS SHUT OFF- A PC
PROVIDES GENERAL GUIDANCE
AROUND- KEY FACTORS TO CONSIDER
BUT IT'S ULTIMATELY THE
UTILITIES MAKING THAT DECISION.
THE PC DOES HAVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS AND
GUIDANCE AROUND NOTIFICATION-
BOTH TO PUBLIC SAFETY PARTNERS.
AND CONSUMERS ARE TWO TO THREE
NOTE DAYS NOTIFICATION- TO
PUBLIC SAFETY PARTNERS ONE TO
TWO DAYS AT LEAST NOTIFICATION
TO ALL OTHER CUSTOMERS. SHE
TURNED TO PAGE THREE ON YOUR
HAND OUT. JUST A BRIEF
DISCUSSION AROUND SOME OF THE
P. C. REQUIREMENTS FOR
UTILITIES TO COORDINATE WITH
STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES ARE SO
I'LL USE MUST COORDINATE WITH.
STATE LOCAL AGENCIES IN COURT
INCLUDING THE- GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
ARE SOME OF THOSE REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDE- ALLOW IN- YES TO AND-
PUT A LIAISON AND THE UTILITIES
EMERGENCY OPERATION CENTERS AND
MICE FOR SO. AND SO PROVIDING
ENSURING DATA- ON WHO COULD
POTENTIALLY BE IMPACTED BY THE-
THE POWER SHUT OFFS. AND
FINALLY PC REQUIRES UTILITIES
TO SUBMIT A POST EVENT REPORT
WITHIN TEN DAYS AND SOME OF THE
INFORMATION INCLUDING THOSE
REPORTS INCLUDES LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THOSE EVENTS. PAGE
FOUR OF YOUR HAND OUT INCLUDES
SOME ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON
ACTIONS TO MITIGATE THE IMPACTS
ON VULNERABLE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS- UTILITIES MUST
TAKE EXTRA STEPS TO NOTIFY
VULNERABLE CUSTOMERS- A LOT OF
THOSE ACTIVITIES REVOLVE
AROUND- MEDICAL BASELINE
CUSTOMERS TO- ENROLL IN A
PROGRAM TO RECEIVE DISCOUNTED
RATES BECAUSE THEY HAVE A PIECE
OF MEDICAL EQUIPMENT. THAT
REQUIRES ELECTRICITY AND SO A
LOT OF THE UTILITIES TAKE EXTRA
UTILITIES TAKE EXTRA STEPS TO
TRY TO NOTIFY. THOSE CUSOMERS
AND IN SOME CASES- ACTUALLY
GOING TO THOSE RESIDENCES AND
KNOCKING ON DOORS TO TRY TO
NOTIFY THEM OF THE OF THE
POTENTIAL PS PS OF AND-
UTILITIES ALSO HAVE COMMUNITY
RESOURCE CENTER SET UP- AND-
THE PC REQUIRES UTILITIES TWO
ASSISTS. CRITICAL FACILITIES
SUCH AS HOSPITALS. FIRE
STATIONS- TELECOMMUNICATIONS
PROVIDERS TO EVALUATE THEIR
POWER NEEDS DURING THE SHUT
OFFS AND IN SOME CASES WILL.
PROVIDE BACKUP POWER IF NOTHING
ELSE IS THERE. PAGE FIVE OF
YOUR HAND OUT- WE DON'T I DON'T
THINK IN THE HANDOUT DO JUSTICE
TO ALL OF THE RESOURCES THAT
ARE OUT THERE FROM- LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- PRIVATE- NONPROFIT
ENTITIES TO. HELP SUPPORT
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS I KNOW
YOU BECAUSE I KNOW A LOT- FROM
THOSE. FOLKS IN ORGANIZATIONS
LATER ON WE JUST WANNA FLY GOOD
THERE'S A WIDE VARIETY OF
RESOURCES THAT ARE OUT THERE-
ONE KIND OF STATE RESOURCE THAT
WAS RECENTLY IMPLEMENTED WAS
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY ESTABLISHED A.
HOT LINE. FOR VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS TO CALL IN AND- CASES
A P. S. P. S. EVENTS AND HAS
WEBSITE THAT HAS A VARIETY OF
RESOURCES AVAILABLE. TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE LOOKING FOR
INFORMATION- SINCE YOU'RE GOING
TO BE DISCUSSING THAT I'M SURE
LATER ON- MOVE ON FINALLY TO
THE- LAST PAGE OF THE HANDOUT
PAGE SIX. WE DISCUSS. TO SOME
OF THE KEY BUDGET ITEMS THAT
WERE IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET- THE
BIGGEST ONE BEING THE SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND ALLOCATION TO CAL-
YES. TO PREPARE FOR AND RESPOND
TO PS PS EVENTS- THE BUDGET
PROVIDED THE FLEXIBILITY TO
THAN MINISTRATION REGARDING HOW
TO ALLOCATE THAT MONEY. HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS ALLOCATED TO
HALF OF THAT MONEY TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS INCLUDING COUNTIES
CITIES AND TRIBES- SOME OF THE
OLDER WILL USES INCLUDE
PURCHASING- BACK UP ENERGY
SOURCES FOR ESSENTIAL
FACILITIES SUCH AS HOSPITALS-
DEVELOPING PLANS TO PROTECT
PROTECT VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
AND. DEVELOPING RISK
ASSESSMENTS OF CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND FINALLY-
JUST ONE OTHER BUDGET ITEM TO
NOTE THAT BUDGET INCLUDE ONE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION- TO FIND- EIGHT
POSITIONS TO CONDUCT OVERSIGHT.
OVER A AND IT'LL POLICY
REGARDING P. S. P. S. EVENTS-
PREVIOUSLY THERE WERE NO OF
STAFF AT PC DEDICATED
EXCLUSIVELY. TO PSP US
OVERSIGHT. SO I WILL IN MY
COMMENTS THERE AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ELSE WANT TO THANK
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FROM THE PRO
TEM FOR. BRINGING THAT URGENCY-
TO THIS OVERSIGHT PARTICULARLY
IN THE WAKE OF THE RECENT
INCIDENTS- A QUESTION FOR
MISTER BROWN I APPRECIATE YOUR
OVER VIEW I KNOW IT'S A HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED ARE THERE ANY
SPECIFIC OBLIGATIONS IN
LONGHORN PROTOCOL. FOR
COORDINATION WITH TELECOM
COMPANIES TO PROVIDE.
COMMUNICATION WITH THEM ABOUT
PLANNED SHUTDOWNS AND TO
COORDINATE GETTING GENERATORS
TO CONTINUE TO OPERATE CELL
TOWERS. IF I RECALL CORRECTLY I
THINK THERE WAS A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT JUST PASSED
THIS YEAR THAT- KIND OF SET UP
PUT SOME REQUIREMENTS IN PLACE
TO KIND OF FACILITATE THAT
COMMUNICATION AND TRY TO ASSIST
IN- YOU KNOW IN PROVIDING- AT
LEAST YEP COMMUNICATING WITH
AND TRYING TO ENSURE THAT THERE
IS BACK UP POWER AVAILABLE THAT
FACILITY AT THOSE TYPES OF
FACILITIES WELL I KNOW SPEAKING
FROM MY DISTRICT IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA. MONTEREY SANTA CRUZ
SANTA CLARA COUNTIES- THAT
COMMUNICATION. EITHER DIDN'T
HAPPEN- WAS SEEN ADEQUATE AND I
THINK PART OF THE PUBLIC
EMERGENCY ALL LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM- YES AND OTHERS-
IS COMPROMISED TWIN. THE
TELECOM COMPANIES AREN'T PART
OF. THE COORDINATION IN ALLOWED
THE ABILITY TO MOBILIZE
EMERGENCY GENERATORS TOOK TO
MAINTAIN COMMUNICATION. THE
LACK OF THAT COMMUNICATION. CAN
PUT LIVES AT RISK IT ALSO
CONTAINS WRAPPED OPERATIONS OF
SCHOOLS AND OTHERS THAT CAN'T
COMMUNICATE. WITH FAMILIES ALSO
RELATED TO THAT IS THERE ANY
REQUIREMENT OF COORDINATION
WITH SCHOOLS OR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- WITH PLANNED
SHUTDOWNS. I THINK SCHOOLS ARE
KIND OF INCLUDED IN THAT THAT
LOW'S LIST OF KIND OF PARTNERS
WHERE UTILITIES ARE REQUIRED
TO- COMMUNICATE WITH THOSE
PARTNERS WHEN THEY'RE PLANNING
ON- IMPLEMENTING A SHOT OFF- I
DON'T KNOW WHO. THE EXTENT TO
WHICH SORT OF THERE'S
COMMUNICATION AROUND- BACKUP
POWER- AT THOSE FACILITIES
MAYBE THE EITHER THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION OR
UTILITIES CAN KIND OF SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT MORE TO THOSE
DETAILS BUT ANOTHER AT LEAST ON
THE WEST OF KIND OF- OF
ENSURING THAT THERE'S
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN UTILITIES
IN THOSE FACILITIES. THANK YOU
IN AND I REALIZE THERE MAY BE
OTHERS BETTER EQUIPPED TO
ANSWER SOME OF THE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS- BUT REPRESENTING
LARGELY RURAL AREAS I THINK-
RESIDENTS IN RURAL AREAS FACE
DIFFERENT CHALLENGES THAN THOSE
IN URBAN AREAS- IN THE RECENT
SHUT DOWN THERE WERE SOME-
RURAL COMMUNITIES IN THE
SALINAS VALLEY. WHO WEREN'T
PROVIDED WITH ANY SUPPORT FOR
RESOURCE CENTERS FOR CHARGING
CELL PHONES FOR COMMUNICATIONS-
THEY WERE LEFT HIGH AND DRY AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING. HOW
WE PUT THOSE HOLES MOVING
FORWARD- MAY I BE THE FIRST TO
ACKNOWLEDGE I THINK EVERYONE ON
THIS DíAS. IF WE CAN. CHECK
CAN SAVE LIVES WITH A PROACTIVE
FOCUSED ENERGY SHUT DOWN
NOBODY'S GONNA STAND IN THE WAY
OF DOING THAT BUT WHAT TODAY'S
HEARING I THINK IS LARGELY
FOCUSED ON HIS WHAT ARE THE
PROTOCOLS AND WHAT ARE THE
COMMUNICATION ACCORDANCE AND
WHAT IS THE VOICE OF CAL FIRE-
WE S. IN THE STATE WORKING WITHTHE PRIVATE UTILITIES- IN THAT
COORDINATION SO. IS MY CALLING
SAID SO WE'RE USING A SCALPEL
IN NOT A SLEDGE HAMMER THE
STAKES ARE INCREDIBLY HIGH AND
I DON'T THINK WE CAN
UNDERESTIMATE THE NEXUS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE OF DROUGHT OF
LOW HUMIDITY AND HIGH WIND
EVENTS THAT ARE UNPRECEDENTED.
THAT SAID. THEY DON'T COME AS A
SURPRISE THEY'VE BEEN
PREDICTED- WE'VE SUFFERED THEM
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS AND
IT'S TIME TO STEP UP. OR
COORDINATED RESPONSE TO PROTECT
HUMAN LIFE. AND RELIABILITY
WITH. THE COMMUNICATION ASPECT
IS ONE THAT'S GOING TO RESULT
IN THE LOSS OF LIFE IF IT'S NOT
PART OF THE COORDINATED
RESPONSE SO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR COUPLE QUESTIONS IN A
STATEMENT BUT I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU CENTER
MCGUIRE. LISTEN SIXTY SECONDS
THERE ONE MORE WELL LEGISLATION
WILL TAKE EFFECT- AS OF JANUARY
HI NOW- TELECOM COMPANIES HAVE
TO INFORM AFTER TRIGGERED
EUGENE OFFICE EMERGENCY
SERVICES WITHIN ONE HOUR OF.
NINE ONE ONE GOING DOWN THAT
WOULD INCLUDE BOTH LANE CELL
PHONES I THINK THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE THERE IS
NO REQUIREMENT FOR REDUNDANT
POWER FOR BOTH CELL TOWERS IN
THE STATE- IS WELL AS LAND MINE
OPERATING CENTERS AND BE VERY
INTERESTED WHEN THE DIRECTOR
FROM THE OFFICE MOODY'S
SERVICES FOR YOU OF COURSE
MISTER CHAIR. COMES UP- LIKE TO
HEAR HIS POINT OF VIEW ON THIS
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS A
GROWING CONCERN IS A CENTER
MONIES ELOQUENTLY POINTED OUT
AND AT DEEPLY CONCERNED FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. CENTER STERN. FAMOUS
CHAIR MISTER BROWN I JUST WANT
TO GET A LITTLE MORE A GRANULAR
FEEDBACK ON THE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE'VE
APPROPRIATED. AS ANY THAT MONEY
GOING OUT THE DOOR YET. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THEY ARE
WELL I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION
THE ADMINISTRATION MIGHT BE
ABLE ABLE TO US THE KIND OF
ANSWER THAT QUESTION PROBLEM
MORE DEFINITIVELY THAN I AM I
KNOW THAT THEY'VE DETERMINED
THAT THE BUCKETS OF THAT WILL
BE USED BY A PART OF THAT
MONEY- IS JUST KIND OF
AUTOMATICALLY- ALLOCATED BASED
ON A FORMULA A PART OF IT I
THINK THERE'S SOME APPLICATION
PROCESS FOR PROVIDING THAT
MONEY- I DID JUST SPEAK MOSTLY
I THINK MY COMMENTS TO THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PEACE I WILL
SAY FOR THE- STATE GOVERNMENT
PEACE HALF OF THE MONEY WILL GO
TO STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS AND OUR STANDING
AS- THE ADMINISTRATION IS NOT
YET DETERMINED HOW THAT MONEY
WILL BE SPENT YET SO THAT'S
NOT. GONE OUT A AND WE CAN
FOLLOW UP ON THE NEXT PANEL IN
YOUR VIEW IS THE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE THIS
LAST UDGET YEAR SUFFICIENT TO
ADDRESS. THE OVERALL SCOPE OF
BACKUP POWER NEEDS STATEWIDE. I
MEAN I THINK. IF WE'RE GOING IF
I WERE EXPECTING SIMILAR LEVELS
OF OFFENSE GOING FORWARD THEN.
YOUR SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR BACKUP GENERATION
FOR. ALL AFFECTED CUSTOMERS IS
PROBABLY. YOU KNOW THAT'S
PROBABLY NOT ENOUGH MONEY FOR
THAT I GUESS YOU KNOW THERE'S
KIND OF IMPORTANT QUESTIONS
AROUND. NO ONE WHICH CASES
SHOULD. CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE
STATE BUDGET- HELP FIND THOSE
TYPES OF BACKUP GENERATION- AND
SO I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
KEY QUESTIONS GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISTER AMERICANS.
THANK YOU- A QUICK QUESTION
AND- CERTAINLY MISTER BROWN IF
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO ANSWER THIS
IT'S A IT WILL BE ON BOARD FOR
THE CPUC TO ANSWER WHEN THEY
COME UP. SO IN LINE WITH YOUR
REPORT AND PAGE THREE WHERE IT
TALKS ABOUT THE POST OF IT
REPORT WITHIN TEN DAYS. ARE YOU
AWARE OF WE HAVE RECEIVED THIS
REPORT FROM THE LAST MAJOR
EVENT. THAT TALKS ABOUT THE
POST EVENT REPORT. THERE'S A
VARIETY OF REPORTS FROM ALL THE
DIFFERENT UTILITIES OUT THE
POST EVENT REPORTS THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE ISSUED TEN DAYS
AFTER THOSE EVENTS THAT ARE
POSTED ON P. UC'S WEBSITE. I
DON'T KNOW WHETHER OR FOR THE
FINAL EVENTS WHETHER THOSE HAVE
BEEN. POSTED AT THE MOST RECENT
EVENTS WHETHER THOSE HAVE BEEN
POSTED YET BUT I KNOW FOR- A
LOT OF THE EVENTS THAT OCCURRED
THROUGHOUT OCTOBER THERE ARE
THOSE POSTERS AND REPORTS FROM
THE UTILITIES THAT ARE POSTED
ON THE- ON THE PC WEBSITE. OKAY
THANK YOU AND. ALSO THE
REFERENCE ON PAGE FOUR OF.
GENERATORS AND BACKUP AVAILABLE
FOR SOME FACILITIES NOT THE
UTILITIES ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE GENERATORS FOR
EVERYTHING. BUT SOME
FACILITIES. ARE I WOULD IMAGINE
THAT MEANS- HOSPITALS OR PUBLIC
SAFETY TYPE FACILITIES. AND
YET- JUST AS AN EXAMPLE I
REMEMBER AN ARTICLE. OF A WOMAN
WHO DIDN'T HAVE OXYGEN-
AVAILABILITY. AND CONTACTED A
LOCAL HOSPITAL AND WAS TOLD WE
CAN'T HELP YOU SO. I THAT WAS
PARTICULARLY DISTURBING AND I
KNOW THAT'L COME UP DURING
THE- LATER PANELS IN TERMS OF
HEALTH FACILITIES AND-
AVAILABILITY BUT WE GOT TO
CONNECT THE DOTS ON- IF THIS IS
A- RESPONSIBILITY. HOW ARE WE
CLOSING THE GAP ON THOSE
RESPONSIBILITIES AND
DETERMINING WHAT FACILITIES. I
NEED TO HAVE THAT OUT REACH TO
GET THOSE THERE. AGAIN YOU GAVE
US THE OF THE- FRAMEWORK AND
THOSE QUESTIONS WILL COME UP
LATER AND HOPEFULLY WE WILL GET
SOME RESPONSES. PARTICULARLY IN
LIGHT OF SOME OF THE STORIES WE
HEARD. THANK YOU. CENTER RUBIO.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT THE EIGHT
POSITIONS ARE YOU KNOW YOU
STATED HERE AT THAT TIME I WAS
SATISFIED FUNDING ONE POINT
THREE MILLION SS I PRAY
pREFERENCES ON PAGE SIX THAT.
THE POSITIONS ARE GOING TO
DEVELOP CRITERIA FOR EVALUATING
THE PROGRAM AND ENSURING THAT
YOU TWENTY COORDINATE WITH
FIRST RESPONDERS. I WANT TO
ADDRESS WITH MUCH MONIES AND
WHICH I BELIEVE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT JOB WHAT IS THE
REQUIREMENT TERMS OF THEIR
EXPERTISE. BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE
HEARING IS THAT WHAT HAPPENS IN
AREAS LIKE MISTER MINE IS
DIFFERENT THAN MINE ARE THEY
GOING OUT ACROSS. CALIFORNIA TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND. WHAT THE
NEEDS ARE. I'M SORRY. JUST TO
CLARIFY THAT PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION GOING OUT THERE TO
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS. I MEAN
THERE ARE AGAIN PROBABLY OVER
ARE MUCH MORE LIKELY TO BE ABLE
TO KIND OF COMMENT ON ON WHAT
THEIR CAPACITY IS AND WHAT
THEY'RE DOING EXACTLY AND I
THINK. THEY CLEARLY RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE WAS. A GAP IN
RESOURCES AVAILABLE- PRIOR TO
THIS YEAR- AND SO I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHERE THEY ARE IN KIND
OF STAFFING UP AND WHERE THOSE
A POSITIONS ARE. RIGHT NOW I DO
I WILL ALSO NOTE THAT THEY-
RECEIVE SOME FUNDING FOR
CONTRACTS AND SO I THINK
THEY'RE DOING SOME CONTRACTING
WITH SOME- THIRD PARTY ENTITIES
TO TRY TO IMPROVE THEIR-
OVERSIGHT AND PROCESS SEES FOR
TRYING TO KIND OF UNDERSTAND
WHAT ALL THE CHALLENGES ARE AND
HOW TO ADDRESS THOSE
CHALLENGES- BUT THEY'RE
PROBABLY. BETTER ABLE TO SPEAK
TO KIND OF WHERE THEY ARE IN
THAT PROCESS. I WILL THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR TRYING TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION. THANK YOU. OKAY
WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT A
PRESENTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER BROWN. WITH WE CAN ASK
CAROLYN LYNN THE CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER OF SENSE AND
SEND YOU GAS AND ELECTRIC TO
COME FORWARD ALONG WITH PHIL
HARRINGTON THE SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT OF TRANSMISSION AND
DISTRIBUTION FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON AND BILL
JOHNSON WELL THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER PRESIDENT
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC. ALSO
IF WE CAN ASK LAURIE JIM MONA.
WITH THE. ALSO WITH THE PACIFIC
GAS ELECTRIC CO SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT CHIEF CUSTOMER
OFFICER. AND SOON MEET SITTING
THE VICE PRESIDENT BASS AT RISK
MANAGEMENT COMMUNITY WHILE FIRE
SAFETY PROGRAMS. SENATE. SO WE
HAVE THE FIRST THEN WE'LL JUST
HAVE OKAY. MULTIPLE FULL HUMAN
VISUALLY THE RIGHT THE PLAN.
OKAY. THEN WE'LL HEAR FIRST
FROM US AND YOU GAS AND
ELECTRIC. IN WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CAROLINE
WHEN AND I AM THE CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER FOR SAN DIEGO
GAS AND ELECTRIC AND TO MY
RIGHT IS GOT KREIDER WHO'S OUR
VICE PRESIDENT CUSTOMER
SERVICES AND TO MY LEFT IS JOHN
JENKINS WHO'S OUR VICE
PRESIDENT ELECTRIC SYSTEM
OPERATIONS WITH MUCH OF THE
WILD FIRE AT RESPONSIBILITIES
WITHIN HIM. I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME
HERE TODAY TO ADDRESS THE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE USE OF THE
PUBLIC POWER SAFETY SHUT OFF
PROGRAM. AS A WILDFIRE
PREVENTION MEASURE. FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT IT ES DE JEANNIE WE'RE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
GOVERNOR NEWSOME. OUR
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS AND THE CPC
COMMISSIONERS TO REDUCE AND
MINIMIZE THE IMPACTS OF PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF. AS WE
CONTINUE ADDRESSING THE THREAT
OF WILDFIRES TOGETHER. WE
RECOGNIZE THE DISRUPTIONS THAT
POWER SHUT OFF BECAUSE AND CAN
HAVE ON EVERYDAY LIVES. ON
SCHOOLS ON BUSINESSES. A LOCAL
AND TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS AND
ESPECIALLY THE VULNERABLE
POPULATION INCLUDING THE
ELDERLY AND THOSE WITH SPECIAL
MEDICAL CARE NEEDS. AND WHILE
WE CONTINUE TO LEARN FROM EVERY
P. S. P. S. EVENT THAT WE HAVE.
WE MAKE IMPROVEMENTS BASED ON
THE FEEDBACK NOT JUST FROM OUR
EMPLOYEES BUT ALSO FROM OUR
CUSTOMERS AND OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS. AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE IS MORE WORK THAT WE NEED
TO DO. OUR WELFARE MITIGATION
PROGRAM HAS GONE THROUGH MANY
ITERATIONS AS WE INCORPORATE
NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND NEW
PROCESS SEES. BUT THE
FUNDAMENTALS FOR US HAVE NOT
CHANGED. AND THE REALLY FOUR
PILLARS THAT WE FOCUS ON. THE
FIRST ONE IS FOR CASTING FIRE
DANGER. ONLY OURS BUT OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY PARTNERS. AT SO
THAT WE CAN PLAN AHEAD. WE CAN
PRE POSITIONED RESOURCES. AND I
JUST OPERATIONS TO MINIMIZE THE
RISK AND RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES
EFFECTIVELY. NUMBER TWO IS
HARDENING OUR INFRASTRUCTURE IN
FIRE PRONE AREAS. TO BETTER
WITHSTAND THE EXTREME
CONDITIONS AND DEPLOY
TECHNOLOGY SO THAT WE'RE ABLE
TO TARGET AND TAYLOR NARAL
OUTAGES ONLY TO THE MOST
ENDANGERED COMMUNITIES. NUMBER
THREE IS OUR ABILITY TO
MITIGATE THE IMPACTS OF SHUT UP
THROUGH BROAD CUSTOMER OUTREACH
AND PUBLIC COMMUNICATIONS IN
COLLABORATION WITH OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
AND THE LAST ONE IS SERVICE
RESTORATION AFTER A P. S. P. S.
EVENT. NOW LET ME ADDRESS THE
QUESTIONS AT HAND. THERE WERE
FOUR SANTA ANA RED FLAG EVENTS
IN THE MONTH OF OCTOBER. THREE
OF THEM WERE BACK TO BACK IN
THE LAST WEEK AND A HALF OF THE
MONTH. OUR EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
CENTER WAS OPEN TWENTY FOUR BY
SEVEN. MONITORING WHETHER IN
GREAT CONDITIONS FOR ABOUT TWO
WEEKS STRAIGHT. AT THE HEIGHT
OF THE BAND'S AROUND TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND CUSTOMERS WERE
IMPACTED WITH THE AVERAGE OUT
OF DURATION OF TWENTY FOUR
HOURS. WELL THE WINDS WERE
SEVERE. FORTUNATELY AND ALL THE
EVENTS THEY DIDN'T LAST LONG.
WE SAW TYPICAL WIND SPEEDS
CONSISTENLY BLOWING AROUND
TWENTY TO THIRTY MILES PER HOUR
AND PEAKING AT ABOUT EIGHTY
MILES PER HOUR IN OUR HIGHEST
ELEVATIONS. ABOUT A HALF A
DOZEN WEATHER STATIONS RECORDED
ALL TIME PEAK WIND GUSTS. OUR
SYSTEM HELD UP WELL GIVEN THE
WEATHER CONDITIONS AND THERE
WERE NO MAJOR FIRES IN OUR
REGION. IN TERMS OF LEFT
LESSONS LEARNED. AFTER EACH PS
PS OF THAT. IT IS OUR STANDARD
PRACTICE TOGETHER FEEDBACK
AGAIN NOT JUST FROM EMPLOYEES.
BUT ALSO OUR CUSTOMERS ARE
PUBLIC AGENCIES AND OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS. ONE LESSON
THAT WE LEARNED IS THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE EVEN TIGHTER
OPERATIONAL PROTOCOLS WITH OUR
NONPROFIT PARTNERS. THIS IS SO
THAT THEY CAN DEPLOY RESOURCES
EVEN MORE RAPIDLY MORE
EFFICIENTLY AND MORE AND MORE
AND BROADLY TO HELP SUPPORT
THOSE WHO ARE AFFECTED BY POWER
SHUT OFFS. ANOTHER LESSON IS
WILL THAT WE LEARNED IS THE
WIDESPREAD NEED FOR BACKUP
GENERATORS. WE CURRENTLY HAVE A
PILOT OF SOLAR BATTERY
GENERATORS FOR MEDICAL BASED ON
CUSTOMERS. AND THIS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY RELY ON
THESE LIFE SUSTAINING DEVICES.
AND THE INITIAL FEEDBACK FROM
OUR PROGRAM IS VERY POSITIVE
HOWEVER IT'S QUITE LIMITED IN
SCOPE AT THIS POINT. IT'S CLEAR
THAT MANY OF OUR CUSTOMERS NOT
JUST THOSE THAT ARE MEDICAL
BASELINE CUSTOMERS ARE
INTERESTED IN OBTAINING
GENERATORS. AND WE ARE IN EARLY
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO AS TO HOW WE CAN
CREATE A BULL GENERATOR PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION WE'RE EXPLORING
WERE MAKES SENSE FOR US TO
BUILD. MICHAEL GRITS TO KEEP
OUR KEY COMMUNITY FACILITIES OR
CORD DOWNTOWN AREAS OPERATING
DURING POWER SHUT OFF SUCH AS
WHAT WE DID IN THE TOWN OF
JULIAN. WELL AS THE GENIE
CONTINUOUSLY INVEST AND
HARDENING ARE INFRASTRUCTURE WE
KNOW THAT OUR WORK TO MITIGATE
WILDFIRE AND THE IMPACT TO OUR
CUSTOMERS IS NEVER DONE. OUR
GOAL IS TO REDUCE OR ELIMINATE
THE NEED FOR. POWER SHUT OFF
THROUGH A STRATEGIC COMBINATION
AND PORTFOLIO PROJECTS
INCLUDING STRATEGICALLY UNDER
GROUNDING. INCLUDING THE USE OF
IT A CONDUCTOR THAT'S COVERED
WITH NON CONDUCTIVE MATERIALS.
INCLUDING ADDING MORE SEXUAL
ISING DEVICES AND MORE BACK UP
GENERATOR SOLUTIONS. WE'RE ALSO
WORKING TO EXPAND OF FALLING
CONDUCTOR PROTECTION TECHNOLOGY
THAT WILL PREVENT BROKEN WIRES
FROM BECOMING AN IGNITION
SOURCE. OUR ENGINEERS HAVE
FIGURED OUT A WAY TO CUT OFF
POWER TO A BROKEN WIRE BEFORE
IT EVEN HITS THE GROUND
ESSENTIALLY BEING GRAVITY. AND
THIS WILL DETECT AND SHUT OFF
POWER IN ABOUT ONE SECOND TIME
FRAME. NEXT YEAR WE'RE GOING TO
BE OPENING OF FIRE SCIENCE AND
INNOVATION LAB WHICH WILL BRING
TOGETHER LEADING THINKERS. AND
PROBLEM SOLVERS N ACADEMIA.
AND GOVERNMENT. AND THE
COMMUNITY TO CREATE FORWARD
LOOKING SOLUTIONS. THAT WILL
HELP PREVENT IGNITIONS.
MITIGATE THE IMPACTS OF FIRES
AND ULTIMATELY HELP BUILD A
MORE RESILIENT REGION. AN
ADDITIONAL AREAS WHERE WE NEED
RELIEF THAT LAND OUTSIDE OF THE
TO LEASE CONTROLS INCLUDE
STANDARDS FOR NEW HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS WITHIN THE HIGH
FIRE THREAT DISTRICTS. AND
STREAMLINED CONSTRUCT ABILITY
PERMITTING AND STREAMLINED AND
A LINE STATE AND FEDERAL.
ENVIRONMENTAL AND CULTURAL
PROJECT REQUIREMENTS. SO IN
CLOSING OUR COMMITMENT TO THE
SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITIES THAT
WE SERVE IS UNWAVERING. MOVING
FORWARD SB JANIE WILL CONTINUE
WORKING DILIGENTLY AT THE BROAD
RANGE OF UTILITY SERVICES
THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH FIRE
WEATHER EVENTS SUCH AS
AGGRESSIVE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT. WEATHER DATA AND
EVENT PREDICTABILITY. ALSO
SHARPENING OUR EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT CAPABILITIES AND
FINALLY IMPROVING EFFECTIVENESS
AROUND CUSTOMER AND COMMUNITY
COMMUNICATIONS. I'M CERTAIN
WILL CONTINUE TO SHOW UP TO
IMPROVE. EACH OF THESE AREAS.
BUT I THINK WHAT'S NEED IN
CALIFORNIA. IS THE THINK BEYOND
OURSELVES. THIS MOMENT IS
CALLING FOR SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
PS PS IS THE RIGHT SOLUTION FOR
RIGHT NOW BUT WHAT'S NEXT. I'VE
SAID AN APP ASPIRATIONAL GOAL
FOR OUR ORGANIZATION. NOT ONLY
TO REDUCE OR MITIGATE THE
THREAT OF WILDFIRES BUT HOW DO
WE ELIMINATED. AND I KNOW THIS
IS A LOFTY THING TO SAY BUT IT
S. P. JEANNIE. THAT IS OUR
NORTH STAR. AND WE ABSOLUTELY
ARE WORKING TOWARDS THAT. I
APPRECIATE THE TIME YOU'VE
ALLOWED ABOUT ME TODAY AND
WE'RE OPEN FOR QUESTIONS. I
JUSTWANT TO ASK YOU MENTIONED
THERE ARE NO MAJOR FIRES WHERE
THEIR FIRES YES THERE WERE
FIRES AND HOW DO YOU DEFINE A
MAJOR FIRE VERSES OF. OF WHAT
WE TALKING WITH BRUSH FIRES
WILL YEAH- I AM LIKE THERE THAT
CATASTROPHIC FIRES OKAY SO WE
DID HAVE FIRES- WHERE PROP
PERSONAL PROPERTY WAS LOST
DIRECT WERE THERE ANY LOSS OF
LIFE. NO NOT THAT I KNOW. OKAY
DO DO YOU HAVE ANY INFORMATION
TERMS OF MANY STRUCTURES WERE
AFFECTED BY THE FIRES- THERE
WAS A FIRE IN RAMONA WHICH I
HAVE TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO
CALIFORNIA WHO IS ON THAT VERY
QUICKLY. AND I DON'T RECALL HOW
MANY STRUCTURES WERE DAMAGE I
BELIEVE SOME OF IT MAY HAVE
BEEN SOME OUT STRUCTURES LIKE
BARNES AND- THINGS OF THAT
NATURE THERE'S ANOTHER FIRE
VALLEY CENTER DURING THAT TIME
FRAME. HAS A BUTTON TO DO AS A
BEEN DETERMINE WHAT THE CAUSE
OF THOSE FIRES WAS. NOT TO MY
KNOWLEDGE OKAY- CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU- SO YOU INDICATED
THAT YOUR- AVERAGE POWER SHUT
OFF TIME WAS TWENTY FOUR HOURS
AND WE KNOW THAT IN THE DE.
REGION THAT MIGHT BY ARE YOU
SERVICE IT WAS LONGER. AND
THERE WERE- AS FAR AS I KNOW
FROM LOOKING AT THE- WINDS DATA
HERE THE WIND- THE HIGH WIND
SPEEDS DID LAST LONGER IN THE
IN SME OF P. GENIES UTILITY
AREA SO THAT MIGHT. EXPLAIN A
LITTLE BIT FOR THE DIFFERENCE
IN TIME BUT COULD YOU JUST ASK
LEVERETT A LITTLE BIT MORE ON
HOW YOU WERE ABLE TO CHIEF A
WITH THERE WERE OTHER FACTORS
BESIDES WIND SPEED THAT ALLOWED
YOU TO ACHIEVE A SHORTER
DURATION OF AN OUTAGE AND
ADDITIONALLY- HOW YOU'RE ABLE
TO WHAT IT WOULD APPEAR. IS
MORE SURGICAL- IN OTHER WORDS
LESS CUSTOMERS CLEARLY YOUR
SERVICE AREA IS SMALLER YOU
HAVE LESS CUSTOMERS BUT AS A
PROPORTION YOU STILL TURN THE
POWER OFF OF A PROPORTIONATELY
FEWER SERVE YOU COULD JUST
ELABORATE A LITTLE ON WHAT
ENABLED YOU TO DO THAT YOUR- I
ARE YOU. YOU FOR THE QUESTION-
I WOULD FIRST START WITH THE
LAST PART OF YOUR QUESTION THAT
IS THAT- SINCE YOU THE
DEVASTATING FIRES IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN- WE NOT ONLY
HAVE BEEN FOCUSED ON TRYING TO
FORECAST FIRE DANGER. BUT ALSO
HARDENER INFRASTRUCTURE AND
PART OF HARDENING OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE ON THE
DISTRIBUTION SIDE OF THE HOUSE
BUT LOWER VOLTAGE SIDE. WE HAVE
BEEN. A THOUGHTFUL ABOUT
INSTALLING SECTION LICENSE
WHICH IS AND WHAT THAT'S ABLE
TO DO IS ONLY LIMIT. UP A SHOT
OFF TO KIND OF THAT THE MOST
ENDANGERED COMMUNITIES. SO WE
PAIR ARE SECTION LICENSE WHICH
WITH THE WEATHER STATION
BECAUSE SOMETIMES SOME OF THE
CIRCUITRY THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
BACK COUNTRY IS IN OVER A
HUNDRED CIRCUIT MILES LONG. AND
THAT NGUYEN CONDITION IN ONE
PART OF A CIRCUIT COULD BE VERY
DIFFERENT THAN A WIN CONDITION
IN ANOTHER PART OF THE CIRCUIT.
SO PUTTING MULTIPLE WEATHER
STATIONS ON A CIRCUIT AND
PAIRING IT WITH THE SEXUAL
LICENSE WHICH HAS PROVED TO BE
A GOOD PRACTICE FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO BE MORE SURGICAL AND
HOW WE- ARE ABLE TO SHUT OFF A
MORE NARROWLY. WHAT I WOULD SAY
TO YOUR FIRST QUESTION IS THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO PATROL BEAT TO
WE DO A 100% PATROLLING OF A
POWER LINE AFTER WE TURN OFF
THE SERVICE. AND THE REASON
THAT WE DO THAT IS BECAUSE WE
CAN FIND DAMAGE TO THAT
CIRCUITRY. AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE BEFORE WE RE ENERGIZE THAT
CIRCUIT THAT THERE'S NO DAMAGE
TO START ANOTHER FIRE. SO WE DO
A 100% PATROLS ON THE CIRCUIT
AND WE DO THAT EITHER BY FOOT
PATROL OR BY CAR OR BY
HELICOPTER THERE ARE CERTAIN
AREAS ESPECIALLY IN THE HIGHER
ELEVATIONS THAT YOU NEED TO PUT
A HELICOPTER IN THE AIR. AND
SOMETIMES THE WIND IS STILL TOO
HIGH FOR US TO GET A HELICOPTER
IN THE AIR SO THOSE ARE JUST
SOME OF THE FACTORS THAT GO
INTO THE TIME FRAME IT TAKES US
TO PATROL. BUT I CAN TELL YOU
THAT IN SAN DIEGO SERVICE
TERRITORY. THE WINDS WERE OF A
SHORTER DURATION SO WE WERE
ABLE TO MANEUVER OUR RESOURCES
ON THE GROUND AS WELL AS THE
HELICOPTER **** THAT WE HAD IN
THE AIR. TO BE ABLE TO WORK AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE TO RESTORE.
SERVICE TO OUR CUSTOMERS. ALSO
I JUST WANTED TO. THANK YOU FOR
COURT COURT NADINE INFORMATION
WITH OUR OFFICE WE GOT- WE
WERE- FACING A DAY LUCIEN CALLS
FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS AND A
GROUP. THAT INFORMATION WAS
VERY HELPFUL TO US TO
COMMUNICATING WITH THEM. BUT
ALSO WHEN AND BEING RESPONSIVE
TO THEIR NEEDS. I DID HERE IN
THE WITH THE WITH THE STATE OF
RADIO STATION AND I TUNED IN TO
THAT STATION AND I HEARD THAT
THEY WERE COMMUNICATING WITH
PEOPLE THAT WERE CALLING IN.
AND EXPRESSING CONCERN THAT
THEY HAD NOT BEEN NOTIFIED IN
THE TAPE THAT THEY HAD NOT
ABSENCE OF INFORMATION. COULD
YOU BRIEFLY- MAYBE TALK ABOUT.
WHAT YOUR IN THE PROTOCOLS ARE
IN TERMS OF INFORMING THE
PUBLIC OF THE- OF THE- SHUT
OFFS. AND IF YOU THINK THAT IT
WOULD BE PRUDENT AND THE WORK
ON THE FUTURE TO COOK
COORDINATED WITH SOME. RADIO
STATION. A TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO THE PUBLIC ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING AND HOW THERE
THERE BUT NOT NOT ONLY THE
POWER COULD BE AFFECTED BUT HOW
WHERE THEY CAN GO TO GET
SERVICES I KNOW IN JULIAN FOR
EXAMPLE THE POWER WAS KEPT ON
THE POOR AND COURAGE TO GO
THERE TO- GET HELP AND HAVE A
PLACE TO STAY WHERE THEY CAN
SPEND THE DAY- OR OR MAYBE EVEN
GET ACCESS TO ICE TO KEEP THAT
IN THEIR FREEZER SO THEY CAN
KEEP THEIR FOOD PROTECTED. CAN
YOU MAY BE A COMMENT ON WHETHER
YOU WORK WITH RADIO STATIONS
CAN THAT BE DONE IN THE FUTURE
OR WHAT IS THE PROTOCOL THAT
YOU FOLLOW THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS SENATOR HUESO I WANT
TO GO BACK TO YOUR FIRST
QUESTION LET YOU KNOW THAT THE
TWO FIRES I MENTION WERE NOT
UTILITY COSTS SO I WANTED TO
MAKE SURE I CLARIFIED THAT- I
WILL TELL YOU THAT IN TERMS OF
COMMUNICATIONS. WE THE GREAT
NEWS ABOUT WHERE WE'RE AT TODAY
VERSES WHERE WE WERE IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN IS WE NOW HAVE
DATA SO WE HAVE OVER TEN YEARS
NOW OF REALLY WHICH RICH
WEATHER DATA WHICH HELPS OUR
METEOROLOGIST BE ABLE TO
FORECAST WHEN AN EVENT IS
COMING SO SEVEN TO TEN DAYS IN
ADVANCE I'M GETTING
NOTIFICATION THAT WE MIGHT HAVE
A SANTA ANA RED FLAG AND
CERTAINLY AS THE MODELS RUN
TWICE A DAY. WE GET MORE MORE
CERTAINTY AS YOU GET CLOSER SO
I WOULD TELL YOU THAT CUSTOMERS
ARE NOTIFIED STARTING AT FORTY
EIGHT HOURS AND THEN AGAIN AT
TWENTY FOUR HOURS AND THEN WE
TRY OUR BEST TO DO THE ONE TO
FOR OUR COMMUNICATIONS
DEPENDING ON THE WEATHER
CONDITIONS AND OUR ABILITY TO
DO SO BUT OUR GOAL IS THAT NO
CUSTOMERS WILL BE SURPRISED WE
WANT OUR CUSTOMERS BE ABLE TO
PLAN THEIR LIVES TO PLAN THEIR
BUSINESSES TO PLAN AROUND
SCHOOLS AND SO THAT'S THE
THAT'S- A MAIN REASON THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT OUR
CUSTOMERS ARE NOT SURPRISED.
BUT EVEN BEFORE YOU GET IT WE
GET INTO A VAN I HAVE TO TELL
YOU THAT CUSTOMER OUT REACHING
AND PUBLIC OUR AND PUBLIC
COMMUNICATIONS IT'S A YEAR
ROUND OF AT THE TIME TO
COMMUNICATE TO CUSTOMERS. IS
NOT DURING AN EMERGENCY IT'S
ALL ACROSS. THE YEAR SO THIS
PAST SUMMER WE HELD. EIGHT
COMMUNITY RESILIENT FAIRS AND
WILDFIRE OPEN HOUSES IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE MOST
IMPACTED. SO THAT CONSUMERS CAN
GO AND GET INFORMATION ABOUT
HOW TO BE PREPARED FOR A POWER
OUTAGE WHETHER IT'S A P. S. P.
S. OR ANY OTHER POWER OUTAGE.
AND ALSO. WE HAVE SENT OUR
SENIOR LEADERSHIP TEAM OUT TO
DO TOWN HALLS AFTER PS PS
EVENTS IN THE MOST IMPACTED
AREAS. FOR ONE REASON FOR US TO
LISTEN TO CUSTOMERS LISTEN TO
THEIR EXPERIENCES THAT THEY
HAVE. SO THAT WE CAN HELP
SUPPORT THEM. SO IN TERMS OF
THE QUESTION AROUND RADIO
STATIONS I WILL TELL YOU THAT
WE SENT OUR DIRECTOR. OF FIRE
SCIENCE AND CLIMATE ADAPTATION
TO ALL THE TELEVISION STATIONS
TO. TALK ABOUT THE UPCOMING.
SANTA ANA RED FLAG EVENTS SO
THAT THERE IS A MUCH BROADER.
COMMUNICATION ON TELEVISION AND
YOUR SUGGESTION ABOUT RADIO IS
ALSO GOOD ON THAT WE WILL TAKE
BACK AND SEE IF WE CAN EVEN DO
MORE IN THAT AREA AND SOMETIMES
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO A
TELEVISION DURING THE EVENT
MIGHT HAVE ACCESS TO
TRANSISTORIZED AB THAT COULD BE
SOME. ADVERTISED IN THE FUTURE-
CENTER WILK THE ONE. THING
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I THANK
YOU FOR TESTIMONY ACTUALLY IS
VERY VERY IMPRESSED BY IT THAT
WAS JUST KIND OF STRUCK SO WE
HAVE ALL THESE MONOPOLIES
YOU'RE NOT DIRECT COMPETITORS
IN THAT RESPECT. SO IN TERMS OF
BEST PRACTICES DO YOU ALL
BETWEEN THE I. O. USED YOU GUYS
SHARE YOUR BEST PRACTICES WITH
THE WITH ONE ANOTHER AS WELL AS
WITH THE C. P. U. C. SO. OUR
RATE PAYERS GET THE BEST
SERVICES DELIVER TEST AS
POSSIBLE. YES SENATOR WILK WE
GET TOGETHER WITH A JOINT. I
OWE YOU PROGRAM WHERE WE SHARE
BEST PRACTICES AND NOT ONLY ARE
WE SHARING WHAT IS WORKING WITH
US IT YOU KNOW HISTORICALLY BUT
WE'RE LEARNING ALSO FROM P.
JEANNIE IN EDISON ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING. AND SEEING HOW
WE CAN INCORPORATE THAT INTO.
OUR E. S. P. S. AND FIRE
WEATHER EVENTS. SERRA KIDS.
WELL LET ME START BY THANK YOU
FOR KEEPING ME UPDATED AS WELL
I GOT TEXT MESSAGES MULTIPLE
TIMES DURING THE SANTA ANA
WINDS ABOUT ALL OF THE COUNTY-
AND MY AREA WAS NOT IMPACTED SO
I APPRECIATE THAT- GOING BACK I
GUESS I HAVE ONE QUESTION. WHEN
WE EXPERIENCE THE FIRES ARE IN
TWO THOUSAND THREE AND TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN- I GUESS I WANT
TO KNOW IN TERMS OF WHERE WAS
THE MOMENT WHERE YOU REALIZE
YOU HAD TO LOOK AT YOUR-
HARDENING AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND DID YOU AT
THAT POINT DEVELOP A PLAN BASED
ON THAT AND- I OBVIOUSLY WAS A
GREAT EXPENSE ON THE FRONT END
TO START TO DO THIS WORK. AND
THEN OF COURSE THE URBAN
INTERFACE BECAUSE WE HAD WHO
ARE OURS WAS URBAN WHEN WE LOOK
BACK AT RANCHO BERNARDO FRENCH
OPEN SKATERS THOSE AREAS UP
THERE- AND LOOKING AT AREAS
WHERE MAYBE THE UTILITIES NEED
TO BE UNDERGROUND AND WE HAVE A
NETWORK OF URBAN CANYONS. ARE
THE GO RIGHT INTO THE HEART OF
OUR CITY AND WE'VE HAD MAJOR
FIRES ALONG THOSE CANYON RAMS.
THE FIRE LONG AGO ON THE RAM OF
THOUGHT MISSION VALLEY OF A
NORMAL HEIGHTS- IT DATE COULD
AT I WANTED TO I KNOW WE'VE GOT
A LOT OF CONVERSATION BUT IN
TERMS OF. THAT DECISION AND THE
RESOURCES TO GO TOWARDS THAT
HARDENING- YOUR PLAN THEN AS
YOU STARTED AND WHERE YOU ARE
NOW- IN TERMS OF THE WORK YOU
STILL HAVE TO DO CAN YOU
COMMENT A LITTLE BIT ON. ON
THAT PLAN. THANK YOU SENATOR
ATKINS- THE DEVASTATING FIRES
IN TWO THOUSAND THREE AND TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN. TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN WAS A MUCH BROADER
POPULATION IMPACTED AND IT
BECAME PERSONAL ALL OF US. THIS
WORK SHOULD THERE BE THREE
EVACUATION THROUGH FRIENDS OR
FAMILY OR EMPLOYEES THAT LOST
THEIR HOMES- SO IT BECAME
PERSONAL FOR US AND I WOULD
HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT POST TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN THE DNA THE
COMPANY CHANGED IT REALLY
CHANGE FROM A CULTURE OF%
KEEPING THE LIGHTS ON WHICH
WE'VE BEEN VERY PROUD OF TO
KEEP OUR COMMUNITY SAFE. N.
WHEN I TALK ABOUT THE CULTURE
IT'S NOT A TOP DOWN CULTURE IT
WELL OURS FROM THE CEO ALL THE
WAY DOWN TO OUR EMPLOYEES ARE
ALL IN. BUT IT'S ALSO BOTTOMS
UP WE HAVE LONG TERM EMPLOYEES
THAT ARE FIELD WORKERS THAT
WERE ALSO IMPACTED AND THEY'RE
ALSO GIVING US IDEAS ON HOW WE
CAN MAKE OUR GRID EVEN SAFER.
SO I REALLY FEEL THAT FROM A
FROM A COMPANY AND A CULTURE
PERSPECTIVE THERE'S NOTHING
MORE IMPORTANT THAN EMPLOYEE
SAFETY AND KEEPING OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE. AND SO I WOULD
JUST TELL YOU HAVING GONE
THROUGH THOSE EXPERIENCES AND
HAVING SEEN THE CULTURE OF THE
ORGANIZATION CHANGE IN FRONT OF
MY EYES. IT IT THAT WAS THE
FIRE THAT ACTUALLY CHANGE THE
DNA EVER COMPANY AND WERE AND
EVERYONE HAS BEEN ALL IN. AND I
WOULD SAY THE FIRST THING WE
STARTED TO DO WAS HARDEN OUR
TRANSMISSION LINES SO THAT WE
CAN KIND OF KEEP THOSE ELECTRIC
SUPER HIGHWAYS- YOU KNOW SAFE
AND NOT HAVING TO TURN THEM OFF
IF. THERE IS THE HIGH WEATHER
EVENTS THEN WE GOT INTO OUR
METEOROLOGY AND WE STARTED
PUTTING IN THESE WEATHER
STATIONS BUT BACK AT THAT TIME
I WOULD TELL YOU THAT THERE IS
REALLY NO PRESCRIPTIVE PLAN AS
TO HOW WE SHOULD. DESIGN
ENGINEER CONSTRUCTOR EVEN
MAINTAIN OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
AGAINST THE INCREASINGLY
VIOLENT THREAT OF WILDFIRES.
THERE WASN'T A BLUEPRINT ON THE
WEATHER NETWORK SO IT JUST
BECAME ONE DECISION TO ANOTHER
DECISION TO ANOTHER DECISION
AND- YOU KNOW I'M I'M PROUD OF
THE WORK THE OF ALL FORTY TWO
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES AT OUR
COMPANY INCLUDING. OF SCOTT AND
JOHN AND NOT THE REMAINING FOUR
THOUSAND ALWAYS WE HAVE OUR
COMPANY THEY'RE VERY FOCUSED
ON. ON MAKING THE THREAT OF
WILDFIRES. SCOTT WOULD LIKE
ANYTHING. THANK YOU. IN CENTER
AND UNITES AT C. PROBABLY THE
YOU KNOW THAT THE REAL THE
OTHER AREA IS JUST MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE CONTINUING TO
INCREASE THE COMMUNICATIONS
WITH OUR CUSTOMERS SO. YOU KNOW
FOR US WE'VE BEEN DOING PS PS
LIKE ADVANCE BEFORE WAS CALLED
PS PS EVENT- PS PS FOR NUMBER
OF YEARS. AND I THINK THAT YOU
EIGHT YOU KNOW IS A YOU KNOW
WE'VE EXPERIENCED IT WAS NOT
EASY AT FIRST YOU KNOW SO THIS
IS REALLY TAKEN A LOT OF WORK
OF WORKING WITH. STRUCTURE
RURAL COMMUNITIES- WHETHER IT'S
JULIANNE OR VALLEY CENTER OR
CAMPO TO MAKE SURE THEY WERE
SPENDING A LOT OF TIME. AS
CAROLINE SAID HE ACTUALLY
HAVING OUR OFFICERS GO OUT
THERE AND SPEND TIME WITH WITH
WITH THE COMMUNITIES- MEANS
UNDERSTANDING KIND OF THE NEEDS
OF OUR OF OUR TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES IN IN SAN DIEGO AS
WELL. AND SO THE I THINK THE
EVOLUTION OF OUR WORK WITH OUR
COMMUNITIES- IT HAS HIS ALSO
IMPROVED AND REALLY WHAT WE
VIEW IT IS THE ONLY WAY WE CAN
BE EFFECTIVE THIS THROUGH
PARTNERSHIPS. TO OUR PARTNERS
YOU KNOW WITH THE WITH THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO- WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO TAP INTO- ACCESS AND
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS NETWORK
WORKING GROUP THAT THROUGH THE
COUNTY. TO REALLY START TO
EXPAND OUR OUT REACH. INTO A
YOU KNOW TO THESE THAT
SENSITIVE POPULATIONS TO MAKE
SURE WE CAN UNDERSTAND THEIR
NEEDS. AND WORK COOPERATIVELY
WITH THE- WITH THE RED CROSS
WHETHER IT'S TWO ONE ONE SAN
DIEGO MEALS ON WHEELS WE
RECOGNIZE AS A COMPANY- LONG
AGO THAT WE CANNOT DO THIS ON
OUR OWN. SO WE'VE GOT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE CONTINUING TO
EXPAND THOSE PARTNERSHIPS
SPECIAL WITH THOSE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO ALLOW US
TO BE MORE EFFECTIVE IN
REACHING OUT TO OUR CUSTOMERS
AND SUPPORTING THEM. AND LASTLY
IN ME JUST AS THIS IS MUCH
SHORTER- I BELIEVE I RECALL AT
LEAST SEVERAL DRILLS. THAT
INCLUDED ALL OF OUR ALL OF YOUR
PARTNERS THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO FIRST RESPONDERS FIRE
POLICE. HOW OFTEN DO YOU ENGAGE
IN THAT THAT TYPE OF OVERALL.
COUNTY WIDE DRILL ARE YOU.
STILL DOING THAT LET JOHN
JENKINS INCIDENT. THANK YOU
CENTER YEAH WE CONDUCT AT LEAST
AN ANNUAL DRILL WE INVOLVE ALL
THE COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND GO
THROUGH THE EVENTS AND THEN.
ALSO JUST GOING TO SAY THAT IN
THE ACTUAL VANS WERE VERY GOOD
A PARTNERING WITH PEOPLE WE
HAVE MEMBERS OF CALLAWAY YES
AND COUNTY AS COUNTY- YES THAT
COME INTO OUR FACILITY. AND ARE
PART OF OUR TEAM HELPING US
RESPOND TO THE SITUATION. WE
ALSO GO AROUND AND MEET WITH
WITH FIRE AGENCIES ON A MONTHLY
BASIS BUT THE FIRE CHIEFS I IN
PERSON. AND REALLY ARE TRYING
TO WORK TOGETHER TO- MINIMIZE
THE EFFECT OF THESE EVENTS TO
OUR POPULATIONS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
CENTER SKINNER. THANK YOU I
WANT TO DO TO LEARN MORE FOLLOW
UP ON THIS HARDENING QUESTION
AND THEIR PRO TEMAS APPS SO.
OUR C. O. O. FROM SD GENIE YOU
REFERENCED. IN THE ARE. IN YOUR
I THINK OPENING STATEMENT
AROUND SOME OF THE HARDENING
THAT YOU ALL ENGAGE IN AND THE
PRO TEM REFERENCED UNDER
GROUNDING OF THE LINES NOW I
THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT THE
UNDERGROUND COMPLIANCE IS QUITE
EXPENSIVE PER MILE AND WHEN YOU
DESCRIBE SOME OF THE HARDENING
THINGS THAT YOU DID YOU DIDN'T
MENTION THAT SO WHAT WHAT I'M-
CURIOUS ABOUT IS. WHAT WERE THE
COST EFFECTIVE HARDENING
INVESTMENTS THAT YOU MADE. AND
THE- THAT MIGHT BE ALTERNATIVE
WHICH TO WORK OTHER THAN UNDER
GROUNDING AND TO HAVE YOU FOUND
THOSE TO BE AS EFFECTIVE
POTENTIALLY ADDS UNDERGROUND
FOR EXAMPLE. I WOULD TELL YOU
THAT THE ONLY REAL 100% FAIL
SAFE WAY TO ELIMINATE THE
THREAT OF WILDFIRES FROM
ELECTRIC INFRASTRUCTURE IS TO
UNDERGROUND HAVING SAID THAT-
IF YOU'RE ABLE TO HARDEN YOUR
LINES WHICH IS REALLY IN OUR
VERNACULAR TO REPLACE OUR WOULD
POLLS WITH STEEL POLES. PUT IN
LARGER WIRE AND BIGGER SPACING
BETWEEN THE WIRES- IF WE'RE
ABLE TO INSTALL THIS FALLING
CONDUCTOR TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
ABLE TO EACH SHOT DETECT WHEN A
POWER LINE IS BROKEN AND SHUT
OFF THE POWER TO THE POWER
LINES THAT THE SECTIONAL ICING
THAT YOU REFERENCE TO KNOW IT'S
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THERE
THAT YEAH IT SAID. THAT IS
UTILIZED ON OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
AND WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
BUILDING THAT OUT BUT IT DOES
NEED A HIGH SPEED COMMUNICATION
NETWORK SO WE HAVE THAT THOUGH
THAT PLAN IN PARALLEL BUT IF
YOU ARE ABLE TO DO THE
HARDENING. AND THE FOLLOWING
CONDUCTOR TECHNOLOGY AND EVEN
REPLACING SOME OF THE BARE WIRE
WITH COVERED CONDUCTOR- WE DO
THANK YOU CAN INCREASE THE THEY
WIND SPEEDS IN WHICH YOU CAN
WITHSTAND. SO WERE YOU REQUIRED
TO LOOK AT IN IMPLEMENTED BEST
AVAILABLE CONTROL TECHNOLOGIES
OR WAS THAT A COLLECTIVE ON
YOUR PART. AT WITH THE THAT WAS
IT JUST THAT WAS OUR MISSION
AROUND YOU KNOW HOW CAN WE SET
A PLAN THAT OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
WOULD NOT BE THE CALLS A LOT A
WILDFIRE. SO IT REALLY IS US
GETTING TOGETHER IN OUR
OPERATIONAL GROUPS AND FIGURED
OUT WHAT ARE THE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES WEEK WE CAN USE
ONE OF THE OPERATING PRACTICES
THAT WE CAN USE. AND HOW DO YOU
REALLY COMBINE THESE IN LAYER
THESE SO THAT WE'RE ABLE TO CAN
WITHSTAND HIGHER AMOUNTS OF
WIND WIND SPEEDS. BUT DO YOU
CONSIDER THE SECTIONAL RISING
THAT YOU DESCRIBED OF FOR THE
POWER SHUT OFF. THAT WAS ONE OF
YOUR HARDENING ABSOLUTELY
HELLO. IN THESE INDIVIDUAL THE-
WOULD POLLS REPLACING WITH
STEEL THE SECTIONAL RISING AND
THE OTHER LINE TECHNOLOGY THAT
YOU DESCRIBED. ARE THEY- LESS
EXPENSIVE PER UNIT I SUPPOSE I
DON'T KNOW WHAT OTHER WORD TO
USE THAN SAY THE UNDER
GROUNDING THE ANSWER IS YES.
AND SO. WHAT WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT NOW IS NOT ONLY DOING
THOSE PORTFOLIO PROJECTS THAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT. AND
STRATEGICALLY UNDERGROUND A
WHERE IT MAKES SENSE BUT ALSO
THE USE A BACKUP GENERATORS
COULD BE A GREAT WAY TO IT IT
MITIGATE THE IMPACTS TO
CONSUMERS. SO YOU'LL SEE US DO
OUR PORTFOLIO THE PROJECTS
INCLUDING BACKUP GENERATORS BUT
JUST FINALLY THE YOU ALL THAT
WAS DONE IN EFFECT ON YOUR OWN.
SELECTIVELY VERSUS BY ANY KIND
OF DIRECTION YEAH WE WEREN'T
MANDATED SO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE HAD- CENTER CHIANG IN
THE CENTER STERN. THANK YOU SO
AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT UNDER
GROUNDING INFRASTRUCTURE AYE I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT
FUTURE CATASTROPHES LIKE
EARTHQUAKES SO WOULD-
UNDERGROUND IN WITH THAT
WITHSTAND EARTHQUAKES. YES I
BELIEVE THAT THAT WOULD THAT
WOULD WITHSTAND. IT DEPENDS ON
OBVIOUSLY THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
EARTH EARTHQUAKE BUT BUT YES IT
IT IS A IT WOULD BE A LA
TECHNOLOGY THAT WOULD ALLOW US
TO WITHSTAND MORE ENVIRONMENTAL.
CONDITIONS THANK YOU. CENTER
MORE LUCK THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- MISS WHEN YOU'RE FALLING
LINE TECHNOLOGY SOUNDS SIMILAR
TO WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
AUSTRALIA- THEY CALL IT POWER
DIVERT ERRORS OR A RAPID BIRTH
FAULT CURRENT LIMITER SINCE
THIS IS THE SAME TECHNOLOGY
IT'S A SIMILAR TECHNOLOGY LA
JOHN FEEL THAT THAT QUESTION.
THE IT'S A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
AND THAT'S- BROUGHT PROVIDING A
WAY TO. I'D EXTRA SINCE THE
PROTECTION FOR YOUR SYSTEM
UNDER CERTAIN CONDITIONS AND SO
WE HAVE A VERSION OF THAT IN
OUR SERVICE TERRITORY WHERE
WHEN WE GET INTO THESE
SITUATIONS WE ENABLE ALL OF OUR
SMART DEVICES ON OUR SYSTEM. TO
GO INTO HYPERSENSITIVE
PROTECTED MODE IF YOU WILL AND
ACTED THE FASTEST POSSIBLE WAY
TO LIMIT THE AMOUNTOF ENERGY
THAT CAN BE DISSIPATED- WHEN AN
EVENT OCCURS ON THE SYSTEM SO
THAT'S MORE ALONG THE LINES OF
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT FROM
FROM AUSTRALIA THE FALLING
CONDUCTOR IS MORE. A CONDUCTOR
BREAKS IN THE AIR AND WE DE
ENERGIZED BEFORE IT HITS THE
GROUND SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT. BUT THE SENSITIVE
PROTECTION AND I DESCRIBES MORE
SIMILAR TO A TO WHAT THE REASON
IN AUSTRALIA AND DOING OTHER
INDEPENDENT RESEARCH I SEE THAT
OVERHEAD LINES ARE IMPROVING-
WHAT KIND OF OUR PEACE IF YOU
PUT OUT TO IMPROVE JUST. THE
LINES. ON A ROUTINE MAINTENANCE
BASIS WHAT WHAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH- THREE
DIFFERENT MANUFACTURERS BIG FOR
US WE ALSO ON OUR LINES TO STAY
IN THE YEAR ONE AND WITHSTAND
HIGH WINDS ONE LISTING CONTACT
FROM FLYING DEBRIS- TREE LIMBS.
US WE WERE WE WORK WITH THREE
MANUFACTURERS TO PROVIDE A
COVER CONDUCTOR THAT HAS TO
STEAL STRANDS IN THE MIDDLE TO
PROVIDE THE EXTRA STRENGTH- AND
THAT ALLOWS YOU TO GO FROM A
CONDUCTOR THE HOUSE TWENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED POUNDS OF TINSEL
STRENGTH THE FORTY FOUR
HUNDRED- SO THAT'S WHEN THE
AREAS WERE WORKING WITH
MANUFACTURERS TO HELP. INNOVATE
AND IMPROVE THE TECHNOLOGY
THEIR- MEN LAST QUESTION IS
WHEN WILL TWENTY A- WHICH-
ALLOWS FOR BEAUTIFICATION SOME
UNDER GROUNDING. A BY- THE LAST
NUMBERS I HEAR FROM THE CPUC.
OR FROM DECEMBER OF FIFTEEN YOU
HAD A HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE
MILLION IN RESERVES TO USE
THROUGHOUT YOUR IN YOUR AREA.
HOUSE HOUSE HAVE BEEN WORKING
AS REGARDS TO TRYING. TO
BEAUTIFY ONE TO GET SOME OF
THESE. WILD FIRES OWN LINES
UNDERGROUND. YES PROBABLY OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS WE'VE
BEEN. WHEN THE TWENTY ETS ARE
REALLY THE CITY'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO DETERMINE.
WHICH LINES THEY WANT TO
UNDERGROUND. SO WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING IS WORKING WITH THEM AND
TALKING TO THEM ABOUT. WHERE
THE RISKIEST AREAS IN THE IS
CITY OR COUNTY WHERE YOU WOULD
YOU CAN UTILIZE THOSE FUNDS SO
THE CONVERSATION HAS TURNED A
LITTLE BIT AND THEY'RE ASKING
FOR FEEDBACK AND WE WANT TO
GIVE THAT FEEDBACK BECAUSE-
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR BEING A MODEL AS WELL
BEING- LOOKING AT SOMETHING FOR
MOST SEVEN AND MOVING FORWARD
SO I JUST WANT TO. COMMEND YOU
ON THAT SENATOR WILL DID YOU
HAVE ANOTHER FOLLOW UP QUESTION
I DID DâN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND THE AND THE PRO CAN
FOR OPENING THIS UP FOR
EVERYBODY BECAUSE THEY DO NOT
SIT ON THE UTILITIES COMMITTEE-
BUT I. I HAD A QUESTION- TERMS
A MICRO YOUR TALK ABOUT MICRO
GRANTS I DON'T SIT ON THIS
COMMITTEE AND I SURE WINNER
MICHAEL GRADIUS BUT I HEAR
ABOUT THAT ALL THE TIME IN. A
SITUATION WHERE AT A COUPLE
COMMUNITIES WITH THAT DIDN'T
HAVE A WINDOW THAT THAT WASN'T
BY THE FIRE AND THEY WERE
TURNED OFF FOR OVER THIRTY
HOURS. AND SO THEY HAD NO PHONE
BECAUSE IT NO LAND LINES IN
THERE'S NO CELL TOWERS THEY HAD
NO WATER BECAUSE IN HAVE ENERGY
BECAUSE EVERYTHING'S ON A WELL
SO I WANT TO LEARN MORE ABOUT.
THESE MICRO GRIDS IN IS A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL OR CAN YOU DESIGN
INTO A CERTAIN WAY OR I JUST
WANT TO. TAKE THIS INFORMATION
BACK FOR OUR NEXT SET OF
PANELISTS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION A MICRO GRID CAN BE
ANY NUMBER OF TECHNOLOGIES FROM
GENERATORS TO MORE RENEWABLE
ENERGY LIKE SOLAR BATTERIES
COMBINED TOGETHER- IN JULIAN WE
DO ROLL OUT AGE A GENERATOR
WHICH IS CONSIDERED AMICRO
GRANT. AND THE- WHAT WE HAD TO
DO TO GET JULIAN WHICH IS A
COMMUNITY AND OUR MOUNTAINOUS
AREAS TO GET THE TOWN A JULIAN
WITH ELECTRICITY DURING THESE
POWER SHUT OFF IS WITH THERE'S
A PAD SETTING FOR THAT
GENERATOR AND WE HAD
UNDERGROUND. CERTAIN FACILITIES
WITHIN THE DOWNTOWN JULIAN AREA
IN ORDER FOR THAT TO WORK BUT
WE ALSO HAVE A MIKE AGREED IN
ERIE THAT WE CALL BORREGO
SPRINGS WHICH INCLUDES A SOLAR
FOR SENATE FACILITY A GENERATOR.
AND A BATTERY SO IT'S ANY
NUMBER ONE OF THE. COMBINATIONS
THAT YOU CAN THINK ABOUT. A
CENTER STERN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR ASK YOU ALL JUST STANDARD
QUESTION I THINK FOR EVERY
UTILITY ON THE PANEL BUT SHE
YOU ALL GOING FIRST IN MANY
RESPECTS HERE NOT JUST ON
PANELS BUT IN TERMS OF GETTING
AHEAD OF THIS PS PS RISK WRIT
LARGE SO VERY QUICKLY- HOW MANY
MEDICAL BASELINE CUSTOMERS DO
YOU HAVE. GIVE A NUMBER THERE
SO IN OUR HEART OUR HIGH FIRED-
THREAD AREAS WE HAVE ABOUT
NINETEEN THOUSAND NINETEEN
THOUSAND AND OVERALL- DESK I'D
I'D HAVE TO GET BACK THE EXACT
SO WHEN YOU'RE HIGH FIRE THREAT
AREAS ABOUT NINETEEN THOUSAND.
AND HOW BIG DO YOU THINK THE
OVERALL SAY AYE HSS SERVE
MEDICALLY VULNERABLE POPULATION
IS WITHIN THOSE AREAS LARGER
THAN THE NINETEEN THOUSAND I
WOULD SAY IT'S CERTAINLY LARGER
THAN NINETEEN AT THE INTER
POINT IT'S- YOU KNOW WE USE
MEDICAL BASS LINE THAT'S THAT'S
A RATE THAT OUR CUSTOMER SIGN
UP ON BUT WE- FULLY ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT. MEDICALLY SENSITIVE
CUSTOMERS THATPOPULATION GOES
FAR BEYOND WHAT OUR MEDICAL
BASELINE POPULAR WHAT COULD
WHAT DO YOU NEED TO GET TO MORE
THOSE PEOPLE YEAH SO YOU KNOW I
THINK IN THE ERROR IT IS AND
WE'VE BEEN TALKING TO THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO ABOUT THIS
IT'S- YOU KNOW HOW CAN WE SHARE
DATA. WHILE STILL PROTECTING
CUSTOMER PRIVACY SUPPOSE WE GOT
ABSOLUTELY MAKE SURE- THAT
OCCURS AND- BECAUSE THE COUNTY
MAY HAVE OTHER TYPES OF
DATABASES AND INFORMATION WHERE
WE CAN START TO SINK THOSE TWO
UP WHERE. WE KNOW WERE MEDICAL
BASELINE CUSTOMERS ARE- BUT THE
COUNTY MAY HAVE OTHER
POPULATIONS- ALSO IT'S
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH AGAIN
WE HAVE A- ACCESS AND
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS WORKING GROUP
IN THE IN THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO. AND THAT'S WORKING WITH
THEM TO ALSO UNDERSTANDING
WHERE THEIR POPULATIONS ARE
BECAUSE THEY ALL HAVE THEIR
OWN- YOU KNOW- GROUPS THAT THEY
WORK WITH AND CUSTOMERS AND SO
I THINK THROUGH THOSE TYPES OF
PARTNERSHIPS THAT'S WE'RE GOING
TO REALLY BE ABLE TO. IDENTIFY
THE AT RISK POPULATIONS AND
REALLY TO BUILD BUILD
MITIGATION PLANS AROUND. THE IN
AND THIS IS AN AREA I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT WE CAN'T BE GOOD
AND OFTEN AND YOU KNOW WE NEED
TO CONTINUE TO AMPLIFY OUR
MESSAGE. IN THE CHANNELS IN
WHICH TUMORS SEE THE
INFORMATION AND IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY A PHONE CALL FROM
US OR AN EMAIL OR TEXT FROM US.
SO AS SCOTT MENTIONED IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO HAVE
VERY TIGHT CONNECTIONS WITH OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND THE A. F. AND WORKING GROUP
WHICH- YOU KNOW I KNOW OUR
ORGANIZATION HAD OVER FIFTY.
MEETINGS WITH. WITH A IF AND
KIND OF PARTNER. TO BE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THEM. OUR
PROGRAM WHAT WE DO AND HOW THEY
CAN BEST PREPARE. UNDERSTOOD
AND THEN BRIEFLY YOUR YOU
MENTION MICRO GRIDS. WHEN I
JUST GET A SENSE OF YOUR
POSITION WE ALREADY PASSED SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE A FEW
YEARS AGO WHICH- GIVES THE P.
YOU SEE A FORTY TO PROMOTE. AND
FACILITATE MICRO GRIDS BOTH.
BEHIND THE METER AND IN FRONT
OF THE METER THE GRADE LEVEL SO
WHEN YOU GET A SENSE OF- YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON WHETHER AN
EMERGENCY TARIFF. OR SOME OTHER
EXPEDITED PROCESS A P. YOU SEE
MAKE SENSE. EITHER FOR BEHIND
THE METER MAKER GRADE I NAY
BILLING OR IN FRONT OF ME. WHY
DO YOU REALLY BELIEVE THAT THE
NOTION OF GENERATORS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR CUSTOMERS TO BE
ABLE TO MITIGATE THE IMPACTS
OF. POWER SHUT OFFS. AND SO
YOU'LL SEE IN OUR UPCOMING
WELFARE MITIGATION PLAN THAT WE
WANT TO INCREASE. THE PILOT
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE FOR OUR
MEDICAL BASELINE CUSTOMERS WITH
THIS. SOUL OR BATTERY
GENERATOR. BECAUSE THE FEEDBACK
FROM CUSTOMERS HAS BEEN. VERY
VERY POSITIVE. THEM BEING ABLE
TO PLUG IN THEIR LIFE SAVING
DEVICES INTO THIS YOU KNOW
FIFTY HOUR SO BATTERY SO.
YOU'LL SEE US REALLY RAMP THAT
PROCESS UP. AND IN TERMS OF
ACTION ALLOWING BEHIND THE
METER CUSTOMERS TO ADOPT THEIR
OWN. GENERATION SO NOT NOT
OWNED BY YOU BUT OWN BY THIRD
PARTIES BEHIND THE METER.
OPENNESS TO THAT- WELL I DON'T
KNOW WHERE YOU POSITION IS THE
PC RIGHT NOW. YEAH I THINK
CENTER- SO LIKE I MEAN I THINK
IN ALL THESE AREAS WERE WHAT
WERE WE WERE WILLING AND OPEN
HAVE A CONVERSATION- WITH YOU
WITH YOUR OFFICE- WITH OUR
REGULATORS IN SN FRANCISCO NOT
SEE WITH COMMUNITY SEMI TODAY
WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF
TERRORISTS AND- AND OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO CUSTOMERS AT THE
WANT INSTALL SOLAR. THEY WANT
INSTALL INSTALL BATTERY BACKUP
SO THERE ARE READY TERRACE IN
PLACE TODAY FOR CUSTOMER OWN
GENERATION. BUT YOU KNOW WE'RE
CERTAINLY OPEN TO A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT COULD
BE NEXT IF THERE'S ANY NEW
IDEAS OUT THERE. SHE THEN I
WANT TO COMMEND YOU FOR GETTING
PROACTIVE. I LAST SESSION I
KNOW WE WEREN'T SUCCESSFUL IN
PUSHING IT THROUGH BUT
HARDENING THOSE CRITICAL
CIRCUITS. AND REALLY PUSHING
FOR A MICRO GRIDS AGAIN AT THE
GRADE LEVEL SO THIS CRITICAL
CIRCUITS DON'T GO DOWN AND THEN
ALSO THE BROADER COMPROMISE
LOOKING BEHIND THE METERS WELL
IN A COMBINATION THOSE TOO SO.
SHE THEN UNDER REPEAL. THANK
YOU. WAS HE HEARD MY QUESTION
EARLIER I WAS REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT YOU KNOW HAVING PEOPLE
NOT UNDERSTAND DID THE
DEMOGRAPHICS ARE THE AREAS THAT
THEIR SERVICE IN BUT I DID HEAR
YOU SAY THAT YOU WERE AHEAD IN
TERMS OF FIVE HAVING SOME OF
THE OFFICERS GO OUT AND SPEND
TIME WITH THE COMMUNITIES-
UNDERSTAND TRIBAL GROUPS AND
ALSO MAKE SURE THAT THE
SENSITIVE POPULATIONS WERE
BEING ADDRESSED AND TAKING CARE
OF WHICH I REALLY COMMEND YOU
FOR BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S A
BIG BIG ISSUE HI JUST WANTED TO
SPEAK IF YOU. CAN IN TERMS OF
THE TRIAL AND ERROR SO YOU'VE
ALREADY EXPERIENCE IN ENGAGING
WITH THESE COMMUNITIES WERE
SPECIFICALLY IF YOU CAN GIVE
EXAMPLES WITH BY THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITY. HOW ARE YOU WORKING
WITH THEM. BUT I WOULD SAY A
LET ME START AND THEN SCOTT YOU
CAN YOU CAN ADD IN HERE. IN
TERMS OF THE TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
WE HAVE A TRIBAL A NEW POSITION
PROBABLY WITH THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS. WHICH IS THE TRIBAL
LIAISON. AND THIS PERSON HAS
BEEN OUR POINT CONTACT WITH ALL
OF THE- AND- THE TRIBAL. TRIBAL
ORGANIZATIONS WITHIN THE
SERVICE TERRITORY. AND THAT HAS
BEEN A GREAT HELP FOR US IN
TERMS OF REALLY OPENING UP THE
COMMUNICATIONS. AND WE HAVE
CONVERSATIONS EVEN BEFORE WE
HAVE A POWER SHUT OFF ABOUT.
THEIR RATIONS HOW LONG WHAT
DOES IT LOOK LIKE SO THAT THEY
CAN PREPARE MORE. I WOULD ALSO
SAY THAT- AT SD JEANNIE WE HAVE
A NEW- WILDFIRE COMMUNITY
SAFETY COUNCIL. BECAUSE
LITERALLY EIGHT- WE'RE ALWAYS
OPEN TO NEW IDEAS AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE ARE KEEPING OUR
PROGRAM FRESH. SO WE HAVE A
WILD FIRES. COMMITTEE SAFETY
PER COUNCIL WHICH BRINGS
TOGETHER TEN INDIVIDUALS WITHIN
OUR OUR- SERVICE TERRITORY.
INCLUDING THE CHAIRMAN FROM THE
TRIBAL. AREAS TO BE ABLE TO
COME ON TOUR A COMMITTEE INCOME
UNDER COUNSEL HERE WHAT WE DO
AND GIVE US RECOMMENDATIONS SO.
WE'RE ALL ABOUT LISTENING. TO
OUR COMMUNITIES LISTENING TO
CUSTOMERS. AND SEEING HOW WE
CAN MAKE SURE. THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THEIR EXPERIENCES
AND HOW WE CAN HELP THEM. THANK
YOU FOR THAT. VERY WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THE ROSTER
NEXT TEAM FROM EDISON TO COME
FORWARD NOW
. WELCOME THANKS FOR
BEING HERE THANKS VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING OUR AXES GOOD
AFTERNOON NOW WELL MADAM PRO
TEM ATKINS AND TEAR HUESO.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
SENATORS IN ATTENDANCE ON CELL
HARRINGTON TO SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT OF TRANSMISSION
DISTRIBUTION FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON. I AM PROUD
TO REPRESENT THE TWELVE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED WOMEN AND
MEN ABOUT C. E. WHO STEADFASTLY
SERVE OUR FIVE MILLION
CUSTOMERS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING AND
ALLOWING THE OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO SHARE THE PROGRESS WE'RE
MAKING AND WHILE FIRE
MITIGATION DISCUSS RECENT
PUBLIC SAFETY POWERSHOT OFFICER
PS PS ACTIVITY. NOT FIRST I'D
LIKE TO KNOWLEDGE OF
FIREFIGHTERS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS WHO WORK AROUND THE
CLOCK IN THE MOST DANGEROUS
CONDITIONS TO SAVE OUR
COMMUNITIES SO FOR THEM OFFER A
HEARTFELT THANK YOU- TO OUR
NEIGHBORS WHO HELP EACH OTHER
EVACUATE. SAFELY TO OPEN YOUR
DOORS TO STRANGERS THANK YOU.
MADISON E. REMAIN COMMITTED TO
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT- MUCH
LIKE SAID YOU'RE GONNA GET GAS
ELECTRIC JUST HEARING AND IN
THAT SPIRIT WHILE I'M HERE TO
BRIEF YOU. I'M ALSO HERE TO
LISTEN. NOW WE WELCOME IN VALUE
FEEDBACK. TO ALL OF US FIRST
RESPONDERS CITIES COUNTIES
UTILITIES. AND THE PUBLIC ARE
DROPPING TO START A WILDFIRE
THE SAME TIME. NOW DIALOGUES
LIKE THIS ARE IMPORTANT AS WE
CONTINUE TO CONFRONT THIS MULTI
FACETED CHALLENGE FOR US. AS
CNN STANDS THE PS PS CAN BE
DIFFICULT FOR OUR CUSTOMERS AND
HARDSHIP FOR MANY. OUR USED PS
PS TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC. NOW
WE DO SO ONLY VERY SERIOUS
WEATHER CONDITIONS AND WHEN WE
DO THIS BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IS
NECESSARY TO REDUCE THE REST
ARE ELECTRIC EQUIPMENT STARTS A
FIRE. NO WELL BEFORE THE
INCREASING THE RISK OF
WILDFIRES WAS APPARENT WE ARE
INVESTNG IN A SMARTER STRONGER
GRID. OVER THIS LAST DECADE
WE'VE INVESTED TWENTY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS ARE ELECTRIC
SYSTEM. NOW OVER THE PAST
DECADE WE'VE ALSO INVESTED
ELEVEN BILLION FOCUSED ON
MAINTAINING AS A SUBSET THAT
TWENTY SEVEN BILLION. UPGRADING%
MODERNIZING THE GRADE WAS STATE
OF THE ART TECHNOLOGY IMPROVES
RELIABILITY AND RESILIENCY WELL
HAVING THE ADDED VALUE REDUCING
THE SCOPE AND SCALE TIAS
OFFENSE. THESE EVENTS ARE THESE
INVESTMENTS ALLOWS TO SECTION
LIES ARE SYSTEM SUBSTANTIALLY
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF CUSTOMERS
THAT COULD BE IMPACTED. NOW THE
FIVE MILLION CUSTOMERS IN OUR
SERVICE AREA WASN'T A HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR TWO PERCENT. OR
IMPACT IN OUR MOST SEVERE EVENT
THIS YEAR. OUR NUMBERS VERY
SIMILAR THE SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC NUMBER YOU JUST HEARD.%
THAT SAID IF YOU'RE A CUSTOMER
WHO'S BEEN IMPACTED BY P. S. P.
S. R. BILLION SECTIONAL IS A
GREAT DOESN'T MINIMIZE ARCHIE
FACE. AND RECOGNITION OF THAT
DIFFICULTY OR ACTIVELY WORKING
WITH CUSTOMERS AND COMMUNITIES
TO DETERMINE HOW WE CAN
MINIMIZE THE IMPACT YES BE YES.
AND THROUGH GREAT HARDENING AND
OPERATIONAL CHANGES REDUCE THE
NECESSITY OF THEM OVER TIME.
THE TODAY I WILL PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON THE PROGRESS FOR
MITIGATION EFFORTS DISCUSS
RECENT PS PS EVENTS. AND
LESSONS LEARNED AND AREAS WERE
ADAPTING APPROACH BASED ON
CUSTOMER FEEDBACK IT'S CRITICAL
TO US. KEEPING PS PS IN CONTEXT
IS JUST ONE OF THE WAYS THAT
SEIZE ADAPTING TO A CHANGING
CLIMATE REDUCING THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT OUR EQUIPMENT WILL CAUSE
THE CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES. I
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE ALLOW FOR
MITIGATION PROGRESS BECAUSE THE
CLEAR LINKAGE BETWEEN
MITIGATION AND PSP S. ACTIVITY.
NOW WE REMAIN LASER FOCUSED ON
IMPLEMENTING OUR WHILE FAR
MITIGATION PLAN AGREED SAFETY
RESILIENCY PROGRAM TO BOLSTER
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS. FURTHER
HARDENER INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ENHANCE OUR OPERATIONAL
PRACTICES IN HIGH FIRE RISK
AREAS. NETWORKS ALREADY THESE
EFFORTS AS WE WAIT TO SEE IF
YOU SEE DECISION OR APPROVAL
FOR THESE PROGRAMS. THAT WE
DEPLOYED FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY
NINE OF OUR PLAN EIGHT HUNDRED
FIFTY WEATHER STATIONS TO
MONITOR TEMPERATURE WIND SPEEDS
AND HUMIDITY LEVELS. THE REAL
TIME DATA THEY PROVIDE IS
CRITICAL AN INVALUABLE TO US
ESPECIALLY P. SPS OFFENSE. NOW
WE'RE ON TRACK TO COMPLETE THE
INSTALLATION ARE PLANNED ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY HIGH DEFINITION
CAMERAS TO MORE QUICKLY DETECT
FIRE MISSIONS. BY THE END OF
THIS YEAR WILL HAVE COVERAGE
ACROSS 90% OF OUR HIGH FIRE
RISK AREAS. NOW WE ILLOWS
INSTALLED FOUR HUNDRED MILES OF
INSULATED OR COVER CONDUCTOR
WIRE BY THE END OF THIS MONTH.
UNLIKE BARE WIRE WHICH IS
INDUSTRY STANDARD SHOULD A TREE
BRANCH POMPON MYLAR BALLOON
BROTHER VEGETATION COMING
CONTACT WITH AN INSULATED LINE.
IT WILL NOT CREATE A SPARK THAT
COULD CAUSE A FIRE. IF ARE
PENDING GENERAL RATE CASES
APPROVED WE WILL INSTALL SIX
THOUSAND MILES OF COVER
CONDUCTOR BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. SIX THOUSAND
MILES. THREE YEARS AHEAD OF OUR
ORIGINAL PLAN AND FOCUSED ON
THE HIGHEST RISK AREAS FIRST OR
FOCUS ON THOSE INITIALLY TO
REDUCE RISK AS QUICKLY AS WE
CAN. NO WE'VE INSTALLED FAST
ACTING FUSES IT MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND LOCATIONS OVER THIS
LAST YEAR AND A HALF WITH PLANS
TO UPGRADE THOUSANDS MORE. OF
THESE FUSES VERY QUICKLY
ISOLATE PROBLEMS AND ELIMINATE
THE POTENTIAL SOURCE OF
IGNITIONS. AND ALSO LIMIT THE
NUMBER OF CUSTOMERS AFFECTED BY
AN OUTAGE FORMA SECTIONALS
ATION. ALL THIS TECHNOLOGY
DESIGNED TO SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE THE CHANCE OF FIRES FROM
UTILITY EQUIPMENT. AND REDUCE
THE NEED FOR PS PS. NEXT I'D
LIKE TO TURN TO PSP INCIDENT
SPECIFICALLY HOW WE MAKE DINNER
JASON DECISIONS AND LESSONS WE
LEARNED FROM CUSTOMER FEEDBACK.
OCTOBER WAS A MONTH OF HARD
HEIGHTENED FIRE RISK ACROSS THE
STATE. DURING THE LAST WEEK OF
THE MONTH FEROCIOUS SANTA ANA
WINDS PROMPTED THE MEASURE
NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE. TO
ISSUE AN UNPRECEDENTED EXTREME
RED FLAG WARNING FOR MUCH OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. IN THIS
PARTICULAR FIRE WEATHER EVENT
ARE MOST SEVERE TO DATE. WE
NOTIFIED MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND CUSTOMERS OF
POSSIBLE P. S. P. S. AND DINNER
JUDGE JUST UNDER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS. FOR THIS
EVENT AND OTHERS THAT OCCURRED
THIS YEAR WE USE GRANULAR WE'LL
TIME WEATHER INFORMATION TO DE
ENERGIZED SECTIONS RATHER THAN
THE ENTIRE LENGTH. OF CIRCUITS
THE PAST INVESTMENTS THOSE I
SPOKE OF EARLIER. HAVE A
QUICKER CIRCUITS IN HIGH FIRE
RISK AREAS TO HAVE AN AVERAGE
OF FOUR ISOLATION POINTS
PROVIDING THE ABILITY TO
ISOLATE PORTIONS OF THE
CIRCUIT. AND A SIGNIFICANT
DECREASE THE NUMBER OF IMPACTED
CUSTOMERS. THESE ARE TWO
IMPORTANT ASPECTS OF OUR PS PS
PROGRAM. THE ABILITY TO MAKE
THE ENERGIES INCISIONS BASED ON
ACTUAL CONDITIONS ON A CIRCUIT
BY CIRCUIT BASIS. AND THE USE
OF TECHNOLOGIES TO MINIMIZE THE
NUMBER OF IMPACTED CUSTOMERS.
WE RECOGNIZE GENERALIZATION MAY
BE SIGNIFICANT HARDSHIP IS A
SIGNIFICANT HARDSHIP FOR OUR
CUSTOMERS BUT IT SERVES A VITAL
PURPOSE. THE CITY IN FACT
PATROLS CONDUCTED AFTER PSP AS
EVENTS FOUND MULTIPLE INSTANCES
OF EQUIPMENT DAMAGE THE TREE
BRANCHES ON POWER LINES THE
COULD HAVE IGNITED A FIRE HAD
WE NOT DE ENERGIZED. THAT WE
CALL PSP HAS TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES LET ME BRIEFLY
SHARE HOW WE DECIDED DE
ENERGIZE A LINE. WE BASE OUR
DECISION ON MULTIPLE FACTORS
INCLUDING NATIONAL WEATHER
SERVICE WARNINGS. ASSESSMENTS
FROM OUR IN HOUSE NEUROLOGISTS
IN FIRE SCIENTISTS. REAL TIME
INFORMATION OBTAINED FROM FEELS
OBSERVERS AND STRATEGICALLY
DEPLOYED WEATHER STATIONS.
CONCERNS FROM FIRST RESPONDERS
AND PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUES AND
EXPECTED IMPACTED THE
ENERGIZING CIRCUITS ON
ESSENTIAL SERVICES SUCH AS
HOSPITALS WATER PUMPS AND
TRAFFIC CONTROLS. THAT WE'VE
ESTABLISHED WRONG PARTNERSHIPS
WITH OUR LOCAL AND STATE FIRE
SORTIES. COUNTY AND STATE
OFFICES OF EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
AND OTHER FIRST RESPONDER
AGENCIES. WE BEGIN OUR RESTREPO
LOOKS A TWO POWERS THREE DAYS.
IN ADVANCE OF THE S. P. S.
EVENTS THAT WE SET UP OUR I AM
T. AS EARLY SEVEN DAYS WE'RE
MOBILIZING TO RESPOND TO THESE
INFO IN SEVEN DAYS IN ADVANCE
OF EVENT. TO SOLICIT POLITICAL
CONCERT POTENTIAL CONCERNS
REGARDING PUBLIC SAFETY WE
CONTINUE TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THIS IMPORTANT PARTNERS
THROUGHOUT THE EVENT. THE
COMBINATION OF LOCAL
COORDINATION AND FORECAST DATA
HOUSE IS TO SCHEDULE PEOPLE
TROLLS. LIFE FIELD OBSERVATIONS
INTO STRATEGICALLY REACH OUT TO
CUSTOMERS WHO ARE AT RISK FOR
POTENTIAL DE ENERGIES ATION.
THE NEXT SELECT DRILLED ON OUR
CUSTOMER NOTIFICATION PROCESS.
IT IS OUR GOAL TO PROVIDE
NOTICE OUR CUSTOMERS UP TO
FORTY EIGHT AND TWENTY FOUR
HOURS BEFORE A POTENTIAL PSP AS
A VENT. HOWEVER WEATHER
CONDITIONS CAN SHIFT
UNEXPECTEDLY SOMETIMES
DRAMATICALLY WHICH IN SOME
INSTANCES CAN LIMIT OUR ABILITY
TO PROVIDE ADVANCE NOTICE. WE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE ALL OF OUR
CUSTOMERS TO SIGN UP FOR PS PS
NOTIFICATIONS. OUR CUSTOMERS
CAN DO THAT BY YOUR ROLLING AT
S. C. .COM FORWARD SLASH PS PS.
NO WE SEND ALERTS AND
NOTIFICATIONS TO CUSTOMERS TO
THE PREFERRED METHOD OF
CONTACT. TEXT EMAIL PHONE. AND
NEXT I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
SPECIFIC GROUPS OF INTO
INTEREST TO ALL OF US MEDICAL
BASELINE CRITICAL CARE AND
ACCESS AND FUNCTION LEADS. WE
ACTIVELY IDENTIFY MEDICAL
BASELINE IN CRITICAL CARE RELY
SUPPORT CUSTOMERS TO ENSURE WE
HAVE THE MOST UP TO DATE
CONTACT INFORMATION. AND THEIR
ROLE TO RECEIVE OUTAGE
NOTIFICATIONS. WE ALSO PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO HELP THEM
PREPARE RESILIENCY AND SAFETY
PLANS WHEN THESE TYPES OF
EVENTS OCCUR. IT WOULD TAKE
EXTRA PRECAUTIONS CRITICAL CARE
CUSTOMERS WHEN WE CANNOT
CONFIRM THAT ALERTS
NOTIFICATIONS HAVE BEEN
RECEIVED. WE SENT A COMPANY
REPRESENTED FOR THEIR HOME TO
NOTIFY THEM IN PERSON. AND MAKE
SURE THEY HAVE AN EMERGENCY
PLAN AND IN SPECIAL SIR
INSTANCES OR CRITICAL CARE
CUSTOMER DOES NOT HAVE AN
EMERGENCY PLAN AND MAY NEED
BACKUP POWER WILL DISCUSS
PROVIDING TEMPORARY SOLUTION.
ACTUALLY IN OUR EXPERIENCE THIS
IS BEEN RELATIVELY RARE. NEVER
ACCESS AND FUNCTION NEEDS
CUSTOMERS WE CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
WITH STATEWIDE AND LOCAL
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
AND COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS. WE
HAVE LEVERAGE EXISTING
PHILANTHROPIC PARTNERS AND
CUSTOMER PROGRAMS TO FOCUS ON
PSP AS PREPAREDNESS. ALL HAS
AWARENESS AND EMERGENCY
PLANNING AS WELL. AND WE
CONTINUE TO BUILD NEW
PARTNERSHIPS WITH INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS COUNTY WIDE
DISABILITY COLLABORATIVE'S. AND
NONPROFIT SERVING PORTABLE
COMMUNITIES. WE'VE ESTABLISHED
TWO NEW PROGRAMS TO ASSIST ARE
IMPACTED CUSTOMERS DURING PSP
OFFENSE. COMMUNITY CREW
VEHICLES A COMMUNITY RESOURCE
CENTERS. THESE ARE OUT WE
CENTERS WE DEPLOYED IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES TO PROVIDE CHARGING
STATIONS SNACKS AND WATER MAYBE
MORE IMPORTANTLY OUR TEAM
MEMBERS TALK TO CUSTOMERS TO
CAPTURE QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS
PROVIDE INFORMATION SPECIFIC TO
THE EVENT ITS ONGOING. THAT
WERE EXPANDING BOTH OF THESE
PROGRAMS SIGNIFICANTLY BY YEAR
END. NOW IN CLOSING I'D LIKE TO
SHARE A FEW ADDITIONAL
OBSERVATIONS IN TAKE AWAYS.
FIRST WE'VE HEARD FROM OUR
CUSTOMERS AND WE VALUE THEIR
FEEDBACK THIS IS A CRITICAL
PART OF OUR PROGRAM. WE'VE MADE
IMPROVEMENTS AND WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK HARD TO FURTHER AUGMENT
OUR PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE JUST
LAST WEEK WE ENHANCE OUR
WEBSITE WITH AN INTERACTIVE MAP
SHOWING HIEROS FIRES THAT ARE
BEING MONITORED FOR POTENTIAL
PS PS. OR ARE CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING A PEACE PROCESS.
IN ADDITION FOR NON ACCOUNT
HOLDERS SUCH AS RENTERS TENANTS
FAMILY RELATIVES. THANK YOU
REGISTER TO RECEIVE OUT ALERTS
BASED ON ZIP CODES. AND WE'RE
ENHANCING THE PRESENTATION OF
QUALITY OF PS PS WEB CONTENT
WHICH INCLUDES A MOBILE FIRST
USER EXPERIENCE DESIGNED TO FIT
SMALLER SCREENS. AND NEXT WE'VE
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED OUR
CAPACITY TO HANDLE THE VOLUME
AND FREQUENCY OF WEB TRAFFIC
FOR EVENTS LIKE PS PS ANOTHER
MAJOR CATASTROPHES. WE'VE HEARD
AND AGREE STRONGLY THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS TO SECTION
LIGHTING CIRCUITS. AND BEING AS
PRECISE AS POSSIBLE WHEN PS PS
IS NEEDED. NOW WILL CONTINUE TO
PURSUE THESE OPPORTUNITIES I
WOULD WELCOME APPROVAL ARE
PENDING GS RP. AND YOUR C.
REQUEST SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
MOMENTUM OF THIS VITAL VITAL
WORK. NO I DIDN'T TOUCH ON IT
TODAY. WE VALUE OUR ROLE IN
ACHIEVING CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
AND AIR QUALITY GOALS. FOR THE
LIKE EXPECTED BIRTHDATE TO PLAY
THE ROLE IT MUST NEW SHARE JURY
TO CLEAN ENERGY ECONOMY. WE
KNOW WE NEED TO FURTHER
STRENGTHEN RELIABILITY AND
RESILIENCY. NOW WITH THOSE
CLOSING THOUGHTS I WANT TO
THANK YOU AGAIN. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE. WE KNOW
HOW IMPORTANT THIS ISSUE IS
THIS ISSUE IS TO YOU AND THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE. IT IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO US AS
WELL. AND HE SAFETY OF OUR
CUSTOMERS EMPLOYEES AND
COMMUNITIES IS OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY. NOT BEHALF OF WOMEN
AND MEN OF THE CITY. MANY ABLY
REPRESENTED BY IBEW LOCAL FORTY
SEVEN. WE REMAIN COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH YOU. OUR
REGULATORS OUR CUSTOMERS ALL OF
OUR STAKEHOLDERS. TO CONTINUE
TURNING COURSE ARISES TO THE
EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGES BEFORE
US. SO THANK YOU AND WELCOME
QUESTIONS THANK YOU SENATOR
BUILDER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- YEAH I WAS GOING TO ASK
ANY QUESTIONS HERE BUT I- YOU
CAUGHT MY EAR YOU'D SEE MADE A
COMMENT. SOMETHING IS. TO THE-
LIKE OF IF APPROVED. YOU I
THINK YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
CODED WIRES SIX THOUSAND. OVER
BY 200-023-6000 MILES. IF
APPROVED YOU COULD DO THIS AND
SO I GUESS FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE I'M WONDERING FROM
THE REGULATORY PERSPECTIVE. ARE
THERE ANY HOLD UPS TO YOU
MOVING FORWARD FASTER TO REDUCE
FIRE RISK IN THAT ALSO. TO
REDUCE THE IMPACTS THESE P. S.
P. S. EVENTS. THANK YOU CENTER
NOT APPRECIATE THE QUESTION-
FIRST OF ALL- AND JUST BACK TO
THE WHOLE BASIS OF PUBLIC
SAFETY POWERSHOT OFFICE-
THEY'RE ONE OF MANY AREAS IN
WAYS THAT WERE REDUCING AND
NEGATING THREAT OF WILDFIRES.
AND WE'RE VERY CONSCIOUS OF THE
IMPACT THAT THEY HAVE ON OUR
CUSTOMERS AND OUR COMMUNITIES-
WE DO NOT TAKE IT LIGHTLY- WE
BASE OUR CAREER ON THE
LIABILITY SO- BUT SAFETY IS
FIRST- WITH THAT- EVEN BEFORE
WE FILED OUR GOOD SAY TO RESULT
YOU PROGRAM WE WERE INVESTING
IN COVER CONDUCTOR IN FACT WE-
WE GOT A- HEAD START- THAT WAS
PRECEDED BY MANY YEARS I
MENTIONED THE- ELEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS WHICH FOCUSED. ON
THINGS THAT COULD HELP US AND
WHILE FIRE MITIGATION THAT WAS
NOT RELATED TO OUR G. S. R. P.
SPECIFICALLY BUT WE'VE BEEN
INVESTING EVEN WITHOUT THOSE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE APPROVED
THOSE PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE
ASSURANCE THAT AS WE GO FORWARD
WE CAN CONTINUE TO DO THAT BUT
AS I SAID WE'VE ALREADY
DEPLOYED FOUR HUNDRED MILES OF
COVER CONDUCTOR- BECAUSE WE DO
IT'S AN IMPORTANT MEDICATION
ELEMENT. WE'VE ALSO- IN GAYS
AND ALL THE ELEMENTS OF RGS RP
THE WEATHER STATIONS I
MENTIONED- THE- THE HIGH
DEFINITION CAMERAS OF
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT THERE'S
MANY LAYERS THAT ARE IN THOSE
PROGRAMS- WE THINK THEY'RE
IMPORTANT SO WE STARTED. WE
STARTED IN PARALLEL FOR OUR-
COMMISSION APPROVAL THOSE
PROGRAMS. GERMAN BOB. I
RECOGNIZE YOU PROBABLY DON'T
WANT TO BE PUT A POSITION OF
CRITICIZING YOUR REGULATOR AT
AT A HEARING LIKE THIS HOWEVER.
I WANT TO ASK THE QUESTION
AGAIN. ARE THERE ANY REGULATORY
IMPEDIMENTS. TO YOU- THE-
CAUSING HOLD UP TO YOU. TO MOVE
FORWARD FASTER ON- MAKING SURE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE THESE FIRE
WE'RE ASKS ONE INTO- TO
MINIMIZE THE IMPACTS OF P. S.
P. S. EVENTS. KELLY CENTER I
CANNOT THINK OF AN AREA WHERE
THAT REGULATORY HOLD UP IS
PREVENTING US FROM DOING
SOMETHING THAT I THINK IN THE
LONG TERM WE'RE GOING TO NEED
THE ASSURANCE THAT WE HAVE
REGULATORY SUPPORT FOR THE WORK
WE'RE DOING BUT WE FEEL SO
STRONGLY ABOUT IT THAT WE-
BASICALLY LEAD. WE LEAD WITH-
WITH OUR ACTIONS AND IT'S WHY
WE STARTED THESE PROGRAMS EVEN
EARLIER THAN WE HAD A
COMMISSION APPROVAL FOR THEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THERE WILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. WELL
YOU SAID YOU ONLY HAD 2% OF
YOUR SERVICE AREA DOWN TO FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE WELL I GUESS I
MUST BE PART OF THE 2% SO I
GUESS I'M PART OF PART OF THE
ELITE CAN YOU YOU TALKED ABOUT
HOW YOU READ YOU CARE ABOUT
YOUR CUSTOMERS SO I WANT TO
THESE ARE THESE ARE DIRECTLY
FROM CUSTOMERS EXPERIENCE. AND
YOU MAY NOT EVEN HAVE AN ANSWER
BELLY SHE KNOW ABOUT IT IN SO
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN BEGIN
MEDICAID IN THE FUTURE SO I
HAVE A EIGHTY TWO YEAR OLD
DISABLED VETERAN- IN A
WHEELCHAIR AND ALSO ON OXYGEN
HE CALLED DURING HIS THIRTY SIX
HOUR SHUT DOWN A CALLED ADDRESS
AND HE WAS TOLD TO CALL NINE
ONE ONE. SO IT IS IT SO
ACTUALLY HE DIDN'T CALL MY
OFFICE HE CALLED A LOCAL SO
WOMEN'S OFFICE IN IN HIM AND I.
BORROWED A TRUCK. DOESN'T KNOW
HOW TO SET UP A GENERATOR AND
DID THAT SO IS THAT WHAT WE'RE
RECOMMENDING YOUR CUSTOMERS DO
IF THEY HAVE A SUCH AS
SITUATIONS THEY JUST CALL NINE
ONE ONE- I'D MAYBE TAKE OUT A
COUPLE OF LEVELS WE GET AND
JUST TO REITERATE- WE- WE
RECOGNIZE THE HARDSHIPS AND
THIS IS A- CASE IN POINT OF THE
HARDSHIPS THAT A P. S. P. S.
PROGRAM CAN PUT IN PLACE-
BEFORE THE EVENT START WE ARE
ENGAGING WITH OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS. AND PARTICULARLY-
FIREFIGHTING OFFICIALS. TO HELP
US UNDERSTAND- WHAT THE
CRITICAL NEEDS MIGHT BE IN A
COMMITTEE NOT ZERO NINE ZERO
AND A CUSTOMER CUSTOMER BASIS.
BUT IN HOW THAT DINNER
DETECTION COULD IMPACT THAT
COMMUNITY- AS TO THE SPECIFIC
SITUATION. WE WOULD. REALLY
WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH THIS PARTICULAR CUSTOMER
SO. IF YOU COULD NOT PROVIDE IS
INFORMATION- AT THE END OF THIS
HEARING I WOULD GLADLY TAKE IT
UP AND WE'LL GET BACK TO HIM. I
DO THINK THEY'RE GOING TO BE
CASES CANDIDLY WHERE- EMERGENCY
RESPONSE IS NECESSARY. WE HAVE
THE CAPABILITY TO SUPPORT
CUSTOMERS BUT I THINK EMERGENCY
LIFESAVING SITUATIONS. NINE ONE
ONE IS A TOOL THAT- CUSTOMERS
WILL NEED TO USE. UP WE'RE
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TAKE
FEEDBACK AND ADJUST OUR
PROGRAMS. AND THIS KIND OF
INFORMATION IS VERY HELPFUL TO
US AND UNDERSTANDING. BOTH
IMPACTS AND WHAT ROLE WE CAN
PLAY. IN MINIMIZING THOSE
IMPACTS. THANK CENTER SO. NEXT
SCENARIO IS THAT I THINK TWO
WEEKS AGO NOW A RURAL
COMMUNITY- ACTING CALIFORNIA.
AND THERE WAS ACTUALLY IT WAS A
THE RULE COUNCIL BUT AT EDISON
WAS THERE AND I WANTED TO
COMMEND THEM FOR THEIR-
COURAGE- WE'RE NOT REALLY GOOD
ON ANSWERS BUT CERTAINLY WORD.
THEY TOOK IT. AND TWO DIFFERENT
PEOPLE WERE THERE AND THEY HAVE
HOME BASED BUSINESSES AGAIN
THEY WERE OUT OVER THIRTY
HOURS. OF THE FILE THE
NECESSARY PAPERWORK TO FILE A
CLAIM THE CLAIM WAS DENIED. AND
THEY CALLED AND THEY SAID- YOU
KNOW JUST TAKE US TO SMALL
CLAIMS COURT. SO I'M JUST
WONDERING SHOULD. MIKE
ASSERTIONS GO THROUGH THIS
PROCESS OR SHOULD WE JUST GO
DIRECTLY TO SMALL CLAIMS COURT
AND IF THEY DO. WHO WOULD THEY
FILED OUT NO- AND THANK YOU FOR
RAISING THAT ON AND I THINK
THIS IS ANOTHER CASE OF WHERE
WE'RE TAKING OUR CUSTOMERS
FEEDBACK. A COMMUNITY BACK TO
HEART- WE HAVE- ODDLY ENOUGH
BEEN ABLE AND HAVE BEEN DOING A
PSP AS WE LIKE WE DID OUR FIRST
ONE AND- TWO THOUSAND AND THREE
TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR TIME
FRAME. A VERY LONG TIME AGO-
DID YOU USE IT. FRANKLY BETWEEN
THEN AND UNTIL RECENTLY I WOULD
SAY STARTED USING IT MORE
AGAIN- IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TWENTY EIHTEEN TIME RAME.
THIS IS THE FIRST YEAR WE
REALLY HAVE USED IT I WOULD
SAY- SUBSTANTIALLY IN OUR
MITIGATION PROGRAM. THIS IS A
LONG WINDED WAY OF SAYING. THIS
IS NEW TO OUR CUSTOMERS ARE NOT
USED TO SEEING THIS. AND WHILE
WE'VE DONE SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC
OUTREACH IN TERMS OF
BROADCASTING COMMUNITY TOWN
HALLS AND OTHER EVENTS- WE
RECOGNIZE CUSTOMERS AREN'T
REALLY READY FOR THIS. IN
RECOGNITION OF THAT WERE
ADJUSTING OUR CLAIMS POLICY FOR
SPOILAGE. I THAT WOULD BE FOOD
AND MEDICAL- AND YOU GIVE.
PRESCRIPTIONS THINGS IT MAY GO
BAD- AT HIGH TEMPERATURES- WHAT
WE WILL DO AT LEAST THROUGH THE
END OF NEXT JANUARY- FOR
CUSTOMERS THAT HAVE BEEN OUT OF
POWER- FOR EIGHT HOURS A MORE.
AND HAVE LESS THAN A TWELVE
HOUR NOTICE OF A- DE ENERGY
STATION WE WILL BE HONORING
THOSE CLAIMS SO I RECOMMEND
THEY GO BACK TO OUR CLAIMS
GROUP- AND WE WILL I WILL
ADDRESS THOSE. IT'S A SPECIFIC
CUSTOMER YOU CAN JUST PUT HIM
IN TOUCH WITH ONE OF OUR
REPRESENTATIVES HERE. I WILL
MAKE SURE THAT GETS TAKEN CARE
OF. SO OKAY SO FOLLOW UP WORK I
WASN'T ASKING THIS ONE BUT NOT
SO YOU SAID ON THE FOOD SPICES
THAT SO THAT. DOES THAT APPLY
TO RESTAURANTS AS WELL THEN. IT
DOES. OKAY GREAT. SO THIS A
PERSON I'VE NOT MET YET I'M
ASSUMING ON THE METER BECAUSE
THERE'S ANOTHER MEDICINE. TOWN
HALL- TOMORROW NIGHT NO NOT
TOMORROW A WEDNESDAY NIGHT I
WILL BE THERE SO IT'S A
CONSTITUENT AN AWKWARD BILLS
SAY. AND I GOT THIS EMAIL IN
LAST NIGHT SO I HAVE NOT
PERSONALLY MET HER. BUT SHE
SAID SHE JUST GOT HER BILL. AND.
THAT SHE WAS CHARGED FOR THE
TIME WHEN. THEY WERE OUT OF
POWER. COULD I GUESS WHAT YOU
GUYS DO IF THEY CAN READ THE
METER THEY JUST MAKE
ASSUMPTIONS. ON HOW MUCH ENERGY
THEY CONSUME SO SHE WAS BUILT.
FOR ENERGY SHE HAD NO WAY OF
DRAWING BECAUSE YOU GUYS CUT
OUR POWER OFF. BOBBI CERTAINLY
I UNDERSTAND THAT WE IN- SOME
OF OUR CUSTOMERS DO GET BILLS
BASIN ESTIMATED USAGE BUT WE
CATCH UP WITH THAT THE NEXT
CYCLE SO OUR EXPECTATION WOULD
BE WE'RE GONNA BACK THAT OUT.
AND THE CHARGE WILL BE FIXED
BUT I CAN TELL THE FIVE HUNDRED
ANGRY PEOPLE WEDNESDAY NIGHT
THAT THAT'S GOING TO BE TAKING
CARE OF AND THEIR NEXT BILL AND
WE WILL NOT CHARGE FOR POWER
DOES NOT DELIVERED THAT'S A
VERY GOOD. IT MIGHT MIGHT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MY FINAL
QUESTION I WENT AT WHAT POINT
WE GONNA LEARN THE. ORIGINATION
AT THE CHECK CANYON FIRE. ALL
THESE FIRES ARE UNDER SOME FORM
OF INVESTIGATION SO I REALLY
CANNOT PREDICT THAT- MY
EXPERIENCE WITH OUR
INVESTIGATIONS IS THAT CAN BE
LENGTHY- MANY MONTHS SO THAT
CERTAINLY PROCESSES I'M GOING
BUT- I REALLY DON'T HAVE A AN
ANSWER FOR YOU FOR AS A TIME
FRAME IS CONCERNED RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THERE ARE MORE
LETTER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU MISTER HERRINGTON YOU
I THINK YOU'VE ANSWERED MY
FIRST TWO QUESTIONS ABOUT- YOU
CALLED SECTIONAL EYES BUT I WAS
USING THE TERM POWER TO BURGER
AND YOU USED FAST ACTING FUSES
SO I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY
HOPEFULLY THE SAME THING THAT I
WAS CONCERNED ABOUT OVERHEAD
LINES AND YOU SAID YOU'VE BEEN.
COVERING THE LINE SO I WANTED
JUST A ADDRESS WILL TWENTY A
WHICH WILL HAVE A REPORT FROM
THE CPUC WHICH CAME OUT TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND YOU STILL HAD ABOUT
A HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
MILLION RESERVISTS DO
BEAUTIFICATION UNDER GROUNDING
OF. OF BLINDS IN YOUR
JURISDICTIONAL AREA. MANY.
FEEDBACK ON ON HOW THAT'S
PROGRESSING AND HOW WE'RE
HELPING COMMUNITIES WITH
WILDFIRE. JONES IS AS FAR AS
RULE TWENTY A WILL HAVE TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON THAT ONE
I THINK THAT'S A- SOME OF THOSE
FUNDS ARE OBVIOUSLY ALLOCATED
TO NON HIGH BAR RISK AREAS-
SOME OF THAT IS. REALLY
DEDICATED AS YOU NOTE FOR
BEAUTIFICATION AN ASCETIC
PURPOSES I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING WE ARE WORKING
THROUGH- UNDER GROUNDING HE IS
A SOLUTION ONE OF MANY ANSWERS
FRANKLY SOME TRADE OFFS
ASSOCIATED WITH UNDERGROUND
AND- RESTORATION TIME IS ONE OF
THEM- TIME TO INSTALL THAT
TECHNOLOGY IS ANOTHER- TALKING
ON THE FIRST POINT OUT WHEN YOU
HAVE A FAULT IN AN UNDERGROUND
LINE IT CAN TAKE SOME TIME TO
TROUBLESHOOT THAT. WE NEED A
MUCH LONGER OUTAGES- THERE
THERE ARE RESILIENCY ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH A CERTAIN
EVENTS THAT CAN AFFECT UNDER
GROUNDING THAT MAY NOT BE
IMPACTING OUR OVERGROUND
EQUIPMENT OR ABOVE GROUND
EQUIPMENT SAME WAY- PERMITTING
CAN TAKE SOME TIME AND AGAIN-
IT TAKES MUCH LONGER TO
CONSTRUCT. AND AGAIN THIS ISN'T
SOLELY ACOSTA ISSUE THE COST IS
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE- IT'S AROUND
EIGHT TIMES MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
EVEN OUR COVER CONDUCTOR
OVERHEAD SOLUTION IS- BUT THAT
IS PART OF OUR ARSENAL THE LAST
WEEK WE DO FEEL THAT THERE ARE
PLACES WHERE UNDERGROUND IS THE
BEST SOLUTION. THE WAY WE'RE
APPROACHING THIS IS A VERY I
CAN USE OR GRANULAR AGAIN A
GRANULAR ASSESSMENT OF RISK OUR
SYSTEM THAT LOOKS AT THE
CONSEQUENCES A POTENTIAL
IGNITIONS AND WE FOCUS ON THOSE
THAT THERE WILL BE AREAS THAT
MAY BE- ARE SO CONSEQUENCE ON
THE END OF A WILDFIRE THAT
UNDERGROUND IS THE BEST
SOLUTION. AND WILL USE THAT
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS THE CASE SO
YOU'RE NOT THE CEO OF EDISON SO
WHAT I'M GONNA ASK YOU BECAUSE
YOU'RE STILL A SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT- YOU- ARE ONE OF
THREE. I USE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES IN THE STATE. SO YOU
SOMEWHERE IN HISTORY YOU GRANT.
FRENCH I ZERO ZONE OF THE
STATE- AND I'M JUST CURIOUS
THEN- IF YOU'RE CHARTER BY THE
STATE IN A SCENE BY THE STATE.
CAN YOUR CHARTER BE REVOKED IN
CAN THE STATE. IN A SENSE
NATIONALIZE YOUR UTILITY IF I
COULD USE THAT TERM TO SAY OKAY
WHAT WE'RE TAKING OVER WE DON'T
LIKE HOW YOU'RE PERFORMING
WE'RE GONNA DO IT OURSELVES YOU
HAVE ANY THOUGHTS OR COMMENTS.
SENATOR THAT ONE'S DEFINITELY
OUT OF MY DEPTH SO- BUT- WHAT I
COULD SHARE WITH YOU THOUGH-
AND IF THIS DOESN'T COME
THROUGH THE TALKING POINTS.
MAYBE WILL FURTHER INTO AN A- I
THINK AS YOU LOOK AT THE I USE
I CAN REALLY ONLY SPEAK FOR US
CALLOUS AND THAT'S WHERE I
WORK- WE ARE COMMITTED TO
INNOVATION AND WE'RE COMMITTED
TO NEW TECHNOLOGIES- MANY
THINGS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IN
TERMS OF OUR APPROACH INCOME A
CONDUCTOR BUT MAYBE THE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES- HAVEN'T HAD A
CHANCE TO SPEAK ON SOMETHING
WHERE WE'VE DEVELOPED. OF THE
ABILITIES ARE SMART METERS TO
DETECT WHEN A WIRES DOWN SALAS
SMART METERS WE DEPLOYED- OVER
THE YEARS- WE CAN USE
INFORMATION COMING FROM THOSE
DEVICES TO PROTECT AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE LINE IS ON
THE GROUND- WE ARE DOING THAT
KIND OF INNOVATION. AND I THINK
THAT THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY
MODEL DOES HELP US IN THE
INNOVATION SPACE SO I CANNOT
REALLY SPEAK TO REGULATORY MAKE
I'M TALKING. MORE ABOUT OUR
PRIDE AND INNOVATION BUT. UP AS
FAR AS A REGULATORY
UNDERPINNINGS OF. UNCLE INTO
STATE OWNERSHIP OF THE
UTILITIES ARE REALLY NOT. SPEAK
ABOUT THAT. BUT YOU HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE STATE AND
YOUR YOUR REGULATED OR YOUR OWN
YES SCENE SO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ABUT THE CPUC AND-
IS. IS ARE YOU ARE YOU HAVE A
GOOD RELATIONSHIP IS IT WORKING
PROPERLY. MY A MY EXPECTED MY
FEELING IS YES IT IS I THINK
THERE IS A- REGULATORS SOMEONE
WHO- AN ENTITY THAT DOT LOOKS
OUT OVER THE- REGULATED
UTILITIES I'VE OPERATED IN
OTHER JURISDICTIONS-JURISDICTIONS OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA- I THINK- HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS WHO ARE
COMMISSIONER CRITICAL. I DO
FEEL WE HAVE ONE- I THINK
THERE'S ALWAYSGOING TO BE-
SOME MIGHT DYNAMICS BETWEEN-
WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING TO DO AND
WHAT- WHAT ARE COMMISSION
ULTIMATELY- GIVES US OF THE OR
TO DO- BUT OVERALL. I FEEL WE
DO HAVE A GOOD RELATIONSHIP.
THANK YOU MISTER HERRINGTON
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M GONNA ASK
A VERY DIRECT QUESTION BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THAT- SENATOR THE
GOOD CENTER FROM NAPA WAS
TRYING TO GET TO. THIS ANSWER-
SO I'VE HEARD THAT THERE IS A
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT INVOLVING
EDISON RELATED TO CREATE SAFETY
AND RESILIENCY THAT HASN'T
BEEN. RELEASED YET SO COULD
SOMEONE FROM. I GUESS WE'LL
HEAR ROM QC BUT LISA FROM YOU
CAN YOU GIVE US AN UPDATE ON ON
THAT PARTICULAR. AGREEMENT BOB
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WELL AS AS
YOU NOTED WE DO HAVE A
SETTLEMENT WHICH OBVIOUSLY. OR
MAYBE NOT OBVIOUSLY BUT DOES-
BOLSTER ARGUE THAT THIS IS
LIKELY TO BE APPROVED I CAN'T
PREDICT THAT- NOT NOT MY- NOT
MY PLACE. BUT I WILL SAY AGAIN
I WAS NOT TRYING TO OF A DOZEN
OR JOBS QUESTION- SPEEDY
RESOLUTION APPROVALS ARE
ALWAYS- I THINK OF A GOOD
OUTCOME. THE NAME WAS TO HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT WHAT WE'RE
DOING IT WILL CONTINUE TO BE
SUPPORTED WE'RE STILL WAITING
FOR APPROVAL FOR THAT AS WELL
AS OUR GENERATE CASE WHICH HAS
BEEN FILED AS OF LAST NOVEMBER.
AND WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
HOLDER COULD. BE I REALLY COULD
NOT SPECULATE ON THAT. THANK
YOU AND THEN I HAVE A QUESTION
REGARDING CELL PHONES AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK IT'S BEEN BROUGHT
UP YET. BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE
HAVE MENTIONED THAT. I'M SORRY.
YET CELL PHONES SO IS BEING
USED FOR EMERGENCY PURPOSES ARE
CELL TOWERS AT LEAST IN YOUR
JURISDICTION ARE THEY AT LEAST
BEING PRIORITIZE IN ORDER TO.
TO RESTORE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES SO- MAYBE BACKING UP
INTO OUR OVERALL PSP AS
PROCESS- WE START. AGAIN DAYS
IN ADVANCE FOR IMMOBILIZE-
PEOPLE IN OUR I AM T. TO
PROTECT THIS COMING. UP AND
THEN RAMP UP EFFORTS RESOURCES
AS IT BECOMES MORE MORE
CERTAIN- WE HAVE THE SAME SORT
OF TO- WEATHER FORECASTS TODAY
WE HAVE A SUPER COMPUTER THAT
ENABLES US TO MAKE- WEATHER
PREDICTIONS- WE ALSO BRINGING
EXTERNAL FORECASTS. WHEN WE GET
TO THE ROUGHLY SEVENTY TWO ARE
MARK WE'RE LETTING OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS. AND OTHER WHAT WE
CALL ESSENTIAL USE CUSTOMERS-
KNOW WHAT'S COMING OUR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS
ARE IN THAT. GROUP AND SO
AROUND SEVENTY TWO HOURS WERE
NOTIFYING THEM OF THE UPCOMING
ARE IMMINENT- EVENT. SO WHEN A
D. INTERFACING DOES OCCUR
BECAUSE I THINK- CENTER TRYING
YOU'RE ASKING ME TO BAR
RESTORATION- WE'RE LOOKING AT A
NUMBER OF FACTORS. WHAT ONE OF
THE KEY FACTORS THIS REALLY
GOVERNING OUR RESTORATION TIME
FRAME. IS THE ABILITY TO GET
OUT IN THE FIELD AND DO THE
INSPECTIONS WE HAVE TO. SELL
ONE OF THE IMPEDIMENTS AGAIN AS
WIND- WE DO HELICOPTER PATROLS
AS WELL AS DRUM PATROLS- BUT
ALSO HAVING OUR- TEAMS OUT IN
THE FIELD. WHEN THE WINDS HAVE-
DECLINE TO A POINT WHERE WE
BELIEVE IT IS SAFE TO RESTORE
POWER TO THE LINES. THAT WE MAY
HAVEDE ENERGIZED. SO I WOULD
SAY WE DO LOOK AT LINES AND IF
THEY HAVE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
THAT WOULD BE ONE OF THE MANY
FACTORS. WE CONSIDER. IN A RE
ENERGIZE ATION SEQUENCE. THANK
YOU CENTERS TURN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF MY CONSTITUENTS. WERE
IMPACTED OVER LAST FEW MONTHS
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT HIGH WINDS
AGAIN THIS WEEKEND. SO FROM THE
LAST TWO WEEKS OF PS PS EVENTS
I'M WONDERING. WHAT YOU LEARNED
AND WHAT I TELL. I MENTION
ALLEN FROM SEAMY VALLEY EARLIER
AND T. FROM THOUSAND OAKS BUT-
HOW FROM SEAMY VALLEY WITH A
FOUR YEAR OLD A TWO AND A HALF
YEAR OLD AN EIGHT MONTH OLD THE
STAY AT. ILLNESS IS AT HOME
MARIA IN CHATSWORTH. JOHN IT
THEN AND DAVID AND RENEE IN
SEEING ME. WHAT WHAT IT IS TO
DO FOR TO GET READY FOR THIS
WEEKEND WHO ARE THEY SUPPOSED
TO CALL OF THEIR MEDICALLY
VULNERABLE AND I SHOULD ADD TO
THAT WAS MY GRANDMOTHER- SO.
YOU KNOW DURING LAST BLACKOUT.
SHE GOT VERY POWER SHUT OFF
WITHOUT WARNING SHE IS
MEDICATION SHE NEEDS TO.
REFRIGERATED LIKELY MY PARENTS
FOUND OUT SHE DOESN'T USE A
CELL PHONE SO THEY WENT TO OUR
HOUSE AND TOOK HER BACK TO
THEIR HOUSE SHE DOESN'T WANT TO
GO TO A COMMUNITY RESOURCE
CENTER WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
MOST SKEPTICAL OF THAT STRATEGY
BEING. WHEN THE ANCHORS OF YOUR
MITIGATION STRATEGY TO HAVE
SENIOR IS EXPECTED TO GO TO
SOME HIGH SCHOOL AND SIT THERE
FOR A DAY- AND LIKE WHEN THEY
CAN BARELY WALK- DOESN'T REALLY
SEEM LIKE THE BEST WAY TO
MITIGATE THAT IMPACTS SO WHAT
ARE THEY SUPPOSED TO DO LIKE
IT'S MONDAY. POWER MAY GO OFF
ON SATURDAY SO WHO THEY CALL IF
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT THEIR
POWER GOING. SO. THANK YOU
CENTER FIRST OFF AGAIN I. WE
UNDERSTAND THIS IS CLEARLY A
CASE OF THE HARDSHIPS THAT WHAT
THE SPS DOES INFLICT ON OUR
CUSTOMERS AND OUR COMMUNITIES-
MILLION PLEASE. UNDERSTAND THIS
IS SOMETHING WE DO FOR THE
PUBLIC SAFETY ASPECT OF IT.
RECOGNIZING THE SIGNIFICANT AND
OFTEN PAINFUL TRADE OFF THEIR-
THAT DOESN'T HELP YOUR
GRANDMOTHER SO- MAYBE TALK MORE
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THAT- OUR
OUR- CUSTOMER CENTER- ARE. WE
HAVE THE NUMBERS THAT THEY CAN
BE REACHED ON IF YOU LOOK AT
OUR WEBSITE WILL BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE MORE MORE INFORMATION.
THAN ENABLE OUR CUSTOMERS TO
REACH OUT- I IMAGINE THERE HAVE
BEEN CASES WHERE WE SEND
REPRESENTATIVES OUT TO
CUSTOMERS THE CRITICAL CARE
CUSTOMER WOULD BE ONE. TO
UNDERSTAND AND FIND OUT ABOUT
THEIR PARTICULAR NEEDS IT'S
ONLY IF THEY'RE LISTED THEY'VE
ALREADY SIGNED UP FOR MEDICAL
BASS LINE AND THEY'RE LISTED IN
YOUR DATABASE A CRITICAL CARE
STE. CUSTOMER BUT- IF THEY CALL
YOUR GENERAL CUSTOMER SERVICE.
HOTLINE YOU YOUR
REPRESENTATIVES TOLD ME YOU
WILL NOT BRING A GENERATOR OUT
TO THAT FACILITY. THAT NOW WE
NEED TO ESCALATE AND WE'LL
ESCALATE TO THE INCIDENT
MANAGEMENT TEAM AND WE HAVE
DONE THAT. IN THAT REQUEST
HASN'T MADE IT THROUGH FOR A
CRITICAL CARE RECENTLY THAT I'M
AWARE OF- IT TO OUR- IS AN
AMENITY TO MORE CUSTOMER CARE
CENTER. BUT THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE WILL ESCALATE TO THE I.
ANTI LEVEL. AGAIN THIS IS- IT'S
A BALANCE WERE TRYING TO STRIKE
YOUR SENATOR. AND WHAT MAY BE
GOING BACK TO UNDERSTANDING
WHAT WE CAN TELL THEM IN A
LONGER TERM- CIRCUITS IN THESE
AREAS THAT WE ARE FREQUENTLY DE
ENERGIZING OR MORE FREQUENTLY
ENERGIZING. WILL BE HARDENED ON
A PRIORITY BASIS. SO OVER TIME
WE EXPECT TO HAVE TO DO THIS
LESSON LAPSED. IN THE NEAR TERM
REACHING OUT TO OUR CUSTOMER
LINES IN CUSTOMER CAROLINE'S.
WILL ENABLE THAT INFORMATION TO
MAKE IT TO THE PEOPLE WHO NEED
TO HEAR THAT IN THE INCIDENT IN
QUESTION- SO I. ALSO WANT TO.
MAKE ONE POINT HERE- SPS IS ARE
WE JUST ONE OF THE MANY WAYS
THAT CUSTOMERS COULD LOSE
POWER- SO THAT IS WHY WE'RE
ENCOURAGING OUR CUSTOMERS TO
REGISTER ON OUR WEBSITE. THAT
THEY ARE MEDICAL BASELINE-
CRITICAL CARE CUSTOMER- IT
COULD BE AN EARTHQUAKE YOU
COULD BE A MAJOR STORM- WHERE
THERE WON'T BE WARNING- AND IN
FACT SOME D. IMAGES ASIANS
OCCUR. DURING FIRES NOT BECAUSE
OUR PRINTER DO DINNER IS ATION
BECAUSE LINES THEMSELVES
NEIGHBOR DOWN. OR WINDS WINDS
TAKE THE LINES DOWN SO OUTSIDE
OF FOR A DECISION TO THE ENERGY
UNDERSTOOD SO IF I'M A MEDICAL
BASELINE CUSTOMER. AND I
FIGURED OUT SOME WAY TO SIGN UP
I HAVEN'T SEEN ADS BY THE WAY
ALL THE BILLBOARDS DON'T TALK
ABOUT SIGNING UP FOR MEDICAL
BASS NAMES IN ADVERTISEMENTS ON
TV ABOUT THIS I MEAN. I DON'T I
DON'T KNOW WHO IN THE STATE
KNOWS ABOUT SIGNING UP I'VE GOT
SEVENTY FOUR THOUSAND. FOLKS ON
MEDICAL BASELINE ESE TERRITORY
BUT ON AYE HSS ALONE IN EDISON
COUNTRY THERE'S THREE UNDER
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE ON HSS SO
CLOSING THAT. ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND PERSON GAP BY
SUNDAY DOESN'T SEEM LIKELY SO
AGAIN. HOW HOW DO PEOPLE WHO
ARE TOO VULNERABLE TO LEAVE
THEIR HOME AND GO TO ONE YOUR
RESOURCE CENTERS. THEY CALL YOU
TO WHERE THEY CALL COUNTY YEAH
I I'VE HAD PEOPLE CALL YOUR
ALLEN THEY SAY GO BUY A
GENERATOR AND THEIR LIVES YOUR
CUSTOMER SERVICE REPRESENTED
LITERACY AND GO BUY A DIESEL
GENERATOR WELL WHAT ARE THEY
SUPPOSED TO DO THIS WEEK I
WOULD SAY CALL THE EDISON
CUSTOMER LINE. OKAY THAT
INFORMATION IS ON OUR WEBSITE
AND IT'S ON THE BILL SO THAT
SHOULD BE READILY AVAILABLE. F
THIS SORT SUPPORT IS NOT COMING
IN TIME- I WOULD SAY- THEY
SHOULD BE CALLING OTHERS OF
THIS OF INCLUDING NINE ONE ONE
CALLS AS NECESSARY- BUT
CONTINUE TO REACH OUT OUTSIDE
OF EDISON. I THINK WE WILL HAVE
A LIMITED ABILITY TO DELIVER
GENEATORS YEAH I'M REALLY AS I
USED TO HAVE IN THE SYSTEM
RIGHT NOW TO DELIVER WELL WE
CONTRACT WITH THIRD PARTIES SO.
MANY ONLY A WEEK IT WOULD BE-
IT WOULD BE DEPENDING ON HOW
MANY THEY HAVE AVAILABLE. COULD
BE IN THE HUNDREDS TO THE
THOUSANDS AT MOST PROBABLY NOT
TENS OF THOUSANDS WE DON'T WE
DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF GENERATORS GIVE
MOBILE. ADDERLEY'S LIKE ESTY
JEANNIE TAKES OUT IN THE FIELD
THEY TAKE THE BIG TRUCKS OUT
THERE WITH A MOBILE GENERATOR
ON IT AND ALSO TO DELIVER ON A
COMMUNITY BY COMMUNITY BASIS IS
THAT. WE HAVE ACCESS TO WE DO
WE HAVE DONE THAT FOR US A
SENSE OF THESE CUSTOMERS THAT'S
BEEN DONE FOR HOSPITALS- THAT
HAS BEEN DONE FOR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS
ARE SAID TO BE VERY BIG
GENERATORS. SO OBVIOUSLY
THEY'RE NOT SUITED FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL RESIDENTS- ONE OF
THINGS WE DO OUGHT TO BE
CAREFUL ABOUTIS. IF THE LINE
ITSELF IS ONE WE'RE DE
ENERGIZED BECAUSE OF A SAFETY
ISSUE. OKAY BUT GENERATOR YOU
KNOW AT THE- END OF THAT LINE
AND PUTTING POWER BACK DOWN
THAT LINE. SIMPLY RECREATES THE
PROBLEM SO IN SOME CASES IT IS
TAKING POWER AWAY FROM THAT
LINE. THAT IS THE OBJECTIVE
UNFORTUNATELY WHICH LEADS TO
THE ENERGIES ATION AND THE
CUSTOMER SITUATIONS YOU
DESCRIBING SENATOR JUST JUST TO
BE CLEAR AND I'LL WRAP UP
MISTER CHAIR BUT- SO YOU'VE GOT
SAY HUNDREDS TO SAY THOUSANDS
OF GENERATORS BUT YOU'VE GOT.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
MEDICALLY VULNERABLE PEOPLE
WITHIN YOUR SERVICE TERRITORY.
WHO COULD BE FACING P. S. P. S.
AS SOON AS THIS WEEKEND. THEY
DON'T THEY WON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
A GENERATOR THREE YOU ARE YOU
GUYS INTERESTED AT ALL ARE OPEN
TO PROVIDING INCENTIVES FOR
PEOPLE. TO GO OUT AND GET. THEM
IN HERE THE COSCO WEBSITE.
RIGHT I MEAN I THAT'S ALL I'M
I'M JUST AN AVERAGE CONSUMER.
HE SAID ON THE ENERGY
COMMITTEE. IT'S THIRTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS TO GET. A YETI
THOUSAND WHAT. WITH A SOLAR
SYSTEM ON IT TO LAST ME A DAY.
THE CHARGE OF FOR SIX HOURS AND
THAT COST ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
BUCKS MORE THAN THE DIESEL
DIESEL ALTERNATIVE. SO IS THERE
ANY- OPENNESS TO SAY. GIVEN AN
INCENTIVE TO CUSTOMERS TO JUST
BE ABLE TO GO OUT AND BUY. SOME
IS A LITTLE LESS DANGEROUS THAN
HAVING MY GRANDMOTHER PLUG IN A
DIESEL GENERATOR THESE ARE
UNITS YOU CAN. PUT YOUR KITCHEN
KEEP YOUR FRIDGE ON SO YOUR
INSULIN DOESN'T GO BAD OR YOUR
FOOD DOESN'T SPOIL. HAVE YOU
ARE YOU GUYS WILLING TO OFFER
ANY KIND OF INCENTIVE LIKE THAT
TO THESE FOLDABLE FEET FOLKS
EVEN IF YOU DON'T HAVE LIKE SAY
THAT. THE GENERATORS TO GET TO
THEM YOURSELF DIRECTLY WHEN
SENATOR WHERE WHEN YOU CONSIDER.
A DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT WE
WANT TO THINGS WE LIKE TO TALK
TO YOU AND OTHERS ABOUT IS HOW
WE CAN PUT A PROGRAM. IN PLACE
AGAIN WE'RE LOOKING TRYING TO
LOOK BROADLY AT ALL THE
CUSTOMER NEEDS- ENCOURAGING
RESILIENCY AND ALSO. OCCUPYING
A REALISTIC SPACE IN AN HOUR
PROVIDING POWER TO WHAT WE CAN
REALLY DO GIVEN OUR REGION AND
THE NUMBER OF FOLKS WE HAVE
AND- AND WERE ACTUALLY SITTING
IN TERMS OF- OF SUPPLYING POWER
SO- WERE OPEN AND WE- WE WOULD
WELCOME THE CONVERSATIONS WITH
YOU AND YOUR TEAM ABOUT WHAT WE
COULD DO NEXT- IN A NUMBER
DIFFERENT BRANCHES INCLUDING.
WHAT WE MIGHT DO IN THE BACKUP
GENERATOR SPITTLE LAST THING
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND-
INCENTIVES SAY TO GO ON BY
TEMPORARY GENERATOR BUT- I KNOW
THAT YOU'RE HIT WITH DEPARTING
LOW CHARGES. AND OTHER FEES AND
ESSENTIALLY WHAT AMOUNTS TO A
FINE IF YOU DECIDE TO GO OFF
THE GRID. AND INSTALL SOLAR
STORAGE AT YOUR HOME AT THIS
POINT- SO WHAT ARE YOU GONNA BE
ADVOCATING IN THE PC GOING
FORWARD ON BEHIND THE METER
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES
AND MICRO GRIDS WE TALKED ABOUT
SB THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE
IMPLEMENTATION. ARE YOU UP FOR-
GETTING RID OF THOSE DEPARTING
LOW CHARGES IN INCENTIVIZING
PEOPLE TO SAY USE THIRD PARTIES
TO. TO GET OFF THAT ESPECIALLY
IN THESEMEDICALLY VULNERABLE
HIGH FIRE SEVERITY ZONE SORRY I
THINK JUST MAYBE BROADLY
SPEAKING BACK TO DEALERS ATION
AGAIN WE ARE WE ARE FOCUSED ON
HEARING ALL FEEDBACK. AND
LEARNING WHAT WE CAN FROM-
THESE EVENTS AND OUR CUSTOMER-
PAIN POINTS. OUR COMMUNITY PAIN
POINTS- RELATIVE TO DISTRIBUTE
ENERGY RESOURCES- BUT YOU JUST
WANT TO FOR ONE THING OUT WE
HAVE OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. D. E. OURS IN OUR
SYSTEM NOW- MEDICAL WASTE LIKE
REGRETS RIGHT- WE DO NOT HAVE A
COLD MICROWAVE RIGHT NOW WE'RE
DOING A PILOT- INSURGENCY TO
HIGH SCHOOL WITH A SOLAR
BATTERY UNIT- THAT SHOULD BE
ON. THE LINE FIRST QUARTER OF
NEXT YEAR. WE'RE VERY OPEN MY
GRADES IS. A HIGH COST BUT I
THINK IT'S CERTAIN SOLUTIONS.
CAN SITUATIONS THEY DO MAKE
SENSE- BUT WHAT I CAN SAY ABOUT
DR AS WE CONNECT AROUND FOUR
THOUSAND OF THOSE MONTH. LEAST
THAT WE ARE. WE CAN DIAZ AND
FRANKLY WOULD BE THOSE AS
COMPONENT. CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE RED WE'RE TRYING
TO LEAVE THE STORE. WE DO THINK
THE DEPARTING LOW SHOULD CARRY
A FAIR. SHARE OF THE FOLKS THE
END. OF THEIR CONTRIBUTION TO
COSTS THAT WE ENCOURAGED TO.
BUILD THE SYSTEM AND ENHANCE
THE SYSTEM SO THAT MIGHT BE
PART OF THE DEPARTING MODE
PEACE THAT WE MAKE STOP TO MAKE
SURE IS FAIR AND EQUITABLE-
WE'VE YOU D. E. OURS IS PART OF
THE FUTURE AND- WE ENCOURAGE
THEM. THANK YOU AND MISTER AND
CAN I JUST WANNA WRAP UP BY
SAYING. LOOK I KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF TENSION IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE ARE TALKING
ABOUT BREAKING UP P. JEANNIE
AND- THEY WANT TO SEE A WHOLE
NEW ENTITY COME OUT OF
BANKRUPTCY AND THERE'S A LOT OF
ANGER. I WILL TELL YOU MIGHT
PERSPECTIVE DESPITE THE OUTRAGE
THAT I SHARE WITH MY
CONSTITUENTS. WE WANT TO SEE IT
IS IN. MAKE IT THROUGH THIS AND
WE'RE COUNT NO WE BELIEVE IN
YOUR CORPORATE LEADERSHIP TO
GET THIS DONE- I HAVE NOT LOST
FAITH IN THIS. IN THIS UTILITY
PERSONALLY- WE KNOW THIS IS
HARD. BUT WE'RE COUNTING ON YOU
TO WORK WITH US AND SORT
THROUGH IS A THANK YOU FOR. I
TO WORK THROUGH A VERY TOUGH
PROBLEM AND HOPEFULLY THIS
WEEKEND IS. BETTER THE LAST FEW
WEEKS THANK YOU FOR THE
INTELLIGENCE MISTER CHAIRMAN.
pTHANK YOU MY SENATOR AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK
WE WILL TAKE TO CENTER. TAKE
THIS BACK. SIR BRADFORD. THANK
YOU THIS YEAR AND I DON'T WANT
TO SPEAK FOR MISTER INTERNET
WAS GONNA GO BACK TO THE
QUESTION THAT SENATOR MORLOCK
GAS AS IT RELATES TO. RULE
TWENTY A RULE TWENTY A FUNDS
CANNOT BE USED ON ANY OF THE
UNDERGROUND AND- THOSE RURAL
AREAS YOU WOULD HAVE TO BE A
RULE TWENTY BE OR TWENTY CITY
AND- MORE. I THINK ONE MORE
LINE A RULE TWENTY CITY. BUT
UNDERSTANDING. THE CUSTOMER
SHEARS COST IN THAT. UNDER RULE
TWENTY A IT'S CALCULATED BASED
ON THE NUMBER POPULATION OVER
HERE FACILITIES AND URBAN AREA.
ON A- COMMERCIAL STREET BUT
WHEN YOU GO OFF COMMERCIAL
STREET THEY BECOME A CRUEL
TWENTY EIGHT ROUTE TWENTY BMI
CORRECT. IT'S HARD TO
UNDERSTAND AND I'M ALL FOR
UNDERGROUND. WHERE IT'S
FEASIBLE- BUT IT'S A VERY
EXPENSIVE- TASKS IT'S ALMOST A
MILLION DOLLARS WAS MORE THAN
MILLION DOLLARS A MILE. AND ONE
ISSUES I WANT TO BRING UP IS
THAT WE ALL ASK FOR A NEW
GROUNDING BUT YOU CREATE
ANOTHER PROBLEM ONCE YOU
UNDERGROUND FACILITY. OUTAGES
ARE EVEN LONGER FOR THEIR
TROUBLE MEANT TO RESPOND WANT
TO FACILITIES UNDERGROUND SO I
JUST WANNA UNDERSTAND NINE TO
TEN CONSEQUENCES WE THINK. WE
CAN UNDERGROUND THIS IS STILL
ALL THERE INFRASTRUCTURE.
WITHOUT CAUSING. LONGER DELAYS
WHAT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT AFTER
REAL QUICK QUESTION AS IT
RELATES TO- LYING CLEARING. AND
THAT HAS BEEN A SUBJECT OF
GREAT CONTENTION- BOTH HERE AND
OUT IN THE COMMUNITY. AND AS A
FORMER EDISON EMPLOYEE WHO
REPRESENTED A URBAN AREA I KNEW
THE CHALLENGES OF. ACCESSING
JUST A RESIDENTIAL BACKYARD CAN
YOU EXPLAIN SOME THE CHALLENGES.
YOU FACE IN A WORLD WHERE AN
ACCESS AND SOME YOUR FACILITIES.
THOROUGHLY CENTER SITE I THINK
THERE'S A COUPLE DIMENSIONS YOU
SAID A RURAL AREA. SIR
UNDERSTANDABLY- PASSIONATE
ABOUT THEIR TREES ARE
VEGETATION- SO ACCESS CAN BE
SOMETHING OF A CHALLENGE- MANY
OR IS THAT WE ARE CLEARING ARE
NOT- A CUSTOMER OWN THEY'RE
ACTUALLY ON NATIONAL FOREST
LAND AND AREAS- SUCH AS THAT
SO- WE HAVE TO WORK TO
PERMITTING PROCESSES TO GET-
GET PERMISSION TO CLEAR
VEGETATION THOSE AREAS- BUT
EVEN WHILE AND URBAN INTERFACE-
VEGETATION CLEARING- IS A
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE CAN BE A
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE- WE
ULTIMATELY ARE MOVING OUR
CLEARANCE DISTANCES WHICH CAN
BE PERCEIVED AS A AS A SHOCK TO
SOME WHO HAVE SEEN BUDGETARY
SOME CLEARANCE- OVER THE YEARS
AT A MUCH LOWER DISTANCE FROM
TREES BUT WE'VE- CONCLUDED
THAT- MORE DISTANCE IS BETTER
IT. KEEPS A SAFER- SO I'D SAY
DOING- IN GAUGING WITH
CUSTOMERS ENGAGE WITH
COMMUNITIES HELPING. THEM
UNDERSTAND WHY WE'RE DOING THIS
IS PUBLIC SAFETY CONCERNS. ONE
OF OUR CHALLENGES- WE ARE WE
HAVE RAMPED UP DRAMATICALLY OUR
VEGETATION CRUZ I THINK PRICE
BETTER BOOK SOON. SEE WHAT THE
LARGE UNDERTAKING IS A WE HAVE
CLOSE TO MILLION TREES IN OUR
TRIM INVENTORY- WE HAVE SEVEN
HUNDRED CRUISE ATTITUDE A THREE
MAN CREW WORKING ON THESE UP
ALL TO ALL THE TIME SO THIS IS
AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF EFFORT
WE'RE DOING SO THERE'S
LOGISTICS ASSOCIATED WITH IT.
OB BUT IT'S ONE OF OUR
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS IT'S BEEN
AROUND FOR A LONG TIME WE HAVE
ENHANCED IT- OVER THE LAST YEAR
YEAR AND A HALF- AND IT'S AGAIN
ONE OF THE SIGNIFICANT ELEMENTS
ARE. WILD FIRE MITIGATION PLAN.
SO I ONE SUGGESTION AS IT
RELATES TO LINE CLEAR AND THE
COST THAT'S BEING INCURRED
SPECIALLY WITHOUT OUT OF STATE
CONTRACTORS. ALLIES IN SOME OF
THE SAME INMATES THERE ON THE
FIRE LINES THAT FIGHT THESE
FIRES INTO A LOT A LINE
CLEARING WHY WOULD YOU NOT
CONTRACT WITH THOSE INDIVIDUALS
AND ALLOW THEM TO DO IT VERSUS
BRINGING IN ALL THESE OUT OF
STATE CONTRACTORS. AND DRIVING
THE COST UP- WE HAVE FIVE IN A
LOT OF AREAS- NOT JUST OF
VEGETATION CLEARANCE BUT-
OVERALL CREWS THAT ACTUALLY DO
THE WORK- WE HAVE RAMPED UP OUR
HIRING IN STATE AND OUT OF
STATE AS WELL FOR THOSE SO WE
WOULD CERTAINLY. WANT TO BRING
AS MANY RESOURCES WE CAN ON THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT FRONT AND
WE ARE WILL CONTINUE TO HIRE
THEIR. IT'S A WEEK I WOULD SAY
WE HAVE PREFERENCE IN STATE OUT
OF STATE BUT- WE'VE- PROBABLY
HARD AS MANY FOLKS AS WE CAN IN
STATE. AND THE OUT OF STATE-
CREWS ARE MAKING UP SOME OF THE
SAUCE OR YOU OPPOSED TO THE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED TO BEING
PART OF THAT BECAUSE THAT'S ON
THE CHALLENGES THESE FOLKS DO
THAT WHILE THEY'RE IN PARTS
RATED BUT ONCE THEY'RE- FREE
AND OUT. THEY SEEM TO NOT BILL
TO GET A JOB DOING EXACTLY WHAT
THEY DID WHAT THEY WERE
INCARCERATED. CENTER WE'D WOULD
LIKE TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON
THAT ONE I DON'T HAVE A- DO YOU
ON THAT AT THIS POINT. THE
RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
HI ONE ADDRESS TWO ISSUES AS IT
RELATES TO THE SAFETY OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY IT AS IT PERTAINS TO
THE PSP HAS PROGRAM AND TALK
SLOW IT RELATES LIMIT TO A
MISTER- STERN SAID. REGARDS TO
HIS GRANDMOTHER- OF COURSE SHE
WAS LIKE ENOUGH TO HAVE SOMEONE
TO GO TO BUT MY QUESTION IS
THERE SEEMS TO BE A DISCONNECT
CONSISTENTLY COMMUNITIES AND
ORGANIZATION BUT- I'M JUST
WONDERING WERE HAVING AN ISSUE
OF NOT. FIFTEEN COMMUNITY
RESOURCE CENTERS NUMBER TWO IS
A TRUST ISSUE THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT THESE CENTERS ARE- AND I
KNOW THAT MOST LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ALREADY HAVE
PROGRAMS IN THE DEAL EMERGENCY
DRILLS FOR. EITHER EARTHQUAKES
AND OTHER STUFF RIGHT SO THEY
ALREADY HAVE SORT OF A SYSTEM
IN PLACE WHERE- IF NOT I'LL
SPEAK TO MY OWN COMMUNITIES I
KNOW THAT OUR SENIOR CENTER IS
TO PICK UP OUR SENIORS EIGHT.
THEY KNOW WHERE THEY'RE OUT THE
KNOLL HOW TO GET IN CONTACT
WITH EACH OTHER IN OUR SENIORS
IN OUR MOST VULNERABLE ALREADY
TRUSTS OUR COMMUNITY CENTER
HAVE YOU CONSIDERED PARTNER
WITH CITIES AND ALLOWING THEM
TO RUN THEIR OWN CENTERS AND
PERHAPS REIMBURSE SOME. AFTER
THE FACT YEAH ON CO SENATOR I'M
NOT SURE. BACK UP WE HAVE IN
THE INSTANCES THAT WE HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN PARTNERED WITH-
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES POINTS THAT
MAY HAVE- SOME INFRASTRUCTURE
LIBRARY OR SOMETHING ALREADY
OPEN AND NO THAT'S NOT NOT WHAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO RIGHT OW-
ONE OF OUR PARTNER
ORGANIZATIONS IN THIS IS THE
RED CROSS SO WE'RE TEAMING WITH
THE RED CROSS. IN BUILDING OUT
ADDITIONAL COMMUNITY RESOURCE
CENTERS- WE'RE OPEN TO ANY AND
ALL PROGRAMS AGAIN WE ARE HERE
TO SEEK FEEDBACK AND THAT'S
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVEN'T
EXPLORED CENTER RUBIO AND LIKE
TO FOLLOW IF YOU AND YOUR TEAM.
A WHAT THAT MIGHT LOOK LIKE-
PART OF OUR MEDICAL BASELINE
PROGRAM IS TO PARTNER WITH
COMMUNTY ORGANIZATIONS THAT WE
HAVE HISTORICALLY. BEEN
PARTNERED WITH DIDN'T TO OUR
HELP OUR VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
WE ARE LEVERAGING THOSE
MECHANISMS- AND THOSE PROGRAMS
AND- AND PARTNERSHIPS AND
COLLABORATIONS THAT ARE ALREADY
IN PLACE- WE'RE TRYING TO DO
THAT AS MUCH AS WE CAN- I THINK
IS THE C. R. C. IT'S NOT ONLY A-
WE'VE GOT THOSE WITH KMART AND
SEARS AND ARE. LOOKING AT SOME
OTHER RETAILERS THAT WE CAN I
HAVE THE CENTERS. IN TO A
PROVIDE. SERVICES. CAN
FACILITIES AND OTHER THINGS TO
HELP PEOPLE ON THE INCIDENT.
BUT LEVERAGING MORE MORE
RESOURCES ARE UP AND RUNNING UP
WERE VERY VERY OPEN TO THAT.
WELL AND I'VE HEARD A YOU KNOW
I APPRECIATE THE RED CROSS Là
YOU KNOW VERY MUCH I KNOW THEY
DO A LOT FOR COMMITTEES BUT I
CAN TELL YOU WITHOUT PROGRAMS
WHERE. THEY GIVE VOUCHERS FOR
VICTIMS TO STAND HOTELS IN OUR
COMMITTEES WILL NOT REACH OUT
THEY DON'T NECESSARILY TRUST
YOU'RE GONNA STATION. FOR
VARIOUS REASONS FOR THEM IT'S A
COMFORT ISSUE. LIBRARIES IT'S
NOT A COMFORT ZONE YOU KNOW YOU
KNOW IT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
LIKE A- SENIOR CENTER COMMUNITY
CENTERS ALREADY THERE'S A TRUST
FACTOR. THEY ALREADY KNOW WHO
THESE FOLKS ARE THEY HAVE THEIR
PHONE NUMBERS IT'S A DIFFERENT
TYPE OF LET'S SAY. CONNECTION
AND SO I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
INSTEAD OF SPENDING A WILL TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WORKS OR
NOT THERE ALREADY HAVE A SYSTEM
IN PLACE BUT- YOU KNOW JUST
WANT TO PUT IT ON YOUR RADAR
THEY ALREADY. HAVE THE
CONNECTION THEY ALREADY KNOW
THE SENIORS AND MEDICALLY FRONT
FRAGILE INDIVIDUALS ARE- THEY
ALREADY HAVE THEIR STAFF IT
WOULD BE A MATTER OF JUST.
LETTING THEM HANDLE IT AND THEN
MAYBE GET REIMBURSED LATER
INSTEAD OF SPENDING MONEY
ELSEWHERE. SENATOR THAT CD KIND
OF PARTNERSHIP AND STRUCTURE
THAT WE REALLY ARE LOOKING TO-
TO- TEAM UP WITH. AND PROVIDE A
WAY OF GETTING MORE MORE
INFORMATION AND POTENTIALLY.
RESOURCE OF THESE COMMUNITIES
OUT I GUESS ARE JUST REQUEST
THAT UP PERHAPS AFTER THE
SESSION. WE CAN HAVE A
DISCUSSION WITH YOU AND OUR OUR
TEAM TO FIND OUT WHAT THIS
MIGHT LOOK LIKE AND EXPLORE
THAT. WE'VE COVERED A LOS LIST
AND THERE ARE MANY MANY THINGS
IN OUR PROGRAM- THAT HAVE COME
FROM DIALOGUE SUCH AS THIS SORT
OF HELP INFORM US. AS TO WAYS
TO MAKE A PROGRAM BETTER-
UNLESS IMPACT OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE CARE ABOUT.
I THINK IT SOUNDS LIKE ONE OF
THEM- PERHAPS SOMETHING HAS
BEEN DONE. ACROSS OUR COMPANY
THAT THE NAVY IS ADVANCE SAID
AGAIN I DID MENTION- WE'VE
COMMUNITY. TEAMED UP WITH A
NUMBER COMMUNITIES AS PART OF
OUR. IT'S ALL COMMUNITY SO.
THIS IS A HAVING COMMITTEE SEES
ME THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
ARE VERY VERY OPEN TO
LEVERAGING OUR PARTNERSHIPS I
KNOW OUR- THE GIVING ASPECTS OF
OUR ORGANIZATION. ARE TEAMING
UP BUT WE MAY BE MISSING
SOMETHING TO TEAR YOU'RE
LOOKING AT SPECIFICALLY SO.
PLEASE HELP US OUT AND THANK
YOU. AND CAL CENTER GALGIANI-
THIS IS JUST A CONSTRUCTIVE
SUGGESTION THAT I OFFER THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
EVERY YEAR HAS DONE AS- A
CALIFORNIA DENTAL CARES AND-
THEY HAVE THESE- DENTAL FAIRS
AROUND THE STATE WHERE THEY
INVITE NOW THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS TO COME AND GET
CARE FOR THE DAY. THEY HAVE
BECOME EXPERTS AT TRIAGE BEING
PEOPLE WHO SHOW UP WITH
WHATEVER DENTAL NEED IT WOULD
BE WHETHER IT'S FROM EXTRACTING
A TOOTH OR PROVIDING AN IMPLANT
OR DEALING WITH AN INFECTION.
THE POINT BEING THAT. I KNOW
THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE WORKING WITH
THE RED CROSS AND HOUSING PIECE
OF T BUT THE DENTAL
ASSOCIATION PUTS TOGETHER WHERE
THEY TRIAGE. DENTAL NEEDS WHICH
HAS A PARALLEL WITH THE NEEDS
THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO SERVE
WHEN IT COMES TO PATIENTS WHO
HAVE. THE MEDICAL NEEDS
MEDICATIONS OF BEING ON AN OX
OF THE OXYGEN TANK WHATEVER IT
WOULD BE SO IT JUST WOULD SEEN
THAT. THERE COULD BE SOME
LESSONS LEARNED I ATTENDED A
SOME OF THESE MANY YEARS AGO
TEN FIFTEEN YEARS AGO AND I
ATTENDED. JUST AGAIN LAST YEAR
AND IN THE. JEAN NUMBER BAY
GROWN IMMENSELY AND THE ABILITY
TO AND TRIAGE THOUSANDS OF
PATIENTS ALL AT ONCE EIGHT WITH
SUCH SMOOTH TRANSITION I WOULD
THINK THAT YOU COULD JUST. HAVE
SOME TIPS THAT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL CONSTRUCTIVE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR APPRECIATE
THAT SUGGESTION AS WELL THANK
YOU. SENATOR WINNER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN. SO I
APPRECIATE- THAT YOU EXPRESSED-
EDISON'S- DESIRE TO EXPAND-
ENERGY STORAGE TO THE PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE TO RELY ON DIESEL
GENERATORS AND- AND CAN HAVE
THAT BACK UP BOB POWER WHEN THE
LIGHTS GO OUT- SO UNFORTUNATELY
MY EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN I
MENTIONED THIS IN MY OPENING
AROUND P. GINNY BUT ALSO
RELATES ADDISON- THAT- EDISON
HAS- NOT ALWAYS BUT OFTEN BEEN
VERY OPPOSITIONAL TO EFFORTS TO
EXPAND- DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES SUCH AS ENERGY
STORAGE- AND WE WERE ABLE TO
PASS- SB SEVEN HUNDRED TO RENEW
THE ESTá PROGRAM AND I
APPRECIATE THAT DESCENDED WORK
WITH US- ON THAT SO THANK YOU.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY ADDISON ALONG
WITH PGA ANY- HAS AND I BELIEVE
US TO GINNY AS WELL- HAS DOZENS
GONE INTO THE SI PC- AND-
VACATED FOR NOT FULLY FUNDING-
AS CHIP- AND SPECIFICALLY-
ADDISON HAS PROPOSED- DIED IT
SHOULD BE DONE BEAUTIFULLY EYES
INDEPENDENT TO YOUR PROGRAMS
YOU PROJECT FOR TWO YEARS AND
YOU FUNDED REDUCTION FUND THAT
WAS OF COURSE COMPLETELY
DEFEATS THE POINT OF THE
PROGRAM THE BEST IS A YOU HAVE
A LONG ENOUGH ONE WAY. THAT THE
INDUSTRY WERE WILL RELY ON IT
AND IN A VERY AND OF INVEST SO
THAT WECAN MAKE I HAVE BETTER
ENERGY STORAGE AND CHEAPER
ENERGY STORAGE- SO GIVEN
EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING WITH THESE BLACKOUTS
AND THE NEED TO HAVE A CLEAN
ENERGY STORAGE AND SET OF
DIESEL GENERATORS- CAN I CAL ON
ADDISON TO STOP OPPOSING THE
FULL FUNDING ABOUT CHIP IN THE
STOP OPPOSING THE EXPANSION. OF
THE DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES. SO AT THANK YOU
SENATOR WINNER AND I. DON'T
HAVE A- PRICE OR TEMA DE IS
WITH ME TODAY SO WE HAVE TO
FOLLOW THE I JUST. DID YOU WANT
TO COME BACK TO- BUT WHAT I DO
IS- A RELATIVE OR OF US SUPPORT
FOR DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES NOT WITHSTANDING
ASKED HIM- I MEANT TO THE
NUMBERS OF. FOLKS WE HAVE
ONLINE- WE JUST RELEASED OUR
COMMUNITY PATHWAY. A DOCUMENT
IT ALSO TALKS ABOUT THE
CRITICALITY WHO DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY RESOURCES AS PART OF A
CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE IN
CALIFORNIA SO. WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE- I WOULD PROBABLY
HAVE TO SPEND MORE TIME WITH
THE UNDERSTAND. SOME OF THE-
SPECIFICS THAT ARE LEADING TO
NOT SUPPORTING FULL FUNDING OF
THAT PROGRAM. SO I FIGURED I
MEAN THE I. R. USE OUR VIEW AT
SOME SORT OF THREAT- AND
FRANKLY THE REASON THAT THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR INITIATIVE WAS
SO SUCCESSFUL IN THE AND
HELPING. DEPLOY THAT SOLAR IS
BECAUSE IT HAD A LONG ENOUGH
RUNWAY AND WAS FULLY FUNDED-
BUT THE EFFORTS OF BY THE
UTILITIES TO UNDERMINE ITS TIP
IS VERY PROBLEMATIC AND I DO
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT. THANK
CENTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THANK YOU FOR COMING HERE TODAY
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. THE LAST BILL
JOHNSON AND THE- P. GINNY TEAM
TO. COME FORWARD NOW. PUT ME
DOWN FOR A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
FOR HIM IN. YEAH WITH ALL THAT.
YEAH AND THE SHOW HERE
. THANK
YOU WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS THANK
YOU FOR CONVENING US TO TALK
ABOUT THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. AS
YOU MIGHT CAN TELL NOT IN FULL
VOICE TODAY. HOW DO MY BEST I'M
HERE THEY WERE SEVERAL MY
COLLEAGUES OR GMO NOW WHO IS
OUR CHIEF CUSTOMER OFFICER. AND
SHE MEETS SAYING WHO IS THE VP
IN CHARGE OF THE COMMITTEE WELL
FIRE SAFETY PROGRAM. AND WE'RE
HERE TO TALK ABOUT LAST MONTH'S
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF
VINCE INITIATED BY PEACHY IN A-
THESE EVENTS RESULT IN TURNING
UP POWER FOR SAFETY ON FIVE
SEPARATE OCCASIONS. OVER FIVE
WEEKS AFFECTING MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THIRTY
EIGHT COUNTIES. AS A POINT OF
COMPARISON P. JEANNIE ONLY DEAR
JUDGE ONE TIME. PRIOR TO TWENTY
NINETY SO THIS IS RELATIVELY
NEW TO US ALL. PART OF MY
REPORTER ALSO DESCRIBED THE
BASIS FOR THESE DECISIONS ALONG
WITH THE SCALE AND DURATION OF
THE SHOT OFF AND ARE
RESTORATION WORK. AND I'LL
SHARE THE LESSONS WE LEARNED
ABOUT BETTER MANAGING THESE
EVENTS AND REDUCING THEIR
IMPACT. THE NEXT TIME EXTREME
WEATHER REQUIRES FACING SUCH
DECISIONS AGAIN. AND FINALLY I
WANT TO CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION
THAT ARE. PER COLLEAGUES HAD
ABOUT HOW WE'RE WORKING TOWARD
A FUTURE WHERE THE KIND OF
LARGE SCALE SHUT OFF WE'VE
EXPERIENCED. ARE NO LONGER
NECESSARY. PARDON ME. FIRST LET
ME EMPHASIZE A BASIC FACT IT.
REALLY SHOULD BE OBVIOUS BY
THINGS EASILY LOST IN THE
TURBULENT ATMOSPHERE AROUND
THIS. WE DON'T ACTUALLY WANT TO
TURN ANYBODY'S POWER OFF. IT'S
THE LAND OF HIS GOT INTO THIS
BUSINESS IS NOT THE WAY WE WANT
TO SERVE CUSTOMERS WE REALLY
DON'T WANT TO DO THAT. AND WE
RECOGNIZE THE LIVING WITHOUT
POWER IS MORE THAN JUST AN
INCONVENIENCE FOR MANY IS A
HARDSHIP. WITH POTENTIALLY
SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES FROM
DISRUPTED ROUTINES AND SCHOOL
CLOSURES. STRAINED BUDGETS AND
LOST INCOME AND FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE AMONG US. THOSE WHO
DEPEND ON LIFE SUSTAINING
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT CANNOT AFFORD
TO REPLACE LOST FOOD. LOSING
POWER FOR AN EXTENDED PERIOD
CAN COME WITH CONSIDERABLE FEAR
AND SAFETY RISKS. SO NONE OF US
WANT TO LIVE IN THAT WORLD. BUT
WE'RE DOING THIS WITH THE
SINGULAR PURPOSE OF PREVENTING
THE DEADLY CATASTROPHIC FIRES
WE'VE SEEN IN RECENT YEARS.
NONE OF US WANTS TO SEE THOSE
HAPPEN AGAIN EITHER. I THINK IT
MIGHT BE WORTH A MOMENT HERE TO.
LOOK AT HOW WE GOT TO THIS
POINT CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY IN
THE SPEED OF CHANGE AROUND US.
OVER THE PAST FEWYEARS THE
WILD FIRE RISK IN OUR SERVICE
AREA ALONE HAS INCREASED AT A
RATE THAT FEW. COULD IMAGINE.
REGIONALES TWENTY TWELVE THE
PARTS OF THE STATE DESIGNATED
AS HAVING AN ELEVATED RISK OF
WILDFIRE MADE UP LESS THAN 15%
OF P. JEANNIE SERVICE AREA. IN
NORTHERN AND CENTRAL CALIFORNIA.
IN FACT IN TWENTY TEN- TWELVE
IN DEALING WITH THE S. P. S.
IMMENSELY AT A DIFFERENT NAME
THEN. THE CPUC SAID THIS QUOTE
THERE'S NO HISTORY OF
CATASTROPHIC POWER LINE FIRES
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA DOESN'T
EXPERIENCE THE SANTA ANA WINDS
TO CONTRIBUTE SIGNIFICANTLY TO
THE RISK OF CATASTROPHIC POWER
LINE FIRES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. BUT THAT CHANGED
AND CHANGED SIGNIFICANTLY IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN MORE THAN EIGHT
THOUSAND FIRES BURNED ACROSS
CALIFORNIA BURNED TWO MILLION
ACRES. AND ALTHOUGH ELECTRIC
EQUIPMENT HISTORICALLY HAS
BECAUSE LESS THAN 10% OF
WILDFIRES. ACCOUNT FOR ROUGHLY
HALF OF THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
AND NEED AS BROAD PS PS TO THE
FORE AS A TOOL TO ENSURE PUBLIC
SAFETY PARTICULARLY NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. SO WHAT DOES THIS
MEAN FOR P. GINNY AS CUSTOMERS
WHY THE INCREASE IN PS PS
EVENTS. BECAUSE THE RISK OF
FIRE HAS INCREASED DRAMATICALLY
TODAY THAT RISK FOOTPRINT OF
LESS THAN 15% TWENTY TWELVE.
DOWN VALVES MORE THAN 50% OF
PIGEON A SYSTEM. THAT'S SYSTEM
COVER SEVENTY THOUSAND SQUARE
MILES SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND AND FORTY THOUSAND
SQUARE MILES OF HIGH FIRE
THREAT AREA. LET'S JUST THINK
ABOUT THAT FOR A MINUTE. THE
RISK EXPOSURE THIS ENERGY
NETWORK CONSERVE SIXTEEN
MILLION PEOPLE IS MORE THAN
TRIPLE A 3100% INCREASE. OVER
APPEAR THAT MOST COMPANIES IN
THIS INDUSTRY WOULD CONSIDER
THE BLINK OF AN EYE. AND SO WE
HAVE TO COPE WITH THIS
HEIGHTENED RISK THE BEST THAT
WE CAN AND TURNING UP POWER FOR
SAFETY IS AN EFFECTIVE TOOL. AS
OUR COLLEAGUE SAID EARLIER
REALLY ONLY ONE OFTHE MANY
TOOLS WERE USING. TO BRING DOWN
THE RISK OF HIGH WINDS DRY
CONDITIONS AND ELECTRICAL
EQUIPMENT THAT CAN CAUSE A
SPARK. AND WE WILL GET BETTER
USING. SO WHAT IS THE SYSTEM WE
HAVE TODAY WHAT SORT OF SHAPE
IS IT IN AND HOW WELL SUITED
ISN'T TO THIS NEW LEVEL OF RISK.
FIRST THERE'S A PERCEPTION AND
I HEARD HERE TODAY. THAT OUR
SYSTEM IS IN SHAMBLES THAT WE
HAVEN'T INVESTED IN. AND THAT
WE'RE TURNING OFF THE POWER
BECAUSE WE'VE NEGLECTED THE
EQUIPMENT. SO I'VE HEARD THIS A
LOT I'VE BEEN HERE SIX MONTHS.
EVER DISALLOWED THAT SIX MONTHS
AND I OF MOSTLY AVOIDED
ANSWERING THIS QUESTION BY
SAYING I CAME TO LOOK FORWARD
NOT BACK. OF. BUT I GOT IT HAS
SO MANY TIMES I THOUGHT I WOULD
INVESTIGATE WHAT THE FACTS. AND
SO HERE THE FAX OVER THE LAST
TEN YEARS P. GINNY HAS INVESTED
MORE THAN THIRTY BILLION
DOLLARS. IN HIS ELECTRIC
TRANSMISSION AND DISTRIBUTION
ASSETS. IN UTILITY SPACE
PROFITS ARE GENERALLY DESCRIBED
AS EARNING THE RETURN THE
COMMISSION SUCH FOR YOU. OVER
THE LAST TEN YEARS FUSION IS
TAKEN TWO BILLION DOLLARS OF
THAT RETURN. AND PUT IT BACK
INTO THE ELECTRIC SYSTEM SO I
CAN PUT THIS IN ANY GREATER
CONTEXT FOR YOU BUT THOSE ARE
SORT OF THE NUMBERS OF WHAT
HAPPENED OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS. MORE RECENTLY HE WE
FINISHED AN UNPRECEDENTED
PROCESS TO INSPECT EVERY
ELEMENT OF OUR ELECTRIC SYSTEM
WITHIN THE HIGH FIRE THREAT
AREAS. WE INSPECTED ALMOST
SEVEN HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND TRANSMISSION
DISTRIBUTION SUBSTATIONS
STRUCTURES. OVER TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DISCRETE ELECTRICAL
COMPONENTS. WE CLIMB THESE
THINGS WE USE DRONES WE
PERFORMED EIGHTEEN MONTHS OF
INSPECTIONS IN ABOUT FOUR
MONTHS. WHATEVER WE FOUND
EQUIPMENT THE NEEDED IMMEDIATE
REPAIR WE FIXED OR REPLACED.
WE'LL BE SURE THAT EVERY PIECE
OF ELECTORAL QUITMAN WITHIN THE
NEXT TO THE HIGH FIRE THREAT
AREA IS SUITABLE TO SERVE OUR
CUSTOMERS AND SYSTEM. ON
MANAGING VEGETATION LONG RIGHT
AWAY AS ALONE WE SPENT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE LAST
TEN YEARS. THE LAST TWO YEARS
WE TRIMMED ALMOST SEVEN MILLION
TREES REMOVED A HALF A MILLION
DEAD TREES. ARE VEGETATION
CLEARANCE EFFORT SUCCEEDS THEY
REQUIRE. BUT THE FACT IS NO MAN
OF TREE CLEARING CAN PREVENT
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES ARE
WINDBLOWN DEBRIS FROM HITTING
AND IMPACTING OUR CLICK. TWO
ENORMOUS THERE ARE WORK WILL
NEVER BE DONE WHEN IT COMES TO
SAFETY OR DETERMINE TO GET A
RIGHT. BUT WE BELIEVE WE MAKE
IT MAY GET A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF RISK WITH THESE PS PS VENTS.
SO NOW FEW SPECIFICS ABOUT THE
OCTOBER EVENTS. NUMBER OF
CUSTOMERS AFFECTED NAY ANYONE'S
FIJIAN AVAIL WAS NINE HUNDRED
FORTY ONE THOUSAND AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER THOSE OR
ACCOUNTS WERE METERS SO YOU CAN
MULTIPLY THAT ROUGHLY BY TWO
AND A HALF TIMES TO GET TO THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE AFFECTED WHICH
IS REALLY. THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING. OUR RECORDS SHOW THE
LONGER STUDIES PERIOD WAS FIVE
DAYS AGAIN DURING THE FINAL
WEEK OF OCTOBER WHEN WE SAW TWO
METEOROLOGICAL SYSTEMS. THE
SEVERE WINDS ONLY FORTY EIGHT
HOURS APART. EXTREME WEATHER
THE PROPERTIES TO SHUT OFF WAS
A ONE IN THIRTY YEAR VAN WITH
SOME OF THE STRONGEST WINDS
EVER RECORDED IN THE REGION.
INCLUDING GUSTIN SONMA COUNTY
OF A HUNDRED TWO MILES AN HOUR.
AND OVER SEVENTY MILE OUR IN
MANY OTHER PLACES HUMIDITY
LEVELS WERE EXTREMELY LOW. WITH
BONE DRY AIR MORE TYPICAL OF
THE MOJAVE DESERT IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND WHEN HIS
HISTORIC WIN SUBSIDED MORE THAN
SIX THOUSAND FIELD PERSONNEL
ALONG WITH MORE THAN NINE
HUNDRED MUTUALLY TEAMS FROM THE
INDUSTRY ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
INSPECTED THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
SORT OF MILES OF TRANSMISSION
AND DISTRIBUTION WAS MORE THAN
ENOUGH TO CIRCLE THE EARTH.
FOUND HUNDREDS OF INSTANCES OF
EQUIPMENT DAMAGE TO THE
LECTURES. PRIMARILY IN THE FORM
OF TREES AND BRANCHES INTO OUR
LINES FROM BEYOND THE
BOUNDARIES OF THE RIGHT AWAY.
CHINESE EXTREME WEATHER
CONDITIONS FIERCE WINDS NEAR
ZERO HUMIDITY IN THE PARTIAL
LANDSCAPE. PARDON ME THESE
TYPES OF HAZARDS COULD HAVE
SPARKED THE DEADLY CATASTROPHIC
FIRE. AND PREVENTING THIS
OUTCOME IS EXACTLY AND THE SOLE
REASON WE CALL THESE P. S. P.
S. OF IT. PUBLIC SAFETY IS WHAT
THIS IS ALL ABOUT IN OUR
PRIORITY MUST BE TO PROTECT
HUMAN LIVES. ABOVE ALL ELSE.
LOOKING BACK OVER THESE EVENTS
WE KNOW OUR PERFORMANCE WASN'T
PERFECT. THE. PARTICULARLY IN
THE OCTOBER NINTH EVENT AND NOW
WE CAN AND WILL AND HAVE TO DO
BETTER FOR EXAMPLE OUR WEBSITE
CRASH SEVERAL TIMES. OUR MAPS
WERE INCONSISTENT OR CALL
CENTERS ROVER LOADED MAINLY
AFFECTED BY THE WEBSITE
PROBLEMS. OUR LEVEL OF
COMMUNICATION AND COORDINATION
WITH THE RELEVANT STATE LOCAL
AND TRIBAL AGENCIES FELL SHORT
OF THE MARK. AND WE LEARN FROM
THE SHORTCOMINGS IN FAILURES WE
LISTEN TO SEE BACK WE'VE
RECEIVED. AND WE PERFORMED OUR
WE'VE IMPROVED OUR PERFORMANCE
EACH TIME. THE P. S. P. S.
EVENTS LATER IN THE MONTH
DEMONSTRATED THAT WE ARE
CONSTANTLY WORKING TOGETHER. TO
GET BETTER SO ARE WE DOING TO
GET BETTER. OUR PS PS
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM HAS BEEN
EXPANDED REFINED TO REACH MORE
PEOPLE MORE RELIABLY. OUR
WEBSITE AND CALL CENTERS ARE
NOW WE WILL HAVE A MUCH HIGHER
LEVELS OF TRAFFIC AND DID SO
WITHOUT INCIDENT IN THE LATER
EVENTS. SHARPENING THE QUALITY
OF OUR OUTREACH MAPS. AND WE'VE
IMPROVE COORDINATION AND
COMMUNICATION WITH A GOVERNMENT
AGENCY PARTNERS INCLUDING
WELCOMING MEMBERS OF CAL- YES
CAL FIRE AND THE CPC TO WORK
ALONGSIDE US. IN OUR EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS CENTER. BUT THERE'S
A LARGER LESSON TO BE DRAWN
HERE ONE THAT WE UNDERSTAND
EQUALLY WELL AND THAT IS
REPEATEDLY TURNING OFF POWER
FROM MILLIONS OF PEOPLE. IN ONE
OF THE MOST ADVANCED ECONOMIES
IN THE WORLD EVEN IN THE
INTEREST OF SAFETY. IS NOTA
SUSTAINABLE SOLUTION TO THE
WILDFIRE THREATS WE FACE. CHAU
ASSURE YOU OF THIS WE DO NOT
EXPECT AN ANNUAL REPEAT OF WHAT
WE WENT THROUGH THIS OCTOBER.
AND WHAT WE PUT OUR CUSTOMERS
AND OTHERS THROUGH THAT JUST
CANNOT HAPPEN AGAIN. WE'RE
WORKING TO NARROW THE SCOPE AND
DURATION OF FUTURE SAFETY SHUT
OFFS AND MINIMIZE YOUR CUSTOMER
IMPACT AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
WE'RE HARNESSING NEW TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGIES TO HELP US DO THAT
INCLUDING MORE WEATHER STATIONS
AND CAMERAS TO PROVIDE MORE
PRECISE LOCAL DATA. AS WELL AS
SEXUAL LODGING DEVICES AND
TEMPORARY GENERATION THAT ALLOW
US TO TARGET THE SHUT OFF AND
KEEP THE POWER ON FOR MORE
PEOPLE. THE SINGLE. HELP
THEY'LL HELP TREMENDOUSLY EVEN
BEFORE NEXT FIRE SEASON. IN
FACT WE HAVE A SIMILAR HISTORIC
WINDOW VENT NEXT OCTOBER WE
BELIEVE THE WORK THEY WERESCOPING RIGHT NOW CAN REDUCE
THAT OVERALL THE FOOTPRINT BY
AT LEAST ONE THE- EVER THINKING
CREATIVELY ABOUT OTHER WAYS TO
HELP OUR CUSTOMERS AND
COMMUNITIES GET THROUGH THESE
OUTAGES WITH LESS HARM AN
INCONVENIENCE. WE'LL SPAR
PARTNERSHIPS FROM THE STATE TO
ACHIEVE THESE IMPROVEMENTS. BUT
THAT'S THE PACE OF CHANGE THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT IN THE NEAR
TERM OVER THE LONGER TERM WILL
CONTINUE TO HARDEN OUR SYSTEM
IS STRONG THE WIRES AND POLES
MANAGING VEGETATION. AND
PUTTING MORE OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE UNDERGROUND
CERTAIN AREAS. SO CLOSE I WANT
TO ASSURE EVERYONE THE
CHALLENGE OF PROVIDING ELECTRIC
SERVICE IN AN INCREASINGLY
HAZARDOUS ENVIRONMENT IS ONE
THAT OUR COMPANY MUST AND WILL
MASTER FOR OUR CUSTOMERS. THIS
ISSUE THAT WE AND MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS CARE DEEPLY ABOUT.
WE MEETING ON MY TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND COLLEAGUES IN THE GYM
NAY AT ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE
FACING THAT CHALLENGE SQUARELY
AND WE WELCOME THE ATTENTION OF
THIS COMMITTEE. AND WITH THAT
WE'LL BE GLAD TO TAKE YOUR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL BEGIN WITH OUR
VICE CHAIR CENTER MORE LUCK I'M
SORRY WITH BECAUSE CENTER
NIELSEN OR REGISTER. SORRY MR
JOHNSON I APPRECIATE YOUR.
DESIRE AND FOCUS ON THE HEAD
AND INDEED WE MUST WE CAN'T
LOOK AHEAD WITHOUT LOOKING A
LITTLE BIT BACK. IN IT IS A
LITTLE BIT UNNERVING TO ME THAT.
SO MANY THESE THINGS THAT. YOU
AND OTHERS HAVE IMPLEMENTED.
ONLY OCCUR WHEN WE'VE HAD THIS
TREMENDOUS FIRE. PROBLEM IN
CALIFORNIA. NOW THE FIRE
PROBLEM INTO DEVELOPING FOR
DECADES GLOBAL WARMING FOR MORE
THAN DECADES. AND THE
ACCUMULATION OF FUELS AND ARE
FORCING A WHILE LANCE MANY
DECADES. AND BY THE WAY THAT'S
A STATE AND FEDERAL PROBLEM TOO
AND THIS COMMITTEE WOULD BE
DOING A DISSERVICE IF WE DO
NOT. EXAMINE STATE AND FEDERAL
pACCUMULATION OF FUELS.
SOMETHING THAT DOES AFFECT YOU
BUT YOU DON'T SO ENTIRELY
CONTROL. I UNDERSTAND THAT. BUT
TO THE POINT THE COMMUNICATIONS.
IT WOULD SEEM TO ME THAT SUCH
DISASTERS COULD HAVE BEEN
ANTICIPATED AND COMMUNICATION
MECHANISMS AND PRIORITIZE
HAITIANS IT COULD HAVE BEEN
ANTICIPATED AND EXIT AT YOUR
EXIGENCY SET UP FOR THAT IN
ADVANCE. IT SEEMS TO ME LIKE
THIS IS REALLY BEEN GOING ON
THE WAY. UP FOR EXAMPLE THIS
NOTIFICATION OF THE NEXT ROUND
THAT WAS FAR BETTER THAN THE
ONES THAT I'VE RECEIVED BEFORE.
SO YOU ARE IMPROVE. BUT IT
WOULD SEEM LIKE THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT COULD HAVE BEEN.
ANTICIPATED AND IF THE
COMMUNICATION THAT WAS KIND OF
ONE OF THE GREAT IRONIES THAT
I'VE RECALL. THERE'S BEEN
SEVERAL CONFERENCE CALLS WITH
LEADERS ABOUT WHAT WAS GOING ON.
ONE OF THE FIRST CONFERENCE
CALLS FAILED. EVEN THE
CONFERENCE CALL. DIDN'T WORK.
AND THAT CERTAINLY CONCERNED ME
A LITTLE BIT. AND THE COMMUNITY
RESOURCE CENTERS THAT WOULD BE
ANOTHER THING THAT I WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT. HAVE BEEN ANTICIPATED.
THE LOCATIONS OF THEM HOME HAVE
BEEN INCONVENIENT OR IMPOSSIBLE
FOR SOME. AND WE'VE HAD AN
AWFUL LOT OF COMPLAINTS ABOUT
THEM RUNNING OUT OF SUPPLIES SO
WHAT IS THE VALUE OF IT. IF THE
SUPPLIES HAVE DIMINISHED OR NOT
AVAILABLE. AND THEY'RE NOT AS
ACCESSIBLE. BUT JUST A FEW
WOULD HAZARD SOME OBSERVATIONS
ABOUT THAT AND- THOSE POINTS
THAT I'VE RACED. CERTAINLY
THANK SENATOR- COUPLE THINGS
FIRST OF ALL AS I SAID THIS IS
ALL RELATIVELY NEW TO US. WE
STARTED THIS YEAR WITH SEVERAL
SMALL EVENTS. ON THE ORDER OF
400-005-0000 CUSTOMERS IN THOSE
WENT WELL. AND SO I THINK WE
GOT A LITTLE COMPLACENT WE HAD
FIGURED OUT AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
WE SCALED UP TO. YOU KNOW
TWENTY TIMES THAT SIZE. IN THE
NEXT EVENT- THE OTHER THING AND
JUST AN OBSERVATION. I THINK WE.
THOUGHT THE BIG EVENT WAS
TURNING OFF THE POWER BECAUSE
FOR US THIS IS AN UNNATURAL ACT
HEROES IN UTILITY BUSINESS YOUR
JOB IS TO KEEP THE POWER ON
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN. I THINK WE
FOCUSED ON THAT IS THE MAIN
EVENT INSTEAD OF THE IMPACT OF
THAT. RIGHT ON THE ON THE
PEOPLE IN AFFECTED SO I THINK
THOSE ARE THE TWO SORT OF BASIC
LEARNINGS WE WEREN'T AS WELL AS
WE THOUGHT. AND WE NEED TO GIVE
A LITTLE MORE ATTENTION A LOT
MORE ATTENTION TO. IMPACTS HAVE
TO SHUT THE POWER OFF AND I DO
THINK AS THINGS WENT ON WE GOT
BETTER AND EACH ONE OF THESE.
HOPING NEVER TO MASTER IT. BUT
I THINK WE HAD BETTER. WELL
AGAIN JUST TO CLOSE ON MY POINT
THOUGH. WE HAVE GOT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THIS IS NOT THE NEW
NORMAL THE STATE CANNOT
TOLERATE THIS AS THE NEW. IT
MAY BE CERTAINLY NEW TO YOU
COMING FROM BACK EAST AND MAYBE
NOT HAVING FACED THIS. I'VE
BEEN DEALING WITH IT MY WHOLE
LIFE. HAVING REPRESENTED
EIGHTEEN DIFFERENT CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW
MANY FIRES FLOODS AND OTHER
DISASTERS I'VE HAD TO CONTEND
WITH. AND THIS IS AN ONGOING
THING IN THESE COMMUNITIES
NEVER HAD WE HAD ONE SO
DEVASTATING IS PARADISE. BUT
ALL OF THE FUEL IS OUT THERE
FOR THAT TO HAPPEN. SO I'M VERY
WARY ABOUT IT AND AS WE
ANTICIPATE WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
VERY DEEP THINKING AND AGAIN. I
SUBMIT THINKING ABOUT THE STATE
AND FEDERAL RESPONSIBILITIES
THAT HAVE CONTRIBUTED AS WELL.
BUT THE COMMUNICATION IS STILL
DEFICIENT AND PEOPLE ARE
EXTRAORDINARILY WORRIED AND
RIGHTEOUSLY VERY ANGRY. AND
MANY HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES.
THANK YOU SIR MORE LUCK THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MISTER JOHNSON- IN IN YOUR
REMARKS I DID NOT HEAR TERMS
LIKE SECTIONAL EYES OR FAST.
ACTING FUSES OR POWER TO
BURGERS OR RAPID EARTH FAULT
CURRENT LIMITERS- COULD YOU
MAYBE HELP ME OUT AND WHAT YOU
SPENT THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS ON
IN THE LAST. TEN YEARS. WELL AS
I SAID BUT ALL I COULD DO IS
FIND THE NUMBERS I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHERE WHEN I KNOW SOME
OF THE WENT ON SEXUAL ISING I
DON'T THINK ANY OF IT WENT ON
TO THE MODERN SORT OF FALL
INTERRUPTION DEVICE I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE ANY THOSE BUT
WE'RE LOOKING ATTHAT TOO- BUT
BASICALLY I THINK WE JUST SPENT
ON. MAINTAINING AND BUILDING
THE ELECTRIC SYSTEM. SO THE
COME. BEING FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THE COMPLAINT I
HEARD THE MOST OFTEN WAS THAT.
YOUR PS PS IS WERE. VERY BROAD
THEY WEREN'T FOCUSED. COULD YOU
EXPLAIN DEBT THAT ACCURATE OR
CORRECT. ALL WILL START AND
THEN I WILL. RELY ON MY AT MY
EXPERT HERE THERE'S A COUPLE OF
BIG DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
SYSTEMS. THE TRANSMISSION
SYSTEM IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
IS MUCH DIFFERENT THAN IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE
THE STAKES TAKING OUT
TRANSMISSION SYSTEMS PIECES
BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING TO IMPACT
A LOT MORE PEOPLE. SO WE HAVE A
DIFFERENT SYSTEM. WE DON'T HAVE
THE TEN YEARS OF SPECIFIC
WEATHER DATA THAT SDG AND HE
TALKED ABOUT WE HAVE GENERAL
DATA- BUT I THINK THE
DIFFERENCE IN THE SYSTEM REALLY
ACCOUNTS FOR. THE SCOPE OF
THESE EVENTS FOR THEM YES.
DOCTOR SAYING HERE TO SPEAK TO
ME. DISCUSS THE SCOPE AND I
COMMITTEE GO BACK TO YOUR
QUESTION CENTERED IN BECAUSE
REGARD TO THE THIRTY BILLION
DOLLARS AS WELLAS THE
ADDITIONAL ITEMS SO THAT YOU
REFERENCE REGARDING FAST ACTING
FUSES RAPTOR FALL CURRENT
LIMITER AND THE WORK THAT WE'VE
DONE IN THE LAST TWELVE MONTHS
AND THE WORK THAT WE HAVE. IN
PLAN GOING FORWARD IN REGARDS
TO THE SCOPE- WE ARE- QUICKLY
ADVANCING OUR CAPABILITIES FROM
A SITUATION AWARENESS AND REAL
TIME MONITORING- BASIS AS WE'VE
HEARD- AND LEARN FROM THE BEST
PRACTICES FROM SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC OVER THE LAST TWELVE
MONTHS WE'VE INSTALLED NEARLY
SIX HUNDRED WEATHER STATIONS
WE'VE DONE A THIRTY YEAR.
CLIMATOLOGY STUDY WE'VE-
ESTABLISHED EIGHTY DIFFERENT
BILLION DATA POINTS SO WE
LEVERAGE NOW FOR THE PURPOSES
OF WEATHER FORECASTING THAT
DOES GIVE US A MORE TARGETED
AND GRANULAR VIEW- IN TERMS OF
WHERE ARE WE GOING TO SEE THE
POTENTIAL A HIGH FIRE RISK-
WILL GIVE YOU TWO DIFFERENT
DATA POINTS TO COMPARE SO IF
YOU LOOK AT THE LARGEST EVENT
THAT WE HAD IN OCTOBER TWENTY
SIXTH. WE HAD DONE NINE AND
FORTY THOUSAND AND AGAIN
CUSTOMER ACCOUNTS- SO A LOT
MORE CUSTOMERS THAT WERE
IMPACTED IF YOU LOOK AT THE RED
FLAG WARNING FOOTPRINT WITHIN
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SERVICE
TERRITORY THAT WOULD HAVE
AMOUNTED TO ABOUT TWO POINT TWO
MILLION CUSTOMER ACCOUNTS SO WE
DO LEVERAGE OUR INTERNAL
METHODOLOGY OUR WEATHER
FORECASTING CAPABILITIES TO BE
ABLE TO HELP. CONTINUE TO
TARGET A AND BECOME MORE
GRANULAR WORK CONTINUE TO
ADVANCED OUT WORK SO GOOD AT
THE MOMENT WE HAVE A THREE
KILOMETER RESOLUTION FOR OUR
SEVENTY THOUSAND SQUARE MILE
SERVICE SERVICE TERRITORY WE'RE
LOOKING TO GET TO ABOUT A TWO
KILOMETER RESOLUTION THAT GIVES
US AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY X.
LEVEL OF GRANULARITY IN REGARDS
TO GETTING AN UNDERSTANDING. OF
WEATHER FORECASTING CAPABILITY
AND WE'RE ALSO LOOKING TO
DOUBLE THE NUMBER OF WEATHER
STATIONS THAT WE'VE INSTALLED
IN THE LAST TWELVE MONTHS OVER
THE NEXT TWELVE TO EIGHTEEN
MONTHS BUT REALLY GET US A
SIGNIFICANT LEVEL OF
PENETRATION. TO BE ABLE TO
ENABLE. THAT CAPABILITY FROM A
GRANT FROM A GRANULAR.
FORECASTED PERSPECTIVE ABOUT
ALONE IS NOT ENOUGH TO YOUR
POINT. B. REFERENCE YOU MADE
REGARDING TO SOCIALIZATION THEY
GO HAND IN HAND THE WEATHER
STATIONS GIVE US THAT
ADDITIONAL GRANULARITY FOR
FORECASTING BUT WE ALSO NEED
THE OPERATIONAL CAPABILITY ON
OUR ELECTRICAL GRID SYSTEM TO
BE ABLE TO SECTIONAL EYES OUR
SYSTEM ITSELF SO WE PUT A PLAN
TOGETHER TO AUTOMATE OR
SOCIALIZE SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DIFFERENT DEVICES ON OUR
SYSTEM. OF INSTALLED MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED- THIS YEAR ALONE
AND IN THE NEXT SIX TO NINE
MONTHS WE PLAN TO INSTALL THE
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE TWO
HUNDRED SOCIALIZATION DEVICES
THAT SHE- BENEFITS ABOUT
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS MEANING THAT
IF WE HAVE A POTENTIAL PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF OF AND WE
CAN MAINTAIN SERVICE TO THE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS OF ALL OF THOSE TWO
HUNDRED SOCIALIZATION DEVICES
ARE GOING TO BE IN PLAY. ADDING
ANOTHER FIVE AND FIFTY DEVICES
FOR THEIR- BENEFITS ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS AND WE ACTUALLY SAW
AN EXAMPLE OF THAT IN THE
OCTOBER NINTH EVENT WHEN WE DID
HAVE AN IMPACT ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
CUSTOMER ACCOUNTS. OF THE TWO
HUNDRED SOCIALIZATION DEVICES
WE HAD IN PLACE WE WERE ABLE TO
LEVERAGE SOME OF THOSE AND WE
WERE ABLE TO STILL MAINTAIN
SERVICE TO ABOUT SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS SO THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY PART OF OUR STRATEGY
AND WERE ACCELERATING AND
MOVING TO ACTION ON THAT. ON
OUR PLAN THE THIRD ITEM THAT I
WOULD MENTION IS THAT
SOCIALIZATION ONLY HELPS WHERE
WE HAVE A SECONDARY SUPPLY TO
AREA OUT THAT IS NOT. WITHIN
THE SCOPE OF THE AT FIRE OR OR
WHETHER RISK THE THIRD ELEMENT
REALLY AT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS
DISTRIBUTED GENERATION ENABLED
MICRO GRATES AND MOVING TO
ACTION ON THAT AND WE ACTUALLY
EMPLOYED SOME OF THOSE
CAPABILITIES IN THE MOST RECENT
EVENTS AND THEY WERE USED IN
THE FORM OF TEMPORARY
GENERATION PRIMARILY PRIMARILY
FOSSIL FUELS BUT GOING FORWARD
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO APPS
ABSOLUTELY LEVERAGE CLEANER
SOURCES. OF DISTRIBUTED
GENERAL. IN THAT REGARD SO
THOSE. THREE REALLY SPEAK. PS
PS AN ADEQUATE FROM THIS YEAR
TO NEXT YEAR. MR JOHNSON I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY SOMETHING THAT
SENATOR BRADFORD MENTIONED IT'S
RULE TWENTY EIGHT AND- THE
UTILITIES PUT CREDIT SOCIETY
BUILD RESERVES AND- ITS USE FOR
BEAUTIFICATION BUT IT'S ALSO
KIND OF BEEN LANGUISHING- AS AS
A SOURCE OF FUNDING AND WHY
BRING IT UP BECAUSE P. JEANNIE
HAS ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FORTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
SITTING. IN FUNDS AS OF
DECEMBER THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN SO
AS SOMEONE WHO HAS HAD A MAJOR
CONFLAGRATION IS DISTRICT I'M
LOOKING FOR AVAILABLE FUNDS
IT'S SORT OF LIKE THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT WE SPEAK
COLLECT ALL THIS MONEY JUST SIX
AND SO IT'S LOW AGGRAVATING SO
THAT'S WHY. I'M BRINGING IT UP
WITH EACH OF THE. MAJOR WE USE-
BECAUSE COMBINED YOU HAVE A
BILLION DOLLARS SITTING IN BANK
ACCOUNTS OR AS CREDITS THAT
COULD BE USED IN SOME FORM OR
FASHION EITHER FOR
BEAUTIFICATION OR- TO HELP
ASSIST AND MITIGATE IN CERTAIN
CITIES AND COMMUNITIES. AND
THAT'S WHY. WE DID SENATE BILL
SEVEN SEVEN SECURITY SEVEN.
OKAY SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTY
FOUR EXCUSE ME- THIS YEAR TO
TRY AND SAY HEY LET'S FROM
REDIRECTED SO WE HAVE SOME
AVAILABLE RESOURCES NOW TO
ASSIST YOU AND YOUR CUSTOMERS
IN TRYING TO. DEAL WITH THESE.
WILDFIRE HIGH RISK ZONES SO I
WOULD ASK THE QUESTION BUT I
WILL ASK THE QUESTION THAT I
ASKED THE LAST. PRISONER IN
THAT IS. AS A FRANCHISEE AS A-
FROM HIS CHARTERED BY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THERE'S TALK NOW
ABOUT YOU KNOW REVOKING OR
NATIONALIZING YOUR- COMPANY AND
YOU ARE PUBLICLY TRADED AND YOU
ARE. IN CHAPTER ELEVEN
BANKRUPTCY SIGNAL MAYBE A
LITTLE VULNERABLE SO I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU CAN ANSWER THE
QUESTION BUT- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
COMMENT ON. SOME OF THESE.
STATEMENTS OF. I WAS A LAWYER
FOR MANY YEARS AND I GUESS I'M
STILL LAWYER BUT I HAVEN'T HAD
A LICENSE FOR TWENTY YEARS SO
TAKE THIS FOR WHAT IT'S WORTH-
AND GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE'RE
IN BANKRUPTCY WE HAVE ACTUALLY.
THOUGHT ABOUT SOME OF THESE
POTENTIAL SOLUTION. SO I THINK
THE STATE HAS THE POWER THE CPU
CITY TO REVOKE ARE FRENCH I
BELIEVE THAT'S A LEGAL
POSITION. I THINK THERE'S
PROBABLY A FAIRLY HIGH BURDEN
THAT GOES WITH THAT. AS TO
NATIONALIZING WHATEVER THE TERM
IS ARE SOME BELIEVE IT'S THE
FIFTH AMENDMENT REQUIREMENTS
THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE MET SO
THAT WASN'T TAKING INVOLVED. SO
THERE ARE NOT THIS COULD TURN
OUT DIFFERENT WAYS. BUT WE DO
HAVE A PLAN FOR THE BANKRUPTCY
COURT TO. THE REST EMERGES P.
JEANNIE WITH A DIFFERENT SORT
OF VISION. BUT LARGE GONNA
HAPPEN IN THE BANKRUPTCY COURT
IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS.
THANK YOU MISTER IT'S AN OF I
WILL TURN OVER TO A LAWYER THEN
A SENATOR MINING. THANK YOU
YOUR CHAIR AND- APPRECIATE YOUR
TEAM BEING HERE TODAY. I WANT
TO LEAD OFF SOMEBODY ALLUDED TO
IT EARLIER. IN THE MIDST OF
SOME OF THE POWER SHUTDOWNS IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA THERE WERE
REPORTS OF P. JEANNIE WORKERS
BEING TARGETED. BY IRATE.
CUSTOMERS AND RESIDENTS IN. TO
THE EXTENT THERE IS ANYONE
LISTENING TO THIS TODAY. I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT'S THE
APPROPRIATE TARGET I'VE SEEN
THE COURAGEOUS WORK OF. WINE
WORKERS NOT JUST P. JEANNIE BUT
ALL THREE UTILITIES AND I THINK.
I SPEAK FOR EVERYONE ON THIS
PANEL IN ACKNOWLEDGING. THE
COURAGEOUS WORK IN THE OVERTIME
WORK OF THOSE TRYING TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC SAFETY. THAT SAID I
DO WANT TO TURN TO SOME OF THE
SPECIFICS OF WHAT P. JEANNIE-
IS DOING IN HELL HELL YOU'VE
MANAGED THE SHUTDOWNS. I THINK
IT WAS SENATOR NIELSEN WHO
RAISED THE QUESTION ABOUT THE
COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTERS- I
REPRESENT A LOT OF RURAL AREAS
IN THE CENTRAL COAST FROM SOME
OF THE- ENTITIES IN THE
CLEANEST ONLY. DIDN'T EVEN HAVE
COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTERS WHEN
THEIR POWER WAS SHUT DOWN. HOW
DO YOU DETERMINE WHEN. WHERE
AND HOW FREQUENTLY TO SET UP
THESE RESOURCE CENTERS- AND
HAVE YOU CONSIDERED CONTRACTING
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WERE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHO HAVE THE
CAPACITY WHO COULD BE ENGAGED
IN AN OUNCE TO USE THEIR
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
COMMUNITY CONTACTS. TO OPERATE
ON THESE COMMUNITY RESOURCE
CENTERS AND TO BE REIMBURSED BY
P. JEANNIE FOR THAT SERVICE. SO
I WILL TAKE THE SECOND PART AND
THEN I'LL ASK LAURIE TO HELP
WITH THE FIRST PART. OF WE HAVE
WE ARE IS COMMISSION AT THE
MOMENT OF CAN WE- CONTRACT HOW
DO THIS DIFFERENTLY AS YOU'VE
JUST DESCRIBED WITH YOUR
QUESTION. THAT WE WOULD
REIMBURSE FOR THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO DO THIS KIND OF THING AS
THEIR MAIN. MAIN JOB AND SO WE
ARE LOOKING ACTIVELY AT THAT
POSITION SO AS TO HOW WE
DETERMINE WHERE THE C. R. SHE'S
ARE GOING HOME LAST GLORIA.
EXPLAIN FOR YOUR QUESTION-
DURING THE OCTOBER EVENTS WE
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
COUNTY- YES THE COUNTY
OFFICIALS TO DETERMINE THE BEST
LOCATIONS- TO PLACE THESE AND
THEN HAD TO WORK WITH
LANDOWNERS TO GET AGREEMENTS TO
PUT THE AT THE C. R. C.'S ON
THOSE LOCATIONS ULTIMATELY WE'D
LIKE TO HAVE HARDENED
FACILITIES THAT- WE MAY BRING
IN BACK OF GENERATION FOR TO
SUPPORT THE COMMUNITIES ON AN
ONGOING BASIS WE THINK SCHOOL
ARE A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO PARTNER WITH- IN YOUR
DISTRICT SPECIFICALLY AND
SPECIFICALLY IN SALINAS IN. WE
HADN'T WE THOUGHT WE HAD AN
AGREEMENT PROPERTY OWNER IN
SALINAS AND IT FELT AT THE LAST
MOMENT WE HAVE FOUR LOCATIONS-
THE WE WENT TO THAT THE COUNTY
HAD RECOMMENDED BUT CREE WITH
YOU WE'RE GONNA BE TO MUCH MORE
WORK WITH THE COUNTIES AND
HAVING THEM HELP TO FIND WHERE
BEST TO PLACE THESE RESOURCE
CENTERS ENSURE THAT THEIR ADA
COMPLIANT ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE
AMPLE SUPPLIES REALLY ENSURE
THAT WE ARE SUPPOSE THE
COMMUNITIES IN THE WAY THAT
THESE POLICE WE SHOULD SUPPORT
THE COMMUNITY AND- THAT. WILL
EXTEND BORDERS THE TYPE OF.
THANK YOU I'M GLAD TO HEAR
YOU'RE LOOK AT. I KNOW AND JUST
SALINAS BUT SOUTH COUNTY.
GONZALEZ IN GREENFIELD WHICH
ALSO HAVE HIGH MINORITY
POPULATION LOW INCOME
POPULATION AND I THINK THERE'S
A PERCEPTION THAT SOME OF THE
RESOURCES WENT TO MORE AFFLUENT
COMMUNITIES. I'M NOT SUGGEST
THAT WAS YOUR INTENT BUT THAT'S
THE PERCEPTION AND SO I WOULD
JUST SUGGEST THAT IN PLANNING
FOR THE FUTURE THEY'RE NOT BE A
DISPARITY IN COMMUNITIES THAT
RECEIVE THE EMERGENCY RESOURCES
THAT ARE REQUIRED- I'D ALSO
LIKE TO DO A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION. ON YOUR
COMMUNICATIONS HOW DO YOU WORK
WITH TELECOM COMPANIES TO A LET
THEM KNOW. THE AREAS ARE GONNA
BE SHUT DOWN I HEARD FROM ONE
OF THE LARGE TELECOM COMPANIES
AGAIN IN MY AREA. THAT SOME
THEY WEREN'T. TAXIDERMY
PARTICIPATING IN ANY- EMERGENCY
CENTER COMMUNICATIONS WITH. YOU
SEE WITH P. JEANNIE WITH- YES
AND THEY WERE LEARNING TRYING
TO GO TO THE WEBSITE THAT HE
CRASHED THEY WERE TRYING TO
MOBILIZE GENERATORS. TWO TOWERS
THEY KNOW WHERE TO TAKE THEM.
WHEN COMMUNICATION DROPS IT
DROPS TO THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AGAIN IN SOUTH MONTEREY COUNTY.
UP IN THE SANTA CRUZ MOUNTAINS.
THAT'S WHEN WE RUN THE RISK OF
LOSS OF LIFE WHEN EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS CAN BE CONTACTED IT
WOULD SEEM A NUMBER ONE PUBLIC
EMERGENCY. FOR P. JEANNIE WOULD
BE. HAVE READY ONGOING
COMMUNICATION WITH TELECOM
OPERATORS IN COORDINATE NOT
WHEN THE SHUTDOWN HAPPENS BUT
IN ADVANCE STARTING TODAY
LOOKING FORWARD THAT THE NEXT
SHUTDOWN EVERYONE KNOWS HOW
THEY COMMUNICATE WITH YOU HOW
YOU COMMUNICATE WITH THEM. AND
HOW THEY CAN DEPLOY GENERATORS
TO MAINTAIN COMMUNICATIONS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT COMMENT IT
WE ALSO HARE THAT CONCERN AS
AS WE LEVERAGE THE
TELECOMMUNICATION NETWORKS FOR
OUR- OUR WORKERS THAT- THAT YOU
MENTIONED AND WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT OF OUR
EMPLOYEES ARE OUT IN THE FIELD.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH TELECOMMUNICATIONS- IT FOR
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS THEY ARE
ASSIGNED ACCOUNTS SO THEY HAVE
ACCOUNT MANAGERS THAT ACTUALLY
ENGAGE WITH THEM ALSO BEEN
WORKING WITH THE STATE OF WITH
YOUR CALLAWAY YES- TO
COORDINATE WITH THOSE- BUT THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS.
BUT WE KNOW THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN CHALLENGES SO OUR IT'S OUR
INTENT TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM- WE HAVE ONE POSITION AND
THAT IS IN OUR OUR INTO THE
COMMAND STRUCTURE THAT SITS IN
THE CUSTOMER BRANCH TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN THAT IS WORKING WITH
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE. AND WE
CONSIDER THE TOP. OF THAT SO
WHAT BUT WE'RE GOING TO ASIAN
WITH THEM AT MULTIPLE LEVELS-
IN ORGANIZATION AND WILL
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE THEM ENSURE
THAT THAT THEY HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION TO MAKE DECISIONS
SURE OF IT ON THE NETWORKS
REMAIN UP AND OPERATIONAL FOR
CUSTOMER. THANK YOU. IN I THINK
MISTER JOHNSON MAYBE BACK TO
YOU IF YOU WANTED TO FOR THE
QUESTION BUT- ESTIMATES OF. THE
LIABILITIES OF P. JEANNIE FROM
THE SEVENTEEN AND EIGHTEEN FIRE
TRAGEDIES ARM WE READ ESTIMATES
OF THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS OF
LIABILITY. IF YOU COMPARE THAT
TO THE. RESISTANCE TO
UNDERGROUND WIRES EIGHT THE
RULE OF THUMB IS TO BE A
MILLION DOLLARS A MILE I KNOW
IT'S PROBABLY HIGHER THAN THAT
NOW. IF YOU TAKE SEVENTY
THOUSAND MILES OF YOUR SERVICE
WHERE'S THAT YOU ALLUDED TO. IN
YEAR OPENING STATEMENT. IF YOU
UNDER GROUNDED ONE QUARTER OF
THOSE. AND A MILLION DOLLAR
SMILE IN THE HIGHEST RISK FIRE
AREAS MY MATH SAYS THAT WOULD
BE ABOUT FIFTEEN BILLION. SO
THE THIRTY BILLION OF LIABILITY
YOU FACE NOW TO SAVE MONEY FOR
SHAREHOLDERS. IF HALF THAT HAD
BEEN INVESTED IN UNDER
GROUNDING IN HIGH RISK AREAS
YOU MIGHT HAVE LIMITED P.
GENIES LEADERSHIP MIGHT HAVE
LIMITED. THE CURRENT LIABILITY
IT'S LOOKING AT NOW SO. AS WE
MOVE FORWARD ARE BEGINNING
CONTINUE TO HEAR THAT UNDER
GROUNDING IS TOO EXPENSIVE OR
WHAT TIPPING POINT DO DETERMINE
THAT YES EXPENSIVE. BUT IN THE
LONG RUN IT'S THE RIGHT AND
MEANT TO MAKE TO PROTECT
AGAINST WHAT JERRY BROWN CALLED
THE NEW ABNORMAL. OF CLIMATE
CHANGE NEXUS. TIRE FIRE.
UNPRECEDENTED WINDOW VENTS AND
THE NEXUS WITH ELECTRIC POWER
LINES. SO I THINK YOU'LL SEE
THIS UNDER GROUNDING
CONSIDERABLY MORE OF OUR SYSTEM.
NOT BECAUSE OF THE LIABILITY SO
MUCH IS YOUR SINCE THE RIGHT
THING TO DO GIVEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. THEY'RE A COUPLE
THINGS ABOUT OUR SYSTEM THAT
ARE UNIQUE WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF SIXTY AND SEVENTY KV
TRANSMISSION. AND A LOT OF
LARGE TRANSMISSION THAT YOU
CANNOT REALLY PUT UNDERGROUND.
SO THIS IS REALLY LIMITED TO
DISTRIBUTION. AND THEN THE
EQUATION WILL BE IS A BETTER
UNDERGROUND IS A BETTER TO PUT
COVERED HARDEN WIRE UP ALL
THESE KIND OF THINGS BUT ALL OF
HIS ACTIVITY WILL BE DIRECTED
TOWARD REDUCING THE RISK. IT
WOULD SEEM IN THE LONG TERM FOR
YOUR SHAREHOLDERS INVESTING IN
REDUCTION OF RISK. WOULD BE IN
YOUR SHAREHOLDERS INTEREST AS
WELL AS THE PUBLIC SAFETY. I
AGREE WITH THAT STATEMENT THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU CENTER MINING
SITTING SENATOR MCGUIRE. I
THINK SO MUCH STRUCTURE
REGRETFUL SIR- ONE I JUST SAY
IF YOU THINK HE'S BEFORE I GET
INTO SOME COMMENTS RESEARCHERS
WELL SOME QUESTIONS AND I'LL-
IN WITH SOME VERY QUICK
COMMENTS AS WELL. WHEN I SAY
THANK YOU MISTER SAYING FOR
TAKING TIME AFTER THE PREVIOUS
MEAN PEOPLE GO THROUGH SOME OF
THE ISSUES I WANT TO POINT OUT
TO MISTER PATTERSON WHO'S HERE
TODAY- IT FOR HIS. EFFORTS
WORKING ON GETTING TIMELY
INFORMATION NOW- AS WELL AS
MISTER HADLEY WHO IS AN
EMBEDDED WITHIN EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS CENTER ON THE NORTH
COAST. A SIXTEEN BE ABLE TO GET
S. SCHOOLS IN CRITICAL FACILITY
UP ON ME AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. I ALSO WANT TO KNOW
IS IT TOO JOHNSON IS BEEN HERE
AT POLICE AS APRIL- AND YOU
HAVE INHERITED BUT A HOT MESS
SIR- AND- WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
GO THROUGH SOME OF THIS. WE CAN
THROW OUT ALL THE NUMBERS WE
WANT THE THIRTY BILLION OR THE
TWO BILLION. BUT IT DOESN'T PUT
IN CONTEXT TRULY WITH THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. OF THE
LINES ARE OVER THE GREED IS. SO
THE TRUTH IS THERE ARE THREE
REASONS WHY WE'RE HERE. THE
TRUTH IS THERE HAS BEEN
HISTORIC LACK INVESTMENT BY
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC
COMPANY BUT WITHIN A TRICKLE
CREEK. I IN THERE HAS BEEN SOME
MISMANAGEMENT HUNTER PERSON.
YOU ARE BEHIND IN MODERNIZATION.
YOUR BEHIND GREAT HARDENING IN
YOUR BEHIND IN VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT. AND IN FACT THE
ONLY TIME THAT I'VE HEARD IN MY
FIVE YEARS SINCE LEGISLATURE AT
THIS CORPORATION IS PRECEDED
YOUR TIME SIR SO I TOTALLY GET
THAT TALKING ABOUT TARGETING
SHUT OFFS. TWO POINT CAMERAS.
AND MAKING SURE THAT- THERE IS
INVESTMENT IN THE SYSTEM IS
ONLY AFTER THESE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES SO WE'RE TAKING A
POSITION TO BE IN REACTIVE
RATHER BEING PROACTIVE. AND THE
STATE DOES OWN SOME SKIN IN
THIS GAME THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION IS NOT HELD THE
CORPORATION ACCOUNTABLE IN
FORESEEN WHAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
FORCED MANY YEARS AGO. ANY ALSO
AVENUE CLIENT ID THAT IS CUT UP
TO YOU BECAUSE P. JEANNIE HAS
NOT INVESTED AS YOU SHOULD HAVE
AS OTHER NEIGHBORING UTILITIES
HAVE INGRID MODERNIZATION.
HARDEN AND IN FACT IN
APPRECIATE MISSING I THINK
YOU'VE BEEN IN THE COMPANY FOR
TWO YEARS. SUMMARY IN THERE
THIS POSITION FOR YOUR SIDE
OKAY THIS IS A THREE YEAR.
APPRECIATE ALL THIS WORK IS
GOING INTO NOW BUT IT'S IN
REACTION TO ALL THE FIRES IN
THE DISASTERS THAT HAVE COST
CALIFORNIANS LIVES. IN IS COST
THEM THEIR LIVELIHOODS. TO HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO TALK- JUST BE A COVER HERE
IN AND LIKE TO BE A WRAP UP
IT'LL BE QUICK. MISTER VICE
CHAIR. TO WHAT HAS BEEN DONE
SINCE THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WILDFIRES BECAUSE
WHAT I'VE HEARD THIS IS MISSING
AND I HAD A CONVERSATION- THE
DATA DOESN'T PLAY OUT.
ESPECIALLY IN MENDOCINO COUNTY
OR CINEMA COUNTY LAKE COUNTY
WHERE WE'VE SEEN SO THE MOST
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IN OUR
NATION'S HISTORY. THE DATA
DOESN'T PLAY OUT- IN REGARD TO
BEING DEPLOYING THE
MODERNIZATION AS YOU STATES
HAVE. AND IN FACT YOUR
REPRESENTATIVES IN MISSING I'M
NOT GONNA KICK THE DEAD DOG
UNDERNEATH HIS TABLE BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT WE'VE ALREADY GONE
THROUGH THIS- YOU HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES THAT GO TO THE
MINUTES YOU KNOW COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS. DON'T EVEN KNOW
THAT THERE IS A WILDFIRE NOT
COUNTY. THE COST LIVES. LET
ALONE YOU KNOW HOW MANY CAMERAS
HAVE BEEN DEPLOYED. OR HOW MANY
MILES OF LINE. HAS CRITICAL
MILES A LINE EXIST. I
UNDERSTAND MR SAYING IT'S BEEN
WORKING WITH THE TEAM ON THAT.
I BRING ALL THIS UP IS SO TEN
YEARS YOU SAY IT'S GONNA TAKE
TEN YEARS IS THAT SATISFACTORY
TO YOU. TO BE A MODERNIZE. OF
NOTE IN THE ME FIRST CLARIFY
WHAT IT IS I ACTUALLY SO. WHICH
WAS A TEN YEAR PERIOD
CONSISTENT WITH THE EXPERIENCE
OF SDG AN EDISON TO GET TO A
POINT WHERE THESE ARE ALMOST
NONEXISTENT OR CERTAINLY
SURGICAL- NO IT'S NOT
ACCEPTABLE TO ME TO HAVE
ANOTHER YEAR LIKE THIS ONE. BUT
LONG KENNEDY'S TO WHAT IS THAT-MEAN FOR US WHO WERE SO IN MY
NECK OF THE WOODS- AT OF THIRTY
DAYS WE HAD FOR POWER OUTAGE.
YOU SAY THAT. IN THE SYSTEM
THERE IS NO MORE THAN FIVE DAYS
YOU HAVE LOCAL OFFICIALS WERE
HERE TODAY THAT WERE OUT FOR
SIX OR SEVEN. SO I DON'T KNOW
WHERE THAT INCONSISTENT COMES
FROM BUT JUST BEING HONEST
ABOUT IT- THIS IS TYPICAL FOR
P. JEANNIE. THEY SAY ONE THNG
AND REALLY THE REALITIES
DIFFERENT. THERE ARE SOME
ISOLATED COMMITTEES ARE OUT FOR
ELEVEN. ELEVEN DAYS. SO I ASK
YOU. WHAT WOULD BE A TIME LINE
THAT WOULD BE SATISFACTORY IF
IT'S NOT TEN. WELL I THINK TEN
IS A GOOD ONE STILL FOR VERY
TARGETED LIMITED SMALL NUMBERS
IN EXTREME CIRCUMSTANCES I
THINK WE NEED TO MAKE GREAT
PROGRESS IN THE NEXT TWO OR
THREE YEARS. AND SO MAYBE WE
CAN TO FIVE TO GET TO A REALLY
GOOD PLACE. BUT THE NEXT COUPLE
OF THREE YEARS OLD THE CRUCIAL
IN MY OPINION. I THINK ONE OF
THE ISSUES AND I APPRECIATE
THAT ONE OF THE ITEMS THAT I
THINK THAT THIS LEGISLATURE THE
ADMINISTRATION- NEED TO BRING
FORTIES WE NEED A PERFORMANCE
BASED- METRICS THAT ARE BUILT
INTO LAW IF WE DO NOT HAVE
THOSE PERFORMANCE METRICS BUILT
INTO LAW. WE'RE GONNA BE
SITTING HERE FIVE YEARS LATER
HAVING THE SAME CONVERSATION
THAT'S WHAT I'M DEEPLY WORRIED
ABOUT. BUT I DID TALK ABOUT
ANOTHER ISSUE. TRANSMISSION
LINES WE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
APPRECIATE THE PHONE CALL IN
REGARDS TO THE CAN KATE FIVE.
THE TRANSPORTATION LANES. UP IN
THE MAYACAMAS NEAR THE GEYSERS
WEREN'T SHUT DOWN. SO WE HAD
THE POWERSHOT OFFICE AND WE HAD
A SECONDARY EMERGENCY- WHERE
THERE WAS AN OBVIOUS CHALLENGE
I WILL USE IN NON TECHNICAL
TERM OF SOME TYPE OF SPARK.
THAT BECAUSE THE FIRE TO START.
I KNOW THAT WE HAVE AN ACTIVE
INVESTIGATION SO I'M NOT GOING
TO GOING TO THAT BUT I'D LIKE
TO BE TO TALK ABOUT YOUR
THRESHOLDS MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT YOU DO NOT SHUT DOWN THE
SET SIZE TRANSMISSION LINES
UNLESS THERE'S GOING TO BE
SUSTAINED. FIFTY FIVE MILE PER
HOUR WINDS. GUSTS STAY HERE
OKAY SINGLE S. MY ISSUE WAS
WITH THAT IS THAT CAL FIRE
FORECASTS FOR THE MY COMMON
THAT NIGHT. IN OTHER LOCAL
FORECAST SHOWED THAT IN GAPS
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABOUT FIFTY
FIVE MILES PER HOUR. IN FACT IN
YOUR OPENING STATEMENT YOU SAID
THAT- IN THE NORTH BAY WAS AT A
HUNDRED AND TWO MILES PER HOUR
AT THAT THE STRONG AS WE TAKE A
LOOK AT MOUNT ST LENA WE LOOK
AT THE MY COMMON MOUNTAINS.
THERE ARE SUSTAIN GASES
SEMINARY SEVENTY OR EIGHTY
MILES PER HOUR. SO I'M TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND IF YOU'RE
SHUTTING DOWN. ONE IN THE
VALLEY. YET WHERE WE LOOK AT
THESE FIRE STARTER HAPPENING UP
IN THE MOUNTAINS WHY WEREN'T
THOSE TRANSMISSION LINES TURN
DOWN WE KNEW THAT THERE ARE
MULTIPLE FORECAST THAT SETS A
STAIN WIND OF OVER FIFTY FIVE.
THAT'S A QUESTION. SECOND I CAN
CHIME CHIME IN ON THE CENTER
REQUIRE THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SO THE FIFTY FIVE MILE
AN HOUR REFERENCE- IS NOT A
BLANKET. FOR EVERY SINGLE
TRANSMISSION LINE WE EVALUATE-
EVERY SINGLE TRANSMISSION LINE
TO BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY WHAT IS
THAT APPROPRIATE THRESHOLD
BECAUSE IT DEPENDS ON. THE
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION OF THE LINE
IF IT'S ON A RIDGE LINE IF IT'S
IN A WIN CORRIDOR. AND WE ALSO
LOOK AT THE- POTENTIAL. FOR
FIRE SPREAD THE ASSOCIATE
CONSEQUENCE AND ALSO THE IMPACT
OF FROM A GRADE STABILITY
PERCENT THEY HAVE BEEN THAT
THIS WAS A HIGHER VOLTAGE- TO
THIRTY KV LINE- THE FORECAST
THAT WE HAD- PUT TOGETHER FROM
A INTERNAL MAYBE ALL YOU
PERSPECTIVE- DID NOT-
NECESSARILY GET UP TO. YOU KNOW
THAT THRESHOLD. WHICH WAS
HIGHER THAN FIFTY FIVE MILES AN
HOUR FOR THIS SPECIFIC LINE TO
MEET THE THRESHOLD FOR
DIGITIZATION. I AM PERPLEXED
AND I'M NOT IN ENERGY EXPERT
WHATSOEVER. BUT HERE'S WHAT
I'LL SAY. YEAH SHUT DOWN. MY
ARM ONE POINT SIX MILLION
PEOPLE TO PEAK SOMEWHERE AROUND
IN THERE GIVE OR TAKE. IF YOU
LEAVE THESE TRANSMISSION LINES
VETERAN FIRE CRITICAL ZONES. UP
AND RUNNING AND IN FACT IN
YEARS PAST YOU HAD SIGNIFICANT
FIRE STARTS IN THAT SAME AREA.
SO YOU KEEP THESE TRANSMISSION
LINES OPEN. THERE IS A
CATASTROPHIC EVENT ON ONE OF
THE LINES INVESTIGATION IS
STILL PENDING. AND THEN YOU
HAVE THE LARGEST WHILE IN
FOREIGN CINEMA COUNTY HISTORY
BURNING DOWN HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE HOMES INVESTIGATION SO
PENDING. I DO SAY I QUESTION A
QUESTION INCONSISTENCY OF YOU
TELL EVERYONE AND THEIR
BROTHER. THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
TURN OFF THE LIGHTS FIRE
SAFETY. AND THEN YOU KEEP THE
DAM TRANSMISSION LINES IN THE
MOST FIRE CRITICAL TERRY
TERRITORY OPEN AND LIFE. GIVE
ME THE UNDERSTANDING HOW THAT
WORKS AND WHY THAT WOULD BE WHY
THAT DECISION WILL BE MADE WE
ACTUALLY DID SHUT DOWN SEVERAL
TRANSMISSION LINES OBVIOUSLY HE
DIDN'T SHUT DOWN THE ONE THAT
HAD THE SPARK SO THAT'S WHY I'M
TRYING TO GET TO SO- IN I
PROMISE TO MOVE ON AFTER THIS
IN JUST FINISH UP BUT- SO
PLEASE- S. AS BILL OF MISTER
JOHNSON MENTIONED IN REGARDS TO
SOME OF OUR SUB TRANSMISSION
LINES OF SIXTY SEVENTY KV- TO
SOME OF OUR LARGER- IN HIGHER
VOLTAGE TRANSMISSION LINES SO
WE DID SHUT DOWN. MANY
TRANSMISSION LINES OF SIXTY
SEVENTY HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN KV-
WITHIN THOSE RESPECTIVE
FOOTPRINTS AS PART OF THE
OCTOBER TWENTY THIRD EVENT AND
I THINK AS YOU STATED OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S TO CREATIONIST
ALONG GOING AND WHEN YOU START
LOOKING AT. THE ACTUAL DESIGN
AND THE CONSTRUCTION. IN THAT
LINE WAS ACTUALLY BUILT IN THE
EARLY SEVENTIES IT WAS
INSPECTED FROM A CLIMBING
INSPECTION RECENTLY IT WAS
INSPECTED WITHIN THE LAST SIX
MONTHS WAS INSPECTED FROM A
DRONE INSPECTION THAT IS
CORRECT SIR- SO GIVEN THE
INSPECTION. INFORMATION FROM A
CONDITION STANDPOINT AS WELL AS
THE DESIGN ON THE CONSTRUCTION
ON THE FORECASTED WIND SPEED
FOR THIS SPECIFIC LINE AND SOME
OF THE FIVE HUNDRED KV LINES IN
THAT SPECIFIC WIND OF AND- IT
DID NOT MEET THE THRESHOLD BUT
THERE WERE A LOT OF
TRANSMISSION LINES THAT DIDN'T
MEET THAT THRESHOLD THAT WE DID
DE ENERGIZE. OUR MOVE ON FROM
THAT ALL THIS IN WITH THIS IS
THAT. WHEN YOU ARE EXPECTING
HURRICANE FORCE WINDS IN THAT
AREA. WHERE YOU HAVE HAD
PREVIOUS CATASTROPHIC FIRE
STARTS. NOT BE AN ENERGY EXPERT
CAN YOU TURN OFF THE POWER TO
ONE POINT SIX NINE FOLKS WHY
YOU WOULDN'T TURN EVERYTHING
OUT. LACKS A MOVE ON. WOULD
LIKE TO BE A TO TALK ABOUT.
YOUR GAME PLAN FOR THE MOST
NEEDY FOLKS AND AS YOU MAY
PREPARE TO TURN OUT THE LIGHTS
AGAIN THIS WEEK WHAT YOU CAN DO
ABOUT SENIORS WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT A COLDER OF IN.
AVERAGE HEIGHT ABOUT SIXTY
SEVEN AT LEAST IN CINEMA
COUNTY. AND A LOW OF THIRTY
FIVE SELECT TO HEAR WHAT THAT
GAME PLAN IS FOR THIS WEEK
SINCE YOU'RE COORDINATING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE EMERGENCY
SERVICES I'D LIKE TO ASK THE
DIRECTOR WHEN HE COMES UP ABOUT
THAT. IT WAS LOCAL%
JURISDICTIONS WHAT IS THAT LOOK
LIKE AS FAR AS ARE YOU CAN GO
WITH THE TYPICAL RESOURCE
CENTERS. TELL US WHAT TO EXPECT.
THE STORE WITH LORI AND THEN
WILL BEGIN ON THE TABLE.
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- WE'RE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE COUNTY ON BEST
ON HOW BEST TO SUPPORT
CUSTOMERS- IN THE AREA WE'VE
BEEN CORNING VERY CLOSELY WITH-
HOW WE SUPPORT- CERTAINLY THE
ELDERLY F. AND CUSTOMERS ARE
MEDICAL BASELINE CUSTOMERS- WE
ARE ENACTING A RESOURCE CENTER
STRATEGIES SOME WILL BE
HARDENED SITES THAT THE
COUNTIES HAVE IDENTIFIED OTHERS
WILL BE- THE OTHER SITES THEY
WILL HAVE HEATING THEY WILL
HAVE COOLING- THEY WILL BE OPEN
FROM EIGHT TO EIGHT. TO SUPPORT
OUR CUSTOMERS WILL BE WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE-
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS TO
SUPPORT OUR AFN CUSTOMERS AND
WORKING WITH OUR COUNTY-
AGENCIES AS WELL AS- OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TO OUR CUSTOMERS. HE JUST. THE
SHERIN THIS SO IF THERE WAS A
SIMILAR VEIN. WHETHER IT IS A
WHILE IN FIRE EARTHQUAKE. OR A
SUSTAIN FORTY EIGHT HOUR TO
SEVENTY TWO HOUR POWER OUTAGE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WOULD BE
EXPECTED TO BE ABLE TO KEEP
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN FACILITIES UP
AND RUNNING. CONTRACT WITH THE
AMERICAN RED CROSS OR HOSTING
THEIR OWN EMERGENCY EVACUATION
CENTER. THEY NEED DOESN'T STOP
AFTER EIGHT PM. SO WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT THESE BONE CHILLING
TEMPERATURES. IN OUR FORTY
EIGHT SEVEN TWO HOURS AHEAD OF
THIS NEXT EVENT. AND AGAIN NOT
AT ALL TRYING TO BE
DISRESPECTFUL I HEARD ABOUT A
THIRTY THOUSAND FOOT TALK SO
ARE YOU PLANNING ON HEATING
CENTERS ARE THEY GOING TO BE
OPEN PASS EIGHT PM AND WHAT DO
YOU CAN DO FOR THE MOST
MEDICALLY FRAGILE BECAUSE WE
SWEET FACE THIS. YA KNOW- IN
THIS LAST EVENT WHAT WE SAW
LOWER TEMPERATURES SO WE'RE
GONNA BE WORKING WITH THECOUNTIES AND WE'VE ALREADY
STARTED THAT WORK WITH THEM TO
DETERMINE- WHERE WE KNOW THE
REQUEST IS OUT THERE TO HAVE
SHELTERS WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE RED CROSS. THEY
RESPOND WHEN THERE IS A
CATASTROPHIC EMERGENCY THEY
DON'T RESPOND IN ADVANCE OF
THAT COULD COMPENSATE THEM TO
DO SO WE- THEY'RE NOT THEY'VE
NOT BEEN OPEN TO THIS POINT TO
DOING THAT WITH US- WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM
AND WORK WITH. OTHER LOCAL
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
IN THE LAW AND- HAD EXTENDED
OUTAGES IT. TWO ON TWENTY SEVEN
THE COUNTY WANTED TO RUN A
SHELTER WE HELP SUPPORT THAT IN
THE COUNTY SO AS WE GET
REQUESTED BY THE COUNTIES WILL
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THEM TO
KEEP GENERATION KEEP HEAT- KEEP
SUPPLIES- WE PROVIDED BLANKETS
TO THE COUNTIES- AND HOT COLD
PERISHABLE FOODS- FOR THE
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT OF OUR
VULNERABLE TRIMMERS I THINK
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE SOME
FOLLOW UP ON THIS AS WE MOVE
FORTY FOR KENNEDY'S HAVE
ALLERGIES. ESPECIALLY IN SOME
OF THE NEXT BUT FOR CENTER
NIELSEN SAID IN A COOLER
TEMPERATURES THEY'RE HAPPY TO
WORK ON THAT THANK YOU- SAID
IT'S IN A PROCEDURE. OF THE
WRAPPING UP HERE MOMENTARILY ON
THIS. ONLINE THAT YOU ARE MOST
WORRIED ABOUT WOULD THAT BE
CORRECT THAT'S PART OF OUR
SYSTEM HARDENING SCOPE CORRECT
IN THE ELEVATOR AND EXTREME FAR
RISK AREA. SO JUST SO I GET A
BETTER SCENE SO. IN THE
BEGINNING TEN YEARS. MR JOHNSON
YOU BELIEVE THAT COULD BE DONE
FOR MISSING YOU BELIEVE THAT
CAN BE DONE AND HOW MANY YEARS
ESPECIALLY THAT SEVEN THOUSAND
MILES MOST FIRE CRITICAL LINE
WHERE YOU HAVE THE MOST ON
ABILITY AND WE'RE SEEING THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT POWER SHUT US.
SO I THE SYSTEM HARDING PLAN-
IS STILL WITHIN THAT TEN YEAR
TIME PERIOD BECAUSE THAT
INCLUDES- REBUILDING THE
OVERHEAD SYSTEM AS WELL AS
UNDER GROUNDING AND WRITE DOWN
A FINE OPPORTUNITIES. TO
CONTINUE- TO COMPRESS. THAT
TIME FRAME NOW KEEP IN MIND
THAT DOESN'T THE ONLY PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE FROM RISK
REDUCTION IN PERSPECTIVE WE
ALSO IMPLEMENTED THIS YEAR. A
RISK INFORMED VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM THAT GOES
WELL BEYOND THE TWENTY
REQUIREMENTS TO REMOVE ALL THE
OVERHANG AS WELL AS POTENTIAL.
THAT RESTRICT THAT COULD BE. A
HIGHER PRONE TO BEND HIGHER
SUSCEPTIBLE TO COME IN CONTACT
WITH OUR LINES AND THAT'S ALSO
A- MULTI YEAR PROGRAM BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT
WE'RE DOING- IN THE SHORT TERM.
IN REGARDS TO REAL TIME
MONITORING INTELLIGENCE
CAPABILITIES FIRE DETECTION
CAPABILITIES. WHAT I SPOKE OF
IN TERMS OF REDUCING. THE
IMPACT OF PS KOPEN. PLEASE I
DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION BUT I KNOW IT'S NOT
GOING TO BETEN YEARS. SO IS
THERE ANY FIVE IS IN A BE
FORCED ON THE SIX I MEAN THIS
IS ONE OF THE THINGS ARE
ACTIVELY LOOKING AT NOW. HOW
MUCH MORE QUICKLY CAN WE DO
THIS TO WHAT WHAT IS IN IN- AS
YOU CAN TELL.ONE AND WE GET A
LOOK AT SPECIFICS BECAUSE- MR
ASKING. SO WHEN COULD WE EXPECT
A REVISED EXPEDITED TIMELINE.
WHO HAVE TO FILE AN UPDATED.
PLAN WITH THE COMMISSION IN
JANUARY IT'S EARLY PART OF NEXT
YEAR THE EXACT TIMING IS- STILL
TBD. YOU WILL SEE THE DETAILS.
LAST QUESTION IN CLOSING
COMMENTS. IN PERSON FOR LOCAL
PUBLIC AGENCIES. LOCAL FIRE
LOCAL POLICE SHARE SOFFICI
AMBULANCE PROVIDERS. THEY HAVE
NOW BECOME THE IMPROMPTU P.
JEANNIE EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
AGENCY. AND THEY'RE RESPONDING
OUT WHEN THE LIGHTS GO OUT. AND
THEY'RE RESPONDING TO A SURGEON
CALLS AND I'LL GO TO LETTERS
THAT HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED BY
LAKE COUNTY MENDOCINO COUNTY A
SURGEON CALLS. FOR THE
MEDICALLY FRAGILE A SURGEON
PATIENT LOADS TO LOCAL
HOSPITALS OF SENIORS AND- HOW
GIVE US YOUR THOUGHTS IN REGARD
TO REIMBURSE SEEN. OUT LOCAL
EMERGENCY AUTHORITIES PUBLIC
AGENCIES OUT DURING PUBLIC SHOT
OFFICE WHAT WOULD YOUR THOUGHT
BEYOND THAT. WELL ACROSS HE
SAID I HAVEN'T GIVEN A LOT OF
THOUGHT TO THAT BECAUSE WE'RE
STILL YOU KNOW AT ONE MORE CUED
UP AND WE'VE BEEN. BURIED IN
THE MIDDLE OF THIS FOR THE LAST
SIX WEEKS. HI I HAVEN'T THOUGHT
ABOUT IT I WOULDN'T HAZARD
UNANSWERED RUBBING GLAD TO
THINK ABOUT AND GET BACK TO YOU.
A CLOSER HERE. MISTER CHAIR AND
YOU SAY THIS. AND I'M READING
THESE YES FROM THE COUNTIES
THAT IN SUBMITTED. THERE HAS TO
BE A FOCUS AND COMMUNICATION
YOUR COMMUNICATION FROM THE TOP.
DOES NOT GET DOWN TO THE GROUND
LEVEL THE COMMUNICATION IS NOT
BEEN CONSISTENT. WANTED TO
ADDRESS MR SAYING THE PREVIOUS
HEARING. THERE ARE SOME
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE TOLD THEY
WOULD BE OFF. AND IN A STATE ON.
AND THE VICE VERSA SOMEWHERE
SAID SOMEWHERE TOTALLY BE A ON
THEN THEY WERE TURNED OFF. I
CONTINUES TO HAPPEN. EVEN
THOUGH WITHOUT THOSE CAN IN
LAST YEAR. THE AREAS OF IMPACT
THAT Y'ALL SAY ARE GOING TO BE
TURNED OFF ITS CONVOLUTED AND
IT'S CONFUSING. EVEN IN THE
WEBSITE- BUT THAT HAS TO BE THE
LOWEST OF LOW HANGING FRUIT. P.
JEANNIE TOLD MENDOCINO COUNTY
OFFICIALS THAT POWERED RESUME
ON OCTOBER TWENTY FIFTH AND IT
DID NOT HE THEN TOLD THEM THEY
WOULD BE RESUMED ON OCTOBER
TWENTY NINTH AND IT DID NOT
HAPPEN. THERE HAS TO BE A
BETTER WAY. OF TELLING LOCAL
OFFICIALS WHEN THE POWERS CAN
BE COMING BACK ON. YOU MENTION
ISSUE OF CHARGING STATION
SAVINGS FOR ATTIC IN THE LEVEL
SERVICE. I HAVE A PICTURE OF A
CHARGING STATION THAT WAS IN
ARCADIA THAT EIGHTY SIX FOOT
COSCO TABLE TWO CHAIRS AND
NOTHING ELSE. I DON'T KNOW WHO
IS DOING QUALITY CONTROL ON THE
P. JEANNIE TEAM. BUT THEY NEED
TO BE BEEFED UP. AND AGAIN I'LL
SAY THIS AGAIN I KNOW MISTER
JOHNSON HAS BEEN HERE SINCE
APRIL. BUT ULTIMATELY THE BUCK
STOPS WITH YOU SIR. AND WHAT I
THINK YOU NEED TO BE ABLE TO
CONVINCE YOUR CUSTOMERS UP IS
THAT. YOU'RE NOT ON STRIKE
THREE. BECAUSE PRIOR TO YOUR
TEN YEAR THAT STRIKE ONE WAS
SAN BRUNO. AND THE COVER UP.
STRIKE TWO WITH TWO SEVEN EIGHT
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND THEN
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
WILDFIRES. AND NOW YOU'RE
ASKING YOUR CUSTOMERS BETTER
TRUST YOU AGAIN ASKED AFTER THE
DEBACLE THESE POWER OUTAGES.
AND KEEP TRUSTS AND IT'S GOING
TO GET BETTER. WE'RE NOW IN
YOUR TO. SO WHAT I WOULD ASK
IS. ARE YOU MY LAST QUESTION
ARE YOU OPEN TO ALL OPTIONS.
BOB P. JEANNIE LOOKING
DIFFERENTLY IN THE FUTURE. A
PUBLIC OPTION ARE YOU OPEN TO
LOOKING INTO REGIONAL OPTION.
AND ALL ENDED RIGHT THERE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR INDULGENCE
FOR FUTURE. WOULD YOU LIKE A
RESPONSE TO THAT YEAH NO
ABSOLUTELY PLEASE AND OF YOUR
ENDING. SO. I'M OPEN TO ANY
RESPONSE THAT SERVES THE NEEDS
BEST OF THE PEOPLE OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. NOW I DO WORK FOR
THE SHAREHOLDERS AT THE MOMENT
SO LET'S NOT KID OURSELVES
ABOUT THAT. I ACTUALLY THINK
CAN KEEPING PIGEON A IS AN
INTEGRATED. DIFFERENT COMPANY
IS THE BEST WAY TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF THE REGION. BUT YOU
KNOW WE ARE A BANKRUPTCY
PROCEEDING HAND- PEOPLE HAVE
DIFFERENT IDEAS A COMPLETED IN
THERE AND SEE HOW THAT WORKS. I
CAME HERE NO REALLY TO BE
HELPFUL AND I WANT THE BEST
OUTCOME FOR THE PEOPLE. THAT'S
WHAT I MEANT. TO BE DETERMINED
THANK YOU CENTER. THANK YOU YOU
KNOW- MISTER JOHNSON- I'VE BEEN
IMPRESSED BY YOUR A DIRECT TALK
YOU'VE BEEN IN MY OFFICE COUPLE
TIMES I'VE SEEN YOU QUOTED IN
THE IN THE PAPERS WITH THAT
STRAIGHT TALK. YOU KNOW I FEEL
LIKE I'M DOING MY JOB IF I
DIDN'T HAVE SOME STRAIGHT TALK
WITH YOU TODAY. AND I'LL TELL
YA NOT WITHSTANDING THE
TRANSMISSION LINES- ISSUE THAT
THE SENATE MCGUIRE JUST BROUGHT
UP. YOU I LOOKED AT WHAT
HAPPENED ON OCTOBER NINTH. AS A
BIG SCREW YOU. DEAR CUSTOMERS
TO THE LEGISLATURE. TO THE
GOVERNOR AND I THINK A TERM
THAT YOU PROBABLY USE IN
TENNESSEE WAS YELLED THAT DOG
DON'T HUNT. AND I REALLY
BELIEVE- THAT THAT HAS REALLY
CREATED AMONGST THE LEGISLATURE.
AMONGST YOUR CUSTOMERS A REAL
TRUST ISSUE THAT WHEN YOU DO DO
A PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD JOB
LATER ON AFTER OCTOBER TWENTY
THIRD IT LEAVES EVERYBODY
WONDERING. WHAT ARE WE GONNA
HAVE NEXT ARE THEY GOING TO BE
DOING THIS TO- YOU KNOW IT IN
IN THAT ON THAT FIRST ONE I
JUST FELT LIKE YOU KNOW THIRTY
COUNTIES. AND YOU KNOW WE WERE
MONTEREY PRETTY CLOSELY IN THE
NAPA VALLEY IN THE SNOW MY
COUNTY LAKE COUNTY AND THE WIND
SPEEDS YEAH THE WE HAD ALL
THROUGHOUT OUR AREA AND
PROBLEMS MISTER SAYING THIS.
YOU KNOW THIS GOES TO YOU.
SORRY. YEAH THERE WAS NO WIND.
LITTLE OR NO WITH ME UNTIL
MAYBE THE THIRD DAY THAT FRIDAY
AND MANY OF THE PEOPLE HAD IT
SHUT OFF ON WEDNESDAY ON
THURSDAY AND FRIDAY SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS YEAR
YOU'RE BEHIND SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC BEHIND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON IN TERMS OF
THESE POWERSHOT OFFICE I GET
THAT BUT- YOU KNOW TO ME I
DON'T REALLY UNDERSTAND THE
LOGIC. IN PULLING THE PLUG WHEN
THE WINDS ARE EVEN AT THE LEVEL
WHERE STATUTORILY. YOU HAVE TO.
I MEAN I UNDERSTAND BEFORE THE
WINDS GET TO FIFTY MILES AN
HOUR FIFTY FIVE WHATEVER THE
STATUTORY- THE- WIND SPEEDS ARE
THE YOU HAVE TO KEEP YOUR LINES
STRONG ENOUGH TO WITHSTAND. BUT
I CERTAINLY DON'T THINK NO
WINTER FIVE MILES AN HOUR EVEN
TEN MILE AN HOUR WINDS- YOU
KNOW IT'S JUST SOMETHING THAT
YOU YOU JUST CONTINUE TO LOSE.
THE OTHER TRUSTS I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THE FACT THAT THE
GREAT IS NOT CONNECTED BUT- YOU
KNOW IN IN IN A COMMUNITY WHERE
YOU HAVE A MILE AWAY. A WHOLE
COMMUNITY THAT'S. OFFERING AND
REALLY ECONOMY IS WORKING AT
THEN A MILE TO THE NORTH IN A
MILE TO THE SOUTH EVERYBODY'S
OFF IN OTHER COMMUNITIES AND
ECONOMIES ARE SUFFERING BEYOND
BELIEF IT REQUIRES- YOU AGAIN
THAT QUESTIONING WHO IN THE
HELL DESIGNED YOUR SYSTEM. SO I
KNOW THIS IS THE INNER I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE HELL YOU'RE GONNA
SAY IDEA AFTER THIS BECAUSE I
REALLY NOT ASKING IT ANY DIRECT
QUESTIONS BUT IT YOU CAN SENSE
THE FRUSTRATION THAT WE HAVE
DEALING WITH OUR CONSTITUENTS
EVERY SINGLE DAY. AND IF YOU
WANT TO CALL ME HERE WELCOME
AND THEY'RE ALL ASKS ME TO
EXPLAIN HOW HE DESIGNED ASSIST.
IN THE YEARS OF THE PREVIOUS
ONES. ON THE FIRST POINT- HI
I'VE HEARD THIS COMMENT THAT.
WE DID THIS EVENT TO SEND A
MESSAGE ABOUT INVERSE OR YOU
KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO PROVE
SOMETHING. I CAN ASSURE YOU WE
WERE NOT. THAT WE WERE
FOLLOWING THE PROTOCOL WE HAVE
ON FILE- DID WHETHER TURN OUT
EXACTLY LIKE WE THOUGHT IT
WOULD NO. BUT THERE WAS NO
MESSAGE THERE OF ANYTHING OTHER
THAN WERE FOLLOWING THE
PROTOCOL AND I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'RE A NEW TO SAY ABOUT THAT
EVENT. HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT AN
EVENT BUT TO YOUR QUESTION IN
REGARDS TO THE DESIGN OF THE
SYSTEM CENTER OBVIOUSLY THIS
IS- THE DATES A LOT OF US HERE
AS WELL RIGHT SO IT'S SOMETHING
THAT- WAS INHERITED AS PART OF
A- THE INTEGRATION OF MULTIPLE.
IN A UTILITIES AND WHEN YOU
START LOOKING AT WHAT'S
DIFFERENT BETWEEN OUR SERVICE
TERRITORY. WE DO SEE A LOT OF
LONG RADIO LINES THAT DO SERVE
OF LOW DENSITY NON URBAN
CUSTOMER MAKES IT WAS
INTERESTING IS WHEN YOU START
LOOKING AT THE RATIO. OF NUMBER
OF CUSTOMERS EVEN THOUGH THE
LARGEST TIRE YOU WITHIN THE
STATE- WE HAVE THE LOWEST
CUSTOMER DOWN. FOR DISTRICT
DISTRIBUTION LIFESTYLE WELL AS
A LOS CUSTOMER DENSITY PER
TRANSMISSION LINES BECAUSE WE
HAVE A LOT OF LONG RADIO LINES.
THAT ARE TRAVERSING NOW THE
HIGH FAR REST BRISK AREAS THAT
ARE PROVIDING SERVICE- TO SOME
LARGE COMMUNITIES AND WHAT
TENDS TO HAPPEN IS. AS. PREVENT
SEGMENTING IN AND- FOCUSING ON
DE ENERGIZING THE- TO LINE
THAT'S TRAVERSING THE HIGH FAR
RISK AREA. THERE'S UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES TO COMMUNITIES
THAT DON'T HAVE A SECONDARY
SUPPLY. AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT
I AS SPEAKING TO IN REGARDS TO
WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE DOING THIS
DRAMATICALLY DIFFERENT FROM
THIS YEAR NEXT YEAR. IS
IDENTIFYING THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR DISTRIBUTED ENABLED.
GENERATION MICRA QUITS TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT POTENTIAL
SECONDARY SUPPLY IN SOME CASES-
WE DON'T HAVE A BACK FEET WHERE
WE CAN ACTUALLY- CONNECTED FROM
ANOTHER CIRCUIT THAT MAY BE IN
A LOWER FIRE RISK AREA. AND FOR
THEIR SEGMENT THE CIRCUIT THAT
WE REALLY NEED TO FOCUS ON FROM
A AT RISK PERSPECTIVE. AND WHAT
REALLY TRANSPIRED ON THE
OCTOBER NINTH OF AND. EVEN THE
SCALE OF THE EVENT ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
CUSTOMER ACCOUNTS WAS THE
LARGEST- SHUT OFF EVENT THAT
WAS DONE ON THE HISTORY OF P.
JEANNIE. AS WE STARTED TO LOOK
AT THE TRANSMISSION LINES THAT
WERE INVOLVED. IN THE SHUT OFF
AND THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
INTERCONNECTED NATURE OF THAT
GREAT IT ENDED UP HAVING A
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
LOSING SOME CUSTOMERS EARLIER
ON- IN A BAND THE AT RISK
WHETHER- REALLY- REQUIRED AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE
FOCUSED ON. TO BE VERY SURGICAL
ABOUT SO THAT WE CAN MITIGATE
THOSE TYPES ISSUES BECAUSE THE
POINTS YOU WERE MAKING. WERE
COMPLETELY ALIGNED ON TO BE
ABLE TO- MINIMIZE THE IMPACT TO
OUR CUSTOMERS FOR MODERATION
PERSPECTIVE. AND THAT'S TWO
FOLD ONE IS TO BE ABLE TO- DE
ENERGIZED AS CLOSE TO THE AT
RISK WEATHER EVENT AT AND
STARTING ABOUT AT RISK WEATHER
EVENT AS POSSIBLE. AND THEN
SECONDARILY AS THAT EVENT SIR
PASSED IS THE SERVICE
TERRITORY. IS TO BE ABLE TO DO
THE RIGHT RATIO IN VERY VERY
QUICKLY AND- THAT WE
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVE DâN. FROM
LAST YEAR I'LL GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE THERE'S ABOUT SIXTY
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS OVER
INVOLVED IN THE OCTOBER. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN EVENT. AND IT TOOK US
NEARLY FIFTY ONE HOURS.
RESTORATION TIME WHICH MEANS
AFTER THE AT RISK WHETHER
SUBSIDE. COMPARE THAT TO THE
OCTOBER TWENTY SIXTH OF AND WE
HAD NINE HUNDRED AND
700-009-0040 THOUSAND CUSTOMER
ACCOUNTS WE WERE ABLE TO DO
THAT RESTORATION ON AVERAGE IN
TWELVE HOURS SO A SIGNIFICANT
IN A DRAMATIC IMPROVEMENT AND
THAT'S REALLY OUR FOCUS. I HEAR
THAT BUT AT THE SAME TIME IF
THERE WAS NO WIND IN MANY OF
THOSE AREAS. WHY DO YOU NEED TO
GO BACK AND CHECK THE LINES. SO
MAYBE IT ISN'T IT I HEAR THE
ANSWER BUT I DON'T REALLY
RECOGNIZE THAT- THAT ANSWER AS
SOMETHING THAT- YOU KNOW REALLY
RED YOUR RESONATES WITH ME
KNOWING. WE ARE WHAT WE HAD ON
THE GROUND. SO TO SERVE GOING
HAVING THAT YOU'LL GO BACK AND
CHECK THOSE LINES THE WIND
SPEED. GOT A- HOUSE NOW. WAS IT
AND THAT'S THAT'S PART OF OUR
PROTOCOL SO THE LINES I DON'T
MEET THAT THRESHOLD BUT ARE
INCLUDED IN SCOPE AS A RESULT
OF THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE
OF THE INTERCONNECTED NATURE OF
THE GRADE THAT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY PART OF
THE SLOPE. SO IN ESSENCE YOU'RE
TRYING TO GET CREDIT. FOR
GETTING THE POWER DOWN POWER
BACK ON. A LOT QUICKER WHEN
THERE WAS NO PROBLEM. SO I
WOULD NATURALLY STATE THAT-
CENTER BECAUSE THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT FOCUS ON OUR
RESTORATION CAPABILITIES IN
REGARDS TO TRAINING DOING
ACTIVE DRILLS- HAVING OUR TEAMS
BECOME VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
CIRCUITS DOING BOOTS ON THE
GROUND PATROLS- DURING THE
EARLY PART OF THE YEAR AS WELL
AS SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDING. OUR
AERIAL FLEET CAPABILITIES WE
WENT FROM SEVEN TO EIGHT
HELICOPTERS WE HAD LAST YEAR.
TO MORE THAN FORTY. AT THE PEAK
AND WE'RE LOOKING TO GO TO- UP
TO SEVENTY- INCLUSIVE OF
WORKING WITH THE OUR CALLOW YES
PARTNERS TO LEVERAGE. NIGHT
PATROLLING CAPABILITIES THROUGH
FIXED WING AND WE'RE LOOKING TO
MAKE THAT PART OF OUR CURIOUSLY
CAPABILITIES WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT FOCUS. ON THE
OPERATION SIDE FROM A
RESTORATION PERSPECTIVE WOULD
REALLY CAME TO BEAR AS WELL. I
ACCEPT AND RESPECT THAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MY COLLEAGUES WERE
ACTUALLY RATHER POLITE THE.
MANY OF US WERE SITTING AT THE
DíAS REPRESENT. YOUR SERVICE
TERRITORY AND. GRANTED IT IS
FAR MORE COMPLICATED IT IS
LARGER IT IS MORE CUSTOMERS
GEOGRAPHICALLY PHENOMENALLY
LARGER TOPOGRAPHICALLY- THERE
SO MANY SO MANY FACTORS SO.
THAT IT IS MORE COMPLICATED I
DON'T THINK ANY OF US UNDER
ESTIMATE BY. YOU HAVE HAD
WHETHER THEY WERE ADEQUATE OR
NOT YOU HAVE HAD THE ABILITY
OVER ALL OF THIS TIME AND I'M
NOT JUST TALKING THE LAST THREE
YEARS OF FIRES BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T NEED THE LAST THREE
YEARS OF FIRES THAT WE ARE IN A
VERY HIGH FIRE DANGER AREA.
STANLEY MORE. PERMITTED NOW BUT
EVEN DURING THE DROUGHT. WE
KNEW THAT WE WERE A GREAT FIRE
RISK THAT ENTIRE TIME. AND
CERTAINLY THE US EMBRATEL
INCIDENT WAS MANY YEARS PRIOR
SO THE ISSUE OF HAVING RATES TO
COVER. THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF
UTILITY FOR SAFETY MAINTENANCE
AND THOSE SORTS OF THINGS. YOU
HAVE THEM AT LEAST YOU HAD THAT
WHICH YOU MORE ASKED FOR NOW IF
YOU NEEDED MORE. THERE IS NOT
BUT WE DON'T HAVE WE'RE NOT
SUPPOSED TO HAVE A CRYSTAL BALL
THAT YOU NEED MORE. AND
CERTAINLY OUR CUSTOMERS RATES
ARE QUITE HIGH. AND YET. AT I
THINK THAT I CAN SAY. WITHOUT
SPEAKING OUT OF TURN. THAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS HAVE NO MORE
CONFIDENCE. IT IS UTILITY. AND
DATE. HAVE A GREAT DEAL OF
RESPECT FOR THE COMPANY NOW I
DON'T WANT TO GO INTO GREAT
MORE DETAIL ABOUT THAT BECAUSE
AS MR MORNING SENATOR MORNING
SHARED. I DON'T WANT THE P.
JEANNIE WORKERS TO FEEL THE
WRATH OF. THE A RATE PAYERS
WHEN THEY ARE SO FRUSTRATED
WITH THIS IT IS NOT FAIR FOR
RIGHT TO TAKE IT OUT ON THOSE
WORKERS- AND YOU ARE BOTH NEW.
BUT WE'RE STILL IN A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE. WE ARE
BEING TOLD AS WAS JUST SENT TO
MISTER REQUIRE AND SENATOR
REQUIRED SENATOR DODD THEY
COULD BE TEN YEARS THAT IS JUST
NOT ACCEPTABLE SO I GUESS I'LL
ALL I ASK IS. ARE YOU WILLING
TO REVISE YOUR HARDENING AND
RESILIENCY PLAN SO THAT YOU CAN.
IT'S VERY PROMPTLY SO THAT YOU
CAN EVALUATE THE BEST AVAILABLE
CONTROL TECHNOLOGIES. THAT ARE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE BECAUSE
CLEARLY UNDER GROUNDING AS WE
KNOW IS VERY EXPENSIVE AND I'M
NOT SAYING WE SHOULD NOT
UNDERGROUND I'M JUST SAYING
THAT IF WE PLAN IF THAT'S OUR
PRIMARY. THAT'LL TAKE FOREVER
CERTAINLY VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
SIMILARLY BECAUSE OF THE SIZE
OF THE REGION AND THE DROUGHTS
AND THE TYPE OF VEGETATION
THAT. IS VERY DIFFICULT BUT
SOME OF THE OTHER TECHNOLOGIES
THAT WE HEARD THE OTHER
UTILITIES. UTILIZING THAT ARE
NOT UTILIZED IN THE SAME LEVEL
BY P. JEANNIE. YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT ALL OF US WOULD EXPECT TO
SEE A REVISION. TO HAVE SOME
IMMEDIATE RESULTS WITH THE
CHEAPER COST EFFECTIVE CONTROL
TECHNOLOGIES THAT CAN ALSO BE
IMPLEMENTED MUCH FASTER BECAUSE
NOT ONLY IS UNDERGROUND
EXPENSIVE IT TAKES A LONG TIME
SO HOW CAN WE GET RESULTS MUCH
FASTER. WELL THE SHORT ANSWER
TO YOUR QUESTION IS YES
ABSOLUTELY WE'RE WILLING TO
LOOK AT OTHER THINGS
ACCELERATE- WE HAVE DONE A
NUMBER OF THINGS WE OF HE THE
RESEARCHER STOLEN SHAMELESSLY
FROM OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
SOUTH ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
AND IN FACT WERE ALREADY
TALKING ABOUT- DO WE HAVE THE
RIGHT THINGS IN THE RIGHT AWAY.
WE NEED TO SWITCH FROM
SOMETHING TO MORE HARDENING.
AND SO YEAH WE'RE LOOKING FOR
THE BEST SOLUTION AIR AND NOT
MARRIED TO THE ONE WE HAVE
ABSOLUTELY. WELL I THINK THAT
ALL OF US WOULD EXPECT TO SEE.
AS PROMPTLY AS POSSIBLE BUT
DONE WELL A REVISION TWO YEAR
PLAN THAT REFLECTS THAT- I ALSO
IN. TO ECHO SENATOR MAGUIRE'S.
THE WAY I DESCRIBE THE
CIRCUMSTANCE WAS FIRST I AM
VERY VERY. RELIEVED THAT WE DID
NOT HAVE DEATHS IN THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA FIRE SEASON STARTS
FAR. BUT WE CAN'T CREATED
DISASTER TO AVERTED DISASTER
AND IN THIS NEXT SET OF POWER
OUTAGES WE DO KNOW THAT THERE
ARE ESTIMATES OF THE
TEMPERATURE DROPS TO THIRTY
SEVEN DEGREES AND THERE ARE
VERY FEW HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO SURVIVE
AFTER A COUPLE OF NIGHTS. OF NO
HEAT AT THIRTY SEVEN DEGREES
NOW CERTAINLY SOME PEOPLE HAVE
THEIR HEAT THROUGH NATURAL GAS
AND PERHAPS IT DOESN'T AFFECT
BUT THERE'S OFTEN EVEN THE BILL
WOULD BE TO TURN IT ON THAT IS
THEN ELECTRICALLY CONNECTED SO.
WE I THINK WE REALLY. WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO HAVE ANY DEATHS INTO
HERE. I APPRECIATE RED RED
CROSS MAY HAVE THEIR OWN SET OF
PROTOCOLS BUT THEN YOU CAN'T
RELY ON THEM YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO SOMETHING ELSE BECAUSE
WE CANNOT HAVE ANY DEATHS IN
ANY OF THE AREAS BY ANY OTHER
CUSTOMERS WHERE THIS NEXT.
POWER OUTAGE IS SET UP. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN-
I AND MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
COVERED IT. QUITE WELL IN TERMS
OF THE ISSUES WITH- THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ON WITH THE
BLACKOUTS AMERICAN REPEAT THAT
I WANT TO FOCUS ON- HOW WE HAVE
MORE RESILIENT COMMUNITIES.
DURING. FOUR FIVE SIX TEN YEARS
WHATEVER IT IS THAT P. GINNY.
SO FIRST WHAT WOULD YOU DO YOU
AGREE WITH ME. ON THAT- CLEAN
ENERGY STORAGE IS PREFERABLE TO
DIESEL GENERATORS IN TERMS OF
PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO HAVE POWER
DURING A BLACKOUT. YES OKAY. SO
BY. WHO CAN I WANT TO ASK YOU
THAT WOULD GIVEN NINE. AND WE
NEED A LOT MORE PEOPLE AND
BUSINESSES TO HAVE ENERGY
STORAGE. IN CALIFORNIA WOULD
AGREE WITH THAT. I AGREE
GENERALLY WITH THAT I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE PENETRATION IS
AN- ABOUT PRETTY MUCH CONSUMED
WITH BANKRUPTCY AND WILDFIRES I
DON'T I DON'T EXPECT YOU TO
KNOW THAT I WILL TELL. THAT WE
WOULD BE ACHIEVED A DECENT.
JOHNS ON ON SOLAR- BUT ENERGY
STORAGE IS WAY BEHIND IN PART
BECAUSE TECHNOLOGIES NEWER-
IT'S- MORE EXPENSIVE ALL THE
COSTS ARE COMING DOWN- AND ONE
OF THE REASONS ONE OF THE WAYS
THAT WE GET THE COST TO COME
DOWN AND GET THE PENETRATION TO
HAPPEN. IS TO DO WHAT WE DID
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR
INITIATIVE WHICH WAS TO HAVE A
REBATE PROGRAM- AND WE HAVE A
PROGRAM NOW- CALLED THE AFTER
PROGRAM- AND WE ARE PASSED
SENATE BILL SEVEN HUNDRED ODD
LAST YEAR. THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
IT. WHICH CREATES A REBATE
PROGRAM FOR INDIVIDUALS FOR
BUSINESS SAYS FOR SCHOOLS FOR-
WHOEVER ELSE TO TRY TO. MAKE IT
MORE AFFORDABLE FOR PEOPLE TO
INSTALL ENERGY STORAGE IN
ADDITION BECAUSE I BELIEVE IT
WAS AT THE SEVEN YEAR PROGRAM.
IT CREATES CERTAINTYFOR THE
INDUSTRY- THAT THIS REBATE
PROGRAM IS GOING TO BE AROUND A
DOZEN VERY EVERY YEAR. THAT WE
KNOW THAT THIS MONEY IS THERE
AND IT WILL BE THERE- AND SO
THEY WILL INVEST AND INNOVATE.
TAB BETTER AND BETTER STORAGE
TECHNOLOGY AND TO CONTINUE TO
BRING THE COST DOWN SO THE ONE
BLACKOUTS HAPPEN PEOPLE CAN
HAVE THE STORAGE WITHOUT HAVING
TO BURN A DIESEL- SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS IN THOUGHTS PRICING
THIS IS THE THIRD TIME OF
RECESSION. IN THIS HEARING-
THAT P. GINNY IN ADDITION TO
THE OTHER I'LL USE IS CURRENTLY
ASKING A CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION NOT TO
PUBLICLY FIND A SEASON NOT TO
FULLY FUND. THE AFTER PROGRAM-
NO EDISON THOSE TAKEN THE
POSITION THAT IT NEEDS TO BE
POINTED SINCE TWO YEARS AT A
TIME WHICH IS COMPLETELY
DEFEATS THE PURPOSE OF HAVING A
SEVEN YEAR. PERIOD P. GINNY HAS
TAKEN THE POSITION THAT THE-
BECAUSE THERE'S A THERE'S A
SURPLUS IN THE FUND RIGHT NOW.
WHICH IS PRECISELY BECAUSE OF
THE UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF THE PROGRAM- AND SO-
THAT'S WHY THIS- SURPLUS HAS
ACCUMULATED I AM CONFIDENT THAT
THE SURPLUS WILL BE UTILIZED
OVERTIME. P. GINNY HAS TAKEN
THE POSITION THAT THE
COMMISSION SHOULD QUOTE RESPOND
SPAT AND COMMIT INSIDE OF FUNDS
AND QUOTE. INSTEAD OF
ALLOCATING MAP AND TOWARDS IT-
AND SO IN OTHER WORDS AND THE
OUT THE FINE EITHER BY REDUCING
PEOPLES- BILLS OR- OR- WHATEVER.
FOR LESS THAN FULL FUNDING OF
YESTER PROGRAM I THINK THAT IT
IS IN P. GINNY'S INTEREST AND
IS IN EVERYONE'S INTEREST TO
HAVE MORE ENERGY STORAGE OF THE
PEOPLE CAN KEEP THEIR LIGHTS
ON. AND SO I WANT TO ASK YOU IS
P. GINNY OPENED TO ACTUALLY
SUPPORTING FULL FUNDING OF THIS
PROGRAM A PROGRAM THAT WAS
CREATED BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR. SO THE
SECOND TIME YOU ASKED THE
QUESTION TODAY I LEANED OVER TO
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES AND SAID
I'M PROBABLY GOING TO GET ASKED
THIS QUESTION. AND THEN I GOT
CALLED UP HERE BEFORE I GOT THE
ANSWER. SO I'M WILLING. TO LOOK
AT ANYTHING AND THINK ABOUT
ANYTHING I CAN I DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH BACKGROUND TO ANSWER
EXACTLY WHAT YOU ASKED BUT I'M
CERTAINLY WILLING TO. THINK
ABOUT AND TALK ABOUT IT COME
VISIT WITH YOU ABOUT IT. I
THINK THAT IT WOULD CREATE AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF GOOD WILL-
WITH A LOT OF DIFFERENT PEOPLE-
IF THE UTILITIES IMPEACHING IN
PARTICULAR- WERE TO YOU KNOW.
REALLY SUPPORT BEFORE FUNDING
AND MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
BECAUSE BECAUSE IT IS SUCH A
SMART INDIVIDUALS HOMES IS
ABOUT BUSINESSES ABOUT SCHOOLS
IT'S ABOUT- FARMERS. NONE WHO
ARE LOSING THEIR CROPS AND WANT
TO BEGENERATE THEIR OWN OUR IN
STORE IT SO I WOULD REALLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONSIDER
WORKING WITH US AND- I ALSO
JUST GOING MORE BROADLY. WE'VE
HAD A NUMBER OF FIGHTS AGAIN
THIS IS NOT SAYS P. GINNY IT'S
WITH THE UTILITIES AND- WITH-
SOMETIMES OTHERS. ON ABOUT-
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCE-
PROGRAMS AND MAKE IT EASIER FOR
PEOPLE TO INSTALL THE AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE UTILITIES
HAVE A HISTORICALLY REFLEXIVELY
OPPOSE THAT AND SEEN AS SOME
SORT OF THREAT- BUT AGAIN I
THINK. NOW WITH EVERYTHING
THAT'S HAPPENING IN THE STATE
AND THAT WILL BE HAPPENING.
UNFORTUNATELY IT APPEARS FOR
AWHILE. WE GOTTA HAVE MORE DVRS
AND I WON A YOU KNOW- CAN I ASK
YOUR WHICH IS P. JEANNIE OPEN
TO SUPPORTING EXPANSION OF DVRS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ABSOLUTELY I THINK IS GOING TO
BE NECESSARY IN REMINDS ME AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE INDUSTRY.
EDISON AGAINST WESTINGHOUSE
RIGHT THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS
IS ABOUT LOCAL VERSUS BIG
SYSTEM AND I THINK. TO REALLY
METERS WILDFIRE RISK WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO DO MORE. YEAH
AND I MEAN I DO I WILL SAY THAT
I DO I HAD MY STAFF WE PULLED-
P. GINNY IS LOBBYING REPORT FOR
I GUESS IT'S FOR- APRIL FIRST
TO SIFT. TO JUNE THIRTIETH OF
THIS YEAR AND THERE ARE. DR
BILLS AND ONCE IT IS HERE THAT
P. GINNY LOBBIED AGAINST WHICH
AGAIN OUR EXPERIENCE IS THAT.
YOU NEED NOT JUST P. GINNY THE
OTHER I- USES WELL. LOBBY
AGAINST PRETTY MUCH EVERY
SINGLE D. E. R. BILL THAT'S
INTRODUCED IN THE LEGISLATURE
AND TRY TO EITHER KILL IT OR
GUIDE IT- YOU KNOW WE HAD A
BILL THIS YEAR SB TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT THAT MOVED THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE WITH. BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT- IT WAS AN COMPLETELY
GUIDED AND WE HAD TO ABANDON
THE BILL AND CAN THAT'S ONE OF
THE BILL'S A P. GINNY LOBBIED.
AGAINST AND SO I. YOU KNOW ARE
YOU LIKE NEXT YEAR HOW MUCH HOW
MUCH YOU ANTICIPATE P. GINNY
WILL SPEND THE LOBBY AGAINST D.
E. R. LEGISLATION. OR TO LOBBY
THE COMMISSION AGAINST YOURS.
PROBABLY ONE COME CLOSE THE
INTERNET IS GOOD I REALLY HOPE
THAT THE ANSWER IS ZERO. I'D
LIKE YOU TO FOCUS THE MONEY ON
FIXING SYSTEM AND AVOIDING THE
BLACKOUTS AND NOT MAKING IT
HARDER. FOR PEOPLE. TO GET
SOLAR AND STORAGE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN. CENTER
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MISS CHEER
AND I'LL BE REAL BRIEF BUT
WE'VE ALL TALKED ABOUT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CUSTOMERS- OUR LOW
INCOME AND OUR MEDICAL BASS
LINE. AND. AS WE ALL KNOW THAT
SHE'S A RATE MECHANISM IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY IDENTIFY
THAT CUSTOMER ON THE GRID FOR
YOU ON OUR PARTICULAR CIRCUIT
SO WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO HELP
IDENTIFY THOSE CUSTOMERS
SPECIALLY IF THEY DO NOT HAVE A
CELL PHONE THEY DO NOT HAVE A
COMPUTER. SO YOU CAN PROVIDE.
ADEQUATE CONTACT AT EIGHT IN A
TIMELY MANNER BECAUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE THINK SIMPLY BECAUSE OUR
MEDICAL BASS LINE YOU GUYS
ALBUM ON A MAP YOU KNOW WHERE
THEY ARE AND THAT'S AND THAT'S
OR THE CASE HISTORY MECHANISM.
JUST LIKE HERE AS I'M A CORRECT.
LARA CENTER BRADFORD THANKS FOR
THE QUESTION- OBVIOUSLY WE DO
KNOW WERE MEDICAL BASELINE
CUSTOMERS ARE AND IF WE DON'T
RECEIVE POSITIVE CONFIRMATION
WITH THOSE CUSTOMERS AND WE ARE
REACH THEM WE WILL SEND AN AND
ONE OF OUR EMPLOYEES TO THEIR
HOME- AND MAKE EVERY ATTEMPT TO
MAKE POSITIVE- COMMUNICATION
WITH THEM IN ADVANCE OF THE
WILDFIRE SEASON WE'VE BEEN
COMMUNICATING WITH THESE
CUSTOMERS THROUGH ALL MEANS OF
COMMUNICATION E-MAIL PHONE
EMAIL- THROUGH SOCIAL CHANNELS
RADIO TELEVISION A TO ENSURE
THAT WE KNOW WHO THEY ARE WHERE
THEY ARE. AND RECEIVE THEIR
CONTACT ATION. WE WILL KING
VERY CLOSELY IN ADDITION WITH
OUR COUNTIES TO IDENTIFY THIS
POPULATION AND WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE COUNTIES. IN ADDITION
WE WILL BE STANDING UP ED AFN
ADVISORY COUNCIL THAT WILL HELP
ADVISE THE COMPANY ON HOW WE
CAN. REACH OUT EVEN FURTHER TO
CUSTOMERS THAT- HAVE SPECIAL
NEEDS CUSTOMERS THAT NEED OUR
SUPPORT IN A VERY DIFFERENT WAY
BE VERY OPEN TO THE FEEDBACK.
IN ADDITION WE'RE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE COUNTIES AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE A GREATER REACH TO THESE
COMMUNITIES AND TO THESE
CUSTOMERS AND WILL BE
LEVERAGING OUR FOUNDATION
FUNDING AND SUPPORT FOR THE
COUNTIES. AND COMMUNITIES NOT
TO OVERBURDEN THE COUNTIES WE
DON'T WANNA OVER BURDEN THEM
WITHOUT THE FINANCIAL SUPPORT-
THAT THEY'LL NEED. TO SUPPORT
THESE CUSTOMERS BUT WE WANT TO
DO THAT IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THEM. AND MY LAST QUESTION IT
WILL NOT NO SIR BECAUSE FROM
THE STATE AND IT WAS A QUESTION
BY BOTH SENATOR DODD AND ANSWER
MCGUIRE AS IT RELATES TO SOME
YOUR TRANSMISSION WHY SOME OF
THEM. WEREN'T TURNED OFF AND AS
A INDIVIDUAL WHO WORKED FOR
TWELVE YEARS FOR UTILITY I'M
NOT HERE TO DEFEND YOU BUT
SOMETIMES A TRANSMISSION LINE
IS FOR FULL TO MANAGEMENT AND
LOAD MANAGEMENT. AN AREA WERE
IT'S SAFE AND YOU'RE STILL
TRYING TO DELIVER POWER TO THAT
AREA MY CORRECT. AND SOMETIMES
YOU SHOULD BE IT BY TURNING
THAT OFF YOU IMPACT MORE FOLKS
ARE NOT EVEN IN IN IN THE FIRE
DANGERS ON OF MY CORRECT. THAT
SO SOMETIMES IS ABOUT LOW
MANAGEMENT AND IT'S NOT A
PERFECT SYSTEM I MEAN SOME OF
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE IS BEEN
THERE A HUNDRED PLUS YEARS SO I
UNDERSTAND. THANK YOU CENTER
AND THAT THOSE EXACTLY MY
REFERENCE TO GREAT STABILITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE TODAY. AND WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
GROUP THANK YOU. AND OUR NEXT
GROUP WILL OF. THE THEME WILL
BE A STATE OVERSIGHT OF PUBLIC
POLICY POWERS. I'M SORRY OF POP
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A GROUP- WE
HAVE ANNA MONO CENTER SHE'S A
CABINET SECRETARY AND ENERGIES
ARE BUT THE OFFICE OF THE
GOVERNOR KNEW SOME WE HAVE MARK
NUCLEAR DO CHEESY HE'S THE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT OFFICE
OF. OF THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES WE ACTUALLY
LEAVE SECRETARY OF THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AND MARK-
GALIA BELIEVE- SECRETARY OF THE
CALIFORNIA HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY. WE ALSO HAVE ONE NAME
AND MEN DONGHAI THESE THE-
DIRECTOR OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. A MERRY BELL BUT
YOU'RE THE PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
ELIZAVETA MELLISH MALASHENKO
SHE'S A DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF SAFETY IN
ENFORCEMENT POLICY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA UTILITY PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. BEN AND I
HAVE A QUESTION FOR. CABINET
SECRETARY AND ENERGIES ARE ON A
MONO SANTOS JUST. AS YOU. YOU
HAVE A DOUBLE TITLE THERE ONE
IS- SECRETARY AND THE WIND IS
THE CZAR SO WHAT DO I CALL YOU-
MADAM SECRETARY OR YOUR MAJESTY
MISTER CHAIR ANNA IS JUST FINE
OKAY. I WAS WELCOME THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US AND
I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF
SINCE YOU HAVE ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE THE- EXPERTS
IN THIS AREA AND WHO- IN WHO
DID- EXTRAORDINARY WORK
ENSURING THAT WE WORKED WITH
OUR LOCAL PARTNERS AND- WITH
LABOR PARTNERS AND- PROVIDERS-
AND WITH MANY OF YOU. ARE DOING
EVERYTHING WE COULD TO.
MITIGATE THE IMPACTS IN THE
DESTRUCTIVE EFFECTS OF THESE P.
S. P. S. LOSE AS WELL AS
EFFECTIVELY PUTTING. OUT FIRES
AND- ENSURING THAT WE WORK
TOGETHER TO MINIMIZE LOSS OF
LIFE- SO THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- OVERSIGHT OF THIS
IMPORTANT OPIC AND- FOR WORK-
THINKS AHEAD FOR A WORK GOING
FORWARD TO- ENSURING THAT WE-
KEEP THE INTEREST. OF
CALIFORNIA- TOP OF MIND AND-
AND THAT WE CONTINUE TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO TAKE CARE
OF PEOPLE'S BUSINESS THE ON THE
TOP ON THE- COULDN'T. OUT OF
THE STORE. FOR HIS EMERGENCY
SYSTEM IS STRONG AND RESILIENT-
IN THE INVESTMENT SO YOU'VE
MADE OVER YEARS OF PAID OFF.
PRE POSITION TEAMS- STRONGER
INVESTMENTS IN BUT IN A TRUCK
SURE. TECHNOLOGY CAL FIRE. THE
WORK AROUND. FOREST MANAGEMENT-
ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT PIECES
HAVE MADE A SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF- REAL
TIME USE OF TECHNOLOGY TO BE
ABLE TO- TO IDENTIFY THE WILD
FIRES A PRE POSITIONED
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO PUT
THEM UP QUICKLY- AND WE SEE IS
YOU KNOW IN THE IN THE WEEK OF
THE MAJOR PS PS VANCE WE CAL
FIRE RESPONDED CALIFORNIA
LOCAL. RESPOND TO A TOTAL OF
WITHOUT OF- INCIDENTS AND ONLY
A FEW OF THOSE FIRES- BECAME-
LARGE SO THESE THE THINGS THAT
YOU HAVE DONE THE THINGS THAT
THAT- THE STATE IS DOING
TOGETHER OUR- KING AND ARE
MAKING A SIGNIFICANT I THE TEAM
BEFORE YOU AND- OUR MEN'S AND
AGENCIES WORKED CLARK QUICKLY
TO ADAPT TO A CHANGING
SITUATION. BE IT THE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH- WITH- I JUST
AS PROVIDERS THAT MARK STEAM-
WORKED ON THE PARTNERSHIPS WITH
HEALTH PLANS TO IDENTIFY
INFORMATION A MEDICALLY FRAGILE
PROB PEOPLE- AS YOU MENTIONED-
SOME OF THE BASE LIKE CUSTOMER
INFORMATION HAS A LOT OF. A LOT
FEWER PEOPLE IDENTIFIED THEM
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT NEED
OUR SUPPORT SO- THE WORK OF-
JULIE LEE AND AMY TONG.
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY SERVICES
PUTTING TOGETHER WEBSITE
OVERNIGHT TO ENSURE THAT FOLKS
SAID RESOURCES IN A ONE STOP
SHOP FOR INFORMATION AROUND.
YOU AYE BENEFITS AROUND- CAL
FRESH IN AROUND A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT FORMATION AROUND WHAT
WAS HAPPENING WITH POWER SHOT
ALSO IN A LOT OF INFORMATION
THAT WAS HELPFUL TO FOLKS IN A
VERY DIFFICULT SITUATION- I
THINK AS WE THINK ABOUT THE-
THE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE FOCUSED
TO DATE IN SOME WAYS THE IN AND
THE FUTURE IN SOME WAYS THE
WALLS IS ESTABLISHED BY YOU AND
TEN FIFTY FOUR. ARE CLEAR-
INCOME TO BE WILL WORKING
TOWARDS SAFE RELIABLE-
ELECTRICITY HANNAH
INFRASTRUCTURE COMING OUT OF
BANKRUPTCY THAT IS PREPARED TO
DO WHAT IS NECESSARY TO PROVIDE
THE- YOU KNOW THE LEVEL OF
RESOURCE THE LEVEL SUPPORT THE
LOVE THE LOVE THE TYPE OF
ELECTRICITY IN A MANNER THAT
THAT CALIFORNIA- NEEDS STILL
SIXTY. LIABLE ON AFFORDABLE.
MANESAR OUR FOCUS- AT EXIT THAT
IS REPAIR NEUTRAL FAIR
TREATMENT OF VICTIMS OF ALL
ALIGNED WITH CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS AND ALL IN
RECOGNITION OF THAT- RETAINING
AND SUPPORTING. THE STAFF THAT
DOES THIS WORK IN THE UTILITY
IS CRITICAL TO HAVE THE TYPE OF
TRANSFORMATION THAT IS NEEDED
TO. ENSURE THAT AS WE ADAPT TO
CLIMATE CHANGE WE DO IT IN A
WAY WE'RE THE TYPE OF
DESTRUCTION THE CALIFORNIA HAS
EXPERIENCED. IS NOT A NEW
NORMAL- SO I'M HAPPY TO. TO
STOP THEIR ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AT THE BACK AND BUT DIRECTOR
DEALER DO CHEERED AFTERWARDS
SERVICES- WE'LL- TALK ABOUT
SOME OF WHAT WE LEARNED SOME OF.
WHAT WE DID AND MY COLLEAGUES
WILL CONTINUE FROM THERE. MR
GREAT OR THE COMPUTER AFTER MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE UP MARKET ARE DUE TO
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES. FIRST LET ME START
OFF BY SAYING THAT THE SCOPE
AND THE SCALE OF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF THAT WERE
IMPLEMENTED BY THE UTILITIES IN
OCTOBER. RESULT IN A SERIES OF
VERY COMPLEX AND CHALLENGING
CONDITIONS THAT WE ALL HAVE TO
COLLECTIVELY MANAGE SOMEBODY
GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT OF A HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THAT BECAUSE
YOU'RE SO MANY. SO MANY THINGS
THAT WENT ALL THE PERIOD OF
TIME THAT- WE HAD THE ENGAGE
WITH. WHAT SUSAN OF COURSE TO
IMPLEMENT THAT- PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF RESTED SOLELY
WITH UTILITIES. THAT DECISION
ALONG WITH THE RED FLAG FIRE
OTHER CONDITIONS THAT EXISTED
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. RESULTED IN
THE STATE HAVE TO MANAGE THE
MEDI CASCADING A COMPLEX
CONSEQUENCES THAT ENSUED.
LEVERAGING ALL OF OUR WELL
ESTABLISHED PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE SYSTEMS ARE PRIMARY
EFFORT WAS TO SUPPORT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. TO PROTECT
RESIDENTS AND. TO MITIGATE ANY
IMPACTS TO LIFE PROPERTY A FIRE.
THE UNIQUE CHALLENGES OF COURSE
OR WITH THESE- OCTOBER PS PS
ADVANCE PROTECT IN THE- IS
WHERE THE OUTAGES OVERLAPPED.
OR EXTENDED FOR MULTIPLE DAYS
INCLUDING JUST THE SHEER
FREQUENCY OF THE EVENTS. THE
SCOPE THE SCALE AND THE
ULTIMATE CASCADING INTER
DEPENDENT. LIFELINE IMPACTS IN
THE AREAS THAT WERE DE
ENERGIZED WHAT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING OVER TIME WAS REALLY
GETTING DOWN YOU KNOW IN THE
DETAIL IN ON THE GROUND AND
AFFECTING SO MANY DIFFERENT
SECTIONS OF OUR LIVES. LEADING
UP TO THE OCTOBER P. S. P. S.
P. JEANNIE HAD INITIATED THREE
SMALLER MORE DEFINED PSP S.
OFFENSE IN SCOPE AND SCALE IN
JUNE SEPTEMBER AND EARLY
OCTOBER. THE LONGEST LASTING
ROUGHLY TWO AND A HALF DAYS AND
IMPACTING BETWEEN FIVE AND
TWELVE COUNTIES RESTORATION
FOLLOWING THOSE SMALLER VANCE
WAS DONE RELATIVELY RAPIDLY.
BETWEEN OCTOBER NINTH AND
OCTOBER ELEVENTH P. GINNY MADE
THE DECISION TO DE ENERGIZED A
MUCH BROADER AREA IMPACTING
THIRTY EIGHT COUNTIES- WITH AN
ESTIMATED POPULATION OF ABOUT
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION WHICH
YOU ARE ARE YOU JUST HEARD FROM
THE PREVIOUS PANEL. IT DOCTOR
OVER P. GINNY AND SHE HATED
THREE BACK TO BACK PS PS EVENTS
ON OCTOBER TWENTY THIRD TWENTY
SIX AND TWENTY NINTH
RESPECTIVELY. AGAIN ATTEMPTING
THIRTY EIGHT COUNTIES MANY OF
WHICH HAD BEEN DE ENERGIZED
SEVERAL TIMES PREVIOUSLY AT
THIS POINT THE FREQUENCY AND
THE SCALE OF THESE EVENTS WAS
EVOLVING INTO REAL SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES. OCTOBER TWENTY
THIRD PREVENT P. GINNY DEANNA
JACKSON ESTIMATED. FOUR HUNDRED
FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
SEVENTEEN COUNTY WHICH LASTED
ABOUT TWO DAYS THIS WAS THAT
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWED ON THE
TWENTY SIX. WITH A DEEP IS IT
OF THE THIRTY EIGHT COUNTIES
WHICH LASTED FOR OVER FIVE DAYS
AND WHILE P. JEANNIE WAS
WORKING YOUR POWER FROM THE
TWENTY SIX THE VAN WHICH THEY
WERE SUCCESSFUL IN SOME BUT ALL
ALL NOT ALL. AREAS THE
INITIATED. YES. ON OCTOBER
TWENTY NINTH. OVERLAP TOO MANY
OF THE SAME COUNTIES THERE
ALREADY DE ENERGIZED FROM THE
TWENTY SIX EVENT. WHICH LASTED
THROUGH NOVEMBER FIRST THIS
OVERALL IMPACTED AN ESTIMATED
POPULATION OF TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION. IN THAT OVERLAP
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE. WHO OF
THOSE WHO WERE DE ENERGIZED ON
THE TWENTY SIX DID NOT SEE
THEIR POWER RESTORED FOR MORE
THAN SIX DAYS AND WEIRD UP TO
ELEVEN DAYS AS A PARTS OF THE
STATE. AT THE SAME TIME P.
GINNY WAS EXECUTING PS PS
SONORA CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON. WAS
IMPLEMENTING A SERIES OF PSP
ESTEVEZ STARTING ON OCTOBER
NINTH AND RUNNING THROUGH
OCTOBER TWENTY SIXTH IMPACTING
PORTIONS OF UP TO SIX SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES AN
ESTIMATED ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE WHICH
LASTED BETWEEN TWO AND EIGHT
DAYS. AND BETWEEN OCTOBER TENTH
AND OCTOBER TWENTY FOURTH
SANTEE GAS ELECTRIC ALSO
IMPLEMENTED THREE SEPARATE PS
PS EVENTS IMPACTING AN
ESTIMATED FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
PEOPLE EACH VARYING INTEGRATION
FROM SEVERAL HOURS TO EIGHT
DAYS. SO AND ALL ARE DURING THE
TIME FRAME- IN MID OCTOBER TO
LATE OCTOBER ALL THREE
UTILITIES WERE SIMULTANEOUSLY
IMPLEMENTING P. S. P. S. ADDING
TO THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
OVERALL SITUATION. BEYOND THE
DIRECT IMPACT TO INDIVIDUALS AT
THIS POINT PARTICULARLY. AS THE
OUTAGES EXTENDED INTO MULTIPLE
DAYS. IMPACTS TO HEALTH AND
MEDICAL. WRITERS SCHOOLS FUEL
AND COMMODITY DISTRIBUTION
CENTERS TELECOMMUNICATIONS
WHICH I'LL TALK ABOUT A SECOND
TRANSPORTATION MANUFACTURING
CRIMINAL JUSTICE WATER DELIVERY
AND WASTE WATER MANAGEMENT
EMERGED JUST TO NAME A FEW.
GIVEN THE SCOPE AND SCALE OF
THE PSP HAS ADVANCED GIVEN BY
EXPECTED RED FLAG FIRE
CONDITIONS ACROSS THE STATE
HELLO YES ACTIVATED THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER FOR OVER HALF
OF OCTOBER TO ADDRESS THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE PS PS
EVENTS. THAT WERE OCCURRING.
LEANING IN IN A BIG WAY WE
MOBILIZED OVER TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY. HELLO YES STAFF AND
CLOSE TO NINETY STATE AGENCIES
TO SUPPORT THE STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER TO PROVIDE DIRECT
SUPPORT TO PUBLIC SAFETY AND TO
THE MANY- COUNTY IO SEES THAT
WERE ACTIVATED TO DEAL WITH THE
CONDITIONS. AS WELL CALIFORNIA
ENHANCE STAFFING PATTERNS AND
PRE POSITION ASSETS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND CAL- YES
STRATEGICALLY PRE POSITION
MULTIPLE- YES A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FIRE STRIKE TEAMS IN
TASK FORCES IN AREAS. WITH HIGH
FIRE THREAT AND PS PS ADVANCE.
WE DISPATCH LAYS ON PERSONAL
FROM CALLOW YES CAL FIRE AND
THE CPU SKI TO EACH OF THE
UTILITIES EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
CENTER. AND WE DEPLOYED STATE
INCIDENT PLANNING SPECIALIST TO
BE G. E. O. C. TO PROVIDE
EXPERTISE ON USING THE INCIDENT
COMMAND SYSTEM. THIS
COORDINATEDEFFORT WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN MAXIMIZING
PREPAREDNESS LEVELS RESPONDING
QUICKLY TO EMERGENCY EMERGING
STE SIT SITUATIONS ENSURING FOR
GOOD SITUATIONAL AWARENESS WITH
RAPID RESPONSE TO FIRE AND
PROTECTION TO LIFE AND PROPERTY.
IN PREPARATION OF THE PS PS
ADVANCE. IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT WE HAD BEEN MEETING
JOINTLY. WITH WITH
REPRESENTATIVES OF ALL THREE
UTILITIES ALONG WITH THE CPUC
AND CAL FIRE WEEKLY. FOR THE
BETTER PART OF A YEAR AND WE
JUST HEARD A LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
THE UTILITIES- BJ TALKING ABOUT
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THEY'VE
HAD- THE REASON WE WERE HAVING
THESE MEETINGS WAS TO BUY DOWN
OR MITIGATE THOSE KIND OF
CHALLENGES THROUGH A
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH. OUR
GOAL WAS AND CONTINUES TO BE TO
ENSURE THAT THE UTILITIES
RECOGNIZE AND ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AS WELL AS OUR OWN
CONCERNS AND EXPECTATIONS- OF
NAB OF NAVIGATING A P. S. P. S.
ADVANTAGE AND A PROVIDING SAFE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICIALS WITH AMP AMPLE
NOTIFICATION. OF PENDING PS PS
EVENTS AND PROVIDE ACCURATE
ONGOING CRITICAL INFORMATION
AND DATA TO BOTH OF US IN THE
PUBLIC. THROUGHOUT THESE
MEETINGS WE WORK TO ENSURE THAT
ALL THREE UTILITIES WERE
DEVELOPING OPERATIONAL CHECK
OPERATIONAL CONSTRUCTS. PUBLIC
FACING MESSAGING. WOULD
EXERCISE A MORE CONSISTENT. AND
TRANSPARENT ACROSS THE BOARD
CONSISTENT AND TRANSPARENT
ACROSS THE BOARD APPROACH WITH
REGARD TO THEIR PUBLIC
EDUCATION THEIR DECISION MAKING
THERE ARE NOTIFICATIONS TO THE
STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND TO
THE ACTUAL EXECUTION OF A P. S.
P. S. EVENT ITSELF. STILL AFTER
ALL THAT DURINGTHE MULTIPLE
PSP AS EVENTS THERE CONTINUE TO
BE CHALLENGES AND
INCONSISTENCIES.
INCONSISTENCIES WITH UTILITIES
ABILITY TO PROVIDE DETAILED AND
TIMELY NOTIFICATION OF THEIR
PLANNED OUTAGES REQUIRED DATA
AND DETAILED MAPS OF OUTAGE
AREAS DETAILS ON CRITICAL
MEDICAL BASS LINE IN VULNERABLE
CUSTOMERS. AT SUPPORT TO
CUSTOMERS IN AREAS WITHOUT TO
USE ANY INFORMATION RELATED TO
OTHER CRITICAL OR ESSENTIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS WAS QUITE
FRUSTRATING DOES PARTICULARLY
WHEN WE STARTED TO ROLL INTO
THESE BIGGER PROBLEMS WHICH WE
AS YOUR STATES BOB SEASONED
AMER TO SEE MANAGEMENT TEAM-
ANTICIPATED IN THOSE MEETINGS
THAT THAT WE TALKED ABOUT AND
WANTED TO ADDRESS THEM WITHIN
THE PREVIOUS YEAR BEFORE WE
STARTED THE PS PS EVENTS. THE
DETAILS HERE MATTER I DETAIL
ABOUT HOW YOU'RE GOING TO PUT A
COMMUNITY RESOURCE IN PLACE AND
WHAT'S GOING TO BE THERE AND
HOW LONG IT'S GOING TO BE OPEN
AND WHAT KIND OF DEMOGRAPHICS
ARE GONNA BE SERVE THERE OR HOW
MANY BASS INE MEDICAL BASED
LIKE BECAUSE THOSE DETAILS
MATTER YOU CAN'T HIT THAT WITH
THE THIRTY THOUSAND FOOT
OVERVIEW. AND THEN EXPECT- BUT
THE ABILITY TO RESPOND AND SO
THIS IS WHERE THEY CAN GET INTO
THE EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT RAIL
ALL WE HAVE TO BE A BIG
ACCOUNTING FOR THOSE THOSE
THINGS BECAUSE DETAILS EQUAL
LIVES IS VERY IMPORTANT.
THROUGHOUT ALL OF THE EVENTS WE
CONTINUE TO COORDINATE WITH
UTILITIES- SPECIFICALLY PGD TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR COMMUNITY
RESOURCE CENTERS RESPONDED TO
THE APPROPRIATE SCALE OF THE
POPULATIONS IMPACTED BY THE PSP
AS A VET. AS THEY WERE ADDING
BIGGER AREA AS THEY NEEDED TO
RAPIDLY INCREASE THE SCOPE AND
SCALE OF THEIR C. R. C.'S AND
TOOK TO THE TO THEIR CREDIT.
THEY WENT FROM YOU TO ONE PER
COUNTY TO THREE PER COUNTY- BUT
THEY WERE STILL ONLY OPEN A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME AND WE
HAVE PEOPLE THAT WERE STILL
NEEDING- SERVICES IN THE
EVENING TIME- BAIT WE WANTED
THEM TO REMAIN OPEN AS LONG AS
POSSIBLE EACH DAY TO PROVIDE
RESIDENTS WITH WATER ICE
BLANKETS INFORMATION. AND POWER
TO CHARGE DEVICES DURING
OUTAGES. MY OFFICE AS WELL
FACILITY TO ENGAGEMENT WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT. AS
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SECURITY AT THESE SITES WHICH
SEEM TO BE A CONCERN FOR P.
JEANNIE. AND WE ALSO TEAMED UP
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
MONIES IN THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES TO HELP KEEP-
OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS IN THE IMPACTED AREAS
UPDATED. AS WELL AS INSURING
THAT P. JEANNIE WEBSITE AND
CALL CENTERS WERE PREPARED TO
SUPPORT AGAIN THE SCALE OF THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT COULD BE
CALLING IN. OF COURSE AS WE ALL
KNOW THIS INCLUDED DEPLOYMENT
OF STATE PERSONNEL AND
RESOURCES TO HELP TEACH ME
STAND UP A NEW WEBSITE. TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION AFTER THE
PRIMARY SITE CRASH YOUR HILL A
BIT MORE ABOUT THAT FROM
SECRETARY LEE IN A MINUTE.
LASTLY TO ASSIST P. GINNY
ACCELERATE TIME- OF POWER
RESTORATION- AS WE HEARD THERE
SO MANY LIGHTS IT NEED TO BE
INSPECTED. ARE WE OFFERED AND
SUBSEQUENTLY DEPLOYED PLANES
AND HELICOPTERS WITH
SPECIALIZED FORWARD LOOKING IF
IT CAMERA TECHNOLOGY. FROM THE
H. P. AND THE NATIONAL GUARD.
TO HELP P. GINNY INCREASE THE
SPEED. HELP THAT THAT HELPFUL
FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
ACCELERATE THE TIME FOR
RESTORATION LET ME SAY THAT AND
WHILE THE PS PS ADDRESS IN-
OCTOBER PRESENTED US ALL WITH A
SERIES OF COMPLEX CHALLENGES.
CALIFORNIA'S EXTENSIVE
CAPABILITIES AND EXPERIENCE
WITH MANAGING MAJOR EMERGENCIES
AND DISASTERS INCLUDING THE
CAPABILITIES OF OUR EXTENSIVE
MUTUAL AID SYSTEMS PROVIDED THE
ABILITY FOR THE STATE TO
SUCCESSFULLY NAVIGATE BOTH THE
PS PS IMPACTS AS WELL AS
MEDICAID SEVERAL FIRES THAT
WERE BY MILITARY SEE OCCURRING
IN BOTH NORTHERN. CALIFORNIA
LET ME JUST CLOSE BY ONE QUICK.
ONE MORE QUICK ME AND TALK
ABOUT TELECOMMUNICATIONS ONE OF
THE- KEY ARE A LIFELINE IMPACTS
CRITICAL LIFELINE IMPACTS THAT-
WAS HIGHLIGHTED- WAS WITH
REGARDS TO OUR
TELECOMMUNICATION SYSTEM. OUT
WHILE MANY CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCE POWER OUTAGES THEY
ALSO EXPERIENCE GAPS AND
OUTAGES IN THEIR CELL LANDLINE
IN INTERNET OR WHAT WE CALL
WIRELINE SERVICES IN SEVERAL
CASES EVEN IF THEY WERE NOT IN
THE DE ENERGIZED ZONE. THE P.
S. P. S. EVENTS COUPLE WITH
NUMEROUS DANNY'S FIRES WE WERE
MANAGING THROUGHOUT THE STATE
HIGHLIGHTED ONCE AGAIN AS I
BEEN BEFORE YOU ALL BEFORE ON
THIS TOPIC. THE VULNERABILITIES
OF OUR PRIVATELY OWNED AND
PRIVATELY MANAGED
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM. AS I
STATED EARLIER WE LOST A NUMBER
OF CELL SITES SOME SIXTEEN
HUNDRED- AND WIRELINE SERVICES
SOME EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS THAT WAS FOR BOTH FOR
BOTH BOYS. A VOICE OVER
INTERNET PROTOCOL AND WIRELINE
BACK CALL- IN THE PS PS EVENT.
THAT WAS DUE TO LACK OF ABOUT
POWER BACK UP AND OF OR LACK OF
SUSTAINABILITY. AND IN MARIN
COUNTY ALONE 57% OF THE ENTIRE
CELLULAR SITES WERE LOST AT ONE
POINT IN MENDOCINO COUNTY THEY
LOST ALL SELL LAND LINE AND THE
ABILITIES. WHAT DOES THIS MEAN
THIS MEANS THAT THAT YOU HAVE
THEY HAVE PEOPLE HAVE THE
INABILITY. THE INABILITY TO
CALL NINE ONE ONE EMERGENCY
INABILITY TO RECEIVE ALERTS ANDWARNINGS. THE INABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE WITH FAMILY OR JUST
TO BUSINESS THE INABILITY FOR
HOSPITALS AND I'M ONE CENTERS
OR CRIMINAL JUSTICE HAS TO SEND
OR RECEIVE CRITICAL DATA. AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY IN THIS CASE
THE INABILITY FOR PEOPLE TO GET
INFORMATION ABOUT THE POWER
OUTAGES. AND OR COMMUNITY
RESOURCES OR RESTORATION
INFORMATION. GIVEN THAT THE
UTILITIES SOUL STRATEGY FOR THE
PUBLIC WAS TO DRIVE THEIR
CUSTOMERS TO A WEBSITE THAT
THEY COULDN'T GET ON BECAUSE
THEY COULDN'T GET THROUGH THE
WIRELINE SYSTEM. SO IT WAS A
VERY FRUSTRATING LOOP OF
CASCADING FAILURES THAT REALLY
CREATED- I ATE A MAJOR. THREAT
TO LIFE AND SAFETY NOTHING
pFRUSTRATING AND WE HAVE SEEN
THE SCENARIO NOW OVER AND OVER
AGAIN FOLLOWING ONE DISASTER
AFTER ANOTHER. SO I JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT- Là WITH THE
CELL SITES BECAUSE IT'S
SOMETHING MORE THAN I THINK. WE
NEED TO TALK ABOUT THEIR A
NUMBER OF LIFELINE CRITICAL
LIFE AYE INTER DEPENDENCIES
BUT- BEYOND THE POWER GOING OUT
AND YOU KNOW THERE ARE THERE
ARE PEOPLE WHO WERE NEEDING
MEDIC MEDICAL. CARE AND I MAY
THINK YOU'RE HERE ABOUT IN A
FEW MINUTES FROM DOCTOR GALLEY-
CELL SYSTEM WHICH IS SUCH A
CRITICAL CRITICAL LIFE LINE-
THAT FAILURE WAS JUST SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT SO
WITH THAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
K. WE HAVE JULIE LEAH THINKER
ONE NEXT. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JULIE LEE AND I AM THE
ACTING SECRETARY OF THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
I'M PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH SOME EXAMPLES
OF HOW GOV OPS DEPARTMENTS
RESPONDED TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWERSHOT OFFICE IN OCTOBER OF
THIS YEAR. THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY WAS ASKED BY THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO P.
JEANNIE ON THEIR WEBSITE DURING
THE FIRST SHOT OFF OF AND
AROUND OCTOBER NINTH. PGA ANY
WAS NOT PREPARED FOR THE
INCOMING VOLUME OF TRAFFIC AND
THE WEBSITE HAD CRASHED DUE TO
THE LARGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
ATTEMPTING TO ACCESS
INFORMATION ABOUT THE POWER
SHUT OFFS. AS SOON AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
RECEIVE THE CALL. AMY TONG CITY
TEASE DIRECTOR IMMEDIATELY PUT
TOGETHER A TEAM OF EXPERTS WHO
INITIATED CONTACT WITH P.
GENIES IT STAFF. I'D LIKE TO
NOTE THAT THE STAFF WERE VERY
COLLABORATIVE TO WORK WITH. CDT
PROVIDED THREE CATEGORIES OF
SERVICE TO P. JEANNIE. THE
FIRST WAS TO PROVIDE ADVICE AND
CONSULTATION TO P. GENIES I. T.
UNIT TO ADDRESS P. GENIES
WEBSITE PERFORMANCE ISSUES.
CITY TV GAVE PGA ANY FEEDBACK
ABOUT THE STRUCTURE OF THEIR
CLOUD ARCHITECTURE AND
IDENTIFIED MORE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR STRONGER VENDOR MANAGEMENT
OF THEIR CLOUD ENVIRONMENTS.
THE TEAM ALSO PROVIDED
CONSULTING SERVICES ON THE
CONFIGURATION AND DEVELOPMENT
OF A SITE DEDICATED TO THE
OUTAGE MAPS TO SEGMENT INCOMING
WEBSITE TRAFFIC AWAY FROM P.
GENIES MAIN SITE. THE TEAM THEN
PROACTIVELY CONFIGURED AND
DEVELOPED A BACKUP SITE TO
ACCOMMODATE THE TRAFFIC TO THE
MAP SITE JUST IN CASE P.
JEANNIE WOULD NEED IT. THE
SECOND ACTION TAKEN BY CDT. WAS
TO ENGAGE THE VENDORS THAT P.
JEANNIE USES FOR THEIR WEB
SERVICES. DIRECTOR TONG TONG
STEAM PROVIDED EXECUTIVE LEVEL
ENGAGEMENT WITH AS THREE
MICROSOFT AND AMAZON WEB
SERVICES TO PROVIDE LARGER
SCALE AND RAPID SUPPORT TO P.
JEANNIE. REALIZING THE
RESIDENTS IN CALIFORNIA NEEDED
ACCESS TO OUT IS OUTAGE MAPS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE THE TEAM
WORK WITH CLOUD PROVIDER IN
SOFTWARE VENDOR TO VALIDATE AND
MAKE MODIFICATIONS TO THE
SYSTEM. TO ENSURE THE LARGE
AMOUNT OF ANTICIPATED TRAFFIC
WOULD BE ABLE TO ACCESS THE
SITE CONCURRENTLY. JEANNIE
STAFFER ABLE TO FOCUS ON
GETTING THE MAPS ON TO A CLOUD
SITE WELL THE CD TO YOU TEAM
WORKS WITH THE VENDORS TO
INCREASE CAPACITY. LASTLY THE
CITY T. TEAM PROVIDED
DIAGNOSTIC TROUBLE SHOOTING AND
LOAD TESTING ON THE MAP SITE TO
ENSURE THE P. GENIES SITE COULD
WITHSTAND A LARGE TRUCK TRAFFIC
VOLUMES ABOUT CRASHING AGAIN.
THE VENDORS ESTIMATED TIME TO
COMPLETE LOAD TESTING WAS
TWELVE HOURS SO CDT DID THE
TESTING THEMSELVES TO SAVE TIME.
AFTER LOAD TESTING THE PUBLIC
FACING PS PS WEBSITE CD TO
DETERMINE THE BEST WAY TO
OPTIMIZE THE SITE WAS TO RESIZE
THE DATABASE SERVER AND
OPTIMIZE STORAGE TO MINIMIZE
WEBSITE LAG. THIS IS A LITTLE
TECHNICAL BUT THANKS TO THE
DIAGNOSTIC AND LOAD TESTING CD
T. WAS ABLE TO ADVISE THE
CONTRACTORAS READ TO REBUILD
THE MAPPING SITE USING A
PREVIOUS VERSION OF CODE
BECAUSE OF CONTINUING ISSUES
THE TEAM FOUND WITH THE NEW
CODE BASE. THESE CHANGES
ADJUSTED THE CONFIGURATION TO
INCREASE TECH SCALING THAT
WOULD SUPPORT OVER ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION CONCURRENT USERS
ONCE P. GENIES SITE WENT LIVE
AGAIN CD TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT AND ASSISTANCE WITH THE
SITE WITH THE SITE. TESTING IT
TO MAKE SURE THE CONTENT SEE BY
VISITORS WAS. CORRECT AND
FUNCTIONING. SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON ALSO
EXPERIENCE SOME ISSUES WITH
THEIR WEBSITE DURING THE FIRST
PS PS OF AND AGAIN AROUND
OCTOBER NINTH. THE DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY CONTACTED SOCAL
EDISON AND OFFERED ASSISTANCE
FACILITATED EXECUTIVE LEVEL
CONTACTS WITH MICROSOFT AND
MONITORED THE SO CAL EDISON
SITE. DURING THE SECOND PS PS
EVENT LATER IN OCTOBER DIRECTOR
TONG AND HER TEAM SUGGESTED
THAT THE STATE BILL THE PORTAL
TO CONSOLIDATE THE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE FIRE INFORMATION. AS
WELL AS THE SECOND PS PS
INFORMATION SINCE WE HAD
OVERLAPPING DISASTERS. ONCE THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE SHOT OFFICE
WAS REALIZED APPROVAL WAS GIVEN
FOR NEW PORTAL NAME TO RESPONSE
DOT CA DOT GOV. AND CITY TO
QUICKLY ASSEMBLED A TEAM AND
SET UP A BRAND NEW WEBSITE
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS. MANY
OF OUR CITY T. EMPLOYEES WORK
THROUGH THE NIGHT ONLY STOPPING
TO REST AFTER THE SITE WAS LIFE.
FROM KEPT CONCEPTION TO
IMPLEMENTATION OVER A WEEKEND
WITH A DOZEN STAFF CDT BUILT
THIS ONE STOP SHOP WEBSITE IN
LESS THAN TWENTY FOUR HOURS. A
DEVOPS TEAM OF C. D. T.
DEVELOPERS AND ENGINEERS WORK
SIDE BY SIDE WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE GOV UPS TO
FUNNEL CONTENT FROM MANY OTHER
STATE DEPARTMENTS. INCLUDING
CAL FIRE- YES HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES CALLIE PA AND MANY
OTHERS. THEY DESIGNED BUILT
TESTED AND DEPLOYED THE CURRENT
RESPONSE DOT CA DOT GOV WEBSITE
ON CD TO USE ROBUST PLATFORM
THAT COULD HANDLE HIGH VOLUMES
OF WEBSITE TRAFFIC. THE TEAM
PROVIDED RAPID IN IT OR ABOUT
UPDATES TO THE WEBSITE
FOLLOWING THE LAUNCH TO ENSURE
THE MOST UP TO DATE AND
RELEVANT INFORMATION WAS POSTED.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE SECURITY
SIZING AND DELIVERY OF THE
WEBSITE AND IT'S ASSOCIATED
TEST AND DEVELOPMENT
ENVIRONMENTS WERE PROVISIONED
LEVERING THE LEVERAGING THE
EXISTING PLATFORM. THE WEBSITE
ARCHITECTURE UTILIZED A CONTENT
DELIVERY NETWORK OR CD AND TO
INCREASE THE SPEED AND
RESILIENCY OF THE SITE IN
ANTICIPATION OF TRAFFIC VOLUME.
AVERAGE PAGE ACCESS TIME WAS
LESS THAN TWO MILLISECONDS THIS
IS IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE WITH
PREPAID CELL PHONES OR SPOTTY
CELL SERVICE WHERE THEY MAY
HAVE ONLY HAVE ACCESS TO DATA
FOR A SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME. CDT
ALSO HEARD THAT RESPONSE DOT CA
DOT GOV MEANT THE AMERICAN
DISABILITY ACT OR ADA STANDARDS
FOR WEBSITE ACCESSIBILITY AND
THAT ALL CONTENT WAS TRANSLATED
INTO MULTIPLE LANGUAGES IN AN
EFFORT TO REACH ALL COMMUNITIES
IMPACTED. THE OTHER GOV OPS
DEPARTMENT THAT WAS ACTIVATED
DURING THE PS PS EVENTS WAS THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
WHENEVER THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACTIVATES
THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER WE
DEPLOYED STAFF FROM DG US TO
ENSURE THERE IS IMMEDIATE
ACCESS TO ANY RESOURCES THAT
MIGHT BE NEEDED DURING A
DISASTER. WHETHER IT'S AN
EARTHQUAKE FOR FIRE RESPONSE OR
THE POWERSHOT OFFICE DID YOU
HAVE STAFF WORKED ON EMERGENCY
CONTRACTS AND PURCHASING AND
THEY ALSO MONITOR ALL STATE
OWNED BUILDINGS AND PROPERTY.
DID YOU HAS COMPLETED OVER ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY MISSION TASK
DURING THE LATE OCTOBER FIRES
IN PS PS EVENTS. AGS IS
MONITORING OF STATE PROPERTIES
ALLOWS US TO REPORT THAT
INFORMATION TO THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE SO THEY'RE IMMEDIATELY
WHERE OF ANY IMPACTS IS THE
STATE SERVICES. THE DEPARTMENT
OF HUMAN RESOURCES OR KELLY
CHAR USE THE DATA GATHERED BY
THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER ON
IMPACTS TO STATE EMPLOYEES. IN
KEEPS EMPLOYEE UNIONS NOTIFIED
OF THOSE IMPACTS TO THEIR
MEMBERS. INCLUDES MY TESTIMONY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MARK
GALEAZZO CALLIE DOLLY GALLAGHER
HI. AND DOCTOR MARK KELLY-
SECRETARY FOR HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY BEFORE
YOU ABOUT THE EFFORTS OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES DURING AND
OUR MANY DEPARTMENTS DURING THE
PS PS EVENTS ARE OF LAST MONTH
AS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY
ALLUDED BOTH THE SCOPE AND
DURATION OF THE RECENT RECENT
SHUT OFFS WERE UNPRECEDENTED
LEAVING MILLIONS. OF
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT
POWER FOR DAYS THE PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF PUT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF ON OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING
THOSE WITH ACCESS AND
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS. DIRE
SITUATION. TO PUT THIS IN
PERSPECTIVE FOR YOU THERE WERE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WE HEARD FROM
DAILY WEATHER WAS BY TWEETER BY
EMAIL OR BY PHONE CALL. THAT
HAD- DEPENDED ON LIFE
SUSTAINING EQUIPMENT BREATHING
MACHINES DIALYSIS MACHINES
NEBULIZER MACHINES WHEELCHAIRS
OR MEDICATIONS WE HEARD A
LITTLE BIT EARLIER LIFE SAVING
MEDICATIONS NOT CHEAP
MEDICATION. THAT DEPENDED ON
REFRIGERATION. I'D LIKE TO
SPEND MY TIME TODAY OUTLINING
THE GAPS WE SAW ON THESE
EFFORTS HOW WE RESPONDED AND
LESSONS THAT WE LEARNED. FOR
RESPONSE EFFORTS TO THE SHOT
OFFICE UNDER THE DIRECTION OF
THE GOVERNOR FOCUSED ON FILLING
CLEARING GAPS LEFT BY THE I
WOULD USE OUR TEAM STEPPED UP
TO ENSURE THAT THE ON MY
MEDICAL NEEDS FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE NEIGHBORS. ACROSS
THE STATE WOULD BE MAD IN THIS
TIME. WE HAD TO KEEP PRIORITIES
ENSURE INDIVIDUALS RESIDING IN
OUR FACILITIES WHETHER THOSE
ARE THE ONES LICENSE BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SOCIAL SERVICES WERE SAFE AND
HAD NO MAN ON MAN NEEDS. WE
ALSO WANTED TO BE SURE THAT
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALSLIVING
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES WHETHER
THOSE ARE. KIDS IN FOSTER CARE
PEOPLE DISABILITIES THE ELDERLY
LIVING IN COMMUNITIES OF THE
ROUND WERE SAFE AND ALSO HAD NO
ONE MAN NEEDS. FOR THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY CARE FACILITIES WE
LICENSE IT WAS DIFFICULT FOR
THEM TO PREPARE FOR THE PS PS
ADVANCE. BECAUSE THE
INFORMATION COMING FROM THE
UTILITIES. WAS A RADIC
IMPRECISE AND OFTEN CHANGING WE
ARE THIS IS A CONSISTENT THEME
EARLIER I THINK IT APPLIED TO
THE FACILITIES THAT WE LOOK
AFTER. IN IN VERY REAL WAYS.
INCREASINGLY IT BECAME HARDER
AND HARDER TO GIVE THEM-
ADEQUATE INFORMATION TO PLAN
FOR THE HOURS AND- DAYS TO
COME. CAN ONE WERE ACTIVELY DE
ENERGIZED THE UNCERTAINTY AS TO
WHEN THEY WOULD RE ENTERPRISE.
PARTICULARLY CHIANG TALENT. A
CUP SUPPLIES INTO DWINDLE FOR
THE VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS AND
COMMUNITIES THE I. O. U.'S
ATTEMPT AND YOU HEARD A BIT
ABOUT IT TODAY TO REACH THE
POPULATIONS INCLUDING
INDIVIDUALS WITH ACCESS AND
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS THROUGH THEIR
MEDICAL BASELINE CUSTOMER LISTS
HOWEVER THESE LISTED NOT
CAPTURE ALL INDIVIDUALS WITH
ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS IN
FACT THEY DID NOT ACCOUNT FOR A
LARGE MAJORITY OF INDIVIDUALS
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT THE
PROPERTY OWNERS AND WE'RE NOT
THE ONES PAYING THE UTILITY
BILLS. THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES ATTEMPT TO REACH OUT
TO MEDICAL BASELINE CUSTOMERS
WAS NOT ENOUGH IN FACT WE FOUND
IT TO BE INSUFFICIENT. WHEN
ELECTRICITY IS OFF FOR TWENTY
FOUR HOURS OR MORE DUE TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY SHUT OFFS
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
BECOME AT RISK. HOWEVER WHEN
THE SHOW OF STERN ENDED DAYS
SOMETIMES WEEKS A POWER SHUT
OFF CAN BECOME A LIFE. I MEAN
EVENT SO HOW DID WE RESPOND WE
MADE IT TO BE NIMBLE. TO WORK
WITH OUR STATE PARTNERS YOU
HEARD ABOUT THE MANY MANY STATE
PARTNERS A CAME TOGETHER I WILL
YOU KNOW PUBLICLY THANK JULIE
AND HER TEAM FOR HELPING US
WITH OUR TECHNOLOGY NEEDS
MARKING YOUR TREAT HIM FOR
WORKING CLOSELY WITH US ON.
HARM AT THE SALK IN MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAD ALL THE RESOURCE WE
NEED TO BE A BILL IN THIS
ATTENTIVE AS POSSIBLE AND THESE
ASSETS WERE DEPLOYED IN REAL
TIME TO MEETTHOSE ON MY NEEDS
AS THEY CAME- OBVIOUS TO US I'M
PROUD OF THE MANY NEW
PARTNERSHIPS WE FOSTER TO
ENSURE THAT WE FULLY LEVERAGED
OUR STATE LOCAL. COMMUNITY
COLLEAGUES. TO ADDRESS THE
YOUNG MAN NEEDS ACROSS THE
STATE. I DO WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK
OF STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC
SERVANTS WHO UNDER EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT SITUATION STEPPED UP
COLLECTIVELY. TO ENSURE THAT
FOLKS WE CHECKED IN ON HAD WHAT
THEY NEEDED TO STAY ALIVE. THE
SAME IS TRUE FOR OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS. THE THEY COALESCED
AROUND US TO ENSURE THAT
TOGETHER WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
REACH MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
WHO NEEDED US THE MOST. OUR
FIRST AREA FOCUS WAS THE
FACILITY TO THE FACILITIES WE
LICENSE WE MADE CONTACT WITH
THEM. TO ENSURE THE ODDS OF
SUFFICIENT SUPPLIES OF FOOD.
ENERGY AND HAD NO ONE MAN AND
MEDICAL NEEDS. THIS INCLUDED
HEALTH FACILITIES DPH AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
LICENSED AND INCLUDED
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES AND
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY IN
CHARTING KIDS IN CHILD CARE.
OUR TOP PRIORITY ONCE WE
REALIZE THAT THE OUTRAGE OF
REACH WAS LIMITED BY THE I. O.
U.'S WAS ALSO TO DO- WELFARE
AND SAFETY CHECKS TO VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. AND ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO DEPENDED ON
ELECTRICALLY POWERED EQUIPMENT.
TO HELP OUR COUNTY AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERS WE LEVERAGE
OUR DATA RESOURCES INCLUDING TI
US TOOLS IN MAPS ZIP CODES AND-
KNOWLEDGE OF WHERE. INDIVIDUALS
LIVES ACROSS THE DE ENERGIZED
AREAS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAD
GOOD INTEL IN- ABILITY TO MAKE
CONTACT. TO ENSURE THAT THEY
HAD TO THE SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED TO US A SUBSET OF
POPULATION WHO IS MOST
CONCERNING AND PERHAPS MOST AT
RISK. WAS THAT GROUP SAID
EXPERIENCE DE ENERGIZED ARM OR
SHUT OFF FOR PROLONGED PERIOD
OF TIME WE OVERLY THIS
INFORMATION WITH THE FEDERAL
MEDICARE CLAIMS DATA ON
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD DURABLE
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT WITH WHICH
FURTHER NARROWED THE ZIP CODE
SO WE NEED TO FOCUS ON. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT. THIS
STATE WAS DE IDENTIFIED THAT
HELPED OR PRINT PARTNERS IN
THEIR- THEIR WORK WHILE
MAINTAINING THE PRIVACY OF THE
INDIVIDUALS ON THE LIST. TO
MAKE SURE WE DID I REACH THE
SUBSET OFPOPULATION. OUR
DEPARTMENT DEPARTMENTS
PARTNERED WITH SEVERAL LOCAL
ENTITIES WHO KNEW THE AREA AND
THE CLIENTS THE BEST. THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES WORK FULLY WITH ITS
REGIONAL CENTERS TO ENSURE
THAT. DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
CLIENTS ROUGHLY TWO THOUSAND IN
THE EVACUATED. AREAS HAD BEEN-
HAD IN THEIR NEEDS MET THE
DEPARTMENT OF EIGHTEEN WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE AREA AGENTS
AGENCIES ON AGING TO ENSURE
THAT. OLDER RESIDENTS WERE
CHECKED ON AND WE'RE RECEIVING
NEEDED SERVICES BUT DEPARTMENT
OF REHABILITATION WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTERS TO ENSURE THOSE WITH.
DISABILITIES WERE CHECKED ON
AND WERE RECEIVING SERVICES.
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES IN COLLABORATION WITH
LABOR PARTNERS DEVELOP TIPS
CHEATS FOR OUR AYE HSS WORKERS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAD A
TOOL THAT CAN EFFECTIVELY HELP
THEM SUPPORTER CONSUMERS DURING
THESE PS PS EVENTS. THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
ALSO CLOSELY WORK WITH COUNTY
PARTNERS TO ENSURE WE WERE
CHECKING ON ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICE CLIENTS AND ALL KIDS IN
FOSTER CARE. AS THE AGENTS WE
CONVENE COUNTY COLLEAGUES
INCLUDING DIRECTOR FROM COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
HEALTH SERVICES SOCIAL
SERVICES. AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TO ENSURE THAT WE WERE
COORDINATING AND PROVIDING ALL
NECESSARY RESOURCES TO FOLKS IN
THE REGION WE HAD REGULAR
COMMUNICATION WITH OUR
ASSOCIATION PARTNERS WE
PROVIDED THEM WITH DATA TO
ENSURE THEY ARE TRACKING THE
MOST VULNERABLE IN THE REGION'S.
FINALLY WE CONVENE THE HEALTH
AND TO ENSURE THEY ARE CRACKING
RESPONSE. EFFORTS AND REACHING
OUT TO VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS.
AS YOU KNOW HEALTH PLANS-
APPROVE ALL DURABLE MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT. THEY ARE AMONG THE
MOST WELL SITUATED TO KNOW WHO
HAS WHAT AND WERE THEY MIGHT
LIVE SO TAPPING INTO THAT
RESOURCE WAS SOMETHING WE DID
IN AN AMPLE SORT OF ON THE SPOT
WAY. SO JUST A MOMENT ON THE
RESOURCES WE DEVELOPED WE
QUICKLY RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO
ESTABLISH PUBLIC FACING
RESOURCES WITHIN THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY. WE
ESTABLISHED SEVERAL DIFFERENT
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THAT
IMPACTED CALIFORNIANS HAD THE
NECESSARY INFORMATION TO
PREPARE AND LIVE THROUGH THESE
VARIOUS EVENTS. WE ESTABLISHED
A NON EMERGENCY HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES PS PS HOTLINE
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE UTILIZING
THEIR EXISTING CALL CENTER. IT
WAS THERE TO SUPPORT MEDICALLY
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS BUT
ALSO BE QUICKLY BECAME A TOOL
FOR FACILITIES WITH QUESTIONS
IT WAS OPEN NINE AM TO NINE PM
THAT WAS AVAILABLE IN MANY
LANGUAGES. AND WE EVEN HAD THE
CAPACITY TO DO FOLLOW UP CALLS
WITH PEPLE WHO CALLED IN DAY
ONE OR DAY TWO WE RECEIVED
HUNDREDS OF CALLS OVER THE-
COURSE OF THE EVENT AND CREATED
ESSENTIALLY A SNOW NEW STATE
RESOURCE THAT CAN BE DEPLOYED
IN THE FUTURE TO HELP. RIGHT
AWAY. WE DEVELOP THE CONSUMER
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF
RESOURCE GUIDE ON OUR WEBSITE
WHICH INCLUDED RESOURCES ACROSS
ALL OF OUR ANY AGENCIES AND
INCLUDED- RESOURCES AROUND
CRISIS COUNSELING TO HELP
INDIVIDUALS WITH ACCESS AND
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS. WE DEVELOP TO
PROPOSE A PERSONAL EMERGENCY
PLAN THEY CAN BE DEVELOPED TO
HELP INDIVIDUALS PREPARE FOR
THESE PS PS VENTS FINALLY TO
HELP WITH MEDICATION NEEDS WE
DEVELOPED A PRESCRIPTION
MEDICATION GUIDE WE ALSO
PARTNERED. WITH OUR EX OPEN TO
PROVIDE INDIVIDUALS. WITH REAL
TIME INFORMATION ON OPEN
PHARMACY. SO WHAT DID E LEARN
QUICKLY WE LEARNED A GREAT DEAL
ABOUT OUR RESPONSE CAPABILITIES
AND AS I ALLUDED TO EARLIER WE
EXPANDED EXISTING CAPABILITIES
AND DEVELOP NEW ONES. TO MEET
UNMET NEEDS IN THE FUTURE. I'D
LIKE TO OFFER THREE LESSONS
THAT WE LEARNED SPECIFICALLY
FIRST WE LEARNED WE ARE DATA
RICH BUT INFORMATION POOR WE
HAVE LOTS OF DATA BUT WE NEED
TO MAKE THAT DATA MORE
ACTIONABLE IN ORDER TO BETTER
AND FORMER RESPONSE ACTIVITIES.
WE MUST PULL TOGETHER VARIOUS
DATA SOURCES FROM ACROSS OUR
AGENCY. UP AS BETTER REFINE HOW
WE DEPLOY ASSETS WHO WE DO
WELFARE CHECKS ON AND HOW WE
ADDRESS UNMET NEEDS. SECOND THE
OUR REACH TO OUR FACILITIES
MUST BE STREAMLINING
COORDINATED WE ALONG WITH OUR
COUNTY PARTNERS WERE REACHING
OUT OFTEN. THIS WAS DUPLICATIVE
AT TIMES RESULTING ARM
CONFLICTING INFORMATION
COORDINATING OUTREACH EFFORTS
TO FACILITIES AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE TO POINT SIMILAR
SCRIPTS WHEN CALLING FACILITIES.
TO CHECK ON THE STATUS WILL BE
WILL BE KEY TO ENSURING THAT WE
STAY TIGHTLY COORDINATED AND
HAVE ACCURATE INFORMATION.
FINALLY AS MANY PEOPLE HAVE
SAID REPEATEDLY TODAY WE
DISCOVERED THE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO PURSUE PARTNERSHIPS- IN VERY
IN A LOT OF STRATEGIC ON
IMPORTANT WAYS WE LEARN QUICKLY
THAT THE ONLY WAY I CAN ENSURE.
THAT THE ABILITY TO CHECK ON
THEM VULNERABLE WAS BY WORKING
WITH MULTIPLE STATE LOCAL AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERS. HI I WON'T
TELL YOU THE MANY STORE IS WE
HAVE OVER. PEOPLE AT THE STATE
LEVEL COORDINATING AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL AND COMING UP WITH
A VERY NOVEL WAYS WHEN WE
DIDN'T HAVE CELL PHONE COVERAGE
WHAT WE KNEW PEOPLE WERE
EXPERIENCES AND PROLONGED SHUT
OFFS. TO GET PEOPLE OUT TO
VULNERABLE PEOPLE'S HOUSES TO
MAKE SURE THEY WERE OKAY. IN
THOSE PARTNERSHIPS WERE WORTH
THEIR WEIGHT IN GOLD AND NEED
TO CONTINUE TO BE BUILT UPON.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE BY
THINKING THE MANY PUBLIC
SERVANTS ACROSS THE STATE
COUNTY YUBA GOVERNMENT CITY
GOVERNMENT FOR THE COMMITMENT
AND DEDICATION IN THIS
RESPONSE. I ALSO WANT TO TAKE
THIS OFTEN OPPORTUNITY TO
THANK. THE COMMUNITY PARTNERS
WHO OPENLY STEPPED UP AND WORK
WITH US TO ENSURE THE MOST
VULNERABLE WERE CHECKED ON AND
CARED FOR. AND THINK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR TAKING AN IN
DEPTH LOOK AT THIS ISSUE TODAY
AND FOR YOUR ON GOING TO GARY
ENGAGEMENT. THE RESILIENCE OF
THE STATE IS ON MATCHED THE
RESILIENCE OF INDIVIDUALS.
UNDER THESE EXTREME
CIRCUMSTANCES WERE ALSO ON
MATCHED. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THANK YOU FOR THAT- JUST WANT
TO MENTION WE HAVE SIXTEEN MORE
SPEAKERS OR WAIT PRETTY FAR
BEHIND. OUR OUR- SHEDULE HERE
SO IF WE CAN MAYBE IN YOUR NEXT
PRESENTATIONS GET TO THE MORE
SALIENT POINTS IN. THE MOST
IMPORTANT PARTS OF YOUR
PRESENTATIONS AND MAYBE. THOSE
AREAS SO YOU THINK ARE MORE
IMPORTANT TO YOUR PRESENTATIONS
AND MOBILE NOW TO MR MENDONCA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I'M BLOODY MENTONE SIGN
THE GOVERNOR'S CHIEF ECONOMIC
AND BUSINESS ADVISER AND
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. AND I WILL BRIEFLY
DESCRIBE THE AS BEST I CAN TELL
THE IMPACT OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFFS ON THE ECONOMY
OF CALIFORNIA AND OUR
BUSINESSES. IN SHORT THE IMPACT
TO CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AS A
WHOLE AS BEST WE CAN TELL FROM
THE INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE IS LIKELY TO BE
RELATIVELY SMALL. THIS IS
LARGELY BECAUSE THE ECONOMY IS
SO BIG AFFECTED AREAS WERE
RELATIVELY CONSTRAINED MANY
LARGE BUSINESSES. ADD BACKUP
POWER IN PLACE TO MITIGATE THE
PS PS IMPACTS THAT'S NOT TO
MINIMIZE THE IMPACT BUT AN
OVERALL ECONOMY. WHEN THE
PUBLIC SAFETY SHUT OFF WAS
ELECTED LARGELY IN. COUNTIES
AND BUSINESSES THAT REFLECT
ABOUT 4% OF THE STATE'S
CITIZENS AND 6% OF THE GDP FOR
RELATIVELY CONSTRAINED TIME
PERIOD THE OVERALL IMPACT IS
LIKELY TO BE SMALL. HAVING SAID
THAT THERE ARE TWO AREAS OF
CONCERN THAT WERE WATCHING. THE
FIRST ONE IS A LONGER TERM
CONCERN IF THESE CONTINUE
AROUND ANXIETY FROM BUSINESSES
ABOUT THE RELIABILITY OF THEIR
POWER. AND ALSO THAT THE POWER
TRYING TO SHUT US HAPPENED IN
MANY PARTS OF THE STATE. AT THE
PEAK OF THEIR PEERS TOURISM
SEASON THAT HAS SUBSTANTIAL
IMPACT ON THE ECONOMIES OF
THOSE REGIONS. SECONDLY THERE
IS A DEEP CONCERN AMONG SMALL
BUSINESSES ABOUT THE ONGOING
RELIABILITY THEY ARE THE
BACKBONE OF OUR ECONOMY AND
OFTEN MORE THAN NOT TO NOT HAVE
ANY BACK UP. POWER IN ON TOP OF
THAT THEY ALSO DON'T HAVE
CAPITAL THE WEATHER A LONG TERM
SHUT OFF AND HAVE THE
CHALLENGES OF BEING ABLE TO
OPERATE. AS IT CONTINUES. MANY
OF THESE SMALL BUSINESSES
IMPACTED WERE WOMEN AND
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES AS
WELL. OUR OFFICE WAS AB WAS
ACTIVATED OR OFFICE OF SMALL
BIZ ADVOCATE DURING THE PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF SOME WORK
HAND IN HAND WITH CALLOW YES
DURING THAT TIME PERIOD. DID
OUT REACH TO OVER NINETY OF OUR
GRANTEES ACROSS THE SMALL
BUSINESS NETWORK ACROSS THE
STATE. AS WELL AS STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATIONS TO ASSESS THEIR
VIEW OF WHAT THE IMPACT WAS.
GENERALLY WERE HEARD FROM SOME
THIS IS ON THE GROUND THAT THEY
WERE NOT IN A POSITION TO
ACCEPT. LOANS OR TO LOOK FOR
LONG TERM CAPITAL MOSTLY
CONCERNED ABOUT NEAR TERM
RECOVERY AND REVENUES. WE ALSO
HAD EARLY DISCUSSIONS WITH
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION IN
CAPITAL PROVIDERS TO. EXPLORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOANS AND
OTHER SPECTRUM OF CAPITAL
AVAILABILITY SHOULD DISCONTINUE
OVER TIME. AND FINALLY WE
LOOKED AT PARTNERSHIPS. THAT
WORK ON RESILIENCE WITH OUR
GRANTEES TO HELP SMALL BUSINESS
PREPARE FOR AN ONGOING OUTRAGE.
LASTLY BECAUSE OF THE CONCERN
AROUND LOST REVENUES WE WILL BE
LAUNCHING VERY SHORTLY A VISIT
CALIPHS IN COLLABORATION WITH
VISIT CALIFORNIA A SHOP LOCAL
AND VISIT CALIFORNIA SOCIAL
MEDIA CAMPAIGN. THAT'S REALLY
FOCUSED ON TRYING TO HELP
PEOPLE REMEMBER THAT CALIFORNIA
IS STILL OPEN FOR BUSINESS.
PARTICULARLY FOCUSED ON OUR
VISITORS SERVING BUSINESSES AND
ARE SMALLER BUSINESSES. THAT
SHOP LOCAL INITIATIVE WILL BE
WE'VE BEEN TO VISIT
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING CONTENT
PLATFORMS AND WILL ALSO EXPLORE
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES TO
HIGHLIGHT. BUSINESSES IN THE
STATE THAT ARE IN FACT OPEN FOR
BUSINESS AND WITH THAT ALSO
I'LL CONCLUDE. NOW MERRY MERRY
THE JR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
VERY BILL BATCHELOR I'M
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION I'M
JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUE
ELIZAVETA MALASHENKO WHO IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SECURITY
AND ENFORCEMENT FOR THE PSP I
HEARD WHAT YOU SAID SIR I HAVE
SEVERAL PAGES BUT I'M GOING TO
TRY AND EDIT AS I GO HOUSE THAT
THAT'S FINE IS AT WORK OKAY-
YOU'VE HEARD THE DETAIL
ACCOUNTS FOR MY COLLEAGUES OF
THE DISRUPTIONS AND CHALLENGES
CALLED CAUSED BY THE PS PS
EVENTS. AND WILD FIRES ON THE
RESIDENTS AND FOR THE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE COMMUNITY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE SO I WILL TRY NOT TO
RETREAD THAT TERRITORY I THINK
ALSO IN THE LAST THREE OR FOUR
WEEKS IT'S BEEN MADE VERY CLEAR
BUT I STATEMENTS THAT I'VE MADE
AT DIFFERENT- FORUMS THAT THE
P. USED HELD THAT- BEERS THE PS
PS WAS NOT WELL CARRIED OUT IN
PARTICULAR BY- ONE OF THE I AO
USE AND THAT IS P. JEANNIE SO I
WILL NOT AGAIN. GO THROUGH OF
THOSE DETAILS I DID SPEND
CONSIDERABLE TIME AT THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER WITH MY DEAR
COLUMNS DURING THE LAST WEEK OF
OCTOBER AND WITNESS THE
MOBILIZATION IN REAL TIME
PROBLEM BUILDING FROM THE
LEADING LEVEL TO THOSE MAKING
REAL DIFFERENCE ON THE GROUND
AND IN THE COMMUNITIES. IS A
WORLD CLASS EMERGENCY RESPONSE
BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HOWEVER I DO NOT WANT WAY FROM
THESE EVENTS WHICH WHICH US THE
IS POSITIVE IMPRESSIONS I WAS
ALSO PROVIDE WAS INSIDE THE HOW
A TOOL LIKE PS PS INTENT
PROTECT PEOPLE AND COMMUNITIES
FROM ARM CAN WIN IN
HAPHAZARDLY. AT THE FACT I HAVE
GAINED SHARPER UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW THE OF ONE ENTITY CAN
RESULT IN BURKE SOCIETY COSTS
THE TEST BEFORE ALL OF IT NOW
PARTICULAR THE CPUC IS TO
ENSURE THAT THE FUTURE USE OF
PSP IS INITIATED AN EXECUTED IN
A MANNER THAT CONSIDERS AND IN
THE BEST. INTEREST OF ALL
IMPACTED BY IT. EVER STOP
DEMANDING BETTER WAYS TO REDUCE
THE RISK AND TO REDUCE THE USE
SCOPE AND IMPACTS OF A POWER
SHUT OFF WITHOUT COMPROMISING
PUBLIC SAFETY. WE SAW PLAY OUT
IN I OWE YOU SERVICE
TERRITORIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE LAST LAST MONTH CANNOT AS
IT'S BEEN STATED AND SHOULD NOT
BE REPEATED. I'VE ONLY BEEN AT
THE CPUC FOR THREE MONTHS BUT
IT IT IT DOES NOT TAKE LONG TO
SEE THE PRIVILEGE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES HAVE IN BEING A
UNIQUE PROVIDER OF ESSENTIAL
SERVICE. PUBLIC IT IS ALL IT
ALSO HAS NOT TAKEN ME LONG TO
REALIZE HOW SOME UTILITIES FAIL
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT A PRIVILEGE
IT IS AND THAT SUCH A PRIVILEGE
COMES WITH GREAT RESPONSIBILITY
TO THOSE THEY SERVE. IT IS A C.
B. U. PC'S THE CPU SEES
RESPONSIBILITY THEREFORE TO
IDENTIFY AND CORRECT SUCH
FAILURES WE MUST ENSURE ANY
FUTURE POWER SHUT OFF THE VENT.
IS NOTHING LIKE THE PLAYED OUT
IN THE P. JEANNIE IN PARTICULAR
AND IN PARTS OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON SERVICE
TERRITORIES LAST MONTH. AS YOU
I WILL SKIP- OUR OUR HISTORY OF
THE P. C. P. SKEWS ME OF THE-
S. P. S. BECAUSE I THINK THAT
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
OUTLINED THAT FOR YOU AND IT'S
IN THEIR HANDS AND OUT SO FOR
THE SAKE OF TIME I WILL SAY
THAT HISTORY. THE UTILITIES
PLANS FOR THESE EVENTS HOWEVER
ONLY EFFECTIVE WHEN THEY ARE
IMPLEMENTED IN A REASONABLE AND
COMPETENT MANNER. THIS DID NOT
HAPPEN ACROSS ALL SERVICE
TERRITORIES LAST MONTH AS I
SAID. THE IMPACT AND SCOPE OF
THE POWER SHUT OFF TO LIVES
BUSINESS AND ECONOMY CANNOT BE
OVERSTATED AS MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE SAID PGA. IN P. G. I IN
PARTICULAR NOT FULLY PREPARED
TO MANAGE SUCH A LARGE SCALE
POWER SHUT UP THROUGHOUT THE
RUPIAH'S PS EVENTS AS HAS BEEN
WELL STATED P. JEANNIE HAD
MULTIPLE ISSUES WITH
COMMUNICATIONS COORDINATION.
AND VENT AND RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT. AMONG VARIOUS
PROBLEMS IDENTIFIED WE WITNESS
FIJIAN NOT HAD ADEQUATELY
PREPARED OR OR HAD PREPARED FOR
THE SCALE OF ITS BUSINESS
OPERATIONS FOR INCREASING
CUSTOMERS CONTACTING THE
UTILITY DURING THE SHUT OFF
EVENTS. AS WELL STATED BY
SECRETARY LEE. WE HAVE ALSO
HEARD FROM THE LOCAL AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS ON THE LACK OF
COORDINATION UNTIL THE
POWERSHOT UPS COMMENCED THE
LACK OF CRITICAL INFORMATION
FLOW IN SOME INSTANCES
BREAKDOWNS INCOMPLETE QUOTE
COMMUNICATIONS WITH OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND I WILL ADD
THAT THAT WAS TRUE INDEED EVEN
IN A LAST PSE EVENT ALTHOUGH
OTHER THINGS HAD BEEN IMPROVED
UPON. AN EXECUTION COME WITH
THE MAGNITUDE OF THESE EVENTS
CREATED AN ACCEPTANCE BOTH
SITUATIONS THAT SHOULD NEVER BE
REPEAT AS I'VE STATED AND THAT
REQUIRES SCRUTINY IN CORRECTION
WELL P. JEANNIE SPENT
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES WORK IN
THE PUBLIC. ABOUT THE RISKS OF
THE POWER SHUT UP THE VENTS AND
WHAT THE PUBLIC SHOULD DO TO
PREPARE FOR AN EVENT. IT IS NOT
CLEAR THE P. JEANNIE SPENT THE
TIME IT SHOULD HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THE UTILITY. ITSELF WAS
PREPARED. THESE ARE THE RECENT
ACTIONS WE HAVE TAKEN IN
RESPONSE TO THESE EVENTS THE
CPUC IS TAKEN IMMEDIATE ACTION
TO HOLD UTILITIES ACCOUNTABLE
INCREASE PUBLIC SAFETY. ON
OCTOBER EIGHTEENTH WE HELD AN
EMERGENCY MEETING TO HEAR FROM
THE TOP P. JEANNIE EXECUTIVES
ABOUT LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE
P. S. P. S. EVENTS. OF THE WEEK
OF OCTOBER SEVENTH AND TO
ADDRESS THE STEPS. THAT THE
UTILITY WOULD TAKE TO ENSURE
MISTAKES AND OPERATIONAL GAPS
WOULD NOT BE REPEATED. THE CPUC
SAFETY IN AND SPENT THE VISION
IS THEREFORE CONDUCTING AN
INVESTIGATION OF THE TWENTY
NINETEEN P. S. P. S. EVENTS TO
EVALUATE THE NATURE. OF THE
LACK OF PREPAREDNESS I'M NOT
ONLY P. GINNY BUT ALSO OF THE
STATE'S OTHER I- USE. THIS
INVESTIGATION WILL ASSESS
WHETHER THE STATE'S INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES PROPERLY
BALANCED THE NEED TO PROVIDE
SAFE AND RELIABLE SERVICE WHEN
PLANNING AND EXECUTING THESE P.
S. P. S. EVENTS. THEIMMEDIATE
FIRST STEP IN THE PRECEDING IS
FOR OUR SAFETY IN ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION TO OVERSEE AN
EVALUATION OF THE UTILITIES
ACTIONS TO DURING AND AFTER.
THE PS PS EVENTS. EVALUATION
INCLUDE THE QUALITY OF THE
UTILITIES INTERNAL COMMUNE
CORPORATION SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS EXTERNAL
COMMUNICATIONS AND PRE PLANNING
AND EXECUTION OF THE PS
ECEVIT'S THE RESULTS WERE
PRESENTED TO THE PUBLIC IN A
REPORT. THIS PROCEEDING IS VERY
IMPORTANT AS IT WILL PROVIDE A
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW. OF BOTH
THE AFFECT NEST AND IMPACTS OF
ALL PHASES OF THE RECENT PS PS
EVENTS TO DETERMINE WHETHER
FURTHER CHANGES TO EXISTING PS
YES REGULATIONS AND
REQUIREMENTS. ARE NECESSARY TO
ENSURE PUBLIC SAFETY. IT MAY
RESULT IN AN ENFORCEMENT FACE
TO ADDRESS FINDINGS OF NON
COMPLIANCE WITH C. D. UC RULES
AND REGULATIONS. ADDITIONALLY
ON OF OUR TWELFTH DIRECTED
PIGEON TO DEMONSTRATE WHY IT
SHOULDN'T BE SANCTIONED FOR XPS
IT PS EVENTS IMPLEMENTED
THROUGH OCTOBER TWENTY
NINETEEN. THE ORDER TO SHOW
CAUSE WILL PROVIDE FOR A.
TIONAL TESTIMONY COMMENTS AND
OR RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
IMPACTED PARTIES INCLUDING
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES. THE PARTIES WILL
ALSO BE PROVIDED AN OPPORTUNITY
TO RIDE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
MONETARY FINES AND ANY
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS AS
APPROPRIATE. WE ARE HOLDING A
PRE HEARING CONFERENCE ON THIS
ISSUE ON DECEMBER FOURTH. THE
ISLEY ORDERED P. G. NEED TO
PERFORM AN AFTER ACTION REVIEW
OF THESE PSP PS EVENTS AND FILE
WEEKLY UPDATES ON CORRECTIVE
ACTIONS UNTIL ALL CONCERNS HAVE
INDEED BEEN ADDRESSED THE
DIRECTIVE ALSO STANDS. AS A
RESULT OF THESE RECENT EVENTS
WE ARE WORKING TOWARDS REVISING
PHASE TWO OF THE PS PS
PROCEEDINGS IN ORDER TO REVIEW
THE PS PS GUIDELINES ADOPTED IN
PHASE ONE AND TO ACCELERATE
CONSIDERATION OF YOU LADY.
INVESTMENTS TO IMPROVE PS PS.
WE ARE ALSO DIRECTING THE
UTILITIES TO EXPAND THEIR UP
COMING UP COMING WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS TO FOCUS%
CREASING THEIR SAFETY
PERFORMANCE AND CREATING MORE
RESILIENT COMMUNITIES IN ORDER
TO REDUCE THE NEED FOR PSP S.
EVENTS BEFORE THE NEXT WILDFIRE
SEASON. I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE UTILITY CUSTOMERS ARE
BEING TREATED FAIRLY BY THEIR
UTILITIES CUSTOMERS SHOULD NOT
PAY FOR SERVICES THEY DID NOT
RECEIVE. AS SUCH WE WILL WORK
TOWARDS ENSURING CUSTOMERS ARE
NOT CHARGE FOR SERVICES THEY
DID NOT RECEIVE DURING THE PS
PS EVENTS. AS WE REFLECT ON THE
PSP OBSERVANCE IN THE WILD
FIRES WE ALSO KNOW THAT THESE
EVENTS LED TO FAILURES IN THE
COMMUNICATIONS NETWORK AS
DIRECTOR GALA DUDE SHE
MENTIONED MOMENTS AGO WE CANNOT
FORGET THE COMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE DURING SUCH
TURBULENT TIMES IS CRITICAL AND
FAILURES IN THE SYSTEM ALSO IN
DANGER LIVES. CALIFORNIANS AND
OUR FIRST RESPONDERS RELY ON
THEIR PHONES AND THEIR INTERNET
WHETHER IT BE A WATER LINE
REQUIRE LESS TECHNOLOGY TO
RECEIVE AND SEND EMERGENCY
NOTIFICATION. WE WHAT WE
LEARNED SENSE THEN IS THAT
FAILURES IN THE COMMUNICATION
NETWORKS OCCURRED ON A
SIGNIFICANT SCALE AS WAS
OUTLINED BY DIRECTORGALA DUTY.
THIS IS PROMPTED ME TO HOLD A
PRE HEARING CONFERENCE ON
NOVEMBER TWENTIETH TWO QUESTION
THE COMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES ON
THEIR EFFORTS TO KEEP THE
SYSTEMS FUNCTIONING DURING THE
OCTOBER PS PS EVENTS. PRE
HEARING CONFERENCE WILL IN FOR
THE SCOPE AND SCHEDULE FOR THE
PRECEDING WHICH WILL ESTABLISH
RULES FOCUSED ON BUILDING A
RESILIENT COMMUNICATION NETWORK
FOR FUNCTIONALITY DURING
EMERGENCIES THE TOPICS INCLUDE.
REQUIREMENT OF A BACKUP BATTERY
POWER AND GENERATORS AT
CELLULAR TOWERS AND HARDENING
OF THE COMMUNICATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AFTER
CONVENIENCE SEVERAL FORMS OVER
THE LAST YEAR TO PROVE
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE
COMMUNICATION COMPANIES AND THE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE AGENCIES WE
HAVEN'T CONCLUDED THAT THERE IS
A LACK OF UNIFORM AND
STRUCTURED APPROACH TO ENSURE
THAT THE COMMUNICATION
PROVIDERS. ARE DRESSING THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES TO PROVIDE
SAFE AND ROLL UP RELIABLE
SERVICE DURING THESE EMERGENCY
EVENTS THIS LACK OF PREPARATION
AND TRANSPARENCY HAS REAL
CONSEQUENCES DURING THE MOST.
RECENT PSP IS EVENTS AND
WILDFIRES AS AGAIN MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER GELLER DUTY MENTIONED
THERE WERE WIDESPREAD REPORTS
OF COMMUNICATION OUTAGES ACROSS
ALL SECTORS MOBILE NETWORKS.
WILL BE IP COMMUNICATIONS AND
THE INNER. AS WE WERE TOWARD TO
FIND PATHWAYS IF AS WE WORK
TOGETHER TO FIND WAYS TO
MINIMIZE THE IMPACT OF PS PS
EVENTS WE MUST ALSO REMEMBER
THE COMMUNICATION PROVIDERS
MUST ALSO BE A PART OF THE
DISCUSSION AND SOLUTIONS. AS WE
ARE TAKING REGULATORY ACT AND
ALL. THE TO HOLDING ALL
UTILITIES ACCOUNTABLE WE'RE
ALSO LOOKING INTERNALLY. WITHIN
THE P. YOU SEE TO IMPROVE
SAFETY AND OUTCOMES ON THE
GROUND AND ORGANIZATIONAL
CHANGE WE ARE MAKING IS TO
IMPLEMENT A PLAN OF A NEW
SAFETY POLICY DIVISION. TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE A TANGIBLE
DOUBLE THE PROGRESS IN SAFETY
THE CPUC WILL COMMIT THE
RESOURCES TO DEVELOP A SAFETY
POLICY AS IT DOES ON OTHER
POLICY MATTERS. HE SAID TO
POLICY DIVISION WILL ENSURE
THAT THERE IS DEDICATED STAFF
TO ANALYZE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
EXISTING SAFETY REGULATIONS
POSED IMPROVEMENTS AND WORK ON
EMERGING EMERGING ISSUES SUCH
AS SAFETY CULTURE. IN CLOSING
WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
MONEY BY EXPRESSING MY
APPRECIATION TO OF COURSE THE
PRO TEM ATKINS AND TO YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND TO THE
SENATORS IN ATTENDANCE TODAY
FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING AND
HAVING ENGAGED IN THE RECENT
WEEKS DURING THESE EVENTS IN
THE DAYS WEEKS AND MONTHS TO
COME WE WILL CONTINUE TO EXPAND
LAST MONTH'S EVENTS EXAMINE
LAST MONTH'S EVENTS AND MONITOR
HOW WELL COMMITMENTS MADE BY
THE OHIO USE AND THE RECALL
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS THE
CPUC HAS IDENTIFIED RE INDEED
IMPLEMENTED. HOWEVER DESPITE
IMPORTANCE OF THE REGULATORY
PROCESSES AND THE ACTIONS WE
HAVE BEEN IN MOTION THEY ARE
MEANINGLESS TO THE PUBLIC
UNLESS THEY TRACK PLAYED INTO
REAL WORLD DEMONSTRATIONS THAT
UTILITIES TRULY TAKING ACTIONS
THAT PRIORITIZE THE SAFETY OF
THE PUBLIC THAT THEY SERVE IT
IS CLEAR TO THE MEMBERS ALLEGED
IT IS CLEAR THAT THE MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE SHARE THIS
INTENT. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO READ. WHY
IS IT THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME THIS AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND I THINK YOU
DID GET TO THE MOST IMPORTANT
POINTS AND REPORTING THOSE AND
REGARDING. THE COMPENSATION
THAT WE'VE HAD TODAY WITH ALL
THE VARIOUS DIFFERENT
PRESENTERS- THE P. UC'S SEEMS
TO BE KIND OF THE CENTRAL
PROCESSING UNIT THE FOCAL
POINT. OF ANYTHING HAPPENING IN
WITH. OR ANYTHING THAT IN THE
MIX REGARDING. OUR OUR NEXT
STEPS AND YOU MENTIONED THAT
YOU WERE. CONDUCT AN
INVESTIGATION BUT ALSO COME UP
WITH A- PLAN- REGARDING THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES IN
THAT ONE TRACK AND THEN YOU'VE
TALKED ABOUT. THIS P. AT PS PS
IMPLEMENTATION GLOCK PLANS ARE
FRAMEWORK FOR A POLICY AND HOW
THOSE. HAPPENED PRECEDING THAT
IS ON GOING ON GOING AND IT'S
GOING TO BE GOING ON I IMAGINE
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE TIME
FRAME FOR EITHER OF THESE AS
BUT I DID WANT TO ASK WHAT IS
THE TIME FRAME DO YOU EXPECT.
THAT YOU'LL NOT ONLY FINISH BY
BEFORE NEXT YEAR'S OF. FIRE
SEASON YES THAT IS OUR INTENT
ON ALL OF THE THINGS I
MENTIONED THE FOUR OR FIVE
THINGS THAT I MENTIONED THAT
ARE UNDER WAY IN THE LAST.
THIRTY DAYS. AND ALMOST
EVERYBODY IN THE UTILITIES THAT
PRESENTED TODAY TALKED ABOUT
AMENDING THEIR- PHONE. WELL
GOALS IN TERMS OF HOW THE HEART
IN THE GRID MAKE THE GRADE MORE
RESILIENT ALL OF A MENTION THAT
THEY HAVE TO REACH OUT TO THE
PC PRESENT THEIR PLANS APPROVED
THE PLANS FOR YOU SEE IMAGINE.
THAT'S GOING TO BE A CONCURRENT.
ROSS SAYS SAYS YOU'RE GOING
THROUGH THIS THEY'RE GOING TO
BE PRESENTING THEIR PLANS- P.
GINNY MENTION THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE. THEIR SUBMITTAL
IN JANUARY I HEARD THAT SO AS
TO WHAT FIRE MITIGATION PLAN
SIR YES YES THAT WILL BE GOING
ON CONCURRENTLY MANY OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY MENTIONED THE
HARD NEED THAT BOTH- ALL THREE
ACTUALLY I USE MENTIONED TODAY
I THINK YOU. TOOK PARTICULAR
ATTENTION TO- THOSE THINGS
MIGHT MENTION BY SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC. ALL OF THOSE THINGS
ARE MENTIONED BY THE BIO USE
WITHIN THEIR WELFARE MITIGATION
PLANS AND WE WILL BE. TAKING
WITH THEM TO UPDATE THEM AS I
JUST SAID. TO FOCUS GREATER
FOCUS ON SAFETY WHICH IS
ALREADY INCLUDED IN THE WELFARE
MEDICATION. AND YES THEY WILL
BE SUBMITTING THEM IN GENERAL
ALL THREE IN JANUARY. NO HAVE A
SPECIFIC DATE SAID LAST IT WAS
FEBRUARY FEBRUARY WILL BE IN
pTHE SAME CYCLE OF. THE GROUP
HAVING THE WOOD OPTED OUT BY A-
IN THE IN THE BANK OKAY THANK
YOU HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
ACCOMPLISH SIGN IN A TIMELY. OF
WE ARE- WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE RIGHT
NOW- WE DID RECEIVE- BUDGET- AN
APPROPRIATION- WE ARE WORKING
IN JULY ONE ON TO ADD TO OUR
RESOURCES BOTH IN A LITTLE BIT
IS AREA AS WELL AS ESTABLISHING
THE NEW WILD FIRE SAFETY
DIVISION. AND THOSE RESOURCE
AND WE'RE INDEED YOU SEE THAT
STORY TO UNDERSTAND THOSE
POSITIONS UP NOW. AND WE'RE
LOOKING WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN IN
FURTHERING OUR RESOURCE NEEDS I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO BE
CRITICAL IN THIS NEXT YEAR AND-
IN WRAPPING UP THIS ENTIRE
PROCESS IS WANT TO MAKESURE
THAT YOU DO HAVE THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY. I APPRECIATE THAT
ACCOMPLISHED AT AND MAKE SURE
WE GET TO OUR GOALS THAT WE
HAVE ANYONE ELSE- SENATOR
SKINNER THAN. SEPTEMBER OF MORE
LOCKED AND SENATOR. NIELSEN.
ALL WHILE OKAY EVERYONE- THANK
YOU AND THEN MCGUIRE THAN THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU.
AS STATE OFFICIALS FOR YOUR
PRESENT SOMEONE AT- A MISTER
UNCONSCIOUS THANK YOU FOR. THE
REFERENCE TO WELL WE DIDN'T
EXPERIENCE STATEWIDE BECAME.
OUR BUSINESSES REALLY WANT
CERTAINTY. THIS THIS CREATES
THAT WORST CASE FOR BUSINESSES
WHERE THEY CAN'T PLANTS
APPRECIATE THAT YOU MENTION
THAT. AND I WANT TO. THANK
MISTER ALI FOR. THE
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT YOUR
DIVISION DEALS WITH SO MANY
PEOPLE WHO CAN BE MOST IMPACTED
BY SUCH OUTAGES IN GLAD THE
STATE HAS BEEN- I THINK MY
EXPERIENCE SO FAR VERY MUCH ON
TOP OF THAT. IT'S REALLY HARD
TO DO THAT WHEN YOU HAVE SO
MANY RESIDENTS AFFECTED BY ANY
PARTY TO. THE MISTER THE CHAIR
WOULD. SAY THE D. AS DURING THE.
OUTAGE SOME OF MY DISTRICT IS
AFFECTED BY THE OUTAGES AND AT
THE SAME TIME WE HAD A
REFINERY- DEPOT FIRE WITH AYE
ET CLOSE FROM BOTH SIDES AND
THEN WE HAD A SECOND FIRE. IN
CERTAIN VALLEJO THAT JUMPED TO
THE DISTRICT IN COULD OF PUT A
REFINERY IN FIVE TIMES HIGHER
IN INTERESTINGLY IN BOTH IN ALL
THE CIRCUMSTANCES BOTH THE
POWER OUTAGES. THE MORE MORE
SPECIFIC IN SMALLER FIRES THAT
HIT JUST MY DISTRICT- I
EXPERIENCED THIS VERY DIFFERENT
SO DURING THE PS PS THERE WAS
MOSTLY. THE COMMUNICATION
THROUGH P. JEANNIE. BUT THEY
ALSO ARE DIVISION OF OUR
GOVERNOR OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES WHERE MY STAFF AND I
COULD CALL IN. AND BE. THERE
WERE GOODS AND BADS BUT IF I
THEN CONTRASTED TO THE- THE
CIRCUMSTANCES IN THE REFINERY
FIRES WHERE WE HAVE A CLEARER
AND I DON'T MEAN THIS JUST FOR
THE STATE BUT I'M RATHER. I'M
COMPARING IT TO THE YES PS IN
THAT WE HAVE A VERY CLEAR
PROTOCOL WHERE IT GOES THROUGH
THE COUNTY OFFICES AND THERE'S
A CLEAR HIERARCHY AND MY STAFF
KNOW IT THEY KNOW WHO AS
DETERMINATION DETERMINE FOR
EXAMPLE WHETHER THERE'S
EVACUATION WHETHER THERE'S ALL
TERM PLACE WHETHER THERE'S YOU
KNOW THE QUICK. THE QUICK
SETTING UP OF CENTERS FOR
PEOPLE TO BE IN AND ALL THAT
AND ALL OF THAT WORKED FOR MORE
SMOOTHLY PS PS THIS IS NOT I'M
NOT DIRECTING THIS AT THE STATE
SO MUCH BECAUSE ACTUALLY THE.
DIFFERENT DIVISIONS I HAD TO
REACT WITH. THE PS PS ON THE
STATE SIDE I FOUND I WAS QUITE
SATISFACTORY BUT WHAT I'M
REALLY POINTING OUT IS THAT
THAT KIND OF DIFFERENTIATION
WHERE THERE WAS A CLEAR.
PROTOCOL AND CLEAR HIERARCHY.
IN THE IN THOSE HAZARDS
CIRCUMSTANCES IT THE
COMMUNICATION WAS SO MUCH
BETTER THE RESIDENTS WERE
BETTER SERVED. AND WHATEVER WE
CAN DO MAKE THE PS PS
EXPERIENCE MORE ANALOGOUS I
THINK WOULD BE HELPFUL. AND
THEN FINALLY MY QUESTIONS ARE
GOING TO BE TO OUR SI PC
PRESIDENT APPRECIATE VERY MUCH
THAT YOU'RE HERE. TWO THINGS
FIRST WHAT DOES SHE HAVE ANY
KIND OF ESTIMATE OF WHAT IT
COSTS IN ANY OF OUR I USE TO DO
THESE POWER OUTAGES NOW
OBVIOUSLY IT'S A IF IT'S- A
MORE RESIDENTS YOU KNOW P.
GENIES WOULD SEEM TO ME.
OBVIOUSLY MORE COSTLY THAN ESTY
GENIES OR STDS BUT DO YOU
REQUEST IN THE TO IN THE REPORT
TO GET LATER. YOU ASK FOR A
COST BREAKDOWN. I HAVE NINE IN
IN THE QUESTION. THEM NOW THAT
IS NOT TO SAY THAT WE CAN'T IN
THE FUTURE BUT THE THINGS THAT
I HAVE DONE SINCE NINETEEN
SIXTY DAYS OR SO BEING HERE I
HAVEN'T BUT I THINK THAT IN THE
PROCEEDINGS WE WILL GET A CALL.
DOWN SETTING WOULD BE HELPFUL
FIRST NOTICE HOW COSTLY IT IS
BECAUSE THAT. HELP US WELL
ANYWAY WOULD JUST BE USEFUL.
THE OTHER- IS YOU MENTIONED THE
DIFFERENT BUDGET FORTIES THAT
WE GAVE SPACE THERE WITH MY
CAR- HAD TO LEAVE EARLY HAD
ASKED SPECIFICALLY- EITHER THE
P. YOU SEE HAD BEEN ABLE TO
HIRE OR ANY OF THE EIGHT F. E.
THAT WERE GIVEN FOR. THAT
SPECIFICALLY FOR PS PS
OVERSIGHT- YES ENTER SKINNER I
LOOKED UP. ON I WAS NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THAT THAT NUMBER
EIGHT AHA THAT CAME FROM A
SPRING LETTER. THAT WAS
SUBMITTED AND ACTUALLY SEVERAL
SEVERAL THINGS THAT WERE
REQUEST THAT THE I'M MORE
COMBINED. TO AS I SAID EIGHT
EIGHT AND A DIRECT
APPROPRIATION OF FORTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS TOOK CARE. IN
SEPARATION. MISSIONS AND SOME
OTHER POSITION. ALSO THERE IS
THAT WERE COMBINED FROM- TEN
FIFTY FOUR. IT. MASON WAS IN I
THINK ONE ELEVEN AND- IT WAS A
COMBINED APPROPRIATIONS YOUR
MAKING PRO ASSIGNED WE ARE
INDEED AND WE WILL MAKE MORE IN
THE UPCOMING BUDGET. EXCELLENT
AND THEN THE OTHER QUESTION AND-
I DON'T. I DON'T LIKE TO
MICROMANAGE OUR ROOM THREE
AGENCIES YOU ALL NEED TO BUT I
JUST WONDERED. BECAUSE IN
ASKING THE DIFFERENT FIRE USE
ABOUT WHETHER THEY HAD EITHER
MANDATED TO IMPLEMENT BEST
AVAILABLE CONTROL TECHNOLOGIES
OR WHETHER THEY ENTER TO
INCLUDE SUCH AN EVALUATION AND
ANY OF THEIR PLANS- THE ANSWERS
THAT. I GOT FROM WHICH WOULD
STAY HADN'T BUT ES DE GENIE FOR
EXAMPLE DID IT ON THEIR OWN.
AND IN PGP INDICATED THAT
THEY'RE LOOKING AT IT NOW BUT I
WONDERED SINCE IT'S. TIVOLI
COMMON FOR OUR AND REGULATORY
AGENCIES TO DIRECT THAT FROM
THE ENTITIES THAT THEY REGULATE
IS THAT SOMETHING THE P.
HOUSTON MIGHT CONSIDER LOOKING
OUT. THE DOOR DIRECTED- TWO HI
SAFE AND RELIABLE ENERGY THEY
ARE DIRECTED TO DO THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN GIVEN IN IN RECENT
LEGISLATION DIRECT FURTHER
DIRECTION SUCH AS IN. AB TEN
FIFTY FOUR SO THERE IS
DIRECTION THAT IS GIVEN TO THEM
IN DIFFERENT PROCEEDINGS AND
YOU THE LEGISLATURE HAVE ALSO
DIRECTED US TO DIRECT THEM SO
THERE ARE DIFFERENT
APPLICATIONS OF ACTIONS YES SO
I WOULD SAY I THINK THAT WAS IN
RESPONSE TO A VERY SPECIFIC
CHEF I CAN RECALL THE TESTIMONY
BUT WILL DEFINITELY. TEN FIFTY
FOUR AS AND I AM ONLY I'M ONLY.
I SUPPOSE SEATED ON IT A BIT AS-
WHEN I HEAR FROM OR ARE YOU U.
pP. JEANNIE THAT THEY FEEL THEY
MAY NEED TEN YEARS I GUESS THAT
FOR THOSE OF US WHO REPRESENT
THAT SURGERY IT'S VERY SCARY TO
CONSIDER THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
NEED THAT TEN YEARS AND CLEARLY
WE KNOW THAT. CERTAIN CERTAIN
TECHNOLOGIES OR HARDENING AND
RESILIENCY TYPE OF- APPROACHES
ARE BOTH FASTER TO IMPLEMENT
AND LESS EXPENSIVE TO IMPLEMENT
AND SO I'M I'M I'M THINKING
AND- I WOULD NOT MANDATE IT TO
YOU ALL BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO DO
AND WHETHER IN FACT THE BEST
APPROACH. BUT IF THERE ARE ONES
THAT ARE AFFECTED AND FAST NOT
AS EXPENSIVE THEN THE SOONER WE
CAN MOVE ON AND IT LEAST IT
TEAMS WOULD BE VERY LARGE CALL.
GREAT AND I THINK THAT- SOME OF
THE TESTIMONY. TODAY ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF INFORMATION
SHARING- I THINK SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC HAD SAID THAT THEY NOT
ONLY DO THEY SHARE INFORMATION
WITH P. GENE IN PARTICULAR BUT
THEY LOOK TOWARD. BOTH P.
JEANNIE IN SOCAL EDISON TO
LEARN THINGS AS WELL AND I
WOULD URGE MORE OF THAT. GREAT
CAN THERE'S MANY MORE THINGS
I'D LOVE TO ASK BUT MY
COLLEAGUES BEACON I DO HAVE TO
LEAVE SO MY LAST QUESTION WOULD
BE TO. TO MISTER TAYLOR DUTY.
DO WE KNOW HOW MUCH OF THE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION THAT- YES
WAS GIVEN TO HELP COMMUNITIES
AND OTHERS PREPARE FOR THESE
POWER OUTAGES HAS SPENT. THERE
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH HAS BEEN
SPENT BUT I COULD TELL YOU HOW
MUCH HAS BEEN ALLOCATED- SO.
THE. IT WAS THIRTY SEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION THAT WAS SHARED
AMONGST. LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
WE'VE ALLOCATED- TWENTY SIX
MILLION OF THAT TOO- COUNTIES-
BUT THE FOLLOWING BREAKDOWN-
WAS A- BASE WAS POPULATION.
GRANT AND- THE GRAND IF YOU'RE
A COUNTY THAT HAS NOT
EXPERIENCED A P. S. P. S. ARE
YOU GET A BASED A GRANT OF A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND.
YOUR COUNTY THEY HAD- HAD
EXPERIENCE PHP ASENATH
POPULATION OF LESS THAN FIFTY
THOUSAND- YOU GOT THE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR GRANT.
AND THEN IF YOU'RE A COUNTY HAD
A POPULATION OF MORE THAN FIFTY
THOUSAND THAT HAPPENS
EXPERIENCED. YES YES. IT WAS A
BASED A PLUS FOR THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR GRANT.
AND THEN WE SEPARATED TIONAL
TEN POINT THREE MILLION- OUR
BASE WAS POPULATION TO ALL THE
REMAINING- IS IN THE STATE'S
THE CABLE SOME CAPACITY. WE
ALSO- ALLOCATED TEN MILLION FOR
CITIES. I'M AND- ONE BAG OF SEE
ALL THE MONEY FOR COUNTIES HAS
BEEN ALLOCATED- TEN MAIN
CITIES- INCLUDED- ALLOCATION
TO- THE STATE'S MOST POPULOUS.
CITY THE THEY HAVE HAD PS PS OF
ALL ABILITIES. DIRECT
ALLEGATIONS WERE SAN JOSE LOS
ANGELES SAN DIEGO IN OAKLAND.
HE'S GOT FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND.
AND THEN ALL THE UP CITIES
OUGHT TO DO A- A COMPETE. FIND
OF- BOB I WAS A STREAMLINED
PROCESS THAT WE PUT IN THESE.
CITIES REQUIRED OUTLINED HOW
THEY'LL TEND TO USE THE FUNDS
AND- THAT THAT IS BASED ON SOME
INFORMATION. POPULATION DAYS OF
P. S. P. S. EXPERIENCE- EXTRA
AND THEN LASTLY- TRIBES WERE-
ALLOCATED. ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION ALSO ON. THIS COMMUNITY
CENTERS HEALTH FACILITIES AND
FACILITIES THAT ARE CRITICAL TO
COMMUNITIES FUNCTIONS DURING
ONE OF THESE A POWER
INTERRUPTIONS ALSO ONE TIME
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
IDENTIFYING ANY QUICK. RESOURCE
CENTERS FOR PUBLIC ACCESS
DURING ELECTRICAL DISTRICT
DISRUPTIONS- AS WELL BACKUP OF
EMERGENCY COMMUNITY THE QUICK
MESSAGES BATTERY POWERED
RADIOS- AND THEN PUBLIC
EDUCATION MATERIALS OR SUPPLIES
FOCUSED ON INDIVIDUAL- AND
FAMILY PREPAREDNESS LOGICAL-
POWERSHOT OFFICE. ALSO
DEVELOPMENT AN UPDATE OF
CONTINGENCY PLANS FOR
ELECTRICAL DESCRIPTIONS OF A
CLOSE CONSIDERATION SUCH AS
PROTECTING INDIVIDUALS WITH
AXES AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS
MEDICAL BASS LINES SOCIAL
MARBLE POPULATIONS.
TRANSPORTATION ADVOCACY PUBLIC
INFORMATION AND PRESERVATION OF
SUCH FUNCTIONS. AS WELL
DEVELOPMENT AN UPDATE OF THE
GOVERNMENT CONTINUITY OF
OPERATIONS PLANNED FOR
JURISDICTION BY JURISDICTION.
AND THEN RISK ASSESSMENT FOR
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
LIFELINES AND THEN POST EVENT
REPORTS THAT IDENTIFY LESSONS
LEARNED TO INFORM CONTINUAL
IMPROVEMENTS SO IS A VERY
BROAD. SET UP OF ELIGIBILITY IS
THAT WE TRY TO PROVIDE UP FOR
THIS EDITION STREAMLINED
FUNDING ALLOCATION- THAT WENT
OUT A WHAT IS NOT ELIGIBLE IS
THE COST THE RESPONSE COSTS
ASSOCIATED. SO SHE DID WITH A
LARGE TRUCK BEDS- LIKE-
RESPONDING TO YOUR BURDENS THE
OPERATIONS CENTER STAFFING.
SECURITY FIRE SERVICE ETCETERA.
ONE TWELVE AND THEY EVEN WENT
DOOR TO DOOR TO SOME OF THE
MIRACLE BASELINE BECAUSE- THEY
SET UP THEIR OWN CENTERS FOR
PEOPLE TO GO NOT JUST TO CHARGE
THINGS BUT TO BASICALLY. BE YOU
KNOW. JUST AND- ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO DIDN'T EVEN HAVE CELL
PHONE SERVICE SO- I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT NAY NOAM NUMBER
MY COMMUNITIES UTILIZE THE
MONEY VERY WELL UNDER MORE LUCK
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- NOW
THAT I HAVE THE STORE WHEN I GO
THROUGH A RISK MANAGEMENT ACT.
HI IS. YOU HAVE BY- YOU HAVE
INVERSE CONDEMNATION OF THEIR
WORRY ABOUT ANYTHING THAT THEY
START THEY HAVE TO PAY FOR THE
DAMAGES. C. A. B. TEN FIFTY
FOUR AND IT'S NEW AND IT ISN'T
REALLY FULLY FUNDED SO THEY
DON'T HAVE THAT AS A BACKSTOP.
THEY'RE READY HAVE MASSIVE
RELEASE IN THE CASE OF ONE
MASSIVE BODIES FOR PAST FIRES
AND NOW THEY'RE LOOKING AT VERY
HIGH INSURANCE PREMIUM COSTS.
SO WHAT BUT WHAT OTHER CHOICE
DO THEY HAVE BESIDES A P. S. P.
S. IF I MAY CENTER I THINK WE
HAVE THREE DIFFERENT I- USE-
WITH THE SAME REGULATORY SCHEME
YOU SEE REALLY DIFFERENT. BY
ALL THREE I USE BOTH IN TERMS
OF THE STATIONS UP UNTIL THIS
POINT AND RELATIVE INVESTMENTS
IN. IN HARDENING THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL AS THE
POSITION MAKING PROCESS IN IN
THROUGH THESE EVENTS AND YOU
SAW CHANGES IN THE USE OF THESE
EVENTS OVER TIME SO IF YOU LOOK
AT SANDY- GAS AND ELECTRIC.
THEY HAVE MADE SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASES IN- IN WEATHER DATA
AND WEATHER INFORMATION TO HAVE
A BETTER SENSE OF- OF WHAT YOU
KNOW WHAT SANTA WINDS ARE GOING
TO BE DOING. THAT ARE USING
THAT TECHNOLOGY IN THEIR
DECISION MAKING THEY HAVE A
STATE OF THE ART YOU'LL SEE
THAT THEY ARE ALL THAT THEY ARE
OPERATING TO MAKE REAL TIME
DECISIONS. THEY ALSO HAVE HARD
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE LOOKED AT
AREAS IN COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
GOING TO BE A HIGHER LEVEL OF
RISK AND- AND THE LOOK AT SOME
SOLUTIONS. FOR HOW TO DO BE A
BIKE RATES ARE MANY GROUPS OR
OTHER APPROACHES FOR HOW THEY
DEAL WITH THOSE BUT WHEN WE BUT
THEY STILL TURNED OFF THEIR
POWERS ALL THREE OF THEM USE PS
PS IN A MUCH. BROADER WAY FOR
SHORTER PERIODS OF TIME
AFFECTING MUCH SMALLER
ENTITIES- SO LOOK FOR EXAMPLE
AT THE EDISON EXPERIENCE THIS
YEAR. THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THE EDISON. THE
POTENTIAL OF PSP S. AND THE
RELATIVE AMOUNT OF- CUSTOMERS
WHO WERE TURNED WHERE ARE WAS
TURNED OFF- AS WELL AS YOU LOOK
AT THE DURATION OF THOSE
OUTAGES IT WAS VERY DIFFERENT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT. THE PGA ANY
SERVICE TOWARD TERRITORY WE
LOOK AT ALL THREE UTILITIES.
THE USE OF PSP A TERMS OF THE
SIZE OF THE EVENT THE DURATION
OF THE OUTAGES THE BACK TO
COLLEGES IT'S A DIFFERENT STORY
FOR THE OTHER TWO UTILITIES AND
THEY'RE ALL OPERATING ON THE
SAME REGULATORY REGIME. SO WE
WOULD AGREE WITH MISS BACK SURE
THAT. BECAUSE NO ONE IS SAID
DON'T USE PSP AS I HAVEN'T
HEARD THAT TODAY BUT- WHEN YOU
DO IT- WE SAW- MAYBE TO
PARAPHRASE MS BOETTCHER-
IMPLEMENTATION AND EXECUTION.
LACK OF PREPAREDNESS RESOLVE WE
SAW. A VERY DISAPPOINTING.
EXECUTION AND SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ROOM SO. WHEN
THAT THE NOW YOUR NEW PAIR IF I
CAN ASK YOU A QUESTION- DID THE
CPUC GIVE ALL THREE UTILITIES.
A NERVE. RATE INCREASES THE PAY
FOR NOT ONLY THE HARPING OF
ASSETS. ALSO FOR THE ABILITY TO
PURSUE RENEWABLE ENERGY
ALTERNATIVES THAT THEY WERE
ASKED TO BUILD THE DO WE GIVE
THEM ENOUGH ROOM. WELL I AS I
SAID I'VE BEEN THERE SINCE
AUGUST SIXTEENTH SO I HAVEN'T
BEEN AWARE OF ALL PROCEEDINGS
BEFORE US BUT I WOULD GENERALLY
SAY YES WE THEY COME BEFORE US.
AT WITH RATE CASES AND- THERE'S
A THEY PROCESS THAT WE USE. IN
THE PROCEEDINGS WITH. A LOT OF
INTERACTION WITH THE WITH THE
PUBLIC IN PUBLIC ADVOCATES. AND
THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND SO FORTH THAT
COME THEIR CUSTOMERS- AND COME
THROUGH THAT PROCEEDINGS WITH
SOMETHING THAT IS THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO BE SAFE RELIABLE AND
AFFORDABLE. I DON'T KNOW IF MY
COLLEAGUES LIKE TO ADD ANYTHING
LESE A TO THE- ORGAN. SO THEN
LAST QUESTION OF MISTER GELLER
DO G. WE JUST APPROVED THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED. A NEW
FEET PER CELL PHONES TO MAKE
SURE THAT NINE ONE ONE WOULD BE.
THERE AND IT NEXT GEN IS IT IS
IT NEXT GEN NINE ONE ONE IT'S
THAT INTERNET BASED. YES IT IS
SO ARE WE GOING TO HAVE TO RELY
ON. ITS MESSAGE WE VISIT MISS
BECHER'S RECOMMENDATION HAVE
BACKUP GENERATORS IN. OTHERWISE
HOW DOES YOUR SYSTEM THREE OUT
OF IT IT IS IT'S A IT'S A
REDUNDANCY IN THE SYSTEM- THAT
IS B. AS MICROWAVE AND INTERNET
BASED STATE BECAUSE THIS DATA
AND VOICE AND LOOK AT WORK
THESE THESE THESE DEVICES ARE
CURRENTLY VOICE AND- SLOWLY
MOVING OFF OF VOICE AND
EVERYTHING'S GOING TO DATA.
THAT'S THE VOICE OVER IP
PROTOCOL TO BE ABLE TO UTILIZE
THE SYSTEM THAT BAD AS A
TECHNOLOGY THAT WOULD BE AS A
SOCIETY ARE BEING PUSHED INTO
WE HAVE NO DIRECT CONTROL OVER
THAT TECHNOLOGY BECAUSE IT IS
PRIVATELY OWNED AND PRIVATELY
MANAGED WHAT WE HAVE IS WE'VE
GOT THE WORKING END OF IT RIGHT
TOWARD THE POINTY END OF THE
SPEAR I UTILIZE IT. BUT WILL
HAVE A SH PRINCES BUT WHEN WE
UTILIZE THIS DEVICE THIS
LIFESAVING CRITICAL
COMMUNICATIONSDEVICE IT HAS
RESILIENCY. BUILT INTO THE
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA. WHICH I
WOULD ALSO ARGUE EXIST IN
HURRICANE PRONE STATE IN
FLOODING PRONE STATE WARREN
CALIFORNIA IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE. ALL SORTS OF KIND OF
DISASTERS DIGEST THIS IS THE
WAY IT IS BEEN THAT WAY SINCE
THE LESSONS WE- WE MADE EIGHT.
AND THE FACT IS THAT BECAUSE WE
HAVE THIS WE NEED TO HAVE
ASSURANCE THAT THE SYSTEM IS
RESILIENT THAT MEANS THAT THE
CELL SITES. ARE HEARTENED THAT
THEY HAVE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
AROUND WHILE FIRE THEY'VE GOT
BATTERY OR FOR. BACK UP BEYOND
A FOUR HOUR TIME FRAME THAT WE
KNOW THAT THEY'RE GONNA WE
STAND PARTICULARLY NOW IT
APPEARS. THAT THE COULD GO FOR
MULTIPLE EIGHTIES WE HAVE TO
KNOW THAT THAT SYSTEM IS STATE
RESILIENT. IN THE BACK CALL THE
FOR THE LINES THERE ARE THE
WIRELINE THAT ARE MOVING THE
DATA. ARE PROTECTED SO THAT
THEY DON'T KNOW THAT OF FIRE OR
BREAK IT EARTHQUAKE THAT THE
WRAPPED IN AND MADE HARDEN.
IT'S A SIMPLE REQUESTWE'RE
ASKING TO BE ABLE TO HARDEN UP
THAT SYSTEM. AND IT'S A
PRIORITY ON THE PART OF THE
PEACE TO DO THAT AND- BECAUSE
THE ALTERNATIVE HAS AND AS
DURING THE PSP. THAT AT THE
HEAT OF THE MOMENT WHILE WE
WERE TRYING TO KEEP THE SYSTEM
OPERATIONAL. THE TELECOMS
WE'RE- GOING ALL OVER THE
WESTERN U. S. FIND A FIND
GENERATORS BY THE HOT. AND DRY
IN THE CALIFORNIA. REALIZING
WHEN THEY GOT CALIFORNIA BORDER
THAT THOSE GENERAL DID MEET AIR
QUALITY REQUIREMENTS AND IN
REQUIRED THE STATE BACK TO MY
OFFICE TO STREAMLINE THAT
PROCESS TO BE ABLE TO GET THEM
INTO THE STATE WHICH TOOK
ACTION ON OUR PART AND THEN
THERE FIND THE PLACE WHERE THEY
WERE GONNA GO PUT THOSE
GENERATORS. THAT'S NOT THE WAY
TO THAT'S REACTIVE AND NOT
PROACTIVE AND WHAT WE WANT TO
DO IS WE TO OUR PARTY WITH
THEM. I IDENTIFY IN A PROACTIVE
WAY HOW DO WE MAKE THE SYSTEM
BETTER BECAUSE THE ENHANCED BY
ONE ONE SYSTEM THAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT THAT DID YOU HELPING TO
FIND IS GOT NOW ALL THE
TECHNOLOGY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE MS RESILIENT IN A IN A BAD
PART OF THE SYSTEMS GET RESERVE
INTO BIG DISASTER. THANK YOU
YOU MISTER. YOU KNOW IT SEEMS
THAT A COMMON THEMES. TODAY AND
WE I DON'T THINK WE REALLY
TOUCHED ON IN DEPTH BUT WE'VE-
TALKED ABOUT NEW TECHNOLOGIES
HELPING TO CREATE THE CIRCUITS
THAT CUT OFF A WIRE. A COUPLE
CA KIND OF FOUR'S
ELECTRICITY ONCE THAT WIRES
SNAPPED IN AN EVENT. TALKED
ABOUT OF THOSE PROVIDING PEOPLE
WITH THE GENERATOR'S AT A TIME
WHEN WE CAN ALL AGREE CHEN USE
GENERATORS ARE VERY HARD TO
COME BY AT SUCH AN ASSET THAT
IT'S VERY HARD TO ME YOU HAVE
TO FEEL THAT YOU HAVE TO
DELIVER IT YOU HAVE TO. GET IT
OPERATIONAL. MAN AS WE TALK
ABOUT A TECHNOLOGY I RECENTLY
ATTENDED A NEST TEACHING THE
SUPPLIER- A CONFERENCE WHERE
THEY'RE TRYING TO SOLICIT. THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO COME UP WITH
SOLUTIONS TO SOME OF THESE YOU
KNOW ENERGY TO DELIVERY- GOALS
THAN THE THEIR FUTURE BECOMING
MORE COMPLEX THAN WE WANT. OF
NEW TECHNOLOGY TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEMS OF TODAY IN THE FUTURE
AND IT JUST SEEMS TO ME ONE WE
HAVE. BATTERY. OF PLANTS NOW
THAT EXIST IN OUR STATE THAT
ARE OF USED TO STORE POWER.
HAVE WE ALREADY HAVE A
TECHNOLOGY WERE WE HAVE BATTERY
POWERS OR POWER A POWER IN OUR
STATE JUST MAKES MORE SENSE TO
ME IF WE COULD. LOCATE ONE OF
THOSE BATTERIES. AND EITHER A
HOSPITAL OR IN THE HOME OF
SOMEBODY WHO. WHO CAN'T BE SHUT
OFF FROM POWER BECAUSE OF THEIR
URGENT NEEDS HEALTH OR WHATEVER
OTHER REASON. AND IF SOMEHOW WE
COULD LOOK THOSE IN THOSE HOUSE
IN THE NEXT YEAR IF THERE IS A
WILL PAY TO IMPLEMENT THAT AND
INCLUDE IT IN TWO. THE GOALS
THAT WE'VE OUTLINED TODAY. IT
JUST SEEMS MORE SENSE TO ME
THAT HAVING. PUTTING THEM IN A
PERMANENT LOCATION IN
ANTICIPATION OF THESE EVENTS
BUT HELP SOLVE A LOT OF THESE
LOGISTICAL POWERS THAT WE COULD
CUT OFF POWER BUT THE UTILITIES
COULD STILL CHARGING THEIR
CUSTOMERS POWERS AS A DROP
DOWN. THAT ENERGY THAT'S BEEN
STORED IN THEIR POWER IT JUST
SEEMS LIKE THEY'LL CONTINUE TO
MAKE MONEY PEOPLE CONTINUE TO
HAVE POWER. WHEN WE COULD SOLVE
THOSE THOSE GOALS WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT ALREADY EXISTS
OR. IS THAT SOMETHING THAT. YOU
THINK IS PRACTICABLE IT IS A
FEASIBLE SOMETHING THAT WE
COULD WORK ON THE SITE HERE TO
MAYBE HAVE IN PLACE BY THE
TIME. THIS AND YOU KNOW THE
NEXT SEASON COMES ALONG I THINK
AND JUSTIN IN TERMS OF A PART
OF WHAT I HEAR AND PART OF WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS THAT. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO SOLVE FOR SAFE
AFFORDABLE RELIABLE AND CLEAN
AND NOT TO CREATE FALSE
DICHOTOMY ABOUT THE EXTENT TO
WHICH SOLVING FOR ONE OF THESE.
RUNS COUNTER TO SOLVING FOR THE
OTHER ONE IN TERMS OF DIFFERENT
OPTIONS IN AND THINGS UNDER
CONSIDERATION THERE SOME REALLY
IMPORTANT WORK THAT IF YOU SEE
HAS LAUNCHED. THAT I THINK WILL
INFORM UP SOME OF THIS PART OF
IT IS AN ANALYSIS OF LOOKING
AT. YOU KNOW WHAT ACTUALLY
WOULD HAVE HOW- HAD POWER BEEN
ON BASE WITH MODELING FOR BASED
ON LINES AT THE GROUND WHAT WE
THINK WOULD HAVE HAPPENED TO
THOSE FIRES TO UNDERSTAND. AS
WE STEP BACK AND WE THINK
AROUND THE USE OF. IT'S REALLY
FOCUSED ON TRYING TO PREVENT
CATASTROPHIC FIRES NOT ANY AND
ALL FIVE SO THE PLACE THAT IT
YOU KNOW LOOKING SO TOOK TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND KIND OF WHAT WE
THINK WOULD HAVE HAPPENED.
MODELING IS IMPORTANT SOME RISK
ASSESSMENT THAT IS ALSO BEING
DONE- LOOKING AT YOU KNOW WHEN
WE LOOK AT WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS
WELL- AND WE LOOK AT THIS
MODELING OR THEIR COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE PARTICULARLY LIKELY TO
BE AFFECTED REPEATEDLY BY THESE
TYPES OF EVENTS AND THEN WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE OPTIONS.
AVAILABLE SURE. AS YOU KNOW AS
YOU IS. YOU KNOW THE COMPANIESLOOK AT MAKING THEIR
INVESTMENTS IN INFRASTRUCTURE
AND OTHER PARTS. HOW DO YOU
MAKE SURE THAT YOU MAKE THOSE
SPECIMENS IN THE PLACES THAT
ARE. GET THE BEST BANG FOR THE
BUCK AND JUST LIKE IN THIS PSP
A CEMENT. THERE WAS A FOCUS ON
FREE FOR THE PLACES WHERE AS-
AS DIRECTOR GO DUTY TALKS ABOUT
THE CASCADING ABOUT EMERGENCIES
SO FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF THE KEY
AREAS OF FOCUS- FOR- YES WAS
LOOKING AT. WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH- WITH THE REFINERY WHAT'S
HAPPENING WATER TREATMENT
PLANTS WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
THE PLACES WHERE IF THEY LOSE
POWER AND WE DON'T HAVE A BACK
UP. THEN IT RESULTS IN ANOTHER.
MENTAL CHALLENGE AT THE BACK
AND WE CAN IT AND END UP WITH
RELEASES INTO WATER INTO OUR
WATER SOURCES IT CETERA. FLYING
THAT SAME KIND OF ANALYSIS TO
FIGURING OUT HOW TO PRIOR. AS A
HARDENING BECAUSE. HOW
DECISIONS GET MADE PART OF THIS
IS AROUND HOW DO YOU MITIGATE.
HOW DO YOU MITIGATE RISK IN THE
POTENTIAL OF THE LOCATION OF
PRE POSITIONING RESOURCES
BECAUSE- PREVENTING A FIRE. BUT
CAN BE VERY QUICKLY PUT OUT- IS
DIFFERENT THAN PREVENTING A
FIRE. IN AN AREA WHERE IT'S
GOING TO BE HARDER TO FIGHT IT
WHERE WE YOU KNOW WHERE IT'S
GOING TO HAVE PREVENTING A FIRE
OUTSIDE OF A LARGE URBAN AREA
VERSUS PREVENTING A FIRE.
OUTSIDE IN AN AREA THAT'S NOT
THE SPARSELY POPULATED. NOT ALL
THE SAME THING AND THAT'S SOME
OF THE IMPULSES THAT. THAT IS
UNDER WAY. IS REALLY LOOKING
AT. WHAT WHAT WHERE IS IT YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT IS THE RISK.
ANALYSIS ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
DATA WHAT ARE THE INVESTMENTS
THAT ARE GOING TO MAKE THE
BIGGEST CHANGE AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE HOW DO YOU LOOK AT YOU
KNOW THIS IS A COMMUNITY THAT
IS GOING TO BE REPEATEDLY
IMPACTED AND WHAT IS THE-
SOLUTION AND THAT IS PART OF.
YOU KNOW THAT IS PART OF WHAT
EVERYONE HERE IN MANY PEOPLE
NOT ERE ARE WORKING ON- A PART
OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN CHARGED WITH
IS LOOKING AT. WHAT IS A GRID
OF THE FUTURE NEED TO LOOK LIKE
TO SUPPORT OUR CLEAN ENERGY
TOOLS- HOW DO WE NEED TO- AND
HOW DO WE- HOW DO WE GET TO A
GRID THAT IS MORE RESILIENT
TRANSMISSION AND THAT IS MORE
RESULTS. IN LIGHT OF WHERE WE
ARE IN IN IN- CLIMATE CHANGE
AND HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT WE
SAW FOR ALL OF THESE. OUTLINED
AND WE DON'T THE SENSE OF
THERE'S A FALSE DICHOTOMY OR
FULL CHOICES BUT WE REALLY LOOK
AT ONE OF THE BEST SOLUTIONS TO
DEPLOY AGAINST THESE CHALLENGES
IN A WAY THAT'S GOING TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA A- SAFER. CLEANER.
MAKE OUR ENERGY MORE AFFORDABLE
OVER TIME. THANK. CENTER
NIELSEN. OKAY CENTER MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH RESEARCH HERE
I'M GONNA START WITH THIS PHOTO
AND JUST QUICKLY IN THIS BILL
THAT'S ABOUT WHERE YOU'RE JUST
TALKING TO BE HEARD- SCO
PACIFIC GAS ELECTRIC TODAY SAY
THAT TEN YEARS IS ACCEPTABLE
COULDN'T PIN DOWN I'M LINE-
RIGHT. GREAT HARDENING. PAGE
MANAGEMENT AS WELL AS
MODERNIZATION. SIX TO NINE
MONTH PLAN WHICH A SOON PART OF
WHAT YOU JUST SAID FITS INTO
THIS. IF YOU CAN JUST BRIEFLY
TOUCH ON IT. WHERE YOU WANT TO
BE ABLE TO BE NEXT FIRE SEASON
I THINK IT'S THE SIZE AND SCOPE
OF THESE OUTAGES. TALK ABOUT.
THE TIMELINE THAT TEN YEAR
TIMELINE. I KNOW IT'S NOT
ACCEPTABLE TO YOU AT TO THE
GOVERNOR KEAN THIS BRIEF
COMMENT ON THAT PLEASE. WELL I
THINK- I THINK IN TERMS OF THE
TIME LINE- AND I THINK THE
GOVERNOR HAS BEEN VERY CLEAR
YOU'VE BEEN VERY CLEAR WE
CANNOT HAVE ANOTHER YEAR LIKE
THIS YEAR- AND WE- AND WE HAVE
TO BE LOOKING AT. OUR GOALS IN
OUR PROGRESS IN A MATTER OF
DAYS WEEKS MONTHS AND NOT. WITH
WITH WHAT IS IT HAS TO HAPPEN
AT EVERY POINT IN TIME BETWEEN
NOW AND NEXT- FIRE SEASON- IN
TERMS OF. IT IN TWO TWO AND
THAT. THE FOR THE FOCUS IS ON
HOW WE'RE GOING TO BE A FOR
HOWARD CLEANER HOW WE'RE GOING
TO BE MORE AFFORDABLE THE-
IDIOT STEPS THAT ARE UNDER WAY.
AS I A IS A IS A PRISON BUDGET
HAS SPOKEN TO THERE ARE THERE
IS BOTH THE WITH THE WORK ON
THE INVESTIGATION THE
INVESTIGATION REFORM-
INFORMING. REVISED PROTOCOLS
THEY REALLY TAKE A BROADER LOOK
AT PUBLIC SAFETY NOT JUST
FOCUSED ON. THE RISK OF CAUSING
A WILDFIRE ALSO RECOGNIZING
THAT THERE ARE LIVES ON EVERY
SIDE OF THE ANGLE HERE AND-
THESE DECISIONS REALLY NEED TO
BE. GETTING INTO ACCOUNT THE
IMPACT ON PUBLIC SAFETY MORE
BROADLY- THERE IS THE WORK THE
ANALYSIS OF THEIR MENTION
AROUND THE RISK ASSESSMENT. AND
UNDERSTANDING. WHAT COMMUNITIES
ARE MOST AT RISK. THERE ARE-
THERE IS A LOT OF WORK UNDER
WAY ON. WHAT IS IT YOU YOU
ESTABLISHED ALL OF THE GOALS-
FOR- TEN FIFTY FOUR AND FOUR P.
JEANNIE COMING OUT OF
BANKRUPTCY. YOU ARE WORKING. AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE TO BRING-
MORE SPACE. TO WHAT WE THINK
THOSE GOALS MIGHT MEAN AND AT
THE END THE P. B. WILL MAKE ITS
DETERMINATION AROUND. WHAT IS A
NOR TIONAL STRUCTURE THAT IS
NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A
SAFE. OTHER WE HAVE UTILITY
THAT IS GOING TO OPERATE
SAFELY- AND- WHAT WHAT IS THE
GREAT NEEDS TO LOOK LIKE WHAT
IT WHAT IS THE OPERATIONAL
STRUCTURES CAN BE MORE NIMBLE
SO IT'S ALL IT'S ALL OF THOSE
ARE. WORK ON THE WAY KEY TIME
LINES. THANK IN THE THEY KNOW
THE JANUARY TIME LINES AS- YOU
SEE YOU THE JUNE THIRTIETH
TIMELINE IS A CRITICAL TIME-
AREA AND WE'RE WORKING ON. IT
AND YOU KNOW THAT THERE'S THE
FIRST STEPS IN BETWEEN NOW AND
THEN AND WE'RE WORKING ON ALL
OF THEM HOPEFULLY THAT ANSWERS
THE QUESTION YEAH. WITH THE
FALL OF BUT I THINK THE OTHER
PIECE THAT I HAVE SOME REAL
CONCERN ABOUT JUST BEING CANDID
ABOUT AS WE TALKED ABOUT WHEN.
THE CEOS WORK HERE IS IT BE
NEAR PERFORMANCE METRICS INTO
LAW. HIS CAN'T BE THE ONLY WAY
TO. GET OUT OF THIS MESS. A IS
MAKING SURE THAT THERE ARE
STANDARDS THAT ARE ADOPTED.
WHETHER THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION LEVEL. LEGISLATIVE
LEVEL SIGNED INTO LAW BY THE
GOVERNOR- AND HAVING THE
PERFORMANCE INDEXES. SO THAT.
RESIDENTS KNOW. EXACTLY HOW
WE'RE HOLDING IN PARTICULAR
CHENEY ACCOUNTABLE. FOR THEIR
ACTIONS IN THEIR INVESTMENT.
ANY WE NEED TO GET AWAY FROM
THE BIG DISCUSSIONS ABOUT.
THIRTY BILLION. IN TO BILLION.
TALKING ABOUT. MILES A MONTH
THIS CAN BE MODERNIZE. WHAT'S
GOING TO BE DEPLOYED ON THE
MILES OF LINE. HOW MANY MILES A
LINE WILL BE HARD PER YEAR-
KEEP GOING DOWN THE LINE RIGHT
BECAUSE THIS IS BE HONEST. I
DON'T FULLY UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
HELL THEY'RE GOING- ANALLY
GOING WHERE THEY'RE GOING. SURE
THEY UNDERSTAND WHERE THEY'RE
GOING. BY AND I THINK THAT WE
OWE IT TO CALIFORNIANS HAD TO
BE ABLE TO PUT THIS
PERFORMANCE. INDEX INTO WHAT
I'D LIKE TO JUST QUICKLY MISTER
CHAIR. AND TWO AT THE DIRECTOR
OF THE OFFICE EMERGENCY
SERVICES. AND I WANT TO SEE
THANK YOU. TO THE DIRECTOR FOR
EVERYTHING HE'S BEEN DOING-
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS AT.
AND WORK WITH HER. THIRTY
THOUSAND FOOT LEVEL HAS SOME
CONCERNS IN REGARDS TO
COMMUNITY RESOURCE. AND WHERE I
AM DEEPLY CONCERNED IS THAT WE
HAVE TO DRILL DOWN. AND
ESPECIALLY WITH A COLD WEATHER
EVENT ESPECIALLY IT'S COMING UP
FOR THE CAN ANOTHER A POWER
SHUT OFF WE HAVE TO DO WHAT IT
TAKES AND- I REALLY DON'T GIVE
TWO FLIPS I DON'T THINK YOU
GIVE TO FLIPS ABOUT HOW IT GETS
DONE BUT WE NEED TO FORCE. IN
PARTICULAR PACIFIC GAS ELECTRIC
BILL TO HAVE THEIR THE
RESOURCES DEPLOYED. INTO THE
COMMUNITIES. CAN YOU TALK ABOUT
DRILLING DOWN TODAY AND NE OF
THE WORD YOU'RE MOUTH I THINK
THAT'S BEEN A BIT OF A
FRUSTRATION ABOUT. GETTING THE
DETAILS AND GETTING THOSE
DETAILS TO. POINT AND PUT INTO
ACTION. WELL THE- THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION I'M I MEAN THAT
THE ISSUE WITH THE- COMMITTEE
RESEARCH THAT IS I THINK IT'S
JUST- SORT OF A- A SYMPTOM OF
THE LARGER SET OF. THE DETAILS
THAT ARE IMPORTANT WHEN YOU'RE
DEALING WITH MANAGING. THAT'S
REALLY WHAT THIS IS RIGHT THE
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF IS
A DISASTER IT COULD BE AN
ALLERGY A CYBER TACTICS OUT THE
POWER GRID AND ALL THE
COMMUNICATIONS THAT'S IN
ESSENCE WHAT WE HAD BUT WE
ACTUALLY DID AND WE KNEW DOING
IT RIGHT. THEN YOU THROW IN
THAT WHILE FIRES AND AN
EARTHQUAKE IN A REFINERY FIRE
YEAH HAPPENING AT THE SAME
TIME. SO SHOULD WE TALK ABOUT
METRICS AND YOU TALK ABOUT THE
MEASUREMENT- THAT IN THE DETAIL
AND YO CAN REALLY EFFECTIVELY
BUILD AND CAN PLAN- WITH WITH-
ACHIEVABLE OBJECTIVES PER
OPERATIONAL PERIOD WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING THE DETAILS SO
DRILLING DOWN TO EXACTLY WHERE
THOSE COMMUNITY RESOURCE
CENTERS ARE GOING TO BE WHAT
IT'S GOING TO BE IN THEM HOW
OFTEN- AND WHAT IS THE
ASSURANCE THAT THE ICE WILL BE
DELIVERED. GIVEN THE FACT THAT
IN. FIVE DAY PS PS EVENT ALL
THE ICE IN CALAVERAS COUNTY IS
NOW GONE BECAUSE THERE'S NO
FREEZER CAPACITY AND THEY SAY
THEY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH I CAN'T
GET ICE. TO GO TO THE COMMUNITY
RESOURCE CENTERS DOES THAT
ANSWER IT DOES NOT MEET THE
METRIC. WE GET ICE AT THAT
CENTER SOUL BACK WE ARE JOB
REALLY IS TRY TO IDENTIFY THOSE
GAPS AND FILL THOSE GAPS AND
THEN AND THEN YOU KNOW. LEAN IN
ALL WITH P. JEANNIE IN THIS
CASE TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTERS HAVE
THE RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED
THAT THAT ADDRESS TO THE
DETAILS AND IF THEY CAN'T DO IT.
HELP THEM GET THERE AND THAT'S
IN ESSENCE WHAT WE DID ON THIS
LAST GO AROUND BUT THERE EAT
THEIR UNDERSTANDING OF INCIDENT
MANAGEMENT. NEEDS TO CHANGE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN YOU'RE
RUNNING A MAJOR DISASTER
OPERATION DETAIL MATTER AND YOU
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT IT FROM NOT
A THIRTY THOUSAND FOOT VIEW.
BUT UP FROM ON THE GROUND IN
THAT'S ONE REASON IT TALKS
ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
REIMBURSEMENT OF LOCAL
EMERGENCY MANAGERS. FIRE
DEPARTMENTS POLICE DEPARTMENTS
SHERIFF'S OFFICES BECAUSE- IT'S
NOT HAPPENING. THE NEED DOESN'T
STOP AFTER EIGHT PM. THIS IS
WELL SO I THINK THAT'S THE
OTHER PIECE THAT WE NEED TO BE
FOCUSING ON IS A PRIOR TO THE
LIGHTS GOING OUT. IF THEY NEED
TO GO OUT. AT THAT WE HAVE
STANDARDS IN PLACE SO THAT THE
PUBLIC IS WHAT RESOURCES
AVAILABLE MY LAST ITEM IS ON.
CELL TOWERS. SO AS YOU HEARD MR
DIRECTOR WE MET WITH
TELECOMMUNICATION
REPRESENTATIVES EARLIER IN THE
YEAR. A TOTAL IS THE WORST CASE
SCENARIO WOULD NOT HAVE. SO NOW
WE'VE GONE THROUGH THE WORST
CASE SCENARIO WHERE I BELIEVE
WE ABOUT SIXTEEN HUNDRED SITES
DOWN ACROSS CALIFORNIA. EIGHTY
SIX THOUSAND LAND IS OUT. A
SCRAMBLE TO BE ABLE TO BRING IT
GENERATORS FROM TEXAS THEY
DIDN'T THE DEADLINE. AND.
CANDIDLY NO STANDARDS IN PLACE
AS A MATTER PRESENT YOUR IT IS
TALKING ABOUT. WOULD YOU SAY
THIS IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
GAPS- WHEN IT COMES TO PUBLIC
SAFETY OF NOT BEING ABLE TO
HAVE YOU SEE YOURSELF PHONE-
AND AT YOUR THOUGHT. PLEASE.
WELL I'M JUST AGREE WITH YOU ON
THAT THAT'S THAT'S ALWAYS I
MEAN IT'S. PLEASE IT WILL WE
ARE AS A SOCIETY THE END OF
THIS IS THE ONLY OPTION. NO
MORE LAND LINES THERE'S NO MODE
DIAL UP SERVICE THAT'S GOING
AWAY EVERYTHING'S GOING TO DATA.
THESE ARE WONDERFUL FANTASTIC
CRITICAL THINGS AND IF WE'RE
GOING TO DEPEND ON A FOR
EVERYTHING WE HAVE TO KNOW THAT
THEIR WORK AT ALL TIMES
BECAUSE- NOW EVERYTHING FROM.
BEING ABLE TO COMMUNICATE TO
TRACKING YOUR MEDICAL RECORDS
EVERYTHING IS ON THESE DEVICES
AND IT'S VERY CRITICAL THAT
THEIR OPERATIONAL. AND THAT YOU
CAN MOVE THAT DATA BACK AND
FORTH. AND THAT HOSPITALS CAN
GET RECORDS WHEN THEY NEED IT
OR YOU KNOW JAILS CAN. CAN BOOK
AND YOU KNOW DEAL PRISONERS AND
WHATEVER ELSE THE CASE MAY BE
SO- IT IS A WEAK LINK- AT.
THEIR SYSTEM AND IT'S SOMETHING
WE AS WERE. UP EATING THE- THE
POWER GRID IN THE UTILITY
SYSTEM WE NEED TO EQUALLY
UPGRADE THE SELL SIDE GET. MAKE
IT HARDER. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR. RIGHT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRPERSON. THANK THIS
PANEL FOR THE INTER AGENCY
COORDINATION AND- THE
GOVERNOR'S OBVIOUSLY. BLOWN UP
A LOT OF SILENCE AND I'M JUST
INCREDIBLY IMPRESSED AT OF THE
CHALLENGES ARE GONNA BE
DAUNTING HERE AND I'M- SOME
AREAS WHERE WE WERE TO REMAIN
FRUSTRATED AFTER WORK THROUGH.
THINGS BUT THE INTER AGENCY
COORDINATIONIS NOTEWORTHY.
THREE QUICK QUESTIONS ONE FOR
PRESIDENT BOETTCHER. TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW YOU INTEGRATE
YOUR PIECE TO OF THE P. S. P.
S. PLANNING INTO YOUR WILD-
MITIGATION PLANNING TIME LINE
SO THERE IS YOU'VE GOT A SORT
OF EXPEDITED TRACK OF THIS P.
S. P. S. O. I. ARE GOING ON.
AND WHAT'S UNDERLYING MY
QUESTION IS I'M WORRIED THAT A
DATE LIKE SATURDAY AND SUNDAY
AND I'M WORRIED THAT. A JUNE
NEXT. YEAR TIMELINE FOR
UPDATING THE WILD FIRE
MITIGATION LANDS ACT. SO HOW
CAN WE FIND IT. SORT OF AN
EXPEDITED CHUNK EVEN AN INTERIM
COMPONENT OF THE WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS THAT JUST
ADDRESS P. S. P. S. PERHAPS ONE
OF THE VERY NEAR TERM BASIS SO
THAT WE CAN. SORT OF. START
MOVING CRITICAL SERVICES OUT
THE DOOR RIGHT NOW- SO I JUST
WANNA GET YOURS SENSE OF HOW.
IF THERE TO WAIT A- I THINK THE
LAW GIVES YOU ALL SOME
DISCRETION TO NOT JUST GOING TO
ONE YEAR IN A THREE YEAR TIME
LINE BUT ON SOMETHING MORE
TRUNCATED FOR A FOR THIS
SMALLER DISCRETE PIECE BUT- I
WANT TO GET A SENSE OF IF THERE
WAS OPEN THIS TO THAT AND TRY
TO GET SOME. SO THERE'S
DEMONSTRABLE PROGRESS EVEN
BEFORE THE END OF THIS YEAR
BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE GONNA
HAVE. A SERIES OF INCIDENTS.
GOING ON A HOLIDAY SEASON. WELL
AS I HAD. THANK YOU SENATOR AS-
HAD MENTIONED EARLIER- RIGHT
AWAY WE CALLED AN EMERGENCY.
MEETING AND THAT WAS FOR THE
PURPOSES. ASKING GINNY
SPECIFICALLY. WHAT THEY HAD
DONE WHY THEY HAD DONE IT AND
FRANKLY WHY THEY HADN'T DONE IT
BETTER. AND THAT WAS- BEFORE
THE EVENTS IN LATE OCTOBER THAT
WAS A FOR TWINS. AND I DO THINK
THAT SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WERE BROUGHT UP THAT WERE THEIR
SHORTCOMINGS THE C. R. LACUS
YOUR SEATS AND THE LACK OF THE
WEB'S. TANNING THE LACK OF
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THE TRIBES.
THINGS THAT FRANKLY AT THE TIME
AND I REPEATED SEVERAL TIMES
ARE. IF YOU'RE AN EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT OR IF YOU'RE IN
EVENT PLANNING FOR GOODNESS
SAKE THESE ARE FAIRLY. EASY
THINGS THAT YOU THINK OF AHEAD
OF TIME AND YOU DO WELL AHEAD
OF TIME YOU'RE NOT DOING IT AT
THE MOMENT CRISIS. SO THAT WAS
WELL POINTED OUT- TO- P.
JEANNIE I DO AND THEY ADMITTED.
IT WE ARE TRACKING THEIR
IMPROVEMENT WEEKLY. I'M THEY
ARE AS I ALSO MENTIONED WE HAVE
A SHOW CAUSE HEARING COMING UP
I DON'T KNOW THAT WILL IMPROVE
THEIR ACTIVITIES I THINK OF
JUST BRING OUT A VERY. A
TRAINED LIGHT ON THE SITUATION
AND HAVE THEM DEFEND WHY THEY
SHOULDN'T BE SIGNED SANCTIONED
HER FIND AT THE- MORE
SPECIFICALLY. FOR BRINGING
THEM. IN BEFORE THE COMMISSION
THE REGULATOR. AS A PRIVILEGED
A LICENSE AND CITY AND
EXPLAINING WHAT THEY HAD DONE
AND WHY AND WHAT WE REFER TO
IMPROVE IN REAL TIME I DO THINK
THERE WERE IMPROVEMENTS MADE
BUT EVENT AN EVENT TO IN
OCTOBER. ARE THEY A 100% BETTER.
THAT'S ALL THAT WE HAVE TALKED
ABOUT WHAT IT WHAT I HOPE TO DO
AND WHAT THE GOVERNOR IS DOING
IS MAKING SURE THAT THE FIRE
SEASON. THIS YEAR LOOKS NOTHING
LIKE WHAT WE SAW ON OCTOBER IN
TERMS. THE USE AN
IMPLEMENTATION OF PS PS SO TO
ANSWER YOU DIRECTLY I THAT THE
REGULATORY SYSTEM IS NOT REALLY
ESTABLISH OR SET UP. ACT
QUICKLY I THINK WE PROBABLY ALL
AGREE ON THAT UNFORTUNATELY.
BUT WHAT WE CAN DO IS THE
REGULATOR SHINE A BRIGHT LIGHT
ON WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND WHAT
THEY'RE NOT DOING AND WHAT THEY
NEED TO BE DOING IF I CAN READ
BETWEEN THE LINES THEN. WE WANT
EXPEDITED ACTION AND FOR PEOPLE
NOT TO GO SPEND THEIR CHRISTMAS
BONUS ON A DIESEL GENERATOR
THAT MIGHT LIKE THEIR HOUSE ON
FIRE AND POLLUTE THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD- AND INSTEAD STATE
TRY TO. SPEND MONEY SAY ON. YOU
KNOW SOME SOLAR MOBILE BATTERY
OR SOME OTHER WAY TO KEEP THEIR
GRANDPARENTS SAFE. I MEAN THE
NEAR TERM THESE ARE LIKE THIS
WEEK DECISIONS. THE FLOW THAT
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A
BACKUP POWER MONEY THAT WENT ON
AN EXPEDITED BASIS WE GOT GOING
THROUGH HELLO YES. MIGHT BE A
MORE EXPEDITIOUS WITH A TO GET
DOLLARS OUT THE DOOR GET
RESOURCE PLAY. FROM A NON RATE
PAYER BASE- IF WE WANT TO GET
SOMETHING GOING IN THE NEAR
TERM- I DO STILL WONDER WHERE
THE UTILITIES. ON ON THE SHARED
FOLDER SIDE CAN STEP UP AND PUT
SOME MONEY FORWARD AND SORT OF
MEET THE STATE HALFWAY. PROVIDE
SOME INCENTIVES- STATE GET THAT
TEAM HUNDRED DOLLAR THOUSAND
WHAT SYSTEM HOW TO THE PLACES
THAT THE CHAIRMAN. MENTIONED
RIGHT NOW FIND AT SAID. GOLLY
VERY- ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED. ALL
THE SITES THAT YOU'VE BEEN
DOING THE CHECKING UP ON. HOW
MANY PEOPLE IS THA IN THAT
UNIVERSE WOULD YOU SAY
STATEWIDE OF SAY EVEN JUST YOUR
LICENSE BASILIDES RIGHT NOW
THAT ARE IN THESE P. S. P. S.
OWNS I MEAN. TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE OTHER WE
TALKING A MILLION PEOPLE THE OF
IT. I KNOW YOU SAID A LOT OF
DATA AND NOT CREATE INFORMATION
GIVE A SENSE OF. HOW BIG THIS
UNIVERSE. COULD TRY TO DELIVER
SOME SOLID AND AS YOU ANSWER
THE QUESTION OF MONEY. YEAH BUT
WE'RE WE'RE TANKS TURNING INTO
AREAS WERE. BEING REDUNDANT NOT
GONNA. ASTRIDE A TRAITOR. BUT I
APPRECIATE IT IT HAS BUT- GO
AHEAD AND ANSWER THE QUESTION
IS. IF USING AND BUT WE STILL
HAVE THIRTEEN PRINT. AND WE'RE
NOT FIFTH HOUR SO SIR. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION I'LL BE
BRIEF WE ESTIMATE THAT IN THE
LAST PS PS EVENTS ABOUT
200-100-0200 FIFTY THOUSAND
IMPACTED INDIVIDUALS IN THE AYE
HSS PROGRAM. THE NUMBER
BASILIDES IN THOSE ZONES. ON
THE PUBLIC SIDE WITH THE
CAPACITY FOR TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF REST AND THEN ON THE I'M
SOCIAL SERVICES SIDE YOU HAD
NEARLY HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
FACILITIES BECAUSE THAT
INCLUDES- MANY OF THE CHILD
CARE FACILITIES THAT RUN EIGHT
TO FIVE RATHER THAN AROUND THE
CLOCK. SO IN TOTAL YOU'RE
LOOKING AT A. THOUSANDS OF
POTENTIALLY IMPACTED PEOPLE WHO
RECEIVE SERVICES THROUGH STATE
AID. THOSE THEIR WEIGHT IN
OTHER WORDS TO HONE IN THAT
UNIVERSE AND START GETTING-
SOME KIND OF BACKUP SYSTEMS
THAT ARE DIESEL GENERATORS OUT
THE DOOR BEFORE THE END OF THIS
YEAR TO THOSE PEOPLE. OWNER IN.
THIS MODEST ON TOAST. LIKE A
REASONABLE GOAL FOR US NOT
WAITING UNTIL JANUARY NEXT YEAR
BUT TRYING TO GET SOMETHING
DONE- BEFORE THE HOLIDAY. SOME
OF THE SOME OF THAT IS- IS
HAPPENING AND AS A PRISON
BADGERS. THE LEARNINGS ARE
BEING IMPLEMENTED A TIME. AND
THE WHAT IS HAPPENING ON THE
UTILITY SIDE OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE GOVERNMENT
SIDE IS CHANGING AT EVERY
CORNER AND- SOME OF THE AREA OF
FOCUS ON THE AREA OF THE
PRIORITIES ARE THESE CLICK
CRITICAL FACILITIES WHERE IF
THEY DON'T HAVE THE NECESSARY
BUT THEN YOU HAVE THESE THESE
OVERALL DOWNSTREAM EFFECTS SO-
BUT IN IN IN TERMS OF THE
BIGGER INVESTMENTS IN TERMS OF
THE OF THE LONGER TERM-
ACTIONS. I THINK SOME OF THOSE
WILL BE HAPPENING OVER TIME AND
OF THE- WHAT THE QUESTIONS THAT
WE ASK FOR THE UTILITY WAS IN
THE FOR THE POOL IN THE PLACES
WHERE THEY DEPLOYED- TECHNOLOGY
AND THEY DEPLOY GENERATION WERE
INTEREST IN WANTING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW MANY PEOPLE
ACTUALLY ACQUIRE THOSE SO THAT
WE HAVE A SENSE OF FOR THE
SOLUTIONS WHERE THEY WERE
TEMPORARY ONES IN NATURE HOW
MANY OF THOSE ARE ON. OUR OUR
LONG TERM THE OTHER PIECE THAT
I'D HIGHLIGHT IN TERMS OF WHAT
THE CAPACITY GENERATION IS IT
COULD BE THAT THE INITIAL
SOLUTION THAT GETS IMPLEMENTED
IS A DIESEL GENERATOR BUT THAT
CAN BE SWAPPED OUT WITH A
CLEANER- CLEANER SOURCE- IN
STORAGE SO PART OF THIS IS HOW
DO WE GET THE RIGHT KIND OF- OF
GRADE AND STRUCTURE IN PLACE.
HOW DO YOU GET THE GENERATION-
TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE SERVICE IN A WAY. THAT
YOU KNOW WORKS IN AND MINIMIZES
PUBLIC SAFETY IMPACTS AND THEN
OVER TIME HOW DO WE ENSURE IF
IT TAKES TIME IF IT CAN'T BE
DONE IN ONE FELL SWOOP HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE KIND
OF THE NO REGRETS INVESTMENTS
THAT CAN BE MAPPED UP WITH THE-
CLEAN INVESTMENTS TO GET US TO
WHERE WE NEED TO GO CONSISTENT
ONE OF OUR GOALS DO YOU. I MEAN
IF I'M SCRAPING TOGETHER A
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND I'M A-
CLASS FAMILY MAKING EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR LESS TO BUY
THAT DIESEL GENERATOR YOU CAN'T
SWAP THAT OUT YOU BOUGHT THAT
DIESEL GENERATOR AND THAT'S
KIND OF. SAID RIGHT I MEAN IT'S
THE FOLKS GOVERNOR VISITED SO.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU SWAP THAT
APPLE. I GUESS I THE ONE OF THE
PIECES THAT WE NEED TO WORK
TOWARDS IS HOW DO WE MINIMIZE.
THIS OF P. SPS AT ALL SO THAT
WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT A LOT OF
CALIFORNIANS GOING OUT AND
BUYING TECHNOLOGY. FOR
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE USED
SPARINGLY AND NOT AND NOT
REQUIRE YOU WOULD JUST. TAPPING
BACK MY PORTER RICO EXPERIENCE.
WE DON'T WANT CALIFORNIA TO
THINK THAT THEY'RE LIVING
IMPORTER RICO BECAUSE THEY ARE
NOT- WE HAVE A MUCH MORE
RESILIENT SYSTEM. WE HAVE- WE
CAN SEE FROM THE SAN DIEGO
EXPERIENCE THAT- THAT WE HAVE A
LOT OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF
OPTIONS THAT ARE AVAILABLE. AND
I DON'T THINK THAT WE WANT TO
CREATE THE ENVIRONMENT WHERE
FOLKS SAY. THIS THIS THIS IS
NOT A NEW NORMAL IT CANNOT BE
IT WILL NOT BE. THERE ARE
BETTER STRONGER SOLUTIONS AND I
DON'T THINK WE WANT TO I DON'T
THINK. WE WANT TO CREATE A
SENSE OF. EVERYONE FEELS LIKE
THEY HAVE TO COME UP WITH THE
WRONG SOLUTION. BECAUSE THAT'S
NOT GOING TO BE THE BEST FOR
THE ENVIRONENT IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE THE MOST SUSTAINABLE IT'S
NOT GOING TO BE THE MOST
AFFORDABLE AND IT'S NOT WHAT IS
NECESSARY. OKAY CENTER STERN
I'M GONNA MOVE TO CENTER WINTER
NOW MEGAN DRESS ONE OTHER ISSUE
THAT WASN'T THAT WASN'T BROUGHT
UP JUST VERY VERY BRIEFLY IF
YOU DON'T MIND MISTER CHAIRMAN
JUST THE FINAL. THE FINAL ONE
FOR AGRICULTURE COMMUNITY AND
ASKING. DIRECTOR DANSA. THAT'LL
ECONOMIC LOSSES. THIS ONE HAS
BEEN AGGRESSIVE. PROMISE YOU
YOU'LL BE YOU WON'T BE
DISAPPOINTED WELL. ASK YOUR
BEST YOUR QUESTION BUT- THANK
YOU. A STORY AND- UTILITY SAID.
MEDICAL AND FOOD SPOILAGE COSTS
COVERED I DIDN'T CARE ABOUT
ECONOMIC LOSSES. HAS BEEN
MONITORING THE SENATE. COMMERCE
IS CONCERNED ABOUT IT. TAKE FOR
EXAMPLE. ONE EIGHT SEVEN IN
THE- LAW ONE FORMER. US POSES
BALLY. OF FROM YES PS INCIDENT.
I TELL YOU HOW MANY MORE IN.
THE REGION BUT YOU KNOW.
THEREFORE WHEN. CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE AND STATE WHAT
CHAMBERS BEEN DOING SOME
SURVEYING. MS A CALIFORNIA IS
GOING TO CHARGE CHARTER IS
GOING TO. COMMISSION A MUCH
LARGER STUDY FOR WHAT THE
OVERALL IMPACT WAS BUT IT'S NOT
THAT GRANULAR THEY'RE ALL
ANECDOTAL AT THIS POINT. ENTER
WINNER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND I HAVE A BILL FOR
THAT SO. FOR I HAVE A- A
QUESTION FOR- PRINCE ABOUT SURE
AND- I PROMISE YOU I'M NOT A
ONE TRICK PONY- TERMS THIS
ISSUE BUT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
COVERED THE OTHER AREAS SO
SYSTEMATICALLY AND THOROUGHLY
THAT I DON'T WANT TO. RECREATE
THE WHEEL. IN TERMS OF- DODD
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES
AND ENERGY STORAGE IN
PARTICULAR AND THAT'S CHIP AND
OF COURSE DVRS AS CHIP ANSWERED
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT POWER
SHUTTLE SO I. I KNOW THIS ISN'T
JUST ABOUT YOU KNOW GETTING
PEOPLE TO MAKE INVESTMENTS FOR.
TRIAGE SITUATIONS THAT
HOPEFULLY WILL NEVER HAPPEN
AGAIN OR WILL TELL FOR A TIME-
THERE MANY MANY ADVANTAGES TO
HAVING- DECENTRALIZE-
GENERATION. ONE OF WHICH IS
DURING EMERGENCIES AND SO. BEST
TIPS IS AS YOU KNOW WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS AND WE ARE GOING TODOZEN OF US IN THE LEGISLATURE
ABOUT BY SENT YOU A LETTER AND
YOU- RESPONDED- WITHOUT MAKING
COMMITMENTS AND I GOT THAT YOU
HAVE AN ONGOING- PROCEEDING-
BUT YEAR THIS LEGISLATURE- RE
AUTHORIZE US TO. AND WITH A
CERTAIN MAXIMUM FUNDING LEVEL-
AND THE IDEA IS TO HAVE YOU
KNOW THE SONGS SEVEN YEAR
PERIOD SO THAT PEOPLE CAN RELY
ON AND THE INDUSTRY CAN LIVE
RELY ON AND WE CAN REALLY.
BECAUSE THE ENERGY STORAGE
SECTOR TO BLOSSOM AND PRICES TO
COME DOWN IN THE COLLEGE OR TO
GET BETTER AND- SO PEOPLE CAN
HAVE MORE MORE DAYS OF STORAGE
AND SO ON AND SO FORTH I KNOW
YOU UNDERSTAND THIS- ABOUT FOR
TO SUCCEED. IN OUT THE HOUSE TO
BE FUNDED AND I THINK THAT
RIGHT NOW THERE IS A AND YOU
HEARD I. SPOKE TO THAT A SEVEN
P. GINNY REPRESENTATIVES THAT
YOU KNOW THE- THE COMMISSION
PUT OUT ITS REQUEST FOR-
FEEDBACK AND PUT OUT THE IDEA
OF NOT FULLY FUNDING AND WAS A
LITTLE BIT LIKE CHIMING THE
WATERS JUST TO BE BLUNT AND ALL
OF THE I. USE CAME BACK AS IT
YEAH DEFINITELY DON'T FULLY
FUNDED. AND THEY'RE PROPOSALS-
WOULD DESTROY THE PROGRAMS MY
QUESTION TO YOU IS- WHAT DO YOU
THINK THE CPUC IS GOING TO DO.
AROUND US CHIP AND IS THE
COMMISSION COMMITTED TO MAKING
THIS A FULLY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM
BECAUSE I DO HAVE A CONCERN
THAT IF THE COMMISSION DOESN'T
FULLY FUNDED OR TAKE SOME OF
THE I. R. USE IDEAS. THE
PROGRAM WILL NOT SUCCEED IN
THAT ONE IT'S UP FOR
REAUTHORIZATION. EVERYONE'S
GOING TO SAY CITY IT'S IN SIXTY
LET'S KELLER. WELL AS YOU
STATED WE HAVE SEEN IN THE
NIGHT SO I CAN'T. PRESUME THE-
WHAT THE COMMISSION WOULD DO
THAT WOULD BE AN APPROPRIATE.
HOWEVER I KNOW THAT THE IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'VE ALSO MET WITH. MY FELLOW
COMMISSIONER- BUT IF YOU COULD
PLEASE SPEAK INTO THE MIKE AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE SORRY I KNOW
THAT YOU'VE MET WITH YOU AND I
HAVE BAD ON THIS SUBJECT AS YOU
HAVE MET WITH MY- COLLEAGUE-
COMMISSIONER WRECK SHAMAN. AND
SO WE'RE VERY AWARE AND VERY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PROGRAM
YOUR CONCERNS THOSE OF YOUR
FELLOW COLLEAGUES- WE WILL BE
IN. MAKING A DECISION I THINK
IN AND FOR THREE TO FOUR WEEKS.
OKAY SO- AND I JUST WANT TO IN
THE STRONGEST POSSIBLE TERMS
ENCOURAGE THE COMMISSION. TO
FULLY FUND THE AND YOU KNOW
THERE IS A SURPLUS IN THE FUND
ONLY BECAUSE OF THE UNCERTAINTY
THAT'S BEEN AROUND THIS PROGRAM
FOR A LONG TIME. AND I AM
CONFIDENT THAT THIS MONEY WILL
BE- ACCESS AND WE'LL SEE A
SIGNIFICANT. EXPANSION OF
STORAGE IN CALIFORNIA IF THE
COMMISSION DOES THE RIGHT THING
IN PULLING FUNDS I LISTENED
VERY CLOSELY TODAY TO YOUR
QUESTIONS AS WELL AS THE
ANSWERS ON THE I. O. U.'S SO I
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH SIR.
THANK YOU. SENATOR BILL. OF
HISTORY REAL QUICK I'M I'M MORE
INTERESTED IN THE ECONOMIC
FISCAL IMPACTS AND JUST.
GETTING ORDER BEHIND THE-
REQUESTS FROM VARIOUS MINUTES
POLICIES GOVERNMENTS FOR MONEY
FROM THE STATE GOVERNMENT THE-
ROAD TO THIS ISSUE AND I THINK
WE HAVE TO HAVE SOME KIND OF.
COST ESTIMATOR OR THERE'S BEEN
SOME MODELING DONE ON THAT I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE HAVE SOME CONSISTENT. HEROES
NOT OFF THE CUFF CHI REPROACH.
TO GET A HANDLE ON THAT ISSUE I
JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT
STATEMENT SO I KNOW THERE'S
SOME MODELING INTERRUPTION COST
ESTIMATORS THERE'S ALL KINDS
OF- ECONOMIC. OF WAYS OF DOING
THAT AND IT WOULD BE VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE GET IT DONE
IN A SYSTEMATIC WAY SO WE GET A
HANDLE ON THAT WE CAN. YOU KNOW
WE WANT TO BE FAIR WE DON'T
WANT A- HAVE ONE GROUP SAY WELL
YOU GAVE THEM A LOT OF MONEY
BUT NOT THIS GROUP AND- THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS REGARDING.
POWER OUTAGE- COST TO
MUNICIPALITIES OKAY SO I JUST
WANT TO SIT IS THAT POSSIBLE IS
THAT. IS THAT A DOABLE ASK ME
IN THE MAKE RESPOND TO THAT
QUESTION FIRST. THE EXISTING
MODELS TO DO THAT OUR MODELS
YEAH THEIR MODELS. THAT
BERKELEY'S LIVERMORE YEAH RIGHT
THERE'S A STANFORD ONE AND
STANFORD WAS RELYING ON THAT
MODEL TO DO THEIR OWN
ESTIMATES. THEIR MDELS AND
SOPHIE ONE ACTUAL ASSESSMENTS
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO DO MORE
STAFF COMPLETE. NERVOUS ABOUT
WHAT THE REAL COSTS- COOLEY-
LAWRENCE LIVERMORE RIGHT EXACT
AS A MODEL IN. OKAY SO THEN THE
OTHER QUESTION I HAD WAS SO.
THE SCENARIO OF FARM. THAT I
PREFER AND WHEN I LOOK AT THESE
THINGS SO. I LOOK AT TEN YEAR
WHEN THEY SAY TEN YEARS THAT
MEANS NOTHING TO MAKE US TEN
YEARS TO FOR A RISE AND IT'S.
YOU KNOW I'M USED TO
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS LIKE ON A
WORKING ENVIRONMENT SO TEN
YEARS ISLIKE SAYING YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO DO IT AND WE DON'T
KNOW WHEN WE'RE GOING TO DO IT.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE. IT IS A
MEANINGLESS STATEMENT OKAY. SO
THAT'S WHY I SAY THREE YEARS.
AND WE HAVE A SCENARIO
DEVELOPED WHERE- ALL THE
EQUIPMENT CAN BE. WORKED ON IN
THREE YEARS AND THEN IN
ADDITION TO THAT ISSUE. GETTING
BACK TO THE MODELING- WHEN YOU
LOOK AT- REDUCING REDUCING THE
POWER INTERRUPTION AND REDUCING
THE COST OF THAT WILL HAVE A
POSITIVE ECONOMIC AFFECT ON
CALIFORNIA IF WE CAN CUT THAT
TEN YEARS DOWN TO THREE YEARS
AND HOW DO WE HOW DO WE
ENCOURAGE. THAT SCENARIO FROM
AN ECONOMIC STANDPOINT I KNOW
THE MODEL I KNOW. WHAT I'VE
STUDIED IN TERMS OF THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT OF THIS IS NOT
SO MUCH ONE ERUPTION DEBTS THE
REPEATED ON GOING YEAR AFTER
YEAR AFTER YEAR OF
INTERRUPTIONS WHEN THE-
BUSINESSES SORT OF TIRE OF THIS
THE- INSURANCE COMPANIES TIRE
OF THIS AND ALSO A NEW ECONOMY
IS. JUST OVER TIME THE
INTERRUPTION JUST HAS A HUGE.
IT IMPACT IN TERMS OF THE
ECONOMY IN CALIFORNIA SO LOOK
AT THE NEXT I'M LOOKING AT A
TEN YEAR DECADE OF THAT THAT'S
NOT GOING TO BE THAT'S NOT AN
ACCEPTABLE THING. I MEAN WE
CAN'T HAVE. THAT KIND OF.
ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES ON THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I KNOW
I REPRESENT. A MILLION PEOPLE
OF IN SILICON VALLEY- WE'RE
DOING PRETTY GOOD ON ECONOMY
BUT I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
COMPANIES THAT ARE. THEY'RE
KIND OF LOOK AT THIS AND YOU
KNOW THEY DON'T KNOW IF THEY
WANT TO CONTINUE THEIR HIGH
ENERGY USERS- THEY'RE WORRIED
ABOUT BACKUP POWER- THERE IS
PEOPLE ARE GETTING THEIR
THEY'RE NOT SAYING THEY'RE
GOING TO LEAVE BUT THEY'RE
NERVOUS ABOUT IT. THIS IS
MAKING PEOPLE VERY VERY
NERVOUS. WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
TEN YEARS THAT WAS THAT THAT
WAS- THAT HAD A NERVE TEN YEARS
THAT HIT A NERVE. SO WE HAVE TO
WE HAVE TO COME UP WITH SOME.
SCENARIOS THAT ARE. FASTER TO
FIND TO FIND OUT WHAT WE CAN DO
IT IN THREE YEARS IS THAT IS
THAT A SOONER WE CAN- LOOK OUT
BECAUSE OTHERWISE IT WOULD IT
SEEMS TO ME HAVE PRETTY. HUGE
MAGNITUDE FISCAL AND ECONOMIC
IMPACT ON CALIFORNIA A LOT OF
JOBS WILL BE LOST YOU KNOW
WE'RE TALKING. A LOT OF THINGS
HAPPENING. I WOULD THOSE THIRTY
RESPONSE TO THAT- JUST SAY
UNDERSTOOD AND AGREED- HI TO WE
AND THAT'S PART OF WHY ARE
FOCUSING CHARGE IS AROUND WHAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN NEXT WEEK NEXT
MONTH IN THE NEXT THREE MONTHS
THE NEXT THE- IN THE NEXUS SIX
NINE MONTHS TO ASSURE THAT NEXT
YEAR IS NOT THIS YEAR OF THE
YEAR AFTER THAT IS BETTER THAN
THE YEAR BEFORE- BECAUSE THE
DISRUPTIVE EFFECT THE
UNCERTAINTY ALL OF THOSE THINGS
ARE A CHALLENGE FOR- OTHER
CHALLENGE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
ARE ON ACCEPTABLE AND- AND WE
NEED TO. WORK TOWARDS MAKING
THE CHANGES ARE YOU KNOW
CULTURAL- ORGANIZATIONAL-
INFRASTRUCTURE WAS THAT NEED TO
OCCUR TO MAKE THE USE OF PSP S.
SPARING AND- AND IDEALLY WERE
TIME FACED OUT THE NOT UNKNOWN
OR ARE YOU A SHOE IS INSURANCE
ISSUE AND AGAIN I THINK THE ONE
TIME LOOK AT ECONOMIC IMPACT.
MIGHT BE SMALL. IT MIGHT NOT BE
I DON'T KNOW OF BUT THE
REPEATED ON GOING. POWER
SHORTAGE OVER A TEN YEAR PERIOD.
AND THE AND THE COST TO THE
CONSUMER AND BUSINESS I THINK
IT'S MORE OF A COST TO BUSINESS
AND RESIDENTIAL WHEN I SAW THE
MODELS IT LOOKS LIKE THE
BUSINESS IMPACT WAS MUCH DOLLAR
WISE A BIGGER. A BIGGER IMPACT.
IF WE HAVE THIS ON A REPEATED
BASIS OVER A LONG PERIOD OF
TIME. OF THAT WOULD HAVE A HUGE
A MUCH BIGGER ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCE OF MY RIGHT IN
TERMS OF THE COST TO INSURANCE
AND THEN AND THEN MAYBE
INSURANCE PEOPLE WITHDRAWING
FROM PROVIDING INSURANCE- TO-
OF OUR BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA
WHICH WILL. WORST BE ANOTHER
THING THAT WILL CAUSE THEM TO
WANT TO LEAVE CALIFORNIA IN
THAT SENSE. YOU ARE CORRECT THE
ONGOING AND SUSTAINED. ACTIVITY
OF THIS SORT WOULD BE REALLY
DAMAGING AND THE- SERVING THAT
WE'VE DONE OF BUSINESSES AND
VISITORS SO FAR IT HAS NOT BEEN
THAT DAMAGING BUT IF IT
CONTINUES AT ABSOLUTELY COULD
BE AND I AGREE WITH YOU. CENTER
WITH ELEMENT LIKE A SCENARIO TO
BE DEVELOPED ON A THREE YEAR
THAT'S WHAT BASE I THINK IT'S
TOO. IT WOULD HELP TOO MUCH IN
MY EAR AND I WOULD HAVE TOO
MUCH OF A CONSEQUENCE SO. AND
CENTER BELL I HOPE THAT WE CAN
DO I'M AFRAID IF YOU KEEP
SPEAKING IN A DRIVE AWAY ALL
THE BUSINESSES CALIFORNIA WELL.
I'M HERE I MET I'M GETTING MY
MIND MY CALLS FROM PEOPLE
SAYING THEY'RE VERY NERVOUS.
RIGHT NOW ALL OF. ESPECIALLY
THE HIGH ENERGY USERS ARE VERY
NERVOUS RIGHT NOW THANK YOU
CENTER BELT. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
IT TOO OKAY I'M SORRY CENTER
PRESS MIGHT VERY QUIRK- TO THE
OFFICE OF ALL YES I'M JUST
CURIOUS. AS P. JEANNIE WAS
COORDINATING WITCHER OFFICE
THEIR PS PS PROGRAM WAS THERE
ANY OBJECTION ARE PUSHED BACK
BY YOUR OFFICE WITHIN THE
THINGS THAT THEY HAD SUGGESTED
BOTH IN THE FIRST PHASE AND
SECOND. WAS THERE PUSHED BACK
BY MY OFFICE BACK INTHEM ABOUT
NOT WANTING TO DO SOMETHING AND
TRY TO SPEAK INTO THE MIKE.
PLEASE SEE CORRECTION TO OBJECT
AS TO WHAT THEY SUGGESTED. I
WOULD SAY THERE WAS ANY PUSH
BACK I THINK THAT THAT THAT
THERE WAS- I THINK IT WAS MORE
SUGGESTIONS ON ON OUR SIDE BACK
TO THEM ON BEING ABLE TO THINK
THROUGH WHAT WAS GOING TO BE
HAPPENING AS A YOU KNOW GIVEN
OUR EXPERIENCE OF UNDERSTANDING
HOW DISASTERS AND FOLD AND SEE
WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN THE
COMMUNITY GIVING THEM
RECOMMENDATIONS ON- HOW HOW
THEY COULD BE- HOW THEY COULD
ADDRESS IT AND POSITION
THEMSELVES BETTER- SUCH AS-
GENERALLY- THEY THEY SEEM TO BE
OPEN TO MOST OF THOSE THE
NECESSARY IMPLEMENT ALL OF
THEM- AND- I WOULD SAY I WOULD
SAY MORE IN THE TIME FRAME OF
THE YEAR LEADING UP TO THE PS
B. AS WE WERE WE WERE MEETING
THE WEEKLY- I PROBABLY GOT MORE
PUSH BACK FROM UTILITIES. ALL
THREE QUITE FRANKLY WITH REGARD
TO- WANTING THEM TO GET IN A
PLACE WHERE THEY WERE MORE
CONSISTENT ACROSS- ACROSS THE
BOARD BUT ACT ACTUALLY DURING
THE P. S. B. AS IN THE CASE OF
P. JEANNIE THEY WERE THEY WERE
WRAPPED THEY WERE PRETTY MUCH
OPEN TO OUR SUGGESTIONS EIGHT
INCORPORATED PRETTY MUCH ALL
YOUR SUGGESTIONS ABOUT ALL OF
THEM BUT THEY WERE YOU KNOW I
MEAN- THEY NEVER HAD UP THE
PHONE ON ME IS THAT I MEAN YOU
KNOW. THANK. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE'RE GOING ON TOUR
NEXT. OUR OUR NEXT SECTION OF
THIS- COMMITTEE HEARING IS
REGARDING THE IMPACTS ON
CALIFORNIANS. AND WE HAVE
THIRTEEN SPEAKERS THAT ARE
GOING TO SPEAK TO HOW THEY WERE
IMPACTED BY THE SHUT OFF AND
I'M GONNA ASK OF THE SPEAKERS
IF EACH. CAN ATTEMPT TO
DESCRIBE THEIR EXPERIENCES.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU CAN
HEAR ME IF YOU CAN A TO- AS YOU
COME FORWARD I'D LIKE TO ASK
YOU TO- LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO
TWO MINUTES THAT'S POSSIBLE
PLEASE. WE DO HAVE THIRTY
SPEAKERS AND IF YOU COULD TO AS
MUCH POSSIBLE LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS ABOUT TWO MINUTES FOR
PRESENTATION. WE'RE GOING TO BE
IT BEGIN WITH ELDERLY ACCESS
AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS POPULATION
THE MATHEMATICALLY VULNERABLE.
AND WE HAVE- CRISTINA MILLS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS. AND
CRISTINA BUS HAMILTON
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS OF
AMERICA. FOLLOWED BY TRACY
MCBROOM THE SYSTEMS DIRECTOR OF
AN EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT. FOR
ADVENTIST HEALTH WELCOME. AND
LET ME SEE HERE WHO ELSE TO
HAVE. JIM MCCARTHY. OKAY THAT
ARE COMMON TO. ALL RIGHT WHO.
CRISTINA MILLS OKAY WELCOME
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE THANK
YOU CHAIRED THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M GONNA TRY TO SPEED
IT THROUGH MY TESTIMONY I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU GUYS
STAYING IN TAKING THIS AS
SERIOUS AS WE ARE IN THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY AGAIN I'M
CRISTINA MILLS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTER SEE A FILE SEE WE
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA'S
DISABILITY COMMUNITY RESOURCE
CENTERS KNOWN AS INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS AND OUR
MEMBERSHIP COVERS FIFTY SIX OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTERS PROVIDE ADVOCACY
ASSISTANCE IN A NUMBER OF
SPECIFIC SERVICES DIRECTLY TO
PEOPLE WITH ANY TYPE OF
DISABILITY AND EFFORT TO
EMPOWER AND SUPPORT DISABLED
PEOPLE IN OBTAINING OR
MAINTAINING THEIR INDEPENDENCE
IN THE COMMUNITY AND OUT OF
INSTITUTIONAL SETTINGS YOU WILL
HEAR DIRECTLY FROM SOME OF OUR
SEE IF I'LL SEE MEMBERS DURING
PUBLIC COMMENT ABOUT SPECIFIC
SERVICES THAT THEY PROVIDED
DURING THE OCTOBER PS PSE
THAT'S- SEE IF I'LL SEE HAS A
LONG HISTORY OF WORKING IN THE
AREA OF DISASTER READINESS AND
RECOVERY. OUR OFFICE HAS
COMMISSIONED A NUMBER OF BEST
PRACTICES AN AFTER ACTION
DISASTER REPORT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN AND HAS WORKED
IN COLLABORATION WITH STATE AND
WELL KNOWN NATIONAL DISASTER
SERVICE EXPERTS TO IMPROVE AND
INTEGRATE PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND OLDER ADULTS
WHO HAVE ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL
NEEDS IN DISASTER OVER AND OVER
AGAIN WE WITNESS THAT
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
ARE CONTINUOUSLY
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
DURING DISASTERS WHICH NOW ALSO
INCLUDE PUBLIC POWER CD SAFETY
SHUT OFFS. NATURAL DISASTERS
AND PS PS IMPACT PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES IN THE COMMUNITY
IN SIMILAR WAYS THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE AMONG
THE TWO IS THAT THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ASSIST PEOPLE
WITH ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL LEAD
SOMEWHAT IN ADVANCE OF A SHUT
OFF HOWEVER SEE IF I'LL SEE
BELIEVES THAT A MAJOR EFFORT A
LOCAL LEVEL NEEDS TO BE IN
PLACE AND MUST INCLUDE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
SERVE PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
AND OLDER ADULTS AS PART OF
THAT PROCESS DEVELOPING.
PROCESSES AND ENSURING THAT
PEOPLE WITH ACCESSIBLE. LEADS
ARE AWARE OF LOCAL SUPPORT AND
ARE PROVIDED ONE ON ONE
TRAINING TO HAVE PERSONAL
DISASTER PLANS IN PLACE IS
ESSENTIAL. WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT.
ACCESSIBLE TRANSPORTATION GAS
MONEY BACK UP ELECTRICITY
SYSTEMS BOTH BATTERIES AND
GENERATORS ACCESSIBLE SHORT
TERM HOUSING FOOD ASSISTANCE OF
ROBUST ACCESSIBLE COMMUNICATION
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT REACHES
PEOPLE WHO ARE DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING REQUIRES WELL THOUGHT
OUT PLANNING AND RESOURCES. WE
ALSO CANNOT EXPECT THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE TRAINED AND
READY ONLY NEED SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS DURING BUSINESS OUR
DAYLIGHT HOURS. THERE'S ROOM
FOR EVERYONE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
TO HAVE A ROLE DURING P. S. P.
S. OR NATURAL DISASTERS IT IS
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO SEPARATE
THE TWO BECAUSE OF HOW SIMILAR
THEY ARE. WE IMPACTING OUR
COMMUNITY ACCORDING TO THE
RECENTLY PUBLISHED REPORT FROM
THE CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL
ONE IN FOUR PEOPLE HAVE A
DISABILITY. HOW MANY OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ALSO HAVE
ELECTRICAL MEDICAL NEEDS IS
UNKNOWN AND SOMETHING WE NEED
TO DO AS IT IS SOMETHING WE
NEED TO DO TO BETTER TRACK.
WELL THE MEDICAL BASS LINE
PROGRAM THAT UTILITY COMPANIES
CURRENTLY EMPLOYMENT ONLY SERVE
A FRACTION OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
LIKELY QUALIFY AND ARE ENROLLED
WE MUST FIND WAYS TO REACH
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNAWARE OF THOSE
PROGRAMS EXISTENCE. EITHER THIS
YEAR. SORRY EARLIER THIS YEAR
SEE IF I'LL SEE ADMINISTERED A
SHORT. DISASTER PREPAREDNESS
SURVEY AND FOUND OUT OF FOUR
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS WHO
COMPLETED IT 20% OF THEM HAD
NEVER HEARD OF OR KNEW THAT THE
MEDICAL BASELINE PROGRAM
EXISTED. IN ADDITION TO THOSE
FINDINGS WE ALSO FOUND THAT 50%
OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO TOOK
OUR SURVEY USE OF MEDICAL
ELECTRIC DEVICES BUT WERE HALF
BUT ONLY HALF OF THEM WERE
PREPARED TO HAVE SOME SORT OF
PLAN IN PLACE OF THE POWER WERE
TO BE SHUT OFF. SEE IF I'LL SEE
WIDELY SHARED OUR SURVEY
FINDINGS WITH PARTNER PARTNERS
AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
ARE ACCESSIBLE FUNCTIONAL NEEDS
AND THE IT INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES. IT WAS. THROUGH
THOSE PRESENTATIONS THAT SEE IF
I'LL SEE HAS APPROACH WAS
APPROACH BY PGA NEED TO DEVELOP
A ONE YEAR PILOT. THAT WOULD
ASSIST INDIVIDUALS WITH ACCESS
AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS DURING
POWER SHUT OFFS THE MEMBERS OF
CA FILE SEED AGREED TO PROVIDE
A LETTER OF SERVICES AND
SUPPORT. HELLO SORRY PROVIDING
SUPPORTS DURING A SHUT OFF ALSO
CONTINUING TO ADVOCATE FOR LONG
TERM SOLUTIONS. LIKE
LEGISLATION ALTHOUGH A SIGNED
CONTRACT HAS NOT BEEN EXECUTED
SEE IF I'LL SEE MEMBERS HAVE
RECEIVED RESOURCES FROM P.
JEANNIE TO ASSIST DISABLED
OLDER ADULTS WITH MEDICAL
NECESSITIES THAT REQUIRE
ELECTRICITY. DURING SHUT OFFS-
I QUICKLY JUST WANT TO GO OVER
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT WERE
ASSISTING AND WATER CENTERS DID
DURING THE MONTH OF OCTOBER-
ARE CENTERS. WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT- TO TWENTY
EIGHT COUNTIES WHICH INCLUDED
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED INCOMING
TELEPHONE CALLS. FROM
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE NOT
PREVIOUSLY SERVED BY THE
CENTERS. OVER AT HOTEL
ACCOMMODATIONS WERE PROVIDED TO
FOLKS THAT COULD NOT JUST TAKE
A BACKUP BATTERY IT NEEDED TO
BE PUT INTO A HOTEL. ON A SHORT
TERM BASIS BECAUSE A BACKUP
BATTERY OR GENERATOR WOULD NOT
BE A SOLUTION TO KEEPING AND
I'M IN THEIR HOME FOR SEVERAL
DAYS- WE DID HOWEVER PROVIDE
OVER TWO HUNDRED BATTERIES TO
INDIVIDUALS IN THEIR OWN HOMES-
MOST OF THOSE USERS AS
ELECTRICAL NEEDS- WERE C. PAP
USERS BI PAP USERS. OXYGEN
CONCENTRATOR MACHINES AS WELL
AS POWER WHEELCHAIRS- WE HAD A
LOT OF INSTANCES WHERE YOU'VE
TALKED ABOUT TELECOMMUNICATION
EFFORTS GOING OUT. OF RANGE IN
SERVICE IN SOME AREAS I JUST
WANT TO BRING UP THE FACT THAT
MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE DEAF AND
HARD OF HEARING- RELY ON THOSE
COMMUNICATIONS SYSTEMS. AND IN
SOME OF THOSE COMMUNITIES WERE
ABSOLUTELY. I KNOW WHERE THAT
IS SHUT OFF WAS OCCURRING IN
THEIR AREA. OUR MEMBERS CENTERS
ALSO PROVIDED OVER FORTY
INDIVIDUALS WITH ACCESSIBLE
TRANSPORTATION- OR GAS TO LEAVE
THEIR HOME AND GET TO A
CHARGING STATION OR HOTEL. IN
NEW WHICH MANY CASES- WERE IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES WHERE IT TOOK
OVER AN HOUR TO GET FROM ONE
PLACE TO ANOTHER. SEE IF I'LL
SEE DOES NOT BELIEVE THAT
BATTERIES OR ANY OF THE
RESOURCES THAT WE PROVIDED ARE
THE SOLUTION THAT FITS ALL WE
KNOW THROUGH TESTING BATTERIES
IN ADVANCE THEY EVEN THE BEST
BATTERY SYSTEMS WILL NOT
SUSTAIN INDIVIDUALS WITH.
DIVERSE ELECTRICAL MEDICAL
DEVICE NEEDS I ALSO WANT TO
BRING OUT THAT- WE HAVE
ACTUALLY SATURATED ONE OF THE
BATTERY COMPANIES. MARKETS AND
THEY NO LONGER HAVE THE
BATTERIES THAT ARE MOST USEFUL
TO OUR COMMUNITY. IN THROUGHOUT
THIS YEAR THEY SAID THAT THE
FIRST BATTERIES WILL BE MADE
AVAILABLE AGAIN IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY AND THAT WAS- ARE
THE BATTERIES THAT WE FOUND
THAT. COULD HELP THE MOST
NUMBER OF PEOPLE- MOVING
FORWARD I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT. AS A PUBLIC POWER
SAFETY SHUT OFF CAN BE AS-
DEVASTATING BUT THERE NEEDS TO
BE TWENTY FOUR SEVEN ACCESSIBLE
COMMUNITY CHARGING STATIONS
WHICH OF ALL BROUGHT UP- AND
THAT THOSE RESOURCES NEED TO BE
PROVIDED BY TRUSTED INDIVIDUALS
AND ENTITIES IN THE COMMUNITY
THAT ARE ALREADY PROVIDING
SERVICES TO FOLKS WITH
DISABILITIES AND OLDER ADULTS-
WITH THAT SAID I WILL LET MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE HERE TO
SPEAK ABOUT THE SERVICES GO
INTO FURTHER DETAIL. THANK YOU
AND AGAIN I'M GONNA ASK
EVERYONE TO TRY TO REPEAT THEIR
COMMENTS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
GIVEN OUR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA BOSS
HAMILTON I'M HERE REPRESENTING
UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS YOU W.
AFFECTS ME- WE REPRESENT A
HUNDRED SIXTEEN THOUSAND I JUST
US WORKERS IN TWENTY ONE
COUNTIES INCLUDING MANY OF THE
COUNTY'S IMPACTED. BY THE PS PS
SO I'M GONNA MOVE QUICK ALSO.
OUR MEMBERS ARE LOW INCOME
WORKING POOR OR THEY ARE
GENERALLY TAKING CARE OF OTHER
LOW INCOME- MEDI CAL RECIPIENTS
OF LOW INCOME SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. THE
FEEDBACK THAT I RECEIVED FROM
OUR FOLKS IN THE FIELD IS-
THESE ARE FOLKS WHO DO NOT HAVE
MONEY TO PURCHASE- GENERATORS
OR RENT GENERATORS OR EVEN THE
GASOLINE TO USE GENERATORS- OR
FOR THAT MATTER LANTERNS- WE
HAD ANY. STORIES OF PEOPLE
USING CANDLES TO LIGHT THEIR
HOUSE AND THEN UNFORTUNATELY
SOME FIRES RESULTING FROM THAT.
WE HAD ISSUES WITH PEOPLE
WHOSE- WATER COMES FROM WELLS
WHICH RUN ON ELECTRICITY SO NOT
ONLY AS YOU KNOW IS THE WATER-
THE ELECTRICITY OUT BUT THE
WATERS OUT AS WELL. LOTS OF
CASES OF PEOPLE LOSING FOOD IN
THEIR REFRIGERATORS AND IF YOU
CAN IMAGINE IF YOU'RE LIVING
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK. THAT IS A DEVASTATING
THING TO LOSE HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS WORTH OF FOOD- BECAUSE
PHONE SERVICE WAS OUT FOR OUR
MEMBERS. THE WERE IN SOME CASES
PREVENTED FROM GOING TO WORK-
BECAUSE EITHER THE CLIENT WAS
NO LONGER AT THE HOME WHERE
THEY- COULDN'T FIND WHERE THE
CLIENT HAD BEEN EVACUATED TO.
SO WE HAD- LOTS OF FOLKS WHO
HAD LOST PAYCHECKS AS A RESULT.
MOVING ON. THE ISSUE
TRANSPORTATION HAS TO BE
ADDRESSED IN MANY OF THESE
PLACES INCLUDING THE RURAL
AREAS THESE FOLKS DO NOT HAVE
TRANSPORTATION TO EVEN GET. TO
THE OPEN CHARGING FACILITIES
AND I DIDN'T HEAR MUCH
DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT AT ALL SO
IF YOU AREN'T ABLE TO GET
THERE- THAT THAT'S A PROBLEM TO
BEGIN WITH I WAS TOLD OVER AND
OVER THAT THE UNCERTAINTY. WAS
A HUGE PROBLEM BECAUSE THE
WARNINGS THAT ARE ISSUED ARE
VERY LARGE AND THEY SAY YOU MAY
YOU MAY HAVE YOUR SHOUT A POWER
SHUT OFF. BUT IT'S UNCLEAR IF
YOU WOULD HAVE IT SO THAT-
PEOPLE WEREN'T SURE WHERE THEY
WERE GOING TO BE IF THEIR POWER
WAS SHUT OFF AND IT WAS
ENTIRELY UNCLEAR WHEN IT WOULD
GET RESTORED. OR AS IT HAS BEEN
MENTIONED IT WOULD SAY ONE TIME
BUT IT DIDN'T HAPPEN THAT TIME
IT WAS ANOTHER TIME. AND THEN
WE'LL WE'RE- FINDING IS FOLKS
WHO THEN BECAUSE THEY WERE
BEING WORN BUT NEVER ACTUALLY
HAD THEIR POWER SHUT OFF FOR
NOW. DISREGARDING THE WARNINGS
BECAUSE OF JUST A NATURAL
INCLINATION TO NOT BELIEVE THEM
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T APPLY TO
THEM IN THE FIRST PLACE. SO I
THINK THE BOTTOM LINE THAT YOU
CAN TAKE FROM- WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE CHRISTINA AND I HAVE
THAT ARE SAYING IS THAT. FOR
THE MOST PART THERE IS NOT
ADEQUATE PREPARATION IN TERMS
OF PEOPLE FOR MEDICALLY FRAGILE
AND WHO HAVE A ACCESS
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS. AND THE
ADEQUATE MEASURES HAVE MOVE FOR
THE MOST PART NOT BEEN TAKEN.
THE STEPS THAT I WANT TO OFFER
YOU IS THE LEGISLATURE. OR
THAT. YOU SHOULD MANDATE IN LAW
CLEAR RESPONSIBILITIES AND
CLEARER MANDATES TO NOT ONLY
THE UTILITIES BUT HEALTH PLANS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT. THAT THEY
MUST WORK TOGETHER AND THEY
MUST CORPS NAY BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW IT A LOT OF THIS IS VERY AT
HAWK. IT REALLY DEPENDS ON WHAT
COUNTY YOU LIVE IN AND WHETHER
OR NOT THE SERVICES. THAT ARE
BEING PROVIDED OR OR OR HIGH
QUALITY OR NOT IS REALLY AGAIN.
JUST A QUESTION OF WHERE YOU
LIVE AND WHAT KIND OF
LEADERSHIP HAPPENS TO EXIST IN
THE IN THAT LOCAL AREA. SO A
LOT OF THIS TO ME IS A QUESTION
OF MANDATES BY THE STATE. THAT
REQUIRE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
CLEAR DIRECTIVES TO EACH OF
THESE AGENCIES- WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT. WHO WHO
YOU KNOW AT THIS POINT IF AND I
JUST AS WORKERS NOT GOING TO
CHECK ON AND I JUST AS CLIENT.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE WHO'S
GOING TO DO THAT I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF FINGER
POINTING WILL THAT PERSON HAS-
THAT AGENCY HAS IT AND THAT'S
JUST SIMPLY NOT HAPPENING.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE. I DO WANT
TO POINT OUT I JUST AS WORKERS
ARE NOT PAID TO GO CHECK ON
THEIR CLIENTS IN MANY CASES
THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE AN OF
MONEY TO PUT THE GAS IN THEIR
CAR. TO GO GET TO THE CLIENT'S
HOUSE TO CHECK ON THEM. THOSE
SERVICES ARE NOT PAID BY THE
STATE. BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
AUTHORIZED SERVICES SO WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO RECOMMEND TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND TO THE
ADMINISTRATION IS THAT YOU.
CONTEMPLATE A VERY EASY WAY TO
AT LEAST PUT SOME EXTRA DOLLARS
INTO PEOPLE'S PAYCHECKS. IN
CASES WHERE THERE ARE THESE PS
PS IS OR WHERE THERE'S ACTUAL
DISASTERS. CONSIDER EITHER
CREATING SOME SORT OF. TIME
CODE SYSTEM WHERE PEOPLE CAN
SAY THAT YOU KNOW I WAS DOING
SERVICES ABOVE AND BEYOND THE
NORMAL COURSE BECAUSE I WAS
CHECKING ON MY CREDIT WAS
EVACUATING THEM ALWAYS SAVING
THEIR LIFE. THINGS THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY NOT GETTING PAID FOR
EONS OR JUST DO IT IN A BLANKET
WAY WERE YOU GIVE. EVERY I JUST
AS WORKER IN THAT DISTANT- IN
THAT AREA JUST EX NUMBER OF
DOLLARS IN ADDITION MAKE IT
EASY YOU KNOW GIVE THEM. PAY
THEM FOR FIVE EXTRA HOURS A
WEEK WITH THE ASSUMPTION THAT
THEY'RE DOING THAT THAT EXTRA
WORK. UTILITIES STATE COUNTIES
HEALTH PLANS ALL NEED TO SPEND
MORE TIME ON PREPARING FOR THIS
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES NEED NOT ONLY A
PLAN A- PLAN B. AND EVEN A PLAN
SEE. AND RELYING ON AUTOMATED
MESSAGES TO WHOEVER MIGHT BE ON
THE MEDICAL BASS LINE LIST IS
ABSOLUTELY NOT ENOUGH. AND I
WANT TO SAY WE BELIEVE UTILITY
SHOULD BE PROVIDING MEAL
VOUCHRS BATTERIES. ACCESSIBLE
TRANSPORTATION GAS VOUCHERS
THAT SHOULD BE PAYING FOR LOST
WAGES FOR I JUST AS WORKERS.
THEY SHOULD BE PAYING FOR MONEY
THAT PEOPLE LOSE WHEN THE
REFRIGERATORS BREAK DOWN. ON
THE SHOULD BE UP FRONT MONEY
AND NOT FILING CLAIMS AND
WAITING SIX MONTHS TO GET PAID
IF YOUR- YOUR CLAIM IS
APPROVED. WORKING PEOPLE SIMPLY
CANNOT FRONT MONEY LIKE THIS
AND WAIT FOR IT TO COME BACK TO
THEM HOPEFULLY ONE DAY. IF THE
GOOD FAITH EFFORT HAS TO BE IN
MAKING THIS MONEY IMMEDIATELY
AVAILABLE WORKING FAMILIES DO
NOT HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY. TO
WAIT MONTHS FOR THEIR MONEY TO
COME BACK TO THAT THANK YOU.
ONE LAST THING DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES THE STATE
CAN ADD PROVISIONS TO MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE PLAN CONTRACTS. TO
ACTUALLY MAKE MANDATED
RESPONSIBILITIES ON HEALTH
PLANS DURING DISASTERS AND
POWER OUTAGES. I COULD TALK
ABOUT BACKUP SYSTEMS FOR. I'M
SORRY I'M SO SORRY THAT WE'RE
JUST I KNOW IT I I'M WELCOME TO
IN TALK IN THE FUTURE THERE'S A
LOT THAT THANK YOU AND WE'LL BE
WORKING ON A LOT OF THE STUFF
IN THE COMMITTEE FUTURE I'M
SURE. AND I HOPE THAT YOU'LL BE
PART OF IT. THAT'S OKAY- WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE SURE YOUR COMMENTS TRACY
MCBROOM. GOOD AFTERELTON NOW
ICE OF HERS RAIN IT'S AFTER
FIVE. AND THANK YOU MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND I WILL DO MY
BEST TO BE EQUALLY AS BRIEF- MY
NAME IS TRACY MAKE ROOM AND I
AM THE DIRECTOR OF EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT FOR ADVENTIST HEALTH.
CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS ON THE
FRONT LINES OF EMERGENCIES AND
DISASTERS EVERY SINGLE DAY THE
STUFF THAT GOES ON IN OUR
HOSPITALS EACH DAY. BUT ALSO TO
LARGE SCALE WILD FIRES THAT
FORCED THE EVACUATION OF OUR
HOSPITALS WE EXPERIENCE THAT
OURSELVES DURING THE- CAMPFIRE.
AS WELL AS PATIENTS SURGES DUE
TO ACTIVE SHOOTERS
TRANSPORTATION DISASTERS
INFLUENZA AND NOW OUR GOOD
FRIEND PS PS- HOSPITALS ARE NOT
IMMUNE FROM PS PS. IN CASE
ANYBODY WONDERED I AM WE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME REALLY
WELL VERSED IN EMERGENCIES AND
DISASTERS PARTLY BECAUSE IT
HAPPENS A LOT IN OUR STATE. BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY- WE HAVE MANY
TOOLS AND RESOURCES TO ALSO
HELP WITH TRAIN AND PRACTICE WE
HAVE THE RESOURCES OF OUR
PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS LIKE MANY
THAT YOU'VE SEEN HERE TODAY
LIKE CALLAWAY YES. SEVEN OF OUR
ADVENTIST HOSPITALS AND IT IS
HELD HOSPITALS AND NUMEROUS
CLINICS WERE TALKING HNDREDS
OF CLINICS ARE IMPACTED BY THE
LAST ROUND OF P. S. P. S. AT
THE END OF OCTOBER. AND JUST
YESTERDAY WE WERE NOTIFIED THAT
WE WOULD GO THROUGH IT AGAIN
JUST EIGHTEEN DAYS FROM THE
CLOSE OF THE LAST HOSPITAL
RECEIVING THEIR POWER. THIS
ALSO MEANS THAT TO DURING IT
ONE OF THESE P. S. P. S. R.
HOSPITALS GO THROUGH THE
PREPAREDNESS ACTIVITIES OF
MOVING AND NONESSENTIAL.
APPOINTMENTS CANCER TREATMENTS
AND SURGERIES TO OTHER DAYS. IN
ADDITION TO MOVING MEDICATION
SENSITIVE MEDICATIONS THE E.
POWER OR EMERGENCY POWER AND
ALSO STANDING UP THERE INCIDENT
COMMAND CENTERS. TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT AN OUTAGE AND MAKE SURE
WE CAN MOVE RESOURCES QUICKLY.
MANY OF OUR HOSPITALS AND I'M
ALSO HAD OUR EMPLOYEES WHO DO
NOT HAVE POWER AT HOME THEY
ALSO DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO PET
OR HUMAN DAY CARE DURING THE
DAY SO OUR HOSPITALS THEY NEED
TO STAND UP THE ABILITY TO- HOW
POWER AT AVAILABLE FOR OUR
EMPLOYEES HAVE A PLACE TO SLEEP
HAVE A PLACE TO SHOWER IN CASE
EMPLOYEES NEED TO STAY. AT THE
HOSPITAL ON THE JOB TO MAKE
SURE WE CAN CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO OUR TO OUR-
COMMUNITIES. BUT DURING THIS
WHOLE TIME THESE LAST POWER
OUTAGES WE AT NO TIME HAD TO
SEND A HOSPITAL ON DIVERSION
NOR DID WE HAVE TO LESSEN. THE
AMOUNT OF SERVICE DELIVERY OR
THE QUALITY OF THAT SERVICE TO
OUR COMMUNITIES. AND THAT'S DUE
IN PART TO THE RESILIENT
HOSPITAL STAFF WHO LIVED AT THE
HOSPITAL. AND CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES AND THE
FLEXIBILITY AS OF OUR HOSPITALS
TO BE ABLE TO. TURN AND TURN
THEMSELVES INTO BASICALLY
EMPLOYEE SHELTERS SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICES THAT THOSE
HOSPITALS NEED TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES. PS PS ARE UNIQUE
IN THAT- WE CAN WE RESPOND TO
DISASTERS EVERY DAY AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER BUT THEY ARE
UNIQUE I THE SENSE THAT
THEY'RE HAPPENING BACK TO BACK-
OFTEN FOR REALLY LONG DURATIONS
OF TIME. ONE OF OUR HOSPITALS
WAS ON PSP AS FOR NEARLY ELEVEN
DAYS. OUR EMPLOYEES GOING FOR
WITHOUT POWER FOR EVEN LONGER
THAN THAT AND STILL ATTEMPTING
TO COME TO WORK EVERY DAY.
THEY'RE ALSO UNIQUE IN THAT
THEY WERE NOT THE TRADITIONAL
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
THAT WE TRAIN TO IS EMERGENCY
MANAGERS A CALLOW YES TRAINS US
ALL TO AN INCIDENT COMMAND AN
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT. ARE NOT
NECESSARILY AVAILABLE ALL THE
TIME DURING THESE TYPES OF
INCIDENCES THERE'S NOT THE SAME
COMMUNICATIONS STRUCTURE.
THERE'S NOT LARGE TASK FORCES
ASSEMBLED AT THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER LOOKING AT
OUR HOSPITAL SURGES BEING
MANAGED WHEN PEOPLE CALL NINE
ONE ONE OR WHEN PEOPLE. PEOPLE
END UP WITH NO OXYGEN AT HOME
OR THEY HAVE NO WAY TO CHARGE
THERE WILL TEAR BATTERIES THEY
COME TO THE HOSPITAL AND THEY
ASKED THE ET STAFF. TO HELP
THEM GET A BATTERY OR HELP THEM
CHARGE THEIR DEVICE OR FILTER
OXYGEN TANKS. SO THEY COME TO
US AND SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT. AND THEN YOUR
TRADITIONAL DISASTER. OUR
UTILITY COMPANIES HAVE
DEFINITELY MADE SOME PROGRESS
FROM EACH OF THE DIFFERENT P.
S. P. S. THAT WE'VE HAD WE'VE
NOTICED THEY'VE MADE SOME
CHANGES AND SOME DIFFERENCES
BUT THERE'S STILL A LOT OF WORK
TO BE DONE ABOUT INTEGRATION OF
THE HOSPITAL COMMUNITY AND
OTHERS INTO THIS PROCESS AND
ALIGNING WITH OUR STATE IS
ALREADY DOING AN EMERGENCY
RESPONSE WE HAVE AN EXCELLENT
REGENCY RESPONSE INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THE STATE AND WE'RE NOT
USING IT FOR THIS PARTICULAR
INCIDENT THE WAY THAT WE DO FOR
OTHERS. AND WE CAN ACHIEVE
SIMILAR OUTCOMES. LASTLY I AM.
A SCAB OVER AND LASTLY I THINK
IT. OUR OPPORTUNITY TO LEVERAGE
HOSPITAL PREPAREDNESS GRANTS TO
HARDEN THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
EXISTS IN OUR HOSPITALS. AS YOU
MAY KNOW NOT EVERY HOSPITAL HAS
ENOUGH EMERGENCY POWER TO POWER
THE ENTIRE HOSPITAL AND
EVERYONE OF ITS CLINICS AND I
THINK WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO CONTINUE TO LEVERAGE
EXISTING GRANT PROGRAMS TO HARD
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE. AS WELL AS
OPPORTUNITIES TO LEVERAGE A
CALLOW YES FORTY DOES VERY GOOD
TODAY. TO INTEGRATE THIS
PROCESS THROUGH WHAT THEY'RE
ALREADY DOING TODAY. THANK YOU.
JIM CARD. MCCARTHY BUT
CURRENTLY YES. IF TERM NÁN
SENATORS- MY NAME IS JOE
MCCARTHY ON THE OWNER OF THE
FIFTY GRAND RESTAURANT AND BAR
OPEN POLLOCK PINES- I THINK A
LOT OF YOU KNOW THE AREAS HI
HILL APPLE HILL SORRY NOT HIGH
HEEL HIGH HEELS ONE OF THE. THE
TO THE FARMS THAT ARE UP THERE
ANYWAY- BUT FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY- TO TALK TO YOU
TODAY ABOUT MY BUSINESS
EMPLOYEES- IN THE COMMUNITY
THAT- WE BELONG TO- AND HOW THE
CURRENT ROUND OF P. S. P. S. S.
OF AFFECTED US- I HOPE THAT- MY
COMMENTS ARE REPRESENTATIVE OF
MOST OF THE SMALL BUSINESSES IN
RURAL AREAS- WE PURCHASED THE
RESTAURANT. IN NOVEMBER OF LAST
YEAR- SO- HAVE HAD IT FOR A
LITTLE OVER A YEAR THOUGH. IT
HAS BEEN- CONTINUOUSLY RUNNING
FOR LESS SEVENTY SIX YEARS- WE
PERSISTED WE PURCHASED IT JUST
IN TIME FOR WHAT WE LOVINGLY
CALL SNOW MAY GET IN- THE
RATHER BRUTAL FEBRUARY
EXPERIENCED- BY MANY OF US
LIVING IN THE SIERRAS. DURING
THAT MONTH WE EXPERIENCED
ROUGHLY TWELVE DAYS A POWER
OUTAGE- NOT MUCH DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT WE- HAVE JUST GONE THROUGH
LATELY- WITH A PROLONGED POWER
OUTAGES WE SAW. ELEVEN DAYS- IN
OCTOBER- AS YOU'V ALREADY
HEARD FROM OTHERS THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT EFFECT ON BUSINESS
HOURS IS. JUST ONE MORE OF
THOSE- WHAT IS DIFFERENT THOUGH
IS OUR CLOSEST TO THE OTHERS
THAT WE- ARE ALSO IF THAT ARE
ALSO AFFECTED BY THIS. NOW WE
ARE A PLACE WHERE PEOPLE ARE
ABLE TO GATHER AND TALK ABOUT
WHAT IS GOING ON AND WE HEAR
ABOUT. HOW PEOPLE ARE DEPRESSED
AND STRESSED DURING TIMES LIKE
THESE IN SOME WAYS IT'S A
LITTLE BIT LIKE POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS. WE ARE PLACE FOR THEM
TO VENT THEIR FRUSTRATIONS AND
THEY OFTEN TALK ABOUT HOW THEY
FEEL THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT NOT
BEING ABLE TO WORK BECAUSE THE
COMPANY THEY WORK FOR. IT'S
CLOSE TO THE POWER OUTAGE. THEY
WONDER HOW. THEY'RE GOING TO
PAY THE RENT FOR THE MONTH. NOW
WHEN POWER GOES OUT MANY OF OUR
CUSTOMERS LOSE RUNNING WATER
THEY NEED TO POWER. THEY NEED
THEIR POWER FROM TEACHING YOU
TO RUN THEIR WELL PUMPS OFTEN
THE GENERATOR STARTS
SUFFICIENTLY SIZED TO RUN THE
LARGE ELECTRICAL DRAW FROM THE
PUMPS. AND WE ARE- WE HAD ONE
CUSTOMER THE CAME INTO A
RESTAURANT IN TEARS. SHE ASKED
IF SHE COULD GET WATER SO THAT
SHE COULD WATER HORSES. FLUSH
TOILETS AND HAVE WASTE WATER
FOR BASIC HYGIENE. ALSO WHEN
THE POWER GOES OUT COMCAST IS
AS YOU'VE HEARD ALREADY GOES
OUT. AND IN MY BUSINESS WE USE
COMCAST FOR PHONE. MANY OF OUR
CUSTOMERS DO AS WELL IN OUR
COMMUNITY HAVE WE HAVE A LARGE
NUMBER OF RETIRED PERSONS. AND
MEDICAL EMERGENCIES THEY LIVES
THEIR FORM OF COMMUNICATION. NO
I'VE I'VE BEEN BLESSED FOR MOST
OF MY WORKING LIFE I'M A
SOFTWARE ENGINEER- IT BY-
PROFESSION- AND I HAVE A DEGREE
IN ELECTRICAL ENGINEERING AND
KNOW WHAT IT IS LIKE TO MAKE-
AS MANY OF YOU DO MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR. WITH RESOURCES AVAILABLE
TO YOU WHEN THE POWER GOES OUT
TIME YOU BARELY CONSIDERED
INCONVENIENCED- TO GO OUT AND
SPEND A THOUSAND DOLLARS ON A
NEW GENERATOR- AT LEAST I KNOW
I DID- FOR MANY OF MY CUSTOMERS
THIS IS HARDLY COMPREHEND
DOUBLE. FROM OF FOR THOSE
MAKING TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR A JENNER
GENERATORS A SERIOUS EXPENSE TO
BE CONSIDERED. AS A BUSINESS
OWNER TO SOMETHING THAT I KNOW
HAVE A FACT I HAVE TO FACTOR
INTO HOW IT BUDGET EXPENSES FOR
THE COMING YEAR. IN FEBRUARY WE
LOST WERE SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO FOOD LOSSES. AND WE LOST
ANOTHER TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
TIE THE TIME THAT WE WERE
CLOSED IN THE ABILITY TO GET
PEOPLE THROUGH THE DOOR. DUE TO
THE SNOW AND OTHER CLASSES. YOU
KNOW AND THIS TIME- WE HAD. HI
TWO GENERATORS RUNNING- AND- AS
THINGS GO THE GENERATOR THAT WE
HAD FIXED- ENDED UP GOING OUT
IN THE FIELD RIGHT IN THE
MIDDLE OF DINNER SERVICE FOR
RETIREMENT- AND- AGAIN. NOW
ANOTHER THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
ANOTHER GENERATOR TO RUN- THE
BUSINESS. THIS IS ON TOP OF THE
FACT THAT WE HAD TO STAY AT
WORK TILL MIDNIGHT TO RUN OUR
GENERATORS LOCK UP GO HOME. TO
A DARK HOUSE WAKE UP WITH A
COLD SHOWER BECAUSE I. TOOK THE
GENERATOR FROM MY HOME AND
MOVED IT TO THE- RESTAURANT-
AND TO GET THE GENERATOR
STARTED UP AGAIN. SO AS THEY
SAY WE WORK THE PROBLEM WE CAME
SOLUTIONS OF COSTS. THE GAS
RUNNING THE GENERATORS COST A
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS A DAY. TO
DAY RUNNING ON P. JEANNIE COST
FORTY. AGAIN WHEN I WAS MAKING
A THOUSAND DOLLARS A DAY BY
MYSELF. AN EXTRA HUNDRED
DOLLARS WOULD BE A BIG DEAL.
WRAP UP IF YOU CAN YEAH OKAY- I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THE
DIFFICULT TO THE P. JEANNIE
HOUSE- AND I FEEL THAT. P.
JEANNIE HAS ITS WORK CUT OUT
FOR IT- THIS IS A DIFFICULT
PROBLEM TO SOLVE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WATCHING PROGRESS
WITH COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. MARK
BURNHEIMER. THANK YOU
JOURNALISM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- BARGAINING ROOM HERE
REPRESENTING THE CINEMA VALLEY
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND ACROSS
STUFF HALF OF MY SPEECH
CHILDREN MAKE THIS AS BRIEF AS
POSSIBLE PERSONAL I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR BEING HERE
I DO WANT TO JUST PAUSE FOR A
MOMENT RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT
WE'VE GOT HALF OF THE STATE
SENATE HALF OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE THERE BEEN COMMUNITIES
IN PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES ALL
OVER THE STATE THAT HAVE HAD TO
STOP WHAT THEY'RE DOING FOR
MONTHS. TO DEAL WITH THIS IT'S
KIND OF INCREDIBLE IF YOU THINK
ABOUT THE COLLECTIVE BRAINPOWER
IN THE MANNER RESOURCES THAT WE
ARE ALL HAVING TO PUT INTO
DEALING WITH THE FALLOUT. FROM
THIS DECISION. I WANT TO THANK.
MS MCCARTHY. SO MANY BUSINESSES
LIKE HIM REALLY DID A LOT. TO
SERVE THEIR COMMUNITIES WHEN.
THEY'RE WITH ANYBODY ELSE TO DO
IT. HEARD SO MNY STORIES OF
BUSINESSES THAT HAD AN EMPLOYEE
RINGING A GENERATOR TO RUN A
SHOP LIKE TO JUST. GIVE PEOPLE
COPY SO THEY FELT LIKE A HUMAN
IN THE MORNING. OR OR GAS
STATION BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY A LOT
OF PEOPLE HAD. A GENERATOR SO
THEY WENT AND BOUGHT BUT IF
THERE'S NO GAS STATION WITH
ELECTRICITY YOU DON'T HAVE ANY
GAS TO PUT INTO YOUR GENERATOR
AND OBVIOUSLY THAT CAUSES A
PROBLEM. SO SPECIFIC NUMBERS
FIFTY NINE AND A HALF PERCENT
OF CINEMA COUNTY LOST POWER FOR
AT LEAST FORTY EIGHT HOURS. IN
CINEMA VALLEY THAT NUMBER WAS
EITHER A 100% EXACTLY OR VERY
DARN CLOSE TO IT BECAUSE PRETTY
MUCH OUR ENTIRE VALLEY WAS SHUT
OFF BETWEEN OCTOBER EIGHTH AND
ELEVENTH. THAT MEANS. FORTY
FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE WITH NO
REFRIGERATION. NO POWER MEDICAL
DEVICES NO ABILITY TO HEAT OR
COOL THEIR HOMES SCHOOLS AND
CHILDCARE CENTERS CLOSE TRANSIT
SYSTEMS HOSPITALS PHARMACIES
BANKING SERVICES PET SUPPLIES
GAS STATIONS. YOU NAME IT ALL
THE THINGS THAT WE RELY ON WERE
NOT THERE TO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES. THE PEOPLE WHO
SUFFER THE MOST WERE WITH LOW
WAGE WAGE EARNERS WHO ARE NOT
ABLE TO REPORT TO WORK BECAUSE
EITHER THEY DIDN'T HAVE CHILD
CARE. OR BECAUSE THEIR JOB WAS
CLOSED. THAT HAS A DRAMATIC
IMPACT ON PEOPLE IN THE IN THE
LOWER INCOME POPULATIONS. WE'LL
TELL YOU STORIES ABOUT TWO
DIFFERENT BUSINESSES ONE IS A
SMALL. BURGER RESTAURANT THIS
LOOK AT INVOICE HOT SPRINGS
THEY JUST OPENED UP LAST SUMMER.
IF YOU THIS IS GETTING A LITTLE
BIT TO DRILL DOWN BUT I WANT
YOU TO KIND OF UNDERSTAND WHAT
IT WAS LIKE FOR THEM. ON
SEPTEMBER TWENTIETH WE GET THE
FIRST WARNING IMPEDE PS PS IT
DIDN'T OCCUR THAT MAY HAVE
CREATED SOME FALSE SENSE OF
SECURITY FOR THEM. ON OCTOBER
FOURTH WE GET THE WARNING FOR
THE SECOND EVENT AND IT TURNED
INTO THE LARGE OUTAGE THAT.
TOOK OUT OUR ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
ON OCTOBER NINTH EXCUSE ME THAT
WAS THE THAT ONE SOMETIME OVER
THAT WE CAN THE GOT THEIR POWER
BACK BUT IT WAS A TOTAL LOSS
ALL OF THEIR INVENTORY FOR THIS
RESTAURANT HAD TO BE THROWN OUT
I'LL LET YOU GUYS ALL THINK
ABOUT WHAT YOU WOULD DO WITH
HUNDREDS OF POUNDS OF GROUND
MEAT AND BEEN REFRIGERATOR TO
YOUR HOUSE IT'S A BIG PROBLEM
JUST GETTING RID. OF THE MESS
THAT WAS CREATED. FINALLY GOT
BACK UP AND RUNNING. AFTER A
WEEK IT TOOK THEM ANOTHER FULL
WEEK TO GET THE- DELIVERIES
BECAUSE THE DISTRIBUTORS
WEREN'T ABLE TO SERVICE ALL OF
THEIR CUSTOMERS BECAUSE EITHER
THEY WERE SHUT DOWN. TO THE
OUTAGE OR BECAUSE THERE IS SO
MUCH DEMAND FOR RESTOCKING
EVERYTHING A RESTAURANT ACROSS
ALL OF. CINEMA COUNTY. HOW ON
OCTOBER TWENTY THIRD THE POWER
DID NOT GO OUT AGAIN FOR THE
BUSINESS BUT MANY OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES DID LOSE POWER AND
THEY DIDN'T HAVE THEIR STAFF
THERE TO. TO WORK ON THE TWENTY
SIX THEY LOST POWER AGAIN FOR A
FEW DAYS. EVEN WHEN THEY WERE
ABLE TO RESTOCK THEIR BUSINESS
THEY COULDN'T. GET A FULL.
DELIVERY BECAUSE YOU CAN'T.
THROUGH LOSING OF ALL OF THAT
INVENTORY AGAIN AND AGAIN SO
THEY WERE SHORTING THEIR ORDERS
AND THAT CREATED NEW PROBLEMS
BEING ABLE TO DELIVER WHAT THE
CUSTOMERS WERE EXPECTING. TO
THE MAIN THING THAT I WANT TO
CONVEY IS. A FORTY EIGHT HOUR
OUTAGE IS NOT FORTY EIGHT HOURS
OF PROBLEM. THE PROBLEM STARTS
AND WE GET THE WARNING. AND
WHEN EVERYTHING IS THROWN INTO
CHAOS AND UNCERTAINTY. AND IT'S
NOT OVER UNTIL A BUSINESS HAS
ALL OF THEIR NORMAL OPERATIONS
BACK UP AND RUNNING WHICH CAN
BE DAYS WEEKS. AFTER THE ACTUAL
OUTAGES TURN BACK ON. SECOND
BUSINESS I WANT TO MENTION IS
THE ONLY HOTEL. THERE IN GLEN
ELLYN. THIS IS A COMMUNITY THAT
WAS HIT VERY HARD BY THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN FIRE AND THERE'S
FRANKLY STILL IN THE RECOVERY
MODE. THE LA HOTEL LAS PART OF
THEIR PROPERTY AND THEY WERE
SHUT DOWN FOR A YEAR. AFTER THE
FIRES. IT WAS REALLY ONE OF THE
ONE OF THE MOST IMPACTFUL
RIBBON CUTTINGS. BUT I DID OF
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE- THING
ABOUT. LITERALLY RISE FROM THE
ASHES AND COME BACK LAST YEAR
WAS JUST SO AMAZING. AND SO
WHEN I GOT THE EMAILS TODAY.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT. THIS IS
THE- Là YOUNG. LOCAL FAMILY IN
SOME OF. THE ROUTE THIS MAYBE
TEN FOURTEEN ROOMS IS NOT A BIG
OPERATION. THIS CUSTOM FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN DIRECT
LOSSES. THAT'S JUST CANCELED
RESERVATIONS FOOD SPOILAGE.
THAT DOESN'T ACCOUNT FOR. LOST
WAGES FOR EMPLOYEES
CANCELLATIONS OF FUTURE
BOOKINGS. THE MARKETING THAT
THEY MEAN THEY SPENT ON-
MARKETING OCTOBER AND SEPTEMBER
OR BASIS MONTHS. AND IT IS ONE
READ THE WORDS THAT HE WROTE.
HE SAID WERE WORKING AROUND THE
CLOCK TO CATCH UP TO OUR NORMAL
OPERATIONS MARKETING THE SLOW
SEASON TAX PREPARATION BUILDING
NEW PARTNERSHIPS ETCETERA. WE
ARE PRACTICALLY CRUMBLING FROM
AN OPERATIONS WHEN IF YOU. AND
THE AND THIS IS HAPPENING
BUSINESSES ALL OVER THE STATE
IT'S NOT JUST US. THE AND THE
AND IT'S FRANKLY IT'S NOT
ACCEPTABLE SO WE HOPE THAT YOU
GET TO MAKE SOME CHANGES- I DO
WANT TO- JUST TOUCH REAL
QUICKLY ON THE NUMBERS BECAUSE
A COUPLE OF YOU'D MENTIONED-
HARD NUMBERS. ARE COUNTY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT BOARD WORK
WITH MOODY'S ANALYTICS THEY'RE
ESTIMATING A FIFTY TO SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLAR IMPACT FOR JUST
CINEMA COUNTY FOR JUST THE
OCTOBER EIGHTH THROUGH ELEVENTH
EVENT. SO YOU CAN MULTIPLY THAT
BY THE NUMBER OF COUNTIES THAT
HAD THE OTHER EVENTS AND THE
LONGER OUTAGES AND- AND KIND OF
GO FROM THERE SO- THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH FOR LISTENING TO US
TODAY WE REALLY DEMAND BETTER
FROM. JENNY I THINK THAT THEY
HAVE MADE BASS IMPROVEMENTS
FROM THE FIRST EPISODE TO THE
SECOND ONE I SAW A BIG
DIFFERENCES BUT BOY WE NEED A
WHOLE LOT MORE OUR GOVERNOR
BROUGHT UP A GREAT POINT WHERE
IN THE MOST INNOVATIVE AND
TECHNOLOGICALLY ADVANCED STATE
IN THE NATION. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I LIKE TO ASK
THE NEXT PANEL SHOP OF
CONTINUING ON THE- BUSINESS
CONCEPT WE'RE GONNA HAVE.
ANDREW CHAIN IS A CHAIN. SHANE
HE'S THE DIRECTOR OF GOVERNOR
FAIR GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR
FOOD BANKS. CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS. AND
IF WE COULD ALSO ASK OF US THE
INDIVIDUALS FROM THE SCHOOLS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT. CORY WILL
IN BURKE ERIN MCALLISTER.
CHRISTOPHER GODLY AND CARMEL
ANGELO TO COME FORWARD AS WELL-
MISTER MISTER CHENEY. CHAIN
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
INTERCHANGE ARE PRESENTING THE
FORTY ON FOOD BANKS ACROSS THE
STATE WHO SERVE ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. OUR MISSION IS DONE
HUNGER IN CALIFORNIA- THE PS PS
BROUGHT SEVERAL LAYERS OF
IMPACT. STRESSING COMMUNITY
CONFUSION A SETBACK THAT
MISSION- BUT FOR CONTEXT OWN
ADDRESS THE POPULAR PERCEPTION
THAT WE RECENTLY HEARD. THAT
TRIPLE PROVIDERS LIKE FOOD
BANKS ARE UNIVERSALLY AVAILABLE
TO THOSE IN NEED. PEOPLE CAN
SIMPLY COME TO US IN A FILTER
FOR REFRIGERATORS- AS
INCREDIBLE AS OUR NETWORK
SERVICES. CALIFORNIANS MISS
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MEALS
MILLION MEALS ANNUALLY
PARTICULARLY CHILDREN. OLDER
ADULTS PEOPLE DISABILITIES
ANOTHER ANIMAL HOUSEHOLDS. TO
EVEN DURING NORMAL TIMES FOOD
BANKS ARE UNDER RESOURCE
NONPROFITS THAT RELYING DONATED
FOOD. AND VOLUNTEER LABOR TO
SERVE THE COMMUNITY. PEOPLE
TRYING TO STRETCH THEIR
HOUSEHOLD BUDGET TO MAKE THEIR
FAMILY. AND 70% OF PEOPLE WHO
VISIT THE BANKS REPORTS GIVING
US TO PAY THEIR UTILITY BILLS
THE LIGHTS ON AND THEIR HOMES
CALLING SOMEONE WOMAN WINNER.
TO THE SHOULD US NOT ONLY TAXED
OUR NETWORK THE DEMON HUNGER
AMONG THOSE ALREADY FOOD AND
SECURE. WHAT CREATING ANOTHER
TEAR PEOPLE WITH UNPLANNED FOOD
LAWSON HARDSHIP TO SIMPLY PUT.
WE CANNOT BE THERE FOR EVERYONE
IN NEED AND CALIFORNIANS ARE
NOT REVEALING THOSE
REFRIGERATORS. SO IN TERMS OF
DIRECT IMPACT OUR FOOD BANKS
AND HERE PRECISE DATA CAN BE
DIFFICULT TO COME BY BECAUSE
THEY DON'T ASK QUESTIONS AS A
EMERGENCY FOOD SERVICE
PROVIDER. WHICH IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT FOR IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES AND OTHERS IN THIS
KIND OF FEAR. BUT IN TERMS OF
FOOD LOS DEGREES OCCURRED IN
HUMBLE COUNTY WHERE THE ENTIRE
COUNTY WAS DE ENERGIZED SO NOT
ONLY TO THE FOOD BANK FOOD FOR
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING A FOOD LOS
SO TO THE- TO THE GROCERY
STORES SO WHERE PEOPLE EXPECTED
TO GO. TO REFILL IS
REFRIGERATORS ESPECIALLY A FOUR
THOUSAND SQUARE MILE COUNTY YOU
CAN IMAGINE THE TIME AND
EXPENSE AGAIN LIKE MISS BEST
HAMILTON SAID EARLIER SINGULAR
EVEN OF THE MONEY TO DO THIS-
JUST REPLACE THOSE WHO SUCKS.
LITTLE PEOPLE WHO WENT WITHOUT.
IN CINEMA COUNTY I THINK WE
JUST HEARD- ABOUT THE SEVERITY
OF THE IMPACT BUT THE RED
EMPIRE FOOD BANK WAS IN THE
MANDATORY EVACUATION ZONE SO
THE COMBINATION OF T. S. P. S.
AND KINCAID FIRE. INTO THAT THE
MOMENT THAT THE STAFF AND THE
PEOPLE WE NEED TO THE
INSTITUTION THE MOST THEY COULD
EVEN ACCESS THE WAREHOUSE RIGHT
NOW OBVIOUSLY THAT WAS A PUBLIC
SAFETY SITUATION BUT IS TO GIVE
YOU A SENSE OF WHAT OUR NETWORK
IS TRYING TO DO. TO FEED PEOPLE
OKAY AND PARTICULARLY THEIR
SISTER INSTITUTIONS SO THERE
ARE AND WILL USE IN PLACE WITH
THE NAPA VALLEY FOOD BANK IN
OTHERS. BUT THEY TOO WERE
STRUGGLING TO FEED PEOPLE
EVACUATE THE FIRES AND THEN-
HAVING THE THERE IF SOMEBODY
SHUT DOWN- DO THAT TO THE PS PS
RIGHT SO THOSE MO USE BRINGING
IN MUTUAL AID SIMPLY CAN'T WORK
IN A WIDE SPREAD. DISASTER LIKE
THE PS CASTRATO- AND JUST TO
GIVE YOU A SENSE FROM SOME OF
THE THAT WE WERE WE WERE ABLE
TO GET. THE SHASTA SENIORS AND
READ ABOUT THE READING THEY SAW
ALMOST A 23% INCREASE IN THEIR
SERVICE LEVELS LIKE THAT ARE
SIMPLY UNSUSTAINABLE FOR FOOD
BANKS THAT ARE ALREADY
STRUGGLING TO ANYTHING IN THE
COMMUNITIES. IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THE SHOTS. ARE
OBVIOUSLY LESS SEVERE.
APPROVING SET THE SCENE TO GO
FOOD BANK. AND THERE'S
TERRITORY WHICH CREATED
CONFUSION ABOUT WHAT FOOD
RESOURCES WERE AVAILABLE. AND
THEY ALSO DID NOT GIVEACT YOUR
COMMUNICATION TO THE BOW ADDS.
ABOUT WHAT FOOD IS NEEDED AT
THE COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTERS.
SO IT'S GOING TO ADD ABOUT THE
NEED TO IMPROVE THAT KIND OF
COMMUNICATION AND COORDINATION.
WITH CAN RESOURCE CENTERS- BUT
BEYOND THE IMPACT OUR NETWORK
IS TO THE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS THAT WE STRIVE TO
SERVE- AND THERE ARE TOO MANY
STORIES TO SHARE BUT- BUT SOME
JUST VERY QUICKLY. THERE WERE
SENIOR AND NAPA. A PARAPLEGIC
OLDER ADULTS STRAPPED TO THEIR
CHAIR. WHO IS STUCK IN THE
AUTOMATED CHAIR AND TO LOOK FOR
MAKING THEIR NETWORK OF
VOLUNTEERS ARE ABLE TO WORK
WITH THEIR SON TOOK ABOUT
BATTERY. TO ACTIVATE THAT CHAIR
ALRIGHT SO THE FOOD BANKS ARE
GOING THE EXTRA MILE WHEN
THEY'RE ABLE BUT OBVIOUSLY WE
CAN'T WE CAN'T GET TO EVERYONE
AS WE HEARD FROM THE PREVIOUS
PANEL. AT FROM THE SAINTLY WAS
CHURCH IN CINEMA- WE KNOW THAT
OLDER ADULTS HAD A THROAT MILK.
GROCERIES I'M SORRY CITY GREENS
FISH. AND OTHER PERISHABLES
THAT THEY WERE SIMPLY NOT ABLE
TO REPLACE BECAUSE FOR BANKS
DON'T HAVE THE KIND OF STOCK N
HAND. SO I WANT TO GIVE- MUCH
THANKS TO CSS WE HEAR FROM THE
SECRETARY GOLLY EARLIER. BUT
THERE IS NO STATE FLEXIBLE FOOD
RESOURCE AVAILABLE AND FEDERAL
AID IS LIMITED AS IS. THIS WAS
NOT A PRESIDENTIALLY DECLARED
DISASTER. WHILE CSS IS AFTER
THE MAXIMUM LEXIBILITY. FOR A
PLACE TO BENEFITS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE STATE'S COMMENTS
EARLIER ABOUT. TRYING TO GET
THE COMMUNICATION OUT WE SAW IT
ON THE- RESPONSE WEBSITE. AND
THAT WAS IN SEVERAL THE
GOVERNOR'S COMMUNICATIONS. IT'S
UNDER USTA'S RULES THAT YOU
CANNOT REPLACE BENEFITS WHAT
WOULD WAY THROUGH THE MASS
REPLACEMENT FEATURE MEANING
THAT INDIVIDUALS HAVE THE
REQUESTED. ON A ONE OFF BASIS-
BECAUSE IT THE REMOTE WILL
POWER SHUT UP IN THE SAME
MONTH. WELL IT'S SIMPLY NOT THE
FAULT OF LOW INCOME PEOPLE AT
THEIR- THE LOS FOOD TWICE IN
THE SAME MONTH. AND WE CAN'T
USE THAT MASS REPLACEMENT
METHOD WHICH IS SO MUCH MORE
EFFICIENT. TO DELIVER THAT
BENEFIT AUTOMATICALLY- ANSWER
THAT ONE OF OUT REACH WELL
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN
WE APPRECIATE THE STATE. A
SUPPORT. WE KNOW THAT ALWAYS
FALL SHORT. SO WHAT CAN BE
DONE. I WANT TO QUICKLY SAY
THAT AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN. BY
THEN SOME WOMEN BRADFORD HAS
NOT BEEN FULLY IMPLEMENTED TO
TRY AND FIGHT UTILITY REALLY TO
FOOD BANKS. AND ULTIMATELY THE
P. S. P. S. EPISODES HAVE
UNDERSCORED THE NEED FOR BACKUP
POWER GENERATION. AND FLEXIBLE
SOURCES OF THE FINNISH FOOD. TO
SUPPLEMENT THE KEY DONATIONS
THAT TO MAKE CAN MAINTAIN
SERVICE WHEN COMMUNITIES. IN
ITS MOST. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER WOLENBERG. BELIEVE ME MY
NAME IS DOCTOR COREY WOLENBERG
AND I'M THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
THE ORACLE UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT MY DISTRICT HAS A NINE
TWELVE ENROLLMENT OF
200-020-0405 STUDENTS THE
DISTRICT ENCOMPASSES
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED
FORTY THREE SQUARE MILES- YOU
HST HAS TWO COMPREHENSIVE HIGH
SCHOOLS OR HIGH SCHOOL IN LOS
PLUMAS HIGH ONE CONTINUATION
SCHOOL PROSPECT HIGH ONE
COMMUNITY DAY SCHOOL AND ADULT
EDUCATION CENTER 77% OF MY
STUDENTS ARE SOCIAL
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED. MY
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
RELY ON MY SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE A
SAFE LEARNING ENVIRONMENT AS
WELL AS PROVIDE TWO MEALS A DAY
ONE OF MY SCHOOL OUGHT SCHOOLS
OFFER STUDENTS THE OPPORTUNITY
THREE MEALS A DAY. WHEN SCHOOLS
ARE CLOSED IT CREATES AN ISSUES
FOR FAMILIES. THERE WITHOUT A
SAFE PLACE AND THEY ARE WITHOUT
FOOD. ON NINE TWENTY FIVE THE
ENTIRE WARBLE ADULT EDUCATION
CENTER IN CHICO AND OR OF A
LOST POWER FOR THE ENTIRE DAY.
AND ALSO A PORTION OF OUR BILL
HIGH SCHOOL LOST POWER IT WAS A
HUNDRED TWO DEGREES. AS AND WE
STAYED IN SESSION AND MOVE
STUDENTS TO COLDER COOLER
CLASSROOMS. ORVILLE ADULT ARE
OR OF A HIGH BUT WE CANCELED
OUR ADULT EDUCATION CLASSES.
THE INTERNET FOR THE ENTIRE
DISTRICT IS HOUSE ADORABLE DOLL
WE WERE ABLE TO GET THE
INTERNET UP AND RUNNING BY
HOOKING IT UP TO A GENERATOR.
ON TEN NINE LOS PLUMES HIGH
SCHOOL LOST POWER FOR THE DAY
WE HAD TO PURCHASE A GENERATOR
TO POWER UP THE PHONES. AND
PURCHASE A GENERATOR. FOR THE
WALK IN REFRIGERATOR FREEZER
AUSTIN'S HIGH. YOU HST SUFFERED
FINANCIAL SAFETY CONSEQUENCES
AS A DIRECT RESULT OF P. GENIES
DECISION TO CUT POWER. EVERY
DAY THAT I CANCEL SCHOOL- YOU
HST LOSES A HUNDRED SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS. RATHER THAN
CLOSE SCHOOLS AND DEPRIVE
STUDENTS TO SAFETY AND MEALS WE
SPENT A PROXY TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GENERATORS FUEL
LANTERNS AN EXTRA HELP THAT
MONEY CAME OUT OF MY GENERAL
FUND THAT IS NOW NO LONGER
AVAILABLE TO PUT TOWARD
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS. HOWEVER
IT WOULD BE NOTED THAT WITHOUT
PROPER POWER MANY OF OUR SAFETY
FEATURES PHONES BELLS FIRE
ALARMS SMOKE DETECTORS WERE
INOPERABLE. ANOTHER REASON I
DID NOT CLOSE SCHOOLS THERE'S
NO GUARANTEE OF BEING GRANTED A
J. THIRTEEN A WAIVER FROM THE-
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
ESPECIALLY WHEN SUPERINTENDENT
THURMAN IS ISSUING STATEMENTS
ENCOURAGING SCHOOLS TO MAKE IT
WORK WITHOUT POWER AND OFFERING
SUGGESTIONS ON HOW TO DO SO. AT
THE ENCOURAGEMENT OF THE STATE
MUCH FOR DAILY ACTIVITIES ARE
TECHNOLOGY BASED WITHOUT
ELECTRICITY MY STAFF IS UNABLE
TO PERFORM DAILY DUTIES.
TEACHERS WERE UNABLE TO
PROPERLY DELIVER LESSONS AND
STUDENTS WERE NOT ABLE TO
PERFORM TASKS WE USE AN ATO
COLOR AND SOCIAL MEDIA AS A WAY
TO COMMUNICATE WITH PARENTS AND
THE COMMUNITY. WITHOUT POWER
THAT IS IMPOSSIBLE.
ADDITIONALLY GIVEN THAT MANY OF
THE OUTAGES ARE HAPPENING A
RURAL PARTS OF THE STATE. EVEN
IF WE HAD POWER TO DELIVER
MESSAGES RESIDENTS ARE WITHOUT
POWER TO RECEIVE THEM. ALS
MANY MY TEACHERS AND STAFF ARE
ALSO IMPACTED BY THE SHUT OFFS.
ARE WITHOUT POWER AND SOMETIMES
WATER. THEY LIKE MANY OF MY
STUDENTS ARE UNABLE TO SHOWER.
DO LAUNDRY INFILL BASIC HUMAN
TASKS WE HAVE ALL COME
ACCUSTOMED TO. P. GENIE IS
AGAIN WARNING OF ANOTHER
POSSIBLE SHUT OFF LATER THIS
WEEK ONCE AGAIN I'M HAVING TO
DECIDE IF WE NEED TO CLOSE MY
SCHOOLS. AND DEPRIVE MY
STUDENTS TO SAFETY AND FOOD OR
HOLD SCHOOL KNOWING MY TEACHERS
AND STAFF ARE NOT ABLE TO FILL
THEIR DUTIES AS THEY MIGHT
OTHERWISE BE ABLE TO. ALL THE
WHILE I'M WHEN THE PROS AND
CONS MAKING SURE SAFETY IS
UPHELD. KNOWING THAT WITHOUT
POWER SAFETY IS IN FACT
COMPROMISED. AS SUPERINTENDENT
I AM RESPONSIBLE FOR MAKING
SURE THE STUDENTS RECEIVE AN
EXCELLENT EDUCATION. TO
TRANSPORTATION TO SCHOOL ARE
FED WHILE AT SCHOOL IN A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT. PLANNED OUT OF
POWER OUTAGES TO WORK MY JOB. I
BELIEVE THAT THERE HAS TO BE A
BETTER WAY FOR P. JEANNIE TO
LIMIT LIABILITY AND JUST
FLIPPING THE SWITCH FOR
SELECTED AREAS. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY THANK
YOU. KERN MCALLISTER. I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- ERR MCALLISTER
WITH THE CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
FIRE DISTRICT AND I SERVICE THE
DEPUTY FIRE CHIEF- MY COMMENTS
TODAY REPRESENT BOTH THE
DISTRICT AND THOSE OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND WERE THANKFUL FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER WITH
STATE LOCAL AGENCIES. TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS. BUT WHEN THE
CONCEPT OF PS PS FIRST CAME
ABOUT- WERE NOT PERFECT WE
LOOKED INTERNALLY WE LOOKED AT
OUR OWN LEVELS OF PREPAREDNESS
WITHIN OUR ORGANIZATION WE HAVE
OLDER FIRE STATIONS NOT ALL OF
WHICH HAVE BACKUP GENERATORS-
THOSE THAT HAVE SOME GENERATORS
DON'T POWER THE ENTIRE FACILITY
SO- WE DID OUR OWN RISK
ASSESSMENT. AND FOUND OUT SOME
OF OUR GAPS WITH AN
ORGANIZATION. AND WE MADE SOME
IMMEDIATE CHANGES IN ORDER TO
FILL THOSE GAPS WE WEREN'T ABLE
TO FILL ALL OF THEM BUT WE DID-
INSTALL TRANSFER SWITCHES WE-
REINFORCED OUR CONTRACTS WITH
FUEL AND EMERGENCY GENERATORS.
AND WE PLANNED FOR- ROUND THE
CLOCK SERVICES IN ORDER TO GET
FUEL NIGHTS AND WEEKENDS. WE
DID IDENTIFY GAP IN OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY RADIO SYSTEM WHERE- WE
NEED TO PROVIDE FOR GENERATOR
AT ONE LOCATION IN OUR COUNTY.
AND WE CONDUCT A PUBLIC
EDUCATION- PRODUCED A CITIZEN'S
GUIDE AND IT OUT REACH WITHIN
OUR COMMUNITY. WE DEVELOPED A
PLAN- AND ONCE WE ARE GOING
INTO  P. S. P. S. EVENT WE
ACTIVATED THAT PLAN NOW SEVERAL
TIMES. INCLUDING TWICE IN
OCTOBER- WE ACTIVATE THE FIRE
DISTRICT DEPARTMENT OPERATIONS
CENTER WE HOLD OPERATIONAL AREA
CONFERENCE CALLS WITH ALL THE
PARTNERS ALL OF THESE THINGS
GOING TO MOTION. AND THERE
AGAIN IN MOTION THIS WEEK IS
WERE PREPARING FOR ANOTHER
EVENT. THE COUNTY- SEE IS
ACTIVATED- AND THIS IS A TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN OPERATION THIS IS
NOT MONDAY THROUGH FRIDAY EIGHT
TO FIVE SO IT'S AN ADDITIONAL
BURDEN THAT'S PLACED. ON OUR
AGENCIES AND OTHER COUNTY
DEPARTMENTS AS WELL. CONTRA
COSTA FIRE SEN FIRE INSPECTORS
TO NURSING FACILITIES AND-
SENIOR LIVING FACILITIES. AND
WE FOUND THE MOST WERE. ILL
PREPARED OR NOT INFORMED OF THE
EVENT. AND IT'S NOT LOST ON ME
I HEARD THE TESTIMONY TODAY
THAT- HSS TO TREMENDOUS AMOUNTS
OF OUT REACH- AS DID THE STATE
AND LOCAL OFFICIALS IN HSS. AND
THOSE CAPPED PATIENTS FROM
BEING DIVERTED INTO THE NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEM SO I APPRECIATE
THEIR WORK THAT WAS VALUABLE
AND IMPORTANT WORK THAT
OCCURRED. ONE OF THE BIGGEST
THINGS WE NEED IN A P. S. P. S.
EVENT IS INFORMATION. TIMELY
INFORMATION ACCURATE
INFORMATION- WE GET BROAD BRUSH
MAPS IN P. JEANNIE HAS MADE
IMPROVEMENTS OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF EVENTS BUT BROAD
BRUSH MAPS. SHOW THAT WE'RE
GONNA SHUT DOWN TRAUMA CENTERS
JAILS FIRE STATIONS AND THE
OMMUNITY ROSS MORE WHICH IS TO
HIM THOUSAND SENIORS THAT LIVE
IN THE WALNUT CREEK COMMUNITY.
AND IT'S NOT UNTIL TWENTY FOUR
TO FORTY EIGHT HOURS INTO THE
WARNING TIME THAT WE LEARN
THOSE ARE NOT IN THE SHUTDOWN
ZONES SO ACCURATE AND TIMELY
INFORMATION IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO LOCAL OFFICIALS. DURING THE
FIRST OCTOBER EVENT WE HAD
POWER DISCONNECTED TORE NINE
ONE ONE COMMUNICATIONS CENTER
AND WE WORKED ON THREE DAYS
WITH EMERGENCY POWER. THAT'S A
PROBLEM FOR US- WE INSTALLED A
BACK UP TO THE BACK UP GOT A
PORTABLE GENERATOR INSTALLED A
TRANSFER SWITCH SO THAT WE HAD
A BACK UP. IT IT'S ON FALLIBLE
TO THINK THAT WE'RE GONNA LOSE
POWER IN OUR NINE ONE ONE
CENTER. WE WENT INTO THE FIRST
EVENT AND MORAGA. BALKED OVER
NINE TO ELEVEN WE HAD A FIRE
THREATENING DOZENS OF HOMES AND
MORAGA- WE HEARD IT PREVIOUSLY
HERE TODAY BUT THE PRE
POSITIONING OF ASSETS AND FIRE
RESOURCES. WAS SO IMPORTANT TO
THAT OPERATION SAVING THOSE
HOMES WE THOUGHT THAT WAS GONNA
BE THE HEADLINER BUT WE WENT
INTO THE LATER OCTOBER EVENT-
AND WE SAW. A SIEGE OF FIRE
ACTIVITY IN CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY. AND AGAIN FOR THE PRE
POSITIONING OF FIRE RESOURCES-
BOTH IN OUR COUNTY AND RELYING
THOSE ON THE NEIGHBORING
COUNTIES WE KEPT THAT FROM
BECOMING A CATASTROPHIC EVENT.
BUT THEN AGAIN WE SAW THE COLD
WEATHER. AND ALL OF. OUR WRAP
WITH THIS. OUT ONE OF THE MOST
CRITICAL THINGS AFFECTING US
CURRENTLY IS HAVING REAL TIME
INFORMATION ON CELL TOWERS HOW
MANY ARE OUT. IT'S NOT UNTIL
AFTER THE EVENT THAT WE
DISCOVERED THAT WE HAD EIGHTY
EIGHT TOWERS DOWN A 12%
DEGRADATION IN OUR COUNTY. AND
THAT'S WHY I COULDN'T
COMMUNICATE WITH INCIDENT
COMMANDERS THEY COULD
COMMUNICATE WITH THE DISPATCH
CENTERS. AND WE COULDN'T
DELIVER EVACUATION WARNINGS TO
RESIDENTS IN OUR COMMUNITY
BECAUSE THOSE CELL TOWERS WERE
DOWN WE DON'T GET THAT UNTIL
AFTER THE FACT AND HAVINGTHAT
INFORMATION REAL TIME. CHANGES
OUR STRATEGY AND TACTICS ON THE
FIRE GROUND THAT'S CRITICAL
INFORMATION THAT LOCALS HAVE TO
HAVE. LASTLY THERE'S A COST- MY
ORGANIZATION SPENDS TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS PER EVENT
FOR ADDITIONAL AMBULANCE
STAFFING TO HANDLE THE
ADDITIONAL NINE ONE ONE
TRAFFIC. THERE'S A COST TO THE
FIRE AGENCIES AS WE ADD
RESOURCES THAT ARE NOT JUST FOR
THE FIRE RESCUE BUT IS THERE
BUT FOR THE PSP ASSESSMENT. AND
I THINK YOU OR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO THANK YOU AND RUN ON THE
WORST EVENTS. IN OUR SOCIETY-
AFFECT US. FIREFIGHTERS OF THE
FIRST THERE SO WE WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE ALL THE
FIREFIGHTERS YOU DIRECT.
CHRISTOPHER GLADLY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE THE
COUNTY SNOWED LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR PAYING ATTENTION TO THIS
ISSUE AND COMMEND YOU ON YOUR
INSURANCE FOR TODAY'S HEARING
ON I'LL SHARE WITH YOU THAT
TOMORROW I'LL BE IN MY
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER FOR
THE SIXTH TIME THIS YEAR DUE TO
DE ENERGIZE ATION. IT'S THE
FIFTY IN JUST THE LAST EIGHT
WEEKS AND SO IT'S A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE FOR OUR COMMUNITY TO
WRAP UP AGAIN AND DEAL WITH
THESE ISSUES I WILL MENTION
THAT THIS IS A CUMULATIVE
EFFECT IN OUR COMMUNITY
REGARDING THE GENERALIZATION
SIDE UP AND DOWN THAT
BUSINESSES ECONOMIC IMPACTS THE
CYCLE AND SOCIAL STRESSES IN
OUR COMMUNITY ARE CUMULATIVE
NOW WE MAY GET A BREAK
HOPEFULLY THIS WINTER BUT I CAN
SHARE WITH YOU IT IS PRODUCING
STRAIN AND STRUGGLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. I WILL. ECHO THE
EARLIER COMMENTS ON
TELECOMMUNICATIONS WE HAD A
FIRE. WE BROKE OF FIRING THE
MIDDLE THIS THING HI LILY DROVE
UP TO THE FIRE THAT NIGHT TWO
HOURS INTO IT I STARTED THAT
FIRE COMING DOWN THE HILL.
KNOWING THAT I COULD NOT WORN
MY COMMUNITY. THAT MY COMMUNITY
COULD NOT RECEIVE MY PHONE
CALLS MY CABLE MESSAGES. I
COULD NOT REACH THEM. AND SO WE
USE HIGH LOW SIRENS ENSURE
SQUAD CARS WE USE NO WEATHER
RADIO WE USED ALL THESE ALTERED
SYSTEMS WE'VE BEEN DEVELOPED
FOR LAST YEAR'S WE KNEW. THAT
WAS NOT AS JUST AS EFFECTIVE.
AS IT WOULD HAVE BEEN IF THE
POWER BEEN THERE IN THE FIRST
PLACE. HE WAS LITERALLY
FIGHTING THIS FIRE WITH ONE
HAND TIED BEHIND OUR BACK. WE
CANNOT COMMUNICATE WITH OUR
COMMUNITY WE CANNOT OPEN
SHELTERS TRAFFIC SIGNALS ROUTE
WE EVACUATED. HUNDRED AND
NINETY THOUSAND PEOPLE. WHICH
IN THE DARK WITHOUT
COMMUNICATIONS ABOUT TRAFFIC
LIGHTS. IT'S STUNNING TO ME
THAT WE DIDN'T KILL PEOPLE
DURING THAT EVENT. SO
GENERALIZATION RADICALLY
IMPACTS OUR ABILITY TO RESPOND
TO THE ACTUAL FIRE VENTURE TO
OCCUR. AND IT FOR THE AXIS AND
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS COMMUNITY THIS
IS A SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE FOR
US. AS WE DON'T KNOW WHO THEY
ARE WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY
LIVE WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THEIR
ISSUES ARE THERE ARE LIMITED
RESOURCES I CAN BE BROUGHT TO
BEAR. FOR MANY THESE PEOPLE AND
I HEARD UTILITIES I WHO'S YOUR
EARLIER TALK ABOUT HARDSHIP AND
CAN BE IT'S NOT IT'S LIFE OR
DEATH. AT SOME POINT WE ARE
GONNA KILL PEOPLE WE HAD A
BROKEN BACK IN ONE EVENT WE HAD
ONE MAN BURKE HIMSELF ON A
GENERAL ELECTRICALLY THIS IS
GOING TO CONTINUE INTO A POINT
WHERE PEOPLE GET COMPLACENT AND
THEN WE'RE GONNA START SEEING
TESTS. AS THE COMMUNITY NO
LONGER SURGES RESPONSABLES
THEIR MOST MOBILE BUT JUST
TAKES IT IS A MATTER OF COURSE
THAT THERE COULD BE TAKEN CARE
OF. AND THEN FINALLY MONEY WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT THIS. THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT COSTS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IT'S US THAT ARE OUT
THERE MEETING THE NEEDS
ANSWERING AND I ONE CALLS
TRYING TO PROVIDE SHELTER
EVACUATING PEOPLE. WE LOSE
REVENUE YOU HEARD AT FIFTY TO
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLAR ECONOMIC
KIT FOR ONE EVENT. WELL A
PERCENTAGE THAT GOES TO FUND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT YOU TAKE AWAY
THAT PERCENTAGE. THAT'S CAN
IMPACT US AND SAID CONSUMER
COUNTY. WERE ALREADY ON THE
ROPES FROM THE FIRES TWO YEARS
AGO WERE LAYING OFF STAFF. TO
PAY FOR PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUES
AND MISSIONS WERE PAYING. FOR
WIRING OUR BUILDINGS AT A
GENERAL FUND MONIES SHOULD BE
GOING TO SUPPORT MENTAL HEALTH
AND OTHER FUNCTIONS. THERE ARE
SOFT COSTS ON HERE TODAY MY
STAFF WILL BE IN THE IDEAS YOU
FOR NEXT THREE DAYS. WE'RE
TAKING HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
EMPLOYEES AWAY FROM THE NORMAL
DUTIES ON A REGULAR BASIS. TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF STAFF HOURS ARE
NO LONGER BEING DIRECTED TO
SERVE THE COMMUNITY OF THE
MISSIONS ARE ALREADY OUT IN
FRONT OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT. WERE
RESPONDING TO BUT WHAT'S
BASICALLY A MAN MADE DISASTER.
A BUREAUCRATIC DISASTER WHAT'S
CAUSING THIS CHALLENGE FOR US.
THAT FINALLY THERE ARE HARD
COSTS WERE SPEND REAL MONEY ON
THIS. STAFF OVER TIME RESPONSE
COSTS FOR SUPPLIES. THE
ESTIMATES. PRIOR TO THE EVENT
FROM LAST WEEK WE'RE FOR HALF
MILLION DOLLARS IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COSTS IS FROM
ACCOUNTING. THAT'S GENERAL FUND
IT'S NOT CAN BE REPLACED. IS
GONNA BE REAL HARD FOR US TO
CATCH UP THAT WE'RE PROBABLY
LOOKING ADDITIONAL STAFF
IMPACTS FOR THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR. AND I WOULD. LIKE TO JUST
BRIEFLY TOUCH ON THE GRANTS THE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
THE STATE KICKED AND THAT'S
GREAT HALF OF IT GOES TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. SOMEONE COUNTY
WILL SEE FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS. THAT'S
OUR WARD. THAT'S IT. FOR
POPULATION OF FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE I CAN BUY TO
MOBILE GENERATORS. IT'S NOT A
TENT IF YOU WANNA MAKE A DENNIS
SAYING AND IT'S GOING TO GO ON
FOR YEARS. WE NEED TO SEE REAL
MONEY COMING OUT OF THE I USED
A NEED TO PULL. THEY NEED TO
PAY FULL FREIGHT. FOR THESE
COSTS WE'RE TALKING SEVERAL
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
NEED. TO GO TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. TO REALLY BEEF UP
THE SOCIAL. SIX SAFETY NETWORKS
THEY'RE GONNA PROVIDE THAT. A
SICKLY THAT'S SECURITY BLANKET
FOR COMMITTEE POLITICS YEARS
FOR THEM TO GET THEIR NETWORKS
PUT TOGETHER PROPERLY THANK YOU.
CAMANCHE LOW HERE CARMEL ANGELO
MENDOCINO COUNTY CEO AND ALSO
INCOMING PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTY EXECUTIVES. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK I ALSO
SUBMITTED TO YOU A LETTER THAT
CAME FROM MY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ARE CHAIR BROWN TO
THE- TO PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC. ALONG WITH THE CHART
THAT'S MARKED INTERNAL DRAFTED
THIS IS A CHART OF CALLS WE
OPENED A COMPLAINT LINE FOR OUR
RESIDENTS TO CALL AND IF THEY
HAD A NEED OR JUST TO CALL AND
LET US KNOW WHAT THEIR
EXPERIENCE WAS. YOU'LL SEE YOUR
DOCUMENT IN FRONT OF YOU IS
MARKED INTERNAL DRAFT ONLY THE
REASON FOR THAT IS THAT THE
CALLS ARE STILL COMING IN THESE
ARE CALLED THERE'S A HUNDRED
NINETY SIX CALLS FROM OCTOBER
THIRTIETH TO NOVEMBER
FIFTEENTH. WHAT'S IMPORTANT
HERE THESE ARE OUR RESIDENTS
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT THAT
WE SERVE IN THAT YOU SERVE AND
YOU CAN SEE THE CHALLENGES THAT
THEY'RE HAVING THERE'S PROBABLY
NOTHING DIFFERENT HERE THAN ANY
OTHER REGION IN THIS STATE THAT
HAS BEEN IMPACTED BY A POWER
SHUT OFF. I WOULD LIKE TO JUST
MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS ABOUT
THE LETTER. WHAT I'D LIKE TO
SAY THOUGH REALLY IS WHEN I GO
BACK AND I SAID IT WOULD IN A
BOARD MEETING TOMORROW WITH MY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. AND THE
PUBLIC COMES IN TO TALK ABOUT
THIS POWER SHUT OFF THAT WE'RE
PREPARING FOR ON WEDNESDAY I'M
NOT SURE WHAT I'LL SAY ABOUT
THIS HEARING I'VE BEEN HERE ALL
DAY JUST AS YOU'VE BEEN HERE
ALL DAY I CAN'T GO BACK AND
TELL MY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OR
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
COME IN. THAT WE'VE
ACCOMPLISHED ANYTHING I CAN'T
SAY THAT THERE'S ANYTHING
DIFFERENT THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN ON WEDNESDAY THAT DIDN'T
HAPPEN ON IN OCTOBER OCTOBER
NINTH TWENTY THIRD TWENTY
SIXTEEN TWENTY NINE. WE HAD FOR
POWER SHUT OFF WE HAD A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY HOURS CONSECUTIVE
HOURS OF NO POWER ALL THESE
PEOPLE THAT CAME IN ALL DAY
WHETHER IT WAS ACCESS TO
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS OR THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY WE
EXPERIENCED THAT AS WELL AND
THE STATEMENT THAT. THERE
WASN'T OR THERE WAS. A MINIMAL
ECONOMIC IMPACT TO THE STATE
MAYBE THAT'S TRUE BUT NOT IN
RURAL COUNTIES AND CERTAINLY
NOT IN MY COUNTY. OR IN OTHER
SMALL RURAL COUNTIES. SO I'M
NOT SURE WHAT I'M GOING TO SAY
TOMORROW BECAUSE I DON'T SEE
ANYTHING DIFFERENT. P. JEANNIE
ON WEDNESDAY IF THEY DECIDE TO
SHUT THE POWER OFF FOR HUNDRED
AND TWENTY HOURS FOR PEOPLE
THAT HAVE MEDICAL NEEDS OR THE
MENTAL HEALTH COMMUNITY BECAUSE
THEY'RE SUFFERING AS WELL.
THERE'S NOTHING THAT HAS BEEN
SAID OR DONE TODAY THAT COULD
CHANGE THAT. SO I'M NOT SURE
WHERE TO GO WITH THIS BUT WHEN
I DO HAVE TO SAY. IS THAT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE LETTER. AGAIN
THERE'S NOTHING HERE THAT
YOU'LL SEE THAT YOU HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM YOUR CONSTITUENTS IN
OTHER REGIONS. THAT HAVE HAD A
POWER SHUT OFF BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND WHEN YOU WANT TO
TALK ABOUT SOLUTIONS ONE. IS
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY CONSECUTIVE HOURS OF
A POWERSHUT OFF AGAIN. IN ANY
REGION OF THE STATE BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE IMPACTED AND WITH
PGA ANY DID IN OCTOBER. WAS AND
THEY CREATED A PUBLIC HEALTH
EVENT FORTUNATELY NOBODY IN MY
COUNTY DIED BUT IT COULD HAVE
HAPPENED IN MY COUNTY OR ANY
OTHER COUNTY. SO I'D LIKE TO
SAY IF THERE'S ANY WAY. OF
PRECLUDING A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
OURPOWER SHUT OFF OR ANYTHING
THAT'S A EXTENDED THAT WILL
IMPACT TO THE EDICALLY NEEDY
OR THE MENTAL HEALTH CLIENTS. I
WOULD ENCOURAGE THAT TO HAPPEN
I DON'T SEE THAT TODAY I'D ALSO
LIKE TO SAY THAT WE HAD P.
JEANNIE COME OUT AND SPEAK TO
OUR BOARD WE HAVE. COME OUT
TWELVE. THEY SAID. BECAUSE
JEANNIE AT THE UPPER ECHELON
HAS NOT IMPACTED THEIR
FRONTLINE STAFF. SAID THEIR
LIAISONS WILL CALL THEY'RE
REALLY GOOD ABOUT CALLING THEIR
GOOD ABOUT. EMAILING BUT THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY INFORMATION
THEY'RE NOT EMPOWERED AND
THEY'RE NOT EDUCATED I LEARNED
MORE ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND MAYBE
YOU DID TOO. THAN I DID FROM P.
JEANNIE AND I WOULD SAY THAT
THE PUBLIC LEARNED MORE FROM
SOCIAL MEDIA THAN THEY DID FROM
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE WE PUT PRESS
RELEASES OUT WHEN WE HAD
INFORMATION. SO AGAIN I KNOW WE
ONLY HAVE ABOUT I HAVE ABOUT
ANOTHER THIRTY SECONDS I'D LIKE
TO SAY AND- AN UNACCEPTABLE
SCOPE AND DURATION IF WE CAN
LOOK AT THAT THE COMMUNICATION
INCONSISTENT INCOMPLETE YOU
HAVE THE LETTER IN FRONT OF
YOU. I THINK THE CPUC SHOULD DO
MEETINGS OUT IN THE REGION'S
I'D LIKE THEM TO COME TO THE
SMALL WORLD COUNTIES AND SEE
WHAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING. AND
HAVE THE HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX
PEOPLE COME IN AND TALK WITH
THEM AS WELL. THERE'S A LOT
HAPPENING AND I WOULD SAY THAT
THERE'S A LOT THAT NEEDS DONE
AGAIN ON GOING COMMUNICATION.
YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT THIS AND
WEKNOW THAT PREVENTION IS
IMPORTANT AND SO WE KNOW CALLOW
YES. WHAT THEY'LL DO IS THEY'LL
WORK WITH THE COUNTIES THE WORK
WITH THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR AND HELP US
PREPARE. AND SO I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE P. JEANNIE DO SOMETHING
LIKE THAT IT CAN'T JUST HAPPEN
WHEN IT'S TWO DAYS BEFORE POWER
SHUT OFF. IN POWER IN THE
LIAISONS GETTING THE
INFORMATION OUT THERE AND DOING
SOMETHING THANK YOU MA'AM. AND
I WANT TO THANK FOR THE LETTER
IT'S VERY INFORMATIVE VERY
THOROUGH VERY WELL DONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SO ITSELF THANK
YOU. IN CONJUNCTION ITH THE
PRESENTATION- SENATOR. PLEASE
KIDS LATE IN THE DAY. SO GOOD
TO YOU YOU HAVE ONE AND ASK A
QUESTION AND THEN- SIR GALGIANI
THANK YOU SO MUCH AT MISTER
CHAIR IN A ONE AT. THANK YOU
TO. OUR PREVIOUS SPENT ON THIS
PANEL. SPECIAL THANK YOU TO-
MISTER ANGELO IN. THE DIRECTOR
OF THE OFFICE EMERGENCY
SERVICES IN CINEMA COUNTY OF
COURSE MR GOLY. I THINK THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS RESEARCH
HERE. PEOPLE ARE EXHAUSTED.
THEY'RE FED UP. IN THE DESERVE
BETTER. FEW OBSERVATIONS AND
ONE QUICK QUESTION NUMBER ONE-
ASISTIR BONE EMISSIONS FROM
ABOUT CHAMBER SAID. I'M LOOKING
IT FLKS GET THEIR ABILITY TO
GET BACK UP AND RUNNING FROM
THESE PARISHES IS TAKING LONGER
THAN WHAT WE SAW FROM THE FIRE
TWO YEARS AGO- IN THAT FIRE. I
DESTROYED NEARLY SIX THOUSAND
HOMES BETWEEN MENDOCINO LAKE
NAPA AND SONOMA COUNTIES- IT
WAS A GOOD TWO WEEKS. BECAUSE
FOLKS STILL WITHOUT POWER
WITHOUT GAS. I THEY WERE SO
BACK YOU WAITED ON. AND THAT
THE IMPACTS ARE REAL IN IT'S
GOING TO BE SUSTAINED. I'D
NEVER SEEN FOOD BANK LINES LIKE
WHAT I SAW TWO WEEKS AGO. IT'S
LIKE WHAT YOU SEE ON TELEVISION
INTERVAL COUNTRIES. AND IT'S AN
ACCEPTED ONE FRIGGIN
ACCEPTABLE. AND THOSE WHO ARE.
HOURLY WAGE EMPLOYEES HAS
SUFFERED THE MOST THEY CAN
RESTOCK THE REFRIGERATORS AS
SOME MAY HAVE SAID THAT THEY
ARE LUCKY THAT THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO. THEY CAN'T PAY THE
RENT. FOR SYNDICATE SCHOOL
LUNCH. SO WE I THINK WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO KICK IN SUPPORT FOR
FOOD BANKS FOR LOOKING AT-
CONTINUED POWER SHUT US INTO
THE NEXT YEAR AND I HAVE A
QUICK QUESTION FOR THE COUNTY
MINISTER FOR THE CHIEF- AS WELL
AS EMERGENCY MANAGER. YOU OF
ALL BECOME P. GENIES EMERGENCY
RESPONSE MANAGEMENT AGENCY. YOU
DON'T WANT IT BUT YOU HAD TO DO
IT. THE QUESTION I ASKED TO SEE
OVER THERE TODAY'S COMPENSATION
FOR LOCAL AGENCIES
UNDERSTANDING HOW CHALLENGING
IT IS IN THIS WOULD NOT
OBVIOUSLY. HELP WITH THE
EXHAUSTION OF THE FATIGUE BY
LIKE TO BE TO GET YOUR TAKE ON
COMPENSATION FOR THANK YOU
WOULD SEE LIKE AN F. MAG GRANT
DURING A FIRE POTENTIALLY 75%
OF COSTS- THAT COME THROUGH
DURING FIRES EARTHQUAKES
ECCENTRIC. AND IF IT'S OKAY FOR
THE CHAIR. THE THREE
INDIVIDUALS THE CHIEF THE
MUSEUM IF THEY CAN ANSWER
BRIEFLY IF THERE'S A PARTICULAR
RESPONSE A BRIEF ANSWER PLEASE.
THE CONCEPT IS GOOD I WOULD
SUPPORT SOME SORT OF MECHANISM
FOR REIMBURSEMENT- THERE IS A
REAL COST AN ACTUAL COST- EVERY
TIME WE OPEN THE EOC THE D. O.
C. WE MOBILIZE RESOURCES
SPECIFICALLY- TO EMS RESOURCES
THAT ARE IN RESPONSE TO PS PS.
THE TICKET NEEDED. AND I WOULD
JUST OFFER THAT IT SHOULD BE A
DOLLAR PER PERSON PER HOUR OF
POWER OUTAGE. THANK YOU. LIKE
TO SAY THAT WE STARTED
PREPARING MONTHS BEFORE THIS SO
THAT WE WOULD BE READY BUT IT
DEFINITELY WITH THE- RESOURCE
CENTERS THAT P. JEANNIE OPEN
FROM EIGHT EIGHT THEYDID NEED
SECURITY AND WE DID SEND PUBLIC
SAFETY OUT THERE AND OF COURSE
THERE WAS NO REIMBURSEMENT FOR
THAT. THANK YOU. THERE ARE A
GALGIANI. AND WHAT I AM WHAT I
WAS HEARING FROM THE C. E. O.
FOR THE COUNTY OF MENDOCINO
COUNTY REMINDS ME OF WHAT I
HEARD MY DISTRICT WE WENT WENT
FOR THE HOUSING CRISIS AND-
PEOPLE WERE DEFAULTING ON THEIR
LOANS AT RATES. THAT WERE JUST
UNBELIEVABLE AND UNHEARD OF IN
MODERN HISTORY AND WE FELT IN
MY DISTRICT FIRST BUT- THE
FRONTLINE STAFF AT THE BANKS
DIDN'T HAVE BE. THE SKILLS AND
KNOWLEDGE TO KNOW WHAT TO DO
HOW TO DIRECT PEOPLE. AND THE
PROBLEM IS HAPPENING SO QUICKLY
THAT THEY THEY COULDN'T ABSORB
ALL OF THE QUESTIONS THEY
DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO DIRECT
PEOPLE AND IT WASN'T UNTIL. WE
WERE DEEP AND- VERY DEEP AND TO
THE MORTGAGE CRISIS THAT. THE
BANKS STARTED HAVING- LOAN
MODIFICATION OFFICERS WHO ARE
SPECIALLY TRAINED ON HOW TO
DEAL WITH THINGS. I CAN
UNDERSTAND HOW THE IOUS ARE SO
DEEP AND THE AND THE- CHALLENGE
OF EVERYTHING THAT'S IN FRONT
OF THEM RIGHT NOW BUT- YOU'LL
BE MAKING A GRAVE MISTAKE IF
YOU DON'T TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
YOUR FRONT LINE STAFF AND GIVE
THEM. SOME TRAINING OR HAVE
SOME. AND SOME INDIVIDUALS THAT
YOU. AND MAY POINT PEOPLE WHO
ARE MORE TRAINED IN WHAT TO DO
AND HOW TO POINT. CUSTOMERS TO
THE RESOURCES IN THE WAY THEY
THEY SHOULD ORAT LEAST HAVE
TROUBLE SHOOTERS OR SOMETHING
IN PLACE SO THAT YOU CAN GET A
LITTLE BIT IN FRONT OF THIS. BY
HAVING FRONTLINE STAFF BE MORE
TRAINED ON HOW TO DEAL WITH
THESE INCOMING PROBLEMS. THANK
YOU WILL LAST FOR NICK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE
AND WERE VERY SORRY THAT IT'S
TAKEN THIS ENTIRE DAY. BUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL
YOUR SERVICE TO OUR STATE.
WE'RE ALSO GONNA ASK BECAUSE
OTHER. A REPRESENTATIVE SERVE
FROM UTILITY AND WATER
DISTRICTS FROM ACROSS THE STATE
TO DAVID PETERSON- DON BOLAND
AND MEL GRANDY. BEGINNING WITH
A DAVID PETERSON DIRECTOR LAST
WEEK IN THIS WATER DISTRICT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS DAVID
PETERSON I'M THE GENERAL
MANAGER OF LOS REGION IT'S
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT WERE
EIGHTY OP RETAIL WATER AND
WASTEWATER AGENCY THAT SERVES
THE WESTERN PORTION OF LA
COUNTY. AND WHAT I WANTED TO DO
IS SHARE WITH YOU- THE
PERSPECTIVE A WATER AND WASTE
WATER AGENCIES ON PS PS EVENTS
I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT ITEM
FOR THE COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER-
AND I'LL BE SHARING MY OWN
EXPERIENCES FROM MY AGENCY BUT
ALSO FROM- FEEDBACK I RECEIVE
STATEWIDE. THROUGH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES. SPECIFICALLY HAVE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THREE
DIFFERENT AREAS ONE WITH REGARD
TO COMMUNICATIONS. TO
OPERATIONAL IMPACTS AND THEN
THREE FINANCIAL IMPACTS AND I
DID SUBMIT ALSO WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THAT I WOULD ASK BE
ACCEPTED FOR THE RECORD. OUR IS
IT WORTH DID YOU SUBMITTED.
OKAY WE HAVE A OPTIONS I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HIGHLIGHT-
AND THAT OUR WATER AND
WASTEWATER AGENCIES WE NEED
ELECTRICITY TO DO OUR JOB WE
CANNOT PUMP AND TREAT THE WATER
THAT PEOPLE NEED AS AS A AN
ESSENTIAL PUBLIC SERVICE
WITHOUT ELECTRICITY. AND WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS VERY
BASIC HUMAN NEEDS HERE DRINKING
COOKING CLEANING BATHING.
SANITATION AND IMPORTANTLY FIRE
PROTECTION AS WELL OUR WATER
SYSTEMS PROVIDE A FIRE
PROTECTION SYSTEM. AND SO OUR
GOAL WHEN WE LOOK AT PS PS
EVENTS AS WATER UTILITIES IS
THAT WE CANNOT HAVE AN
INTERRUPTION IN SERVICE WE NEED
TO PROVIDE CONTINUOUS SERVICE
REGARDLESS OF THE CONDITIONS.
AND SO WE HAVE A GREAT
CHALLENGE IN DOING THAT- IN
TERMS OF COMMUNICATION ARE HIGH
ENERGY PROVIDER IS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON. WE RECEIVE
SIXTY SIX NOTIFICATIONS OF PS
PS EVENTS TEN OF THEM RESULTED
IN SHUT OFFS AND I WILL SAY
THAT WITH EDISON WE HAVE HAD A
POSITIVE. EXPERIENCE IN THAT
THE DATA WAS BOTH TIMELY AND
ACCURATE BUT IT TALKING TO MY
COLLEAGUES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT IS NOT ALWAYS THE CASE AS
YOU'VE HEARD. TODAY THOUGHT
GENERALLY SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WE'VE HEARD IS THE LACK OF
ADEQUATE ADVANCE NOTICE OF THE
SHOT OFFICE. THE ACCURACY OF
THE DATA AND THE GRANULARITY OF
THAT DATA AND THEN LAST
INFORMATION LACKING ON THE TIME
LINE FOR RESTORATION OF
SERVICE- SO IN TERMS OF THE
FIRST RECOMMENDATION
COMMUNICATIONS IS THAT THERE'S
NEED AND VALUE. IN HAVING
ENHANCED AND STANDARDIZE
COMMUNICATION PROTOCOLS FOR PS
PS EVENTS. WITH REGARD TO
OPERATIONS FOR OUR UTILITIES
THERE'S MAJOR OPERATIONAL
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE WHEN
THE POWER GOES OFF WE HAVE TO
COMPLETELY OPERATE OUR WATER
SYSTEMS DIFFERENTLY. OUR WATER
SYSTEMS ARE VERY AUTOMATED WE
HAVE TO BRING IN EMPLOYEES WHO
ARE NOT NORMALLY AT WORK WE
HAVE TO PUT PUMPS IN MANUAL
MODE WHEN WE GET A
NOTIFICATION. WE ACTUALLY
CALLING ALL OF OUR PUMPS TO
GOING FILL OUR WATER TANKS AND
THEN WE HOLD OUR TANKS AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL POSSIBLE WE DON'T
ALLOW THEM TO CYCLE THROUGH THE
NORMAL RANGE LIKE THEY DO- AND
THEY'RE DESIGNED TO OPERATE. ON
ALL OF THAT. REQUIRES USING
POWER AT TIMES WHEN WE WOULD
WOULD NOT NORMALLY. FREQUENTLY%
DURING PEAK PERIODS AND ONE
POWERS MOST EXPENSIVE. AND THEN
WHAT POWER ACTUALLY GOES OFF
THERE'S A WHOLE SERIES OF
ACTIONS THAT WE NEED TO TAKE WE
NEED TO DEPLOY EMERGENCY
GENERATORS. AND THEN WE NEED TO
CONTINUOUSLY GO OUT AND- CHECK
ON THOSE EMERGENCY GENERATORS
REFUEL THEM AND WE NEED TO HAVE
MECHANICS ELECTRICIANS ON HAND
ALL TIME AT ALL TIMES. TO
SERVICE THOSE GENERATORS. TOM
WE HAVE AGENCIES AS WELL WHO
HAVE HAD TO RENT GENERATORS AND
RENTING GENERATORS HAS BEEN
DIFFICULT. IN SOME CASES
GENERATORS ARE NOT AVAILABLE
FOR RENT. ALL OF THESE
GENERATORS FOR THE TYPE AND THE
SIZE OF. OUR FACILITIES THAT WE
NEED MOVING- WATER REQUIRES A
LOT OF POWER. THESE ARE LARGE-
PIECES OF EQUIPMENT AND RUN ON
DIESEL POWER. ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE RUN INTO IS
THAT- THERE ARE STRICT AIR
QUALITY REGULATIONS THAT APPLY
TO THESE DIESEL ENGINES. AND
THAT HAS BEEN A BARRIER FOR US
IN RUNNING OUR ENGINES UNDER
SOME CIRCUMSTANCES SOURCE
SECOND RECOMMENDATION. IS THAT
SOME ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL WITH
REGARD TO THE NUMERIC RUN
TIMES. THAT ARE CONTAINED IN
BOTH STATE AND LOCAL AIR
QUALITY REGULATIONS. FOR
GENERATORS AND THEN LAST IN THE
AREA FINANCIAL IMPACT. THERE'S
A BIG FINANCIAL IMPACT IN TERMS
OF ADDED LABOR OVERTIME
EQUIPMENT RENTALS I MENTION
PEAK PERIOD POWER. AND THEN
FUEL- AND THEN ON THE CAPITAL
SIDE THERE'S A BIG IMPACT IN
TERMS OF. PURCHASING ADDITIONAL
PORTABLE GENERATORS AND ALSO
FIXED ON A STATIONARY EMERGENCY
GENERATORS. BY WAY OF EXAMPLE
THE EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT THAT SERVES A LARGE
PORTION OF WESTERN. I RIVERSIDE
COUNTY THEY ESTIMATED FOR THEIR
AGENCY ALONE. THAT WOULD COST
SIXTEEN AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THEM TO GET
GENERATORS THAT THEY NEED. ONLY
FOR THEIR COMMUNITY SO IF YOU
WERE TO EXTRAPOLATE THAT
STATEWIDE TO QUICKLY SEE THAT
THERE'S HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN NEED. BOB THE
GOVERNOR'S PROGRAM IN THE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IT'S BEEN TALKED ABOUT IS VERY
HELPFUL THE PROBLEM IS THAT
MONEY IS ON AVAILABLE TO
SPECIAL DISTRICTS LIKE MINE.
THAT MONEY IS ONLY AVAILABLE TO
STATE COUNTY AND LOCAL
INCORPORATED CITY GOVERNMENT SO
THERE'S A NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR INDEPENDENT SPECIAL
DISTRICTS LIKE MINE IN EASTERN
IN THE HUNDREDS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT
PROVIDE WATER SERVICE THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU. NOT DONE BOLAND.
PHONE CALL ONE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR SEE WE AA ARE I'M HERE
REPRESENTING OUR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS FOLKS WE
REPRESENT IN THE STATE
OPERATION CENTERS THE PARTNER
THE OLE YES REPRESENTING POWER
ON THE THREE I- USE FROM THIS
MORNING- WE REPRESENT
TELECOMMUNICATIONS CABLE WATER
WASTEWATER GAS IN PIPELINES IN
A AS SUCH WE STAMP THE UTILITY
OPERATIONS CENTER WE CAN'T TWO
OF THE P. JEANNIE ENGINEERS AND
WE HAD A SEASON THERE SO WE HAD
TIMELY INFORMATION FROM THE
GREED AS THIS EVENT UNFOLDED.
IT CANNOT BE OVERSTATED THE
LAST MONTH'S POWER SHUT ALL
PLACED A SIGNIFICANT BURDEN ON
ALL OF OUR TELECOMMUNICATION
NETWORKS ALL OF OUR TELL COMMON
CABLE NETWORKS RUN ON
COMMERCIAL POWER NO ONE FOR SAW
THE SERIES OF POWER SHUT OFF OR
THE SIZE OR MAGNITUDE OR THE
GEOGRAPHIC SCOPE COMMERCIAL
POWER IS. REALLY CRITICAL TO
PROVIDING ANY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES
NETWORKS ARE DESIGNED WITH
BACKUP POWER MULTIPLE POINTS OF
THE NETWORK TO WITHSTAND
ISOLATED AND TEMPORARY POWER
ISSUES BUT NETWORKS ARE BUILT
ON A FOUNDATION OF A CONTINUOUS
SOURCE OF POWER RESPONDING TO
THESE ON PRESIDENT PROLONGED
WIDESPREAD OUTAGES WAS A TRULY
HURT PLANETES WIRELESS AND
WIRELINE CARRIERS WERE FACED
WITH MAINTAINING A VAST
MAJORITY OF TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES ACROSS THE STATE
BECAUSE THIS PROGRESSED IN THE
NORTH AND ENDED IN SAN DIEGO ON
THE SOUTH. WE ARE VERY ADEPT AT
RESPONDING TO GEOGRAPHIC TO
FIRE STILL LANDSLIDES TO FLOODS
BUT WHEN YOU TRY TO MOBILE DOES
KIND RESOURCES ACROSS AN EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILE PER AT
THAT THE. STATE IT BECOMES
TREMENDOUSLY DIFFICULT. WHEN
THE I. O. U. SIMULTANEOUSLY
SHOT PORTIONS OFF WE THEN HAD
TO REACH OUT TO A SCALE ON
HEARD OF. BY AUGMENTING ALL OF
OUR EXISTING EQUIPMENT WITH
HUNDREDS OF IN STATE AND OUT OF
STATE RESOURCES. CARRIERS
COMMUNICATE WITH THE I. O. U.'S
DIRECTLY TO PREPARE FOR
RESPONDED THE SHUT OFFS BACKUP
POWER SOLUTIONS WERE INCLUDED
COMBINATIONS OF PICS GENERATORS
BACKUP BATTERIES IS
STRATEGICALLY PLACED PORTABLE
GENERATORS. THROUGHOUT THIS
FOLLOWED ALL ESTABLISHED IN
LEGAL PROTOCOLS ADDITIONALLY
WIRELESS CARRIERS PROVIDED
DETAILS STATUS THREE TIMES A
DAY THE CALIFORNIA- E. S.
THROUGH SEE WE A WE PROVIDED
THOSE ON THE GENERATORS ONLINE
OFFLINE IN OFFTHE GRID. AT
SEVEN AM ONE THIRTY AND SEVEN
PM EVERY DAY IN THE SOCK TO THE
SOCCER AUTHORITIES AT NO POINT.
DID WE HAVE TO ASK OR DID WE
HAVE TO SEND OPINION QUERY
SICK ANY COMMERCIAL CARRIER
FOR INFORMATION THEY READILY
PROVIDED. THERE HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANT. NETWORK FAILURES
CAUSING WIDESPREAD IN TANKS. IN
THESE REPORTS THAT WERE FIRE
RELATED. THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED IMMEDIATELY UPON THE
LOSS OF THE NETWORK AT NO POINT
WERE ANY THESE CANCER DELAYS
AND PROVIDING DE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PICTURE
DELAYED OR NOT PROVIDED ON THE
WIRELESS SIDE NETWORK CENTRAL
OFFICES HAD IN ZIP FIX
GENERATION DESIGNED FOR
MULTIPLE DAYS AS WELL AS BACK
UPS TO PROVIDE POWER WHEN
GENERATORS ARE OFFLINE. IN THE
EVENT OF A COMMERCIAL IT IS LOS
THE ACCESS TIME FRAME
GENERATORS NEED IN THIS
REFUELING BECOMES A CHALLENGE
IN SAFE CONDITIONS PER THE MORE
REMOTE TERMINAL SUBS NOTES
WHICH CONNECTED TO THE CENTRAL
OFFICE OR HIGGINS HAVE BATTERY
BACKUP SYSTEMS THAT ROUTE
ROUTINELY RECHARGE WHEN PLACED
BACK ON BY GENERATIONS THESE
ALSO EXCEEDED THE TIME LIMIT.
MAINTAINING POWER TO BOTH
WIRELINE AND WIRELESS
DISABILITIES IT IS A MOVING
TARGET AND AS THE P. S. P. S.
PROGRESS AND THEN WAS
REESTABLISHED DURING THE FIRST
TWO SHUTTLES IN SOME CASES IN
HUMBLE COLOR CARRIERS HAD LESS
THAN TWELVE HOURS NOTICE TO PRE
STAGED GENERATORS DUE TO THE
CHANGING CONDITIONS BY THE PS
PS. STAGING GENERATORS IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT BUT IT IS
ALSO TIME AND FUEL SENSITIVE SO
TO ADDRESS LIMITATIONS OF
BATTERY WIRELESS MISSILE OF
THESE OFTEN IF NOT ALWAYSHAVE
BATTERY SOLUTIONS ON COMMERCIAL
I WOULD CHOOSE THAT ARE
DESIGNED FOR ONE TWO OR EVEN
THREE DAYS BEYOND THAT THEY'RE
NOT IN THE DESIGN THANK OR
ROBUST BACKUP POWER SOLUTIONS
THEN ARE DESIGNED FOR A VARIETY.
OF PHYSICAL AND TECHNICAL NOT
TO MENTION PERMITTING. WELL FIX
GENERATORS ARE OFTEN
PERMANENTLY INSTALLED SITES
WERE STRUCTURES FEASIBLE AND
PERMITTED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
PORTABLE GENERATION ALLOW MORE
FLEXIBILITY. IN THE ABILITY TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE GENERAL
TO MAN AND CAN BE RAPIDLY
DEPLOYED. THESE ALSO LOW HAM
LIMITATIONS AS TO THE PLACEMENT
AND LOCATIONS INCLUDING WHERE
WE CAN'T ACCESS ROOFTOPS
EQUIPMENT SITES. IN THE WAITED
THE GENERATORS BEING
TRANSPORTED IN LEGALLY MOVED
YOU RIGHT OVER THE LESS ONE
FIRES BREAK OUT AND SO NORMAN
LOS ANGELES CARRIERS MAINTAIN
THAT SERVICE CONTINUITY AND
DEPLOYED CAL'S. COLDS AND ALL
OTHER ASSETS. WHAT WE DO NEED
ASSISTANCE FROM RELIEF WITH OUR
AIR RESOURCES BOARD IN CARBS
RESTRICTIONS WHEN WE'RE
BRINGING THINGS IN FROM OUT OF
REACH IN OR OUT OF STATE. WE
CANNOT BE IMPEDED BY OUR OWN
REGULATIONS BURKE AIR SAFETY OR
ANYTHING ELSE AT NO TIME WAS
ASSISTANCE NOT PROVIDED BY
MULTIPLE CARRIERS MITIGATION
EFFORTS GOING FORWARD THE
IMPACT IN THE FUTURE MAYBE
LESSEN WITH THE GREATEST DEGREE
POSSIBLE. CARRIERS ARE NOW
EXPLORING WAYS TO IMPROVE HOW
TO RESTORE AND WHAT PROTOCOLS
CAN BETTER MEET THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES THAT CALIFORNIA'S
GRID. ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT
HELPED US IN THE U. OC IS THE
AND BETTING OF S. C. E. N. P.
GENIES TECHNICAL DIRECTORS OF
THE GRID SO THAT WHEN A CIRCUIT
CAME ONLINEWE COULD WE CROSSED
OUR PEOPLE REMOVE THE GENERATOR
AND RELOCATED TO WHERE IT'S
NEEDED. THAT WAS IN REAL TIME
ON REAL CIRCUITS AND WAS A REAL
ADVANTAGE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MEL GRANDY. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
BUT INMIGRANTE ON THE ELECTRIC
UTILITY DIRECTOR FOR THE CITY
OF YOU KILEY OF. WE ARE
DIFFERENT IN TWO WEEKS TWO WAYS
OF ANY OTHER SPEAKER YOU'VE
LISTENED TO TODAY. ONE WAY IS
THAT WE ARE A PUBLIC POWER
UTILITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT ABOUT
25% OF THE CITIES THE STATE'S
FLOAT. IN YOUR CARDIO WE'RE
FORTUNATE TO BE A PUBLIC POWER
UTILITY. WE SERVE SIXTEEN
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS AN EIGHT DAY
INFLUX OF ABOUT THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE COME INTO THE
DAY. THROUGHOUT ALL THESE
OUTAGES A DEFECTIVE LAKES MOMA
AND SINGLE COUNTY. THE CITY OF
YOU BECAUSE IT WAS A RESOURCE
CENTER THE WHOLE CITY. EITHER
WE HAVE POWER O DURING SOME OF
THE- S. P. S. EVENTS OR OUR OWN
SYSTEM WENT DOWN UNDER THE
TWENTY SIX TO VENT. BUT.
BUSINESSES LIKE COSCO SAFE WAY
WALMART HAD GENERATORS WE
ASSISTED THEM WITH GENERATORS
TO KEEP THEM UP. WE'RE A FULL
SERVICE UTILITY SO WE DID ALL
ONCE WE HEARD OF THE ISSUE
COMING UP. THE PS PS WITHDREW
ON FRIDAY IGHT LISTEN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS IN ADVANCE WE
IMMEDIATELY ASSEMBLED OUR
COMMUNICATION CENTER. AND
THAT'S ALSO WITH THE CUSTOMER
SERVICE CENTER THE CONTACTED OR
MEDICALLY. MEDICAL CUSTOMERS SO
OUR MEDICAL CUSTOMERS ARE
CONTACTED DIRECTLY ALREADY
LARGE BUSINESSES WERE CONTACTED
DIRECTLY TO WARN THEM AND TO
MAKE THEM AWARE OF THIS. NOW I
CAN GO THROUGH EVERYTHING
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR THE SAME
THING AS MANY OF THE OTHER
CITIES DID BUT COMING OUT OF
THIS. THREE THINGS ARE
DEFINITELY DIFFERENT BUT I WAS
MENTIONING WEIRD TWO WAYS
DIFFERENT ONE WHERE PUBLIC. OUR
UTILITY THE SECOND IS WE'RE
TRANSMISSION CUSTOMER P.
JEANNIE. WE'RE NOT THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS WERE ONE TO
P. JEANNIE. AND BEING ON THE
TRANSMISSION LEVEL IT'S MUCH
MORE TECHNICAL IT'S MUCH MORE
INFORMATION THAT WE NEED TO GET
FROM P. GINNY WE WERE TREATED
IF YOU WILL AS A- HOUSEHOLD
CUSTOMER. BEING THAT ONE
CUSTOMER. IN THE THREE THINGS
THAT WE NEED AND REQUEST IN ONE
WORK WITH PT BEYOND IS A
COMMUNICATION PROTOCOL THOSE
PRODUCT TO YOU BEFORE. THAT
COMMUNICATION PROTOCOL WHAT WE
FOUND IS THAT HE THROUGHOUT THE
EVENT YOU WOULD HAVE THE
WEBSITE THE CONFERENCE CALL IN-
POINT OF CONTACT HAVING THREE
DIFFERENT PIECES THE
INFORMATION. VERY RARELY THEY
WERE CONSISTENT THOSE TIME LIKE
SEVEN. THAT'S ONE SECOND ONE IS
ADVANCE PLANNING. ON THE
TRANSMISSION SIDE IT'S NOT
MAGIC. IT'S THE STUDIES AND YOU
CAN BRING UP ABOUT EIGHT OR TEN
SCENARIOS OF WHAT COULD HAPPEN
THAT AS WE DID ON THE TWENTY
SIX THAT WOULD COVER THOSE
SINNERS SO WE COULDN'T THREE
PLAN. AND THIS CAN BE DONE
MONTHS AHEAD THAT WE CAN PRI
PLAN HOW WE'RE GOING TO RESPOND
TO THOSE ISSUES SO IF WE HAVE A
PLAY BOOK IF YOU WILL OF. PRE
PLANNING THE EVENTS ON THE
TRANSMISSION LEVEL NOT THE
DISTRIBUTION. AND THEN THIRDLY
IS ALSO WITH MUTUAL AID MUTUAL
AID WE FOUND THAT WE WERE
CALLED UPON. THE ELEVENTH HOUR
IT WASN'T A- FEW DAYS AHEAD OR
AT THE VERY BEGINNING OF THE PS
PS WE'RE CALLED UPON AT THE
VERY. THE ELEVENTH HOUR OF THE
EVENT WHERE IF WE HAD SOME
PLANNING ON THAT ALSO WE COULD
BE MUCH MORE ADVANTAGE
ADVANTAGE IN RECEPTACLE TO MOVE
FORWARD. THANK YOU THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE YOU OUTLINING YOUR
REQUESTS. HEATHER BRINGS US TO
THE END OF OUR OF OUR PRESIDENT
FOR CALENDAR YEAR OUR AGENDA
NOW WE'RE GOING TO GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT SO IF THERE'S MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT. ON ON THIS PROCEEDING
AND THE ON THE EVENTS THAT ARE
RELATED TO THIS. THIS HEARING A
PLEASE LINE UP AND TRY TO LIMIT
YOUR COMMENTS BUT A MINUTE IF
YOU CAN. PROCEED MA'AM. THANK
YOU SENATOR BYRD AT DEL KERO
EXECUTIVE THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR
AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION I'LL
KEEP MY COMMENTS VERY BRIEF
CENTER I CAN STARTED OFF TODAY
TALKING ABOUT THAT'S HUMAN
NATURE IN THE STATE OF CRISIS
TO WANT TO HELP EACH OTHER
NEIGHBOR TO NEIGHBOR. IT'S IN
THAT SPIRIT THAT WE ARE HERE
TODAY TO JUST MAKE FIVE FOUR
THREE MAIN POINTS ABOUT THE
VALUE OF DISTRIBUTED SOLAR
STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES TO SOLVING
THE CURRENT CRISIS THAT
CALIFORNIA FINDS ITSELF IN ONE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO RELY JUST ON
DIESEL GENERATORS FOR EMERGENCY
BACKUP SOLAR AND STORAGE
TECHNOLOGIES ARE DEPLOYABLE
RIGHT NOW WE'RE TALKING FLAT
BED TRUCKS WITH RECHARGE
BATTERIES. MOBILE PEAVEY UNITS
THAT CAN ACTUALLY KEEP A
CUSTOMER AS BIG AS A PUBLIC
SCHOOL OPEN DURING THE UPCOMING
BLACKOUT WE'RE HERE TO HELP AND
DEPLOY THOSE RESOURCES LIKE WE
DO IN OTHER REGIONS THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY. SECOND IS TO
SENATOR TWICE SO TO YOUR
COMMENT EARLIER WE COULD
ACTUALLY FOCUS AND DEPLOY
ENERGY STORAGE SYSTEMS FOR
CRITICAL NEEDS PURPOSES OVER
THE COMING YEAR IN ADVANCE OF
THE NEXT WAVE OF BLACKOUTS NEXT
YEAR JUST TO GIVE YOU ONE SENSE
pTWO THOUSAND SCHOOL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA WITH.
SOLAR SYSTEMS AREREADY WE
COULD FOCUS IN A AND A QUICK
THOSE SCHOOLSWITH A BATTERY
BACKUP SYSTEM ESPECIALLY
FOCUSING ON THOSE SCHOOLS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE SUBJECT LIKELY
TO PASS PASS EVENT NEXT YEAR.
GET THOSE FOLKS WITH BOLTED AND
STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE
ALL CAN ALSO CAN PROVIDE
BENEFITS TO THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICT YEAR ROUND. THE THIRD
WAY AND THIS GETS AT P. GENIES
POINTS ABOUT SECTION LIES ATION
AS WE LOOK FOR LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS WE AGREE WITH THE
IDEA OF SEXUAL LIES IN THE
GREAT IN KEEPING THE LIGHTS ON
COMMUNITY BY COMMUNITY. P.
GINNY MENTIONED MIKE REGRETS I
WANT TO REALLY HIGHLIGHT FOR
YOU THAT THERE ARE OTHER
BENEFITS TO ROOFTOP SOLAR AND
STORAGE SYSTEMS BEHIND THE
METER IN ADDITION ONE IS EVERY
CUSTOMER THAT HAS THEIR OWN
SOLAR AND STORAGE SYSTEM.
WITHIN THAT COMMUNITY SECTION.
IS PROVIDING A IS DRAWING LESS
ON THE GRID DURING THAT OUTAGE
EVENT THEY ARE LESS OF A BURDEN
ON THE GRID AND THEY ARE
ACTUALLY PROVIDING A RESOURCE
IN THAT WAY. SECOND IS THROUGH
VIRTUAL POWER PLANTS WE CAN
AGGREGATE ALL OF THOSE SMALL
BEHIND THE METER SYSTEMS THAT
ARE PROVIDING VALUE YEAR ROUND
AND CLEAN ENERGY AROUND YOU
SAID YOU'D BE BRIEF. CENTER WE
ARE WE'RE HERE TO HELP WE HOPE
THAT YOU WILL HOLD A WHOLE
PANEL AND A WHOLE DAY JUST ON
SOLUTIONS WE HAVE MORE
SOLUTIONS THAT WERE DEPLOYING.
WE DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE A STATE
WIDE PLAN TO BRING DISTRIBUTED
SOLAR AND STORAGE TO SCALE AND
AT SPEED. LET'S MAKE THAT
HAPPEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AND WORK BECAUSE SPEAK
INTO THE MIKE AS MUCH AS YOU
CAN SO SORRY ABOUT. AND CAN YOU
ASSEMBLY HAVE THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES
JUST WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
THAT MISTER PETERSON MADE.
RELATED TO WATER AGENCIES IN
THE IMPACT OF PS PS EVENTS.
AQUA REPRESENTS APPROXIMATELY
FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. MANY OF
THEM ARE EXPERIENCING THE
IMPACTS OF A P. S. P. S.
EVENTS. WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE WATER DURING THOSE
EVENTS WE FEEL IT'S CRITICAL TO
CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE DO THAT.
A NUMBER OF CHALLENGES ARE
PRESENTED. WHEN THE POWER GOES
OUT AND SO JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT AQUA'S IS PREPARED TO WORK
WITH THIS- LEGISLATIVE BY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE-TO. FULFILL ALL OUR OUR MANDATE
OF PROVIDING WATER WASTEWATER
SERVICES. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR CATTY
BURKE WITH THE HEALTH OFFICER'S
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THE SIXTY ONE.
PHYSICIAN HEALTH OFFICERS IN
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND COUNTY
JURISDICTIONS. THE SERGEANT IS
DISTRIBUTING A LETTER FROM US
YOU HEARD A LOT OF GREAT
INFORMATION TODAY. ABOUT HOW
THESE POWER SHUT US DON'T
NECESSARILY INCREASE PUBLIC
SAFETY- SO IN THAT SENSE WE
THINK THEY MIGHT BE BEST NAMES-
AND WE JUST IN THAT LETTER
POINTED OUT THAT IN SOME
DISASTERS SUCH AS HURRICANE
IRMA IT WAS THE LOSS OF POWER.
THAT ACTUALLY COST MORE LIVES
THAN THE DISASTER ITSELF- SO
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOU'VE DONE
TODAY WE HOPE TO HEAR MORE
ABOUT THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
GOOD EVENING SIR. SENATORS ON
GROUNDS TO SEARCH WITH THE
GREEN YOUTH ALLIANCE. THANK YOU
FOR HOLDING THIS MARATHON
SESSION ON THE- YES AND- HOPE.
PLEASE CONSIDER FIXING THE
WIRES AND INSTALLING.
PREVENTION RELAYS TO CUT THE
POWER IN THE LINES GO DOWN SIX
IN ORDER BOTH REDUCE THE IMPACT
OF THE PS PS AND ITS DURATION.
AND YOU HEARD FROM MISTER
JOHNSON OF PHOTO P. JEANNIE
THAT THEY CAN BURY THE
DISTRIBUTION LINES ANOTHER
TRANSMISSION LINES SO MAYBE
THAT TRANSMISSION IS BURNED
IT'S LOS BRIDGE AND- WE SHOULD
BE CONSIDERING MICRO GRIDS. ON
A MUCH BIGGER LEVEL ACROSS THE
ENTIRE STATE PLEASE CONSIDER
THE. ANALOGOUS PROGRAMS THAT
YOU HAVE FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLES
AND HOW WE CAN USE THOSE TO RUN
CRITICAL LOADS IN OUR HOUSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. HI ANA ACT
IN WITH FREED CENTER FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING COVERING
FIVE WORLD COUNTIES INCLUDE
INCLUDING ABOUT IT AND YUBA
COUNTIES. WE SCREEN A HUNDRED
AND NINETY SEVEN CALLS DURING
THIS LAST POWER OUTAGE HOPE THE
EIGHTY INDIVIDUALS WITH BACKUP
BATTERIES HOTELS OR
TRANSPORTATION THROUGH SUPPORT
OF P. JEANNIE FUNDING- WE HEARD
STORIES THAT YOU COULD NOT
BELIEVE FOR THOSE WITH
DISABILITIES AND OLDER ADULTS
PEOPLE WHO SET UP SIX HOURS
LEFT OF OXYGEN. I'M GONNA LAY
DOWN IN BED SO THAT I DON'T USE
IT YOU KNOW ANY MORE OXYGEN
THAN I NEED TO. I DRIVE AROUND
EVERY FOUR HOURS TO TRY TO FIND
POWER TO POWER MY OXYGEN
MACHINE. SO I'M I HAVE. A
COUPLE THINGS I JUST WANT TO
MENTION ONE IS THAT THROUGH OUR
SERVICES WE REDUCE HOSPITAL
READMISSIONS WE AT FOURTEEN
PEOPLE GO INTO THE HOSPITAL
JUST FOR POWER IN OUR WORLD
COMMUNITY AT THE BEGINNING OF
OCTOBER. DURING THE NEXT SET OF
POWER OUTAGES WE ACTUALLY HAD
ONE OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS GO
BACK TO DOOR INTERVENTIONS. SO
IF YOU- SOLUTIONS I'D LIKE TO
THROW OUT THERE ONE IS STATE
OPERATIONS NEED TO INCLUDE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE. RESOURCES
IN STATE STATE MEDICAID
CONTRACTS WE NEED MANAGE CARE
PROVIDERS HMO THAN ANYONE
HEALTH PROVIDER THAT PROVIDES
DME. ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGY ALSO
PAPER BACK UP BATTERIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT PROVIDING
THOSE THAT THE A ME TOO- WE
NEED LOCAL SUPPORT TO ASSIST
THE ONE ON ONE TRAINING- AND
SUPPORT THAT ASSN THE LOCAL
GRASSROOTS LEVEL ARE DOING- SO
WE NEED SUPPORT THAT LOCAL
COLLABORATION AND WE NEED. A
ROBUST COMMUNICATION SYSTEM AND
I'LL JUST SAY THERE'S A COUPLE
THINGS PLAY ON THE STATE THAT
THIS IS A VERY RELEVANT
CONVERSATION ONE IS THE
GOVERNOR'S MASTER PLAN ON
AGING. RIGHT THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY THERE TO TALK ABOUT
HOW WE COORDINATE. AROUND
ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS- WE
ALSO HAVE AGING AND DISABILITY
RESOURCE CONNECTIONSTHAT FREED
AS A PART OF IT. AND WE SEE
THAT PLAYING OUT ON. A REAL
LEVEL LOCALLY THAT HELPS US
COORDINATE SERVICE. AS AND GET
PEOPLE THE RESOURCES THEY NEED
TO LIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AMY
DURBIN OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION APPRECIATE
THE DISCUSSION TODAY AND SEE
MAY LOOKS FORWARD TO BEING PART
OF ONGOING DISCUSSIONS TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN PRESERVE
ACCESS TO MEDICAL CARE AND
NECESSARY MEDICATIONS AND
TREATMENT. DURING PS PS THANK
YOU. GOOD EVENING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
RUSSELL RAWLINGS I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY FOR
RESOURCES FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING. THE INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTER SERVING SACRAMENTO AND
YOLO COUNTIES. ALTHOUGH OUR
IMPACT HAS BEEN VERY LIMITED
GIVEN THAT YOLO COUNTY IN OUR
CATCHMENT AREA WAS THE ONLY
COUNTY TO BE AFFECTED BY PS PS
WE HAVE SEEN- THE- EFFORTS AND
HAVE SOME CONCERNS THAT- WERE
HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED AND I
PERSONALLY HAVE NOTICED THAT
THERE IS A LACK OF. DISCUSSION
AROUND TRANSPORTATION
RESILIENCY IN THIS PLAN AND I'M
CONCERNED THAT PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND OTHERS WILL
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO THE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS BUT THEY
RELY UPON DURING THESE TIMES OF
CRISIS. ADDITIONALLY I WOULD
LIKE TO REMIND THE COMMITTEE
THAT PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
ARE THE LARGEST AND MOST
DIVERSE MARGINALIZED GROUP.
THEY ARE- PEOPLE OF ALL TYPES-
LGBTQ PLUS- ALL RACES AND
ETHNICITIES AND INCLUDING THOSE
WHO ARE HARD OF HEARING AND
BLIN AND ALL PLANS MUST
INCLUDE. THE ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THESE
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. HI GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS DANNY
ANDERSONAND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE INDEPENDENT
LIVING RESOURCE CENTER SERVING
VENTURA SANTA BARBARA AND SAN
LUIS OBISPO COUNTIES. AND IN
ADDITION TO EVERYTHING THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN BROUGHT UP TO KEEP
IT BRIEF I JUST WANT TO MENTION
HOW IMPORTANT IS FOR THE- THE
CENTERS THAT MAYBE OPEN UP FOR
CHARGING TO HAVE THE CAPABILITY
TO CHARGE LARGER MEDICAL
DEVICES MORE THAN JUST CELL
PHONES AND ALSO HAVE PEOPLE.
WHO ARE THERE WHETHER FROM
PARTNER AGENCIES OR SOME OTHER
ORGANIZATION WHO ARE TRAINED ON
HOW TO COMMUNICATE WITH AND HOW
TO SERVE INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES. I'M THE ONLY
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTER IN
THE STATE HO HAS BOTH PGA ANY
AND AS C. E. AS PART OF HER
SERVICE AREA AND WE ARE WORKING
WITH BOTH COMPANIES IN
DIFFERENT WAYS. AND I'M SEEING
SOME REALLY POSITIVE THINGS
FROM THAT THE OTHER THING I
WOULD LIKE TO JUST GO BACK TO
IS THAT THE MEDICAL BASS LINE
PROGRAM WELL IT IS A WONDERFUL
PROGRAM IT'S CERTAINLY AS WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT ALL DAYS NOT
CAPTURING EVERYBODY WHO HAS
NEEDS. SO MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE KEEPING IN MIND THAT
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT
ON THE MEDICAL BE SIGNED
PROGRAM THAT PERHAPS AREN'T
GOING TO BE GETTING. BATTERIES
FROM PROGRAMS THAT MAY BE
SPECIFIC TO THAT PROGRAM BUT
ARE STILL VERY VERY LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
WHO ARE BARELY MAKING RENT AT
THEIR AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHO
CAN'T GO OUT AND BUY A
GENERATOR BY A BACKUP BATTERY
SYSTEMS ARE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT OTHER FUNDING SOURCES TO
HELP THOSE PEOPLE. WHO NEED IT
JUST AS MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT THE
THIRTY SEVEN WORLD CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES. WE'VE BEEN GROUND
ZERO IS AT THE CENTER FOR A LOT
OF THESE P. S. P. S. EVENTS- SO
FIRST OF ALL WANT TO THANK YOU
ONE FOR YOUR ATTENTION AND THEN
TO. FOR NUMEROUS COMMUNICATIONS
WITH YOUR STAFF. ABOUT THESE
EVENTS AND HOW WE CAN MITIGATE
THE IMPACT THE WAS EVENTS GOING
FORWARD. SO OUR PERSPECTIVE IS
WE UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR IT
NARROWLY TAILORED P. S. P. S.
EVENTS. EVENTS THAT MITIGATE
THE IMPACT ON CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND- SINCE THE
POPULATIONS. BUT WE'RE STILL
DEEPLY CONCERNED WITH THE
ROLLOUT OF THESE EVENTS TO
DATE. ESPECIALLY THE IMPACTS ON
COUNTY OPERATIONS LIKE WE'VE
HEARD WITH RESPECT TO- PERSONAL
DEPLOYMENT AND BACKUP
GENERATION- THE PROVISION OF
CRITICAL EMERGENCY SERVICES.
BECAUSE OUT JUST TO THE
COMMUNICATIONS NETWORK- IMPAIR
OUR ABILITY TO RESPOND IN THE
EVENT OF AN EMERGENCY WHEN A
GENERATOR CATCHES A HOUSE ON
FIRE OR SOMEONE RUNS OUT OF
OXYGEN- AND THEN. OF COURSE
CONSEQUENCES FOR SOMETHING OF
AN AT RISK- CALIFORNIANS SO THE
UTILITIES MUST REDUCE AND
MITIGATE THE IMPACTS TO THOSE
ENTITIES. AND A COUPLE
INTERESTING- ASPECTS OF THAT I
DIDN'T HEAR COME UP. WITH
RESPECT TO TELECOM AND THE
OUTAGES IN THE TELECOM SECTOR.
WE HEARD AN ANECDOTE OF IMPACTS
THE FIRE DEPARTMENT. WHERE THE
FIRE STATION COULDN'T CONTACT
THE CREWS OUT IN THE FIELD-
WHERE SOME FIRE DEPARTMENT HAD
TO RELY ON HAM RADIO'S. TO
PROVIDE SITUATIONAL AWARENESS
AND THAT'S KIND OF. INTERESTING
IN THIS DAY AND AGE WHEN WE
HAVE SUCH- CONNECTIVITY ACROSS.
A LARGE PART OF THE STATE NOT
ALL THE STATE BUT A LARGE PART
OF THE STATE. SO BE ON THAT WE
ARE VERY INTERESTED IN
COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTERS. THE
NUMBER OF CENTERS THAT WILL
PROVIDED SO FAR- AREN'T
ADEQUATE IT'S ONE TO ABOUT
EVERY TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHEN THEY'RE DEPLOYED-
WE APPRECIATE THE EFFORT BUT AT
THE SAME TIME THEY NEED TO BE
OPEN. ALL. THIS IS FOR THE
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES- ESPECIALLY
THOSE SENT TO THE POPULATIONS
WITH MEDICALNEEDS. THANK YOU
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH UTILITIES ON BETTER
COORDINATION FOR C. R. C.'S AND
THANK YOU. CAN JONES WITH THREE
FIFTY BAY AREA THREE FIFTY
MARIN- JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT
THIS IS CLEARLY AN EMERGENCY
AND I THINK YOU'RE TREATING IT
LET THAT WAY. THE UTILITIES AS
YOU HEARD BILL JOHNSON SAY
TODAY HE WORKS FOR THE
SHAREHOLDERS. ANY DOESN'T HAVE
MUCH TIME MORE THAN TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT WILDFIRES AND
BANKRUPTCY. SO IDEAS LIKE MIKE
REGRETS THERE'S A CQC MAKING
JUST STARTING ON THAT THAT'S
BASED ON SENATOR STERN'S BILL
COUPLE YEARS AGO BUT THAT BILL
BASICALLY GAVE THE UTILITIES
PRETTY MUCH POWER OVER. MICHAEL
GRIDS AND- THEY DON'T WANT THEM
SO THAT'S NOT EXACTLY A GOOD.
LINE OF ACTION FOR THAT KIND OF
THING AND WE REALLY NEED THOSE
RIGHT AWAY SO IT REALLY COMES
DOWN TO THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS
TO MICROMANAGE BECAUSE- THE
CPUC DOESN'T ONE OF MY
COMMENTS. THE UTILITIES ARE NOT
USED TO DOING THAT THE ONLY
PLACE THAT CAN HAPPEN IS RIGHT
HERE. THANK YOU. ALYSSA STILL
HIGH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION I
WE APPRECIATE BEING INCLUDED IN
TODAY'S DISCUSSION AS MISTER
PETERSON NOTED SPECIAL
DISTRICTS PROVIDE CRITICAL
SERVICES IN VITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT. PROVIDE
PUBLIC SAFETY AND ARE CRITICAL
TO MOVING FORWARD AND THROUGH
THESE PAST RESIDENTS. WE HAVE
EXPERIENCE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES TO THE DELIVERY OF
SERVICES- DURING THEM AS HE
ALSO NOTED WERE APPRECIATIVE
FOR THE FUNDING ASSISTANCE THAT
WAS GRANTED TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES BUT UNFORTUNATELY
SPECIAL DISTRICTS HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO ACCESS THAT FUNDING. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE MOVING FORWARD TO
INCREASE RESILIENCY AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT INFRASTRUCTURE AND
OUR ASK COULD BE THE ANY
DISCUSSIONS FOR FUNDING
ASSISTANCE MOVING FORWARD
SPECIAL DISTRICT WOULD BE
SPECIFICALLY ELIGIBLE. TO DROP
THAT DOWN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI AMAZON AVENGERS PHOTO WITH
THE CLEAN COALITION SOME OF YOU
KNOW US. AND I SENT A NUMBER OF
YOU AN EMAIL YESTERDAY WITH
SOME BACKGROUND INFORMATION SO
PLEASE FEEL FREE FREE TO REACH
OUT WE WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH
YOU BUT IN A NUTSHELL. THIS
ISN'T A HUGE PROBLEM THERE'S NO
EASY SOLUTION BUT THERE ARE
SOME ACTIONS THAT WE CAN TAKE
AND THAT WE SHOULD TAKE WE
SHOULD REPLACE FRAGILE WIRES.
WE SHOULD INSTALL POWER
INTERRUPTERS TO STOP WIRES FROM
SPARKING WE HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT IS AVAILABLE. AND WE ALSO
HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY FOR
MICROGRAMS AND WE SHOULD PUT
LOCAL COMMUNITIES IN CHARGE OF
CREATING SOLAR PLUS STORAGE MY
CURRENT. COMMUNITY MICRO GRIDS
IN PARTICULAR BRING
UNPARALLELED ECONOMIC
ENVIRONMENTAL AND RESILIENCE
BENEFITS TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND THEY CAN KEEP CRITICAL
COMMUNITY FACILITIES ONLINE AND
DEFINITELY DURING ANY LENGTH OF
POWER OUTAGE. NOW AGAIN WE HAVE
THE TECHNOLOGY FOR THAT WHAT WE
NEED IS A POLICIES AND MARKET
MECHANISMS TO PROLIFERATE
COMMUNITY MICROGRAPHS AND
THAT'S WHERE YOU CAN HELP US WE
NEED. FEET IN TERRACE TO MAKE
THEM ECONOMICALLY VIABLE WE
NEED TO FIX THE TRANSMISSION
ACCESS CHARGES MARKET
DISTORTION WHICH UNFAIRLY
DISADVANTAGES CLEAN LOCAL
ENERGY. IF WE FIX THAT WE GET A
LOT MORE CLEAN LOCAL ENERGY AND
DON'T HAVE TO RELY AS MUCH ON
EXPENSIVE. VULNERABLE
TRANSMISSION LINES AND WE NEED
TO DIVEST S'UTILISE OF THEIR
TRANSMISSION ASSETS WHICH WOULD
REMOVE THEIR CURRENT CONFLICT
OF INTEREST WITH CLEAN LOCAL
ENERGY. THANKS VERY MUCH. HI IF
I WAS ONE THAT I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF YOU FOR HANGING IN HERE
TONIGHT AND FOR CREATING THIS.
AVENUE FOR ALL OF US TO HEAR
INFORMATION. YOU SHOWING IS
THAT YOU CARE AND THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS JENNIFER TANNER AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF INVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA GREEN TEAM AND ALL
THE THIRTY SIX INDIVISIBLE AND
THREE FIFTY GROUPS THAT SIGNED
THE LETTER TO LEGISLATORS TO
AMEND AB TEN FIFTY FOUR. THIS
LETTER IS INCLUDED IN THE
PROPOSAL FOR REAL WILD FIRE
MITIGATION THAT WAS JUST SENT
TO ALL THE SENATORS. IN THIS
COMMITTEE. ASKING THE FOLLOWING.
WIRES ARE THE ROOT CAUSE OF THE
FIRE IS NOT THE TREES MAKE
FIXING WIRES MANDATORY RIGHT
NOW ONLY TEARING OUT TREES IS
MANDATORY NUMBER TO PUT IN
PROTECTIVE RELAYS TO STOP THE
SPARKING BEFORE IT STARTS A
FIRE WE KNOW THAT THIS
TECHNOLOGY EXISTS EVERYONE
SHOULD BE IMPLEMENTING IT NOT
TO SAN DIEGO GAS AND NUMBER
THREE DEVELOP COMMUNITY MICHAEL
GOODS FOR EMERGENCY ENERGY
DURING BLACKOUTS MICHAEL ENERGY
SOLAR ENERGY IT'S ALL HERE
RIGHT NOW WE SHOULD BE DOING
THIS. NOW THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT HI I'M
LAUREN COLUMN WITH US YOUR CALL
CALIFORNIA HERE REPRESENTING
THIRTEEN LOCAL CHAPTERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND HALF A MILLION
MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS IN THE
STATE. CALIFORNIA'S WILDFIRES A
MASSIVE POWER SHUT OFFS ARE
JUST THE LATEST IN A GROWING
STREAM OF DISASTERS THAT
REQUIRE ACCELERATED EFFORTS TO
CUT CLIMATE POLLUTION. I'D LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT JUST A FEW THINGS
THAT WE DEEM ARE NECESSARY TO
BETTER ADAPTED TO THE CLIMATE
CRISIS AND MINIMIZE FUTURE
POWER SHUT OFF AND THEN
IMPACTS. FIRST WE GREW THE
EMPHASIS PLACED ON GREAT
HARDENING AND MONITORS AYE
MODERNIZATION DURING THE
DISCUSSION TODAY- WE NEED GREAT
HER NAME PROGRAMS ALSO
IMPLEMENT A SAFETY FIRST
APPROACH. AND WE ALSO NEED TO
REPLACE OLD EQUIPMENT WITH
EQUIPMENT DESIGNED WITH
ELECTRIFICATION OF LOCAL
RENEWABLE ENERGY AND STORAGE IN
MIND AND WE AGREE THAT THIS
HARD NAY MUST BE DONE IN A
TRANSPARENT MANNER SO THAT
UTILITIES CAN BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. SECOND WE NEED TO
ENCOURAGE EFFORTS TO HELP HOMES
AND COMMUNITIES MOVE TOWARDS
BECOMING MORE INDEPENDENT OF
THE GRID INCLUDING BEHIND THE
MAITRE CLEAN ENERGY AND STORAGE
AS WELL AS MICROGRAMS. MY
GRAVERT SERVING COMMUNITIES
WITH THE RENEWABLE ENERGY
SHOULD BECOME THE STANDARD
CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY GRADE WILL
BE CHALLENGED BY EVENTS THAT
ARE EXPECTED TO OCCUR MORE MORE
FREQUENTLY. AS CLIMATE CHANGE
CONTINUES TO CAUSE EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS AND WE BELIEVE
IF PROPERLY CITED DESIGNED AND
OPERATED THAT MICROBE GRADES
HAVE A GREAT VALUE AND CAN BE
AN INCREDIBLE ASSET TO THE
STATE'S CLIMB ADAPTATION GOALS.
LASTLY IN ADDITION TO CUT DATA
TATIAN EFFORTS WE MUST CONTINUE
TO FIGHT AGAINST GLOBAL WARMING
AND THAT'S IT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE TO
REDUCE OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. THE CARBONIZED
ECONOMY AND PHASE OUT GAS
ENTIRELY WHILE ALSO WORKING TO
BUILD THIS RESILIENT STATE.
THAT CAN CONTINUE TO FUNCTION
DESPITE DESTRUCTIVE EVENTS
THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING JOHNSON
YOUNG WITH THE CALIFORNIA MRS
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
AND OUR ASSOCIATION IS
COMPRISED OF UTILITIES IN BOTH
THE PUBLIC WATER AND ELECTRIC
SECTOR. WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
FOR ALLOWING US TO HAVE
COMMENTS TO DAY WE DO ONE ECHO
THE SENTIMENTS THAT WERE RAISED
BY MISTER PETERSON AS WELL AS
OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES. I AND SINCE OUR
ASSOCIATION DOES REPRESENT
PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITIES ON
BOTH THE WATER AND ELECTRIC
SECTOR WE JUST WANNA SERVICE
RESOURCE TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
STAFF MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU.
HI **** ROOMS- WILDFIRE
SURVIVOR ASSOCIATED WITH A LOT
OF WILDFIRES YOU'RE RIGHT FOR
GROUPS IN CINEMA COUNTY. I'M
ALSO PARTY TO THE CPUC. ARM
WERE OUT THERE SUFFERING FIRST
IT BY THE WILDFIRES WHAT OF
FOLKS ARE HIT MULTIPLE TIMES BY
THE POWER SEEK TO SHUT OFFS
WONDERING WHERE SAFE PLACES TO
GO- I WOULD JUST- ADVISE THAT.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO.
REGULATE OR LEGISLATE. A SAFETY
CULTURE- I WOULD SAY METRICS
METRICS METRIC METRICS YOU
CAN'T MANAGE WHAT YOU CAN'T
MEASURE. THERE ARE FINANCIAL
MECHANISMS IT SHOULD BE PUT IN
PLACE AND REGULATED. SO IT
INCENTIVIZE IS THE UTILITIES TO
INVEST IN THE RIGHT THINGS
TOWARDS RENEWABLES. THAT INVEST
IN THE RIGHT THINGS IN TERMS OF
SAFETY. ADDITIONALLY THERE
NEEDS TO BE PERFORMANCE METRICS
UP IN DOWN. UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE WE CAN'T JUST
PICK TEN FIFTEEN TWENTY METRICS
AND EXPECT THAT THOSE ARE GOING
TO PERFORM. WE LEARN FROM THE
CAN KATE FIRE THIS JUMPER WAS
NO WHERE ON ANYONE'S RADAR. IN
TERMS OF SOMETHING THAT SHOULD
BE CHECKED. THIS NEEDS TO BE
DONE WE CAN'T RELY ON THOSE
SIMPLE THINGS ONE OTHER THING
THAT I WOULD JUST POINT OUT.
ONE OF THE UNINTENDED SIDE
EFFECTS OF AB TEN FIFTY FOUR.
IS THAT IT IS PUSHING SPEED
OVER AFRICA SEE. AND EVERY
PLACE IT HITS AND A BANKRUPTCY
PROCEEDING. PARTIES ARE
MOTIVATED TO QUICKLY COME TO A
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. THAT DOES
NOT LOOK AT THE FEASIBILITY OF
HOW P. JEANNIE WILL BE ONCE IT
EXITS BANKRUPTCY. WE NEED TO
ESTABLISH THAT ARE WELCOME ANY
AND ALL PARTIES TO COME TO THE
TABLE. IN AND PUT FORWARD A
GOOD SAFETY PLAN A SOLID WAY TO
MOVE FORWARD BUT IT NEEDS TO BE
BASED ON METRICS. SIMILARLY IN
THE CPUC WE ARE LOOKING AT.
SHORT CUTS TO- TO THE
PROCEEDINGS SO THAT WE CAN MOVE
ALONG AT A FAST PACE ANYTHING
THAT YOU CAN DO. TO MAKE SUE
THAT THAT AFRICAN. SEASON
COMPROMISED I WOULD APPRECIATE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMISSION MOKE SIMON
LAKE COUNTY DISTRICT ONE
SUPERVISOR. BUT ALSO THE
TROUBLE CHAIRMAN OF THE
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA- ALL SPEAK
FIRST FOR THE COUNTY SIDE. LAKE
COUNTY HAS BEEN AFFECTED. MORE
THAN ANY OTHER COUNTY. NOW
WE'RE NOT SAYING MORE
DEVASTATING THE PARADISE FIRE
WAS ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATING
WE'VE AT 65% OF OUR LAND BASE
THAT IS BURNED OVER THE PAST
FIVE YEARS. SO FOR LAKE COUNTY
TWENTY FIFTEEN IS WHEN THE
CATASTROPHIC FIRE STARTED I WAS
NOT CAUSED BY P. G. BUT THAT'S
WHEN WE HAD OUR FIRST INITIAL
CATASTROPHIC FIRE. YEAR AFTER
YEAR WE'VE BEEN INUNDATED BY
FIRES ONCE AGAIN THIS YEAR EVEN
WHEN THE POWER SHUT OFF WAS
POST REVENGE THAT WE HAD THE
KINCAID FIRE WHEN I WOKE UP
EVERY MORNING. SEEING HUNDRED
FOOT FLAMES LESS THAN TWO MILES
AWAY FROM MY HOME EVERY DAY. SO
AS WE MOVE THROUGH THIS PROCESS
IS GOING TO MAKE SURE. THAT
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS I
APPRECIATE THE COMMISSION TODAY
BUT I WASN'T STANDING IN LINE
I'M GOING THROUGH. AND TAKING
THE PS PS CALL THIS COMING AT
FOUR AM WEDNESDAY MORNING IN
LAKE CONTY. AND I HEARD TODAY
A COUPLE TIMES IN ALL WELL ONLY
TWENTY FOUR HOURS. IMAGINE
SITTING HERE TODAY TRYING TO
HAVE THIS COMMISSION HEARING
WITH NO CELL PHONE CONNECTION
NO LIGHTS IN TRYING TO TAKE
CARE OF BUSINESS AND HELP YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IT CAN'T BE DONE.
I JUST. COME HERE EVERY DAY ARE
THAT I'M GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK AT THIS COMMISSION
HEARING THE CPUC. TO CARRY THAT.
MESSAGE FOR OUR AND DISABLED
OUR ELDERS. YOU KNOW OUR YOUTH
THAT ARE MISSING SCHOOLS ARE
MOST IMPORTANT THING WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE-
WE NEED TO REALLY HARD IN THE
LINES IF IT BURNS DOWN REPLACE
WITH BETTER EQUIPMENT. AND
YOU'RE GOING THROUGH THEIR MAKE
SURE YOU'RE APPROACHING THE
OTHER INDIVIDUALS PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS WHO HAVE EQUIPMENT
THAT'S ON THEIR FOOD ON THEIR
PROPERTIES AND PROBABLY. FORTY
YEARS OLD THE NEED TO BE
REPLACED THESE ARE THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE DONE. WE'VE SENT
MULTIPLE LETTERS FROM THE CITY.
BOTH CITY OF CLEAR LAKE IN LAKE
ANALLY COUNTY AS ONE TO LET YOU
KNOW THE IMPACTS. BUT THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATING THANK
YOU SIR FROM A TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT STANDPOINT. THERE IS
NO REPRESENTATION I SAW
EVERYTHING ELSE REPRESENTED IN
THIS STATE SIDE GOVERNMENT
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS ON THAT
PANEL THAT SET UP THERE TODAY.
WHEN YOU TURN OUT THE LIGHTS IN
THIS STATE SPECIALLY IN LAKE
COUNTY. THEY COME TO THE TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS LOOK FOR SHELTER.
JUST LIKE THEY DID AFTER THE
FIRES AND WILL CONTINUE DOING
THAT BUT YOU NEED TO COME UP
WITH A SOLUTION THAT HELPS
EVERYONE. AND HELPS IS
COMMUNITY MOVE FORWARD FOR THE
POOREST COUNTY IN THE STATE.
AND WE NEED HELP GETTING UP
AFTER EACH ONE OF THESE
DISASTERS. POINTED TO P. GINNY
AND EVERYBODY ELSE WHAT'S COME
UP WITH A SOLUTION WORK
TOGETHER. WE WILL COME WITH
SOLUTIONS TO SENATOR REQUIRE.
BILL DODD AGUILAR CURRY ALL OF
OUR REPRESENTATIVES. BUT WE
NEED SOME SOLUTIONS AND IT'S
NOT ACCEPTABLE. TO
UNACCEPTABLE. I COME FROM THE
FOOTBALL FIELD. YOU DO YOUR JOB
YOU GOT YOUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
YOUR JOB EVERYONE SUCCESSFUL
THANK. YOU THAT'S HOW YOU
BECOME SUCCESS THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AMEN
TO THAT SIR. HI THANK YOU
CHAIR- AND ALL OF THE SENATORS
FOR STAYING SO LATE FOR THIS
MARATHON PS PS HEARING- MY
NAME'S ALLEY DO TRUE I AM THE
SENIOR POLICY ADVISER FOR THE
MIKE ARE GOOD RESOURCES
COALITION AND CHIEF STRATEGIST
REIMAGINE POWER. WE DO HAVE THE
SOLUTIONS TODAY WE ARE READY TO
PLAY THEM TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION THAT NOBODY SEEMS TO
WANT TO ANSWER CENTER HUESO WAS
THAT YES WE CAN DEPLOY A BACKUP
POWER IN ALL FACILITIES IN THE
NEXT YEAR. THERE'S A PROGRAM
AVAILABLE FOR IT IT IS EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WE
SHOULD BE FULLY FUNDING IT- I
AM HEARING IN THE SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY NINE IMPLEMENTATION
PROCEEDING A LOT OF PUSH BACK.
FROM MANY DIFFERENT GROUPS- AND
YOU CAN READ THE COMMENTS I
WON'T NAME THEM ALL
INDIVIDUALLY ABOUT COST
SHIFTING. AND THAT WE SHOULD
NOT CREATE TARIFFS AND READ AND
GO AND INCENTIVES FOR
MICROGRAMS BECAUSE OF COST
SHIFTING THAT MAY OCCUR. IF I
DIDN'T HEAR COST SHIFTING TODAY
IN ALL OF THESE PRESENTATIONS I
DON'T KNOW WHAT COST SHIFTING
IS. THE FACT THE UTILITIES AND
MANY OTHER PARTIES THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE REPRESENTING THE
PUBLIC ARE SO CONCERNED ABOUT
COST SHIFTING OF ALLOCATION. OF
COST ALLOCATIONS FROM ALL OF
THE FROM THE UTILITIES. IT'S
JUST NOT WELL PLACE ANYMORE-
SECOND ON PERFORMANCE BASED
REGULATION. IF WE HAD
PERFORMANCE METRICS FOR INNER
CONNECTION OF DISTRIBUTE ENERGY
RESOURCES I THINK THAT WOULD
BETTER ALIGN THE FINANCIAL
MOTIVATIONS WITH THE NEED TO
INTERCONNECT TO ST ENERGY
RESOURCES BEHIND THE METER.
THAT ALL CUSTOMERS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES. YOU ALL KNOW WHO I
AM I'M HERE IS A RESOURCE FOR
YOU PLEASE REACH OUT TO ME IS
THAT WE CAN HOUSE MORE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT MY GRADES.
AND D. E. R.'S BEING DEPLOYED
IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE WE ARE THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD SENATOR BALLOT. AND WE
HAVE THE TECHNOLOGICAL
INNOVATION AND THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT IS GOING TO BE MASSIVE
IF WE DON'T DO SOMETHING TODAY.
WE NEED TO CLEAR THE
IMPEDIMENTS CLEAR THE BARRIERS
THIS IS A CRISIS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I APOLOGIZE I CAN HELP MYSELF
CARE MORTENSEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES JUST TWO QUICK POINTS.
WE COUNTIES WANT TO BE A
RESOURCE TO YOU WE ARE YOUR
PARTNERS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
WORK TO IMPROVE THE SITUATION.
WERE ALSO IN THE PROCESS OF
DOCUMENTING ALL THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE LOS PS PS
EVENT- SO THAT WE CAN WORK
THROUGH THOSE AND SEEK
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'D LIKE TO THANK
EVERYONE- FOR COMING OUT BE
PART OF THIS- JUST SOME. LAST
MINUTE BIGKNOWLEDGE MEN'S
BEFORE WE ADJOURN TODAY JUST
LIKE TO THANK OUR STAFF MEDIA
CEREMONY. FOR PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER. THE PROTONS OFFICE
ALSO FOR WORKING WITH US. TO
REALIZE HIS HEARING AND ALL OF
YOU WHO HAVE BEEN PART OF THIS-
PROCESS IN THIS HEARING ALL
YOUR IDEAS AND YOUR COMMENTS-
IT'S GONNA BE A LONG YEAR- NEXT
YEAR AS WE AS- AS WE HAVE. WORK
WITH OUR DIFFERENT AGENCIES TO.
PROVIDE AN ADDICT ADEQUATE
RESPONSE TO THE NEED HERE- SO
MEMBER MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR PARTICIPATING THIS
PROCESS AND AGAIN OUR
CONDOLENCES TO ALL THE VICTIMS.
AND OUR GRATITUDE TO ALL. THE
FIRST RESPONDERS HAVE BEEN PART
OF THIS PROCESS TO HELP
INTERPRET PROVIDE. RELIEF AND
DEFENSE TO THE PEOPLE OF OUR
STATE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET
IT PLEASE AND GERMAN HAVE A
VERY SAFE EVEN IN A VERY. GOOD
EVENING AND A GOOD WEEK GOOD
NIGHT. WE ARE NOW ADJOURNED